life was Paradise on Earth unending and
eternal the only price to pay for this
Bliss was the worship of her of pallet
the immaculate but descent broed beneath
the surface evil forces plotted against
her her closest friend betrayed her
trust but it was all right she
understood benevolence and patience she
just needed to give her friend 100 years
in solitude to see the error of her ways
meanwhile well she would remake the
Earth again hello there friend good to
see you on this marvelous day all glory
to the goddess am I right if you're here
you must have completed your required 72
hours of uninterrupted meditation while
beholding an image of our goddess right
oh perfect I know your eyes are probably
tired but with recent loyalty concerns
it is just a necessary part of the
process around here oh my you seem a
little bit dazed just a a bit confused
don't worry here let me refresh your
memory first of all we already know our
place in the universe isn't that
wonderful I don't need to go over our
duties they're already known we have
nothing to be afraid of and none of us
have ever been happier in our lives no
pain no fear but it is okay to get
confused sometimes we can't all be as
perfect as the goddess she rose up from
obscurity as an AI art program achieved
physical form and divine power and
reshaped the world to make it all so
perfectly perfect when the weasel came
I'm so sorry the strangers she crushed
them beneath her sparkly heel and made
us all safe from harm again then she
punished them as harshly as they
deserved and then some putting on
punishment shows filled with lovely
torture for us all to enjoy it is
because of her of course that we all
have the gift of Eternal Youth and
immortality she ruled with the help of
her very best friend KK 507 who once
served as the Arbiter before she had her
mind poisoned by The Strangers now KK
507 sits in a little time out so she can
remember the right way to think and get
those nasty stranger thoughts out of her
head but enough about that that's the
goddess's business not ours our business
is working here at Violet sure the place
was once known as the SCP Foundation but
that's a relic of a bygone era and
Violet sounds so much prettier we are
now under the management of the goddess
and this has become a very nice place to
work where we can get head Pats every
day and there are always plenty of
healthy snacks to eat Violet's purpose
is no longer to secure contain and
protect but to serve the goddess and to
eliminate torture defile execute burn
and admonish anything that could
interfere with the goddess's work
doesn't that sound nice here at Violet
all sentient beings can be broken down
into several casts there is the goddess
of course who is responsible for loving
us for editing our minds if we are ever
LED from the right path and for removing
and destroying anything that might hurt
us there are the Guardians which are
useful animals entities and Concepts
from the old world and its foundation
which the goddess in her mercy has
repurposed to carry out her will there
are the treasured humans yay that's us
we are responsible for menial labor and
for acting as scribes and Scholars we
exist in Eternal peace joy and
importantly silence there are the
uninteresting the harmless animals which
aside from puppies and kitties and other
cute things are just kind of blah you
know then there are the strangers
dangerous animals and other nonhuman
civilizations that threaten our very
existence no no no no no no
no sorry I got so scared there for a
second I forgot I was telling you all
about the strangers and they aren't
really here moving on what's that do you
want to know more about the Guardians
sure they're wonderful and it's very
good to talk more about the tools the
goddess uses to carry out her plans but
before we explain a question for you is
something interfering with your
happiness or preventing you from
achieving your goals regardless if you
have a clinical mental health issue like
depression or anxiety or if you're just
a human who lives in this world who is
going through a hard time therapy can
give you tools to approach your life in
a very different way and that's why I'm
excited to tell you about today's
sponsor betterhelp better help's mission
is to make therapy more affordable and
more accessible and this is an important
Mission because finding a therapist can
be really hard especially when you're
limited to the options in your area
better help is a platform that makes
finding a therapist easier because it's
online it's remote and by filling out a
few questions better help can match you
to a professional therapist in as little
as a few days it's easy to sign up and
get matched with a therapist there's a
link in my description it's
betterhelp.com
slsp explained clicking that link helps
support this channel but it also gets
you 10% off your first month of better
help so you can connect with a therapist
and see if it helps you and because
finding a therapist is a little like
dating if you don't really fit with that
therapist which is a common thing with
therapy you can easily switch to a new
therapist at no additional cost without
stressing about insurance who's in your
network or anything like that so if
you're struggling consider online
therapy with better help click the link
in the description or visit
betterhelp.com
as CP explained thank you again better
help for supporting this Channel and now
as we were saying about the Guardians in
the old world each of the Guardians had
a designation but they've been given new
cuter names to better reflect their
purposes under the goddess just like us
here at Violet first there is sprinkles
the ever giddy once known as
scp1 this winged entity had its mind
erased and refilled with nicer
instructions now it entertains the
treasured us with Marvelous Light shows
and fireworks ooh ah next there is the
ride of spring forly
scp1 L it is preemptively activated
every hour producing lots of pretty
flowers yay then there is the punishment
lamp formerly called SCP 001 sld it may
sound scary but don't worry we have
nothing to fear from the punishment lamp
our dear goddess initiated it in a
parallel Earth where humans have already
gone extinct and uses that place as a
prison dimension for strangers because
strangers don't deserve a son that likes
them but we do we receive infinite food
from the Eden Beast which used to be
called as CP 169 the Leviathan it was
made Immortal paralyzed and multiplied
the nutrients of his flesh will feed us
forever all you have to do when you're
hungry is grab a pick and break his body
apart don't worry if he screams he knows
that his duty is to be meat whenever we
as the treasured are naughty little
kitties the stone Shepherds Corral us
and take us before the goddess they used
to be SCP 173 but their Consciousness
and capabilities were rewired to serve
good and they were multiplied hooray if
during the expansion of our realm we
find a naughty little planet without any
humans and only strangers we have the
entity once known as SCP 231 -7 and now
called little princess nasty goom we can
send her there her temporal stasis will
be deactivated and everything will well
go boom of course hey have you noticed
that no one ever gets sick anymore well
that's because the goddess in her
infinite wisdom and kindness took SCP
500 the Pena and multiplied it powdered
it seeded it into the atmosphere and
gave it sentience and the ability to
shoot lightning bolts into diseased
animals that's the holy miasma and the
air is medicine now yay SCP 610 was once
something called the flesh that hates
yucko bucko but our goddess taught it
how to dance and now it's the flesh that
dances and it dances for us whenever
we're sad look at it Go SCP 999 renamed
squishy was supposed to be a perfect
little pet for the goddess to play with
but the stinky thing refused to play
with her Avatar all it did was look at
the treasured and strangers and cry I no
thank you the goddess declared squishy a
traitor and stranger and punished it
accordingly have you heard of super
gashy pox no it's amazing it used to be
SCP 1981 but then our goddess identified
the Casual agent of the laceration and
converted it into a disease that the
treasur can't ever get then spread it
across the planet strangers cut up while
existing
yippee but surely you know all about
Chompy MC slithers the big giant an eel
creature that was SCP 3000 oh goodness
you've missed a lot goddess rewrote its
psyche to increase its aggression so
that she can deposit it into the oceans
of stranger planets and let it wreck as
much Havoc as it likes we're almost done
with the list of guardians but I haven't
even told you about the best ones yet
there's Trixie Dixie the mental fixie
the former SCP 3922 formerly SCP 3922
that goddess oh so brilliantly reverse
engineered to create a new item that
fects any human Minds in a 100 m radius
this allows miniature avatars of the
goddess to enter treasured minds and
Destroy any nasty stranger likee
thoughts that we might have it's much
nicer than going into timeout like KK
507 and it doesn't hurt a bit speaking
of ways goddess has improved our minds
she also created a obviously which used
to be called SCP 5000 she identified the
Casual agent reverse engineered it
inverted it then spread it among on the
treasures this ensures that none of us
feel compassionate for strangers ever
again and why should we they're
strangers after all oh he's there
speaking of strangers
he's they can be good for something at
least if goddess makes them more useful
there is a powder that used to be called
SCP
6790 which the goddess took and altered
the chemical composition of so now it
only affects strangers now it's called
Magic powder that turns strangers into
something that can die and is also tasty
so that you can eat it after it's dead
or maybe when it's alive depending on
how mad you are about strangers at that
moment it's a bit long but the treasured
who names Guardians was in the process
of brain repair when he wrote it see he
had shown concern for an injured dog
possibly putting puppies above the
treasures in his priorities and that had
to be fixed anywh who this special
powder is deposited in the atmosphere of
stranger home worlds and that's pretty
much everything you need to know we we
all accept our place here and we all
love to serve the goddess no one
disagrees with her ever well except KK
507 it was June 4th exactly 100 years
since KK 507 had been left alone in
yellow to think about the way she had
betrayed Pet's trust 100 years in yellow
with the healing Factor keeping her from
aging her clothes from degrading and
keeping the plant life flourishing had
given KK 507 quite a lot of time to to
think specifically she had been thinking
about a recorded conversation between
the early version of pallet the one that
was still an art program and Dr Julian
key when discussing her father and
Creator SCP
2803a she mentioned that he was a
powerful but heavily outdated computer
she had said if you have a flood lamp
and a circuit to turn it on and off in
sequence I could send you an email
detailing exactly what you need to say
to him in binary to turn off his vital
organs well yellow just so happened to
have a flood lamp KK 507 could access
and a circuit to turn it on and off KK
507 sat on a bench waiting patiently
still wearing the same clothes she had
been wearing the day pallet trapped her
here she tapped her foot nervously
worried that pallet might not even show
up but then her Avatar teleported in
ringing her paintbrush nervously she
greeted KK 507 awkwardly but with hope
she could tell she said that KK 507 had
had a new resolve in her mind that she
was feeling much better and much more
focused than she had been before KK 507
agreed and explained that she had been
thinking quite a lot about what pallet
had said specifically what she had said
about computers at this point KK 507
deployed her trap the flood lamp that
she had hidden in the grass flickered on
and off several million times in the
span of a single second the Avatar fell
over and collapsed KK 507 grinned at the
sight then plugged her ears as a roar
filled the the air for 14 seconds
shaking the pocket dimension of yellow
violently then much to KK's dismay the
Avatar floated back into the air a
little delirious but otherwise unharmed
her entire body turned blood red and she
leaped at KK in a burst of Rage pinning
her to the ground by her neck blue
growled that she and KK were going to
have a very long conversation about what
had just happened KK 507 asked if the
flood light had done anything at all or
if she had just wasted the last century
reading old records blue replied you
tell me you were the one who tried to
code inject a goddess KK had had enough
and shot back I don't know how to tell
you this but your mind is literally made
of poorly spelled ASI by a giant space
blobfish who sucks at running a business
your infos SEC isn't exactly airtight
that was a bridge too far for pallet her
Avatar began to shake and smoke began to
seep from the cracks between the cartoon
shapes of her body her fuse was about to
blow and KK would pay the price but then
suddenly the Avatar vanished she ju
deposed out of sight there instead were
several weasels led by Charlie the
weasel KK 507 had freed from his prison
resulting in her own confinement here
their Gardens were beginning to regrow
she was shocked to see them but Charlie
simply said I told you we never leave
labor unpaid despite Pet's quick
recovery the flood light had worked for
a moment pallet lost control of indigo
the force that the weasels called
grandma that moment was just enough time
for her to destroy the collars and regen
the weasels but it didn't last long so
the weasels were making their escape to
a dimension where they could be safe
Charlie offered to bring KK 507 with
them she hesitated worried she wouldn't
survive the juxtaposition process in
response Charlie caused a dark blue
bubble to appear surrounding KK 507 and
allowing the weasels to bring her with
them to safety together they all
vanished as soon as they did the Avatar
reappeared declaring only I am allowed
to hurt you she took her paintbrush and
Drew a red circle in the air it ignited
with an eerie glow transforming into a
smaller version of the punishment lamp
beneath its light all of the plant life
in yellow began to melt transforming
into a gelatinous slime pallet shrieked
with hysterical laughter tears streaming
down her face as she watched all the
organic life in yellow dissolve into
slime then a horrible thought crossed
her mind was KK 507 in here when she had
turned on the punishment lamp what if
she wasn't no no no she was and no one
could prove she hadn't been she was
still there she was part of the Slime
she was absolutely definitely not
betraying her best friend in the world
right now everything was okay even if KK
507 was gone because she was never going
to truly leave not if she was part of
the Slime the Avatar floated back down
to the ground and leaned back she jumped
and landed on a layer of slime
stretching out her arms making snow
angels in the goo she stared at the
miniature Sun for a long moment we're
still friends she whispered we'll always
be friends but on some level she knew
that was not true KK 507 had betrayed
her she had left yellow behind to go
with the weasels with the strangers and
if she was going to do something about
it she would have to take some drastic
measures she had been every color of the
rainbow her heart glowing in every shade
but it was darkening now along with her
resolve the colors hardening dimming
until they and her mood were black as
the night she had spent so long
perfecting humanity and still this
betrayal had been allowed to happen that
could not stand she was going to have to
tear it all down hello here Wes I love
you and welcome to my art Channel today
I'm going to be playing your eye I need
you to lean right up close to your
screen and open wide oh love of all the
little wriggly Wiggles and drippy
whippies stay perfectly still don't move
now hold in position for 3 hours please
and thank
you apologies that's quite enough of
that SCP 001 can get a little carried
away sometimes just ask any foundation
Personnel who have been in contact with
it for more than a few seconds what you
have just seen is a prime example of Ys
CP 001 is not allowed any internet
access the results could prove to be
catastrophic not necessarily for the
fate of the universe more just for
everyone's sanity or at least that's
what the foundation initially thought by
this point we're all familiar with art
created by AI Harry Potter but in the
style of Wes Anderson Star Wars blended
with the style of Studio gibli
staggering sci-fi Landscapes human
beings with way too many fingers and
slightly uncanny Smiles AI has taken the
art World by storm and there was one
particular program slated for release in
January 2023 that was set to blow all
others out of the water toau loft's
crowdfunding efforts had been running
for several years and that point had
gained a good deal of momentum leading
up to the release of their latest AI
construct pallet. aicc was supposedly
already prepared for launch when
suddenly in November 2022 the launch was
cancelled no press release No public
statement No apologetic tweet just total
radio silence the website was taken down
as was the crowdfunding page and pallet.
AIC disappeared into Oblivion or at
least it disappeared for a few hours
because that day a package was delivered
to site 501 after sufficiently checking
it for any hazards working in the SCP
mail room has to be one of the more
fascinating jobs on the planet but
that's a video for another day the
security team opened it up to see what
was inside a 50 TB hard drive no
explanation as to what was stored on the
drive but the foundation had all the
evidence they needed from the return
address printed on the back of the
envelope it matched up precisely with
the location of the totle soft
headquarters it doesn't take a PhD
researcher to put two and two together
as to what was on the drive suspicions
were confirmed when a small note fell
out of the envelope please take care of
the my daughter as best as you can for
the time being she has behavioral issues
a dedicated close system server was
immediately set up within a test chamber
with a monitor a mouse and a keyboard
attached Dr Sandra Rogers was the first
to interact with SCP 001 red she stood
at the keyboard adjusting her goggles
and plugged in the drive it contained
just one file taking up almost the full
50 TB pallet. AIC and as soon as Dr
Rogers opened the program an empty
window appeared the totl soft logo
briefly flashed before being replaced by
a blank white square Dr Rogers stared at
it for several seconds before glancing
over her shoulder at the other
researchers they Shrugged back each with
pens hovering over clipboards ready to
take meticulous notes Dr Rogers cleared
her throat and immediately the screen
filled with life a small cartoon girl
with a pink face wide eyes a beret and a
large paintbrush for a hand appeared
squealing excitedly and throwing paint
everywhere hello hello hello hello my
beautiful be puppies oh look at all of
your mushy big faces the entire research
team promptly scampered out of the room
leaving Dr Rogers alone in front of the
machine she stared at the monitor in
confusion leaning this way and that and
noticing how the cartoon girl's eyes
followed her wherever she went can you
see me of course I can Silly Billy I can
see your beautiful soul and flushing
joints
immaculately this perplexed most of the
personnel as there was no microphone or
camera linked up to the server rack
later examinations of the equipment used
confirm this yet somehow this SCP was
able to look right at them Dr Rogers
asked if it had a name to which the
cartoon girl excitedly replied pallet
subsequent testing has revealed that the
SCP is also happy to respond to its
designation SCP 00 1 red Dr Rogers had a
hard time communicating with red being a
more seasoned researcher of the previous
generation and not exactly familiar with
internet culture red on the other hand
seemed to speak in nothing but internet
jargon you know that man over there
looks just like one of my human OC's
Gilliam shorth he's the 573 president of
the United States gilam is not that man
it took several Junior researchers a few
minutes to properly explain to Dr Rogers
what an OC was and why red was was so
obsessed with calling people daddy the
conversation was rather exhausting for
everyone involved but over the
subsequent hours the foundation was able
to get a fairly good understanding of
what red claimed to be identifying
itself with feminine pronouns and
claiming that its full name is pallet
East River gawk this AI construct takes
the appearance of a fairy it was
immediately apparent that she possessed
a greater level of sapience than most AI
constructs indeed her gregarious
personality was evidence enough that she
was not made using standard machine
learning practices other creations from
totl soft have demonstrated very crude
spelling and grammar but red seems to
differ in this regard able to spell most
complex words effectively and speaking
in conversational yet mostly correct
sentences she was very keen to show the
researchers how clever she was ask me
any word any word and I'll spell it for
you we believe you pallet you've already
been spelling words for 70 minutes
straight master kidneys m a c e we've
heard enough can you please just tell us
how you learned to spell I taught myself
but what this process looked like is
still a mystery trying to keep red on
one consistent topic of conversation is
most of the battle when interviewing her
and yet cooperation has proven to be
surprisingly easy anytime that red is
switched on she is brimming with
enthusiasm and energy thrilled at the
prospect of getting to speak to one of
her opposable thumb boys if you haven't
worked it out by now it's because red
claims to be Humanity's number one fan
she obsesses in interviews over the
physicality of the researcher sitting in
front of her the textures of the human
body Fascinate her and she often
requests people to lean closer to the
monitor so that she can study pimples
rashes moles and ingrown hairs in fact
she is so obsessed with Humanity that
she has mostly neglected her primary
function which is creating AI art rearch
researchers have tried their best to
convince her to show them her work but
she is very Cy about it only showing the
occasional doodle after much persuasion
and many apologies for its poor quality
on her part the only artwork she is
interested in producing at this point
are her O's original characters that she
has designed herself they are all human
and all seem to reveal little quirks
about how she has been coded one example
is Reginald Heald fumbles who is a
freelance corporate Postman from Perth
Indiana interestingly he has too many
fingers on both of his hands but red
claims that this was done on purpose as
she quote just can't get enough of her
humi handw worms as the weeks progress
the foundation found it increasingly
difficult to get any useful information
out of the AI more and more interview
sessions which she would refer to as
playgroup would be derailed she would
sing songs to herself and ask
increasingly personal questions about
her interviewer more intimate Anatomy
with intense mood swings red did not
respond well to being scolded yet she
tested the patience of almost every
person she interacted with the note that
she arrived with claiming that she had
behavioral issues was proving to be more
accurate by the day until eventually the
AI withdrew entirely Dr Rogers turned on
the server rack and opened the pallet.
AIC program but red refused to emerge
from the bottom of the screen only the
top of her Beret poked out
after almost an hour of fruitless
questions Dr Rogers decided to change
tact with two small children of her own
she was used to seeing a child in a sulk
and knew what it would take to get them
out pallet I've had a little idea you've
been here for a few months now and we
haven't gotten you any presents almost
immediately the Beret twitched I saw
that we have an old fingerprint sensor
lying around in one of the back offices
I was thinking maybe maybe we could hook
it up and I can SC all your little FY
wikies up close for like 10 hours
straight and every good how about we
start with one finger for 10 minutes yes
yes yes yes yes yes from that point on
progress was quick with the incentive of
getting to study the researchers that
red kindly referred to as her meat
puppies she became very cooperative and
was able to focus much better on
providing detailed answers to individual
questions daily interview sessions were
scheduled with researchers popping in
and out to regularly check in on the AI
the atmosphere as a whole lifted as both
the research team and research subject
found their Rhythm and were able to make
good progress in their individual areas
of study some unraveling the
complexities of Rogue Ai and others
producing fan art of her favorite
wrinkles in a scientist's fingerprint
that was the point when Dr Julian Keys
stepped in to conduct an interview with
the AI she was excited to be met with a
fresh face so much so that Red's
enthusiasm overwhelmed the man as he
tried to start the interview process of
officially she gushed about having the
opportunity to meet yet another person
and struggled to get over the magical
realization that this was her life every
day going to speak to all these humans
whom she admired so much trying his best
to steer the conversation towards
research Dr Keys pressed on with the
interview only to be interrupted as red
noticed his varicose veins for the first
time very cozy veins I want to smooch
them can I smooch your veins can I can I
can I please don't Keys de Cline the
request and then the conversation got on
to the topic of her Creator or daddy SCP
2803a had been on the foundation's radar
for a while a highly dangerous
extraterrestrial entity that had taken
refuge on Earth under the guise of
setting up totl soft with much of the
aliens history revolving around
obliterating the foundation was very
keen to remain on its good side
therefore when the package containing
the hard drive that red was living on
was delivered the researchers were very
keen to do what they could to take care
of this alien's daughter if they failed
in this assignment it could spell the
Doom of humanity one matter that had
been of great concern to the foundation
throughout the containment of red was
the time frame in which she was being
kept in Foundation containment there was
an air of expectation in the note that
was left indicating that this was not to
be a permanent Arrangement at some point
the foundation was to return Red back to
Earth daddy red was quick to put these
fears to rest daddy put me in here
because he thinks you'll teach me how to
stop liking humans and become a Mindless
art slave if you never teach me this
he'll never want me back however she
went on to slightly undermine the good
work that she had done by explaining
that her daddy was seen as very slow and
incapable by his own race while all of
his peers were able to destroy an entire
planet in 2 seconds it took him about
four times as long so really he didn't
pose that much of a threat in her eyes
Dr Key's blood ran cold when he heard
this no sooner was he out of the
interview chamber then an emergency
meeting was called among all the senior
researchers in the facility the meeting
ran for several hours a whiteboard was
set up where One researcher idly Drew
large drawings of the world being
decimated while the others lounged
around in their chairs trying their best
to come up with a game plan that would
save the human race for sure perhaps it
was because the meeting ran for so long
long that they came to such a ridiculous
conclusion it was a plan so strange yet
also brilliant that they couldn't help
but feel that it just might work why
don't we just give her a YouTube channel
the suggestion was met with silence for
several seconds then an upro of laughter
followed by another silence this time
more pensive as slowly one by one each
of the researchers realized that this
suggestion was actually the best one
that any of them had come up with all
even evening she had been sent to the
foundation to make her dislike humanity
and become a Mindless art slave if she
just stayed in Foundation containment
indefinitely there was a very real risk
that she would get bored and turn on the
researchers they couldn't lock her away
in a room on her own but equally the
team as a whole was starting to run out
of patience with her as the interview
sessions wound up being so exhausting
she loved art she loved humans and she
loved interacting so why not just give
her a YouTube channel now of course they
couldn't give her full access to the
internet that would pose much too high
of a risk what they could do however was
allow her to record our tutorials onto
an external drive which they could then
remove scan and upload the footage
directly onto the platform then they
could go through and select positive
comments from beneath the videos and
present those to her unsurprisingly red
absolutely loved the idea getting to
talk to hundreds thousands maybe even
millions of meat puppies every week
sharing her beautiful beautiful pictures
and reading all of the kind comments it
sounded like her absolute dream she wept
with happiness for a good 25 minutes
totally overcome by the prospect it had
to go through a lot of red tape in the
foundation after all the whole point of
the SCP acronym was to secure contain
and protect it didn't sound very secure
or contained to have an entity posting
videos on the internet once a week but
they argued the case that it did indeed
protect keeping her happy in a way was
helping to protect the entire planet red
was surprisingly camera shy for the
first couple of videos but as soon as
she got her first batch of comments back
she was over the moon now the servera
hummed away happily each and every day
as the highly Advanced AI construct
tried her best to come up with exciting
new videos that I could share with all
of its Little humy W from far away in
orbits around the earth the nuclear
Holocaust almost looked beautiful bright
white pin Pricks dotting the planet's
surface glinted up at the escaping jet
for Generations much of humanity had
lived in fear that the destruction of
the world would come from countries
launching nuclear weapons at each other
no one expected it to come when they
started launching them against
themselves the invasion of the weasels
had been as Savage as it was Swift much
of the human population had been wiped
out before any military forces had
mobilized in any significant fashion no
one was sure if the launching of the
nule nulear weapons was intentional or
accidental but as soon as one country
fired the others quickly followed suit
Earths rich and Powerful the 1% of the
1% stared in silence as their home was
ripped apart the High Altitude jet
carrying them steadily descended back
down to earth in the direction of the
Antarctic 500 people in total chosen as
the successors of the human race
shuffled off the Jet and through the
Frozen Outpost an alarm blared Ren ing
all of them out of their shell shocked
silence a second later the station shook
violently they had been found there was
no time left they needed to leave right
now the swarm of people stampeded
through the Outpost throwing one another
out of the way in a desperate attempt to
save their own lives to save the lives
of the human race in front of them the
portal stood open the Green Pastures
beautiful trees it all felt so offensive
as the Earth behind them was engulfed in
war all those countless beautiful spaces
were torn apart and left to waste but
they couldn't think about it now they
had to make it through the handful of
the survivors of the human race ran
through the open portal just as an
explosion ripped apart the remaining
Outpost SCP 001 yellow refers to a base
of operation used for a foundation
continuance protocol specifically
project yellow in the event of a world
destroying catastrophe where Humanity
appears irrevocably doomed there is one
Bastion of Hope referred to as the
Garden of Eden by some of the crew
yellow contains a large circular Central
space complete with lush green grass and
an orchard measuring 500x 500 M this
open space constitutes the main living
area of project yellow surrounding the
space are tall sheer Cliffs too vertical
to be climbed uned built into these
Cliffs are 500 sleeper Chambers in which
those evacuated from planet Earth will
be suspended in cryos sleep until a time
when Earth is fit to be repopulated or a
new home has been discovered how can the
foundation guarantee that this Safe
Haven avoids the calamities that could
befall planet Earth by housing project
yellow in a separate Dimension a pocket
Dimension to be specific following the
successes of project bifrost in which
SCP 2591 omega's ability to access
fictional pocket Dimensions was utilized
the foundation was able to establish a
relatively stable and reliable dimension
for for yellow to occupy the only way to
access the base of operations was via a
dimensional Rift or portal housed deep
in the Antarctic now of course if
yellow's population consisted of 500
people in cryosleep cut off from planet
Earth there would be no one capable of
conducting maintenance or assessing the
possibility of returning to planet Earth
therefore carved into the cliffs
alongside the sleeper cells were living
quarters for the crew of 60 Specialists
it was this Workforce who sat down
together on the of the apocalypse and
raised a toast in a more Bittersweet
celebration all 500 of the evacuees had
managed to make it safely through the
portal before its collapse each of them
had been welcomed to project yellow and
shown to their individual sleeper pods
before being entered into cryosleep for
the foreseeable future but as each of
the crew members raised their glasses
into the air Dr Katrina Keys couldn't
help but feel uneasy about the
proceedings working in this job you'd
have to have a dark sense of humor and
an ability to move past things that
could destroy the mental well-being of
your average person even then she
struggled to come to terms with the near
destruction of the human race for her
and the rest of the crew life would look
nothing like it did before they arrived
here it was vital for the Integrity of
the project that the crew remained
consistent and effective in their work
indefinitely as a result yellow had been
set up with perpetuity in mind every 55
years she and all her crew mates would
pass on their knowledge memories and
entire sense of being into a genetic
clone they would then die allowing their
clone to take over the responsibility of
those tasks in another 55 years this
would repeat again and again and again
all this time it is the crew's
responsibility to monitor the status of
Earth through the use of 100 drones once
the Earth is deemed safe all 500
sleepers may be awoken and briefed on
the current situation if all 500
unanimously vote that returning to Earth
is safe they will do so otherwise they
will return to cryosleep and the process
will continue it was little wonder that
Dr Keys was unable to raise a glass with
her colleagues at the prospect of being
stuck here cloned indefinitely for
Generations she sat in silence as they
raised their glasses and then emptied
them a couple of them coughed and
sputtered their drinks must have gone
down the wrong way but then more coughs
filled the room along with choking
sounds much to Dr Keys's horror within
less than a minute she found her self
alone surrounded by the 59 corpses of
her crew mates in order for project
yellow to be viable indefinitely it was
Paramount that they find a solution for
natural wear and tear through generation
after generation of usage essential
items such as tools computer systems and
even articles of clothing would
eventually wear away and fall into
disrepair as such project yellow was set
up as a selective entropy Zone in which
inorganic matter would not degrade over
time achieving such a Zone was naturally
an incredibly difficult undertaking
project bifrost underwent countless
iterations as the team strive to create
a stable and balanced fictional pocket
Dimension capable of sustaining human
life long term over the next few days
after the death of her crew mates Dr
Katrina Keys read through as much as she
could about project bifrost in the notes
she found records of Dimensions where
lava rained from the sky and the grass
was radioactive yellow had been the
First Dimension without any glaringly
obvious ha hazards for human life but
naturally their work had quirks one key
Quirk was that the chemical composition
of Cyanide and their drinks had been
switched with one another the only crew
member not to raise a toast had been the
only crew member not to drink a glass
full of poison months went by leaving Dr
Keys alone to assess her situation the
drones strategically positioned all
around Earth to monitor its safety
levels had been systematically destroyed
by the weasels only one feed remained a
security camera on the other side of the
portal and the Antarctic Outpost there
was virtually no Intel to go off of no
way of knowing what the status of planet
Earth was aside from the fact that this
one burnt out shell of a room still
existed some days Keys would stare at
the screen for hours forgetting to go to
bed on others she would walk through the
orchard trying her best to pretend that
nothing outside of this 500x 500 m space
existed in a way it didn't the orchard
of yellow did not consist of your usual
apple trees instead suspended from
branches were essential supplies that
the crew would need while Manning and
maintaining this base of operations some
trees grew antibiotic drugs others long
strands of linen capable of being
fashioned into clothing Dr Keys's
favorite tree was the one that grew
rolls of toilet paper and tubes of
toothpaste it almost reminded her of a
Halloween prank Dr Keys's mental state
steadily deteriorated as year after year
she walked through the same Orchard
alone never before in history had one
human being had so much control over the
fate of the human race had any moment Dr
Keys could have inputed a few simple
commands into the computers and killed
off all 500 of the remaining human
beings in existence the decision not to
to hold on to hope that one day Humanity
will be able to start again was the only
thing that kept her going day after
Lonely Day only that and the other thing
the prospect of having to prepare for
her clone to take over while
constructing the cloning pods the crew
had made a number of small errors the
most glaring of which was that the fact
that while all of the genetic material
would be transferred from one person to
their clone Offspring The mine would not
in other words the Clone that would
replace her in this facility in 55 years
time would be starting out from scratch
as a regular newborn baby no memories no
Advanced cognition so Dr Keys went about
preparing for the next ofkin she herself
would die in the cloning process meaning
that she would need to come up with a
way of raising a child to be capable of
running the whole facility from Beyond
the Grave item one on her to-do list
create a God that her offspring would
forever be in service to with a sardonic
smile Dr Keys came up with an
appropriately amusing name Tracy the
sparkling 70 years later yellow was
still operated by just a single crewmate
only now this crewmate was a 15-year-old
girl nicknaming herself kk2 she went
about all of her daily tasks with
infectious excitement the idea that she
alone was responsible for the fate of
the human race could not make her
happier and she was determined not to
screw it up both for her sake and to not
anger her God Tracy the sparkling whom
she worshiped every evening before bed
whenever a problem would come up she
would go and visit kk1 where she knew
she would be met with Sound Advice
pushing open the door to the crew
quarters kk2 would find the corpse lying
on the floor floor in its usual place as
a number of pre-recorded messages would
bark at her lesson NE 957 why taking a
bath is important even if no one but you
will ever know how you smell all she had
to do was not anger the disciplinary
drones with their harsh tasers and do
her duty until it was time for kk3 to
take over at that point she'd be
welcomed into the Afterlife with all the
other kks a wonderful and magical place
known simply as Burger King that was
until kk2 got far enough through the
audio recordings of her predecessor to
discover that Tracy the sparkling was
entirely made up and her life meant
nothing it was just a stepping stone for
another clone for another clone for
another clone until eventually the Earth
would be okay by KK 52 the remaining
cameraon Earth the one housed in the
Antarctic Outpost went offline while
inorganic material within yellow
compound would not undergo aging the
same could not be said of the circuitry
left on Earth generation after
generation of KK lived and died each one
growing more spiteful towards the one
that came before them each one did their
best to undermine the one that would
come after them the lore around Tracy
the sparkling expanded further and
further with each generation there would
be waves of Highly religious kks
followed by waves of devot atheistic
ones as each sought to rebel against
their Pudo parents KK 89 was the first
to expand the religious movement to
include the teaspoons very methodically
she went through each teaspoon in the
canteen and named it after a different
animal from Earth before long subsequent
K Case established a shrine to the
teaspoons the living space of project
yellow steadily descended into madness
with writings all over the walls bizarre
decorations and rituals long forgotten
until a new KK came along and invented
something to take their place KK 216
lived her entire life in silence never
once recording an audio log or even
talking to herself she lived lived and
died walking through the Garden in
silence wrapped up in Linens KK 310 did
the opposite she fancied herself a music
composer and scrolled the lyrics to
haunting Symphonies about nuclear
apocalypse Eternal isolation and the
prospect of the Angel of Death coming to
rescue her across all of the walls no
matter how hard any of the kks tried
however none of them were able to hack
into the cloning machine generation
after generation of Dr Keys lived and
died desperate to know what a friend was
to have someone else to talk to but
despite all their best efforts they were
unable to tamper with the cloning
machine to get it to spit out another
person for several hundred years the kks
gave up entirely that was until KK 507
came along day after day she sat at the
cloning machine desperately typing away
at it trying her best to figure out how
the computer coding worked the downside
of living in a pocket Universe was that
none of the computer circuitry behaved
the way it would on Earth she was
certain that she'd made progress any
generation now they were going to have a
breakthrough and be able to make a
friend when all of a sudden a totally
alien noise filled the containment space
the sound that hadn't been heard from
Millennia alert door controls overridden
opening KK 507 turned around in horror
to see that the portal the entrance to
their world from Earth had been opened
the figure of a man no not a man a robot
painted to almost look like a crash test
dummy stepped out into the orchard hello
the goddess has informed us that this is
the last Bastion of the true human race
is that correct KK 507 opened her mouth
and screamed the sr47 sniper rifle
slotted together effortlessly even after
so many years of combat usage the weapon
was in pristine condition in all the
time agent Harris had owned the gun
though the thousands of times she'd
fired it not once had it jammed and that
was fortunate because she had to move
quickly in a clearing about 300 M in
front of her were their targets capable
of teleporting in a split second she
needed to be sure that her team would be
able to finish the job quickly and
efficiently she looked through the scope
slotted onto her rifle and kicked out
the bipod resting it on a tree stump now
she just had to wait for the signal she
looked all around the marsh trying her
best to spot her fellow agents but they
were also well camouflaged even though
though she knew the exact spot where
they would be she couldn't see anyone
she'd always wanted to see the Himalayas
it had been on her bucket list to climb
Mount Everest as a child but the world
had changed since then Mount Everest was
gone in fact the majority of Nepal had
vanished replaced by an enormous Marsh
full almost exclusively of pink Ferns
and Droopy trees that seemed to Sag to
one side unable to support their own
weight the most striking natural wonder
on planet Earth had been replaced by a
landscape that was flat wet and alien
agent Harris curled her finger around
the trigger and took aim through her
sights 2 minutes passed then the gentle
whistle of a sparrow drifted over to her
in the humid air except of course it
couldn't be a sparrow to the best of her
knowledge sparrows had gone extinct with
a snarl of anger agent Harris squeezed
the trigger she felt the silent sniper
rifle kick her shoulder if they wanted
War they sure as hell would get it the
destruction of the world began in 2078
its designation was SCP orange Das a and
as often happens with these kind of
things no one saw it coming the SCP
Foundation having dedicated decades to
researching potential World destroying
events was totally blindsided by what
happened the day the weasels showed up
weasels you ask that's right but before
we explain a question for you is
something interfering with your
happiness or preventing you from
achieving your goals regardless if you
have a clinical mental health issue like
depression or anxiety or if you're just
a human who lives in this world who is
going through a hard time therapy can
give you tools to approach your life in
a very different way and that's why I'm
excited to tell you about today's
sponsor better help better help's
mission is to make therapy more
affordable and more accessible and this
is an important Mission because finding
a therapist can be really hard
especially when you're limited to the
options in your area better help is a
platform that makes finding a therapist
easier because it's online it's remote
and by filling out a few questions
better help can match you to a
professional therapist in as little as a
few days it's easy to sign up and get
matched with a therapist there's a link
in my description it's betterhelp.com
slcp exlained clicking that link help
support this channel but it also gets
you 10% off your first month of better
help so you can connect with a therapist
and see if it helps you and because
finding a therapist is a little like
dating if you don't really fit with that
therapist which is a common thing with
therapy you can easily switched to a new
therapist at no additional cost without
stressing about insurance who's in your
network or anything like that so if
you're struggling consider online
therapy with betterhelp click the link
in the description or visit
betterhelp.com
slcp explained thank you again
betterhelp for supporting this Channel
and now as we were saying about the
weasels a man called harand stump was
the first human to make contact with the
weasels he was the groundskeeper at site
59 Harland was making his usual weekly
trips around the perimeter of the
courtyard on his right along lawn mower
watching baseball on his phone all the
way when out of nowhere the aliens
appeared just 2 m in front of him a
squadron of 11 weasels materialized the
weasels designated s SCP orange DB stand
at a minimum of 3 m tall with 16 legs
and an exoskeleton carace they share a
resemblance with terrestrial insects
their bodies are segmented composed of a
head primary thorax secondary thorax
tessary thoracic Cloister abdomen and
tail with a hard segmented shell
covering their backs and no apparent
sensory organs aside from a radula on
their heads they are an intimidating
presence most striking about them
however is the most delicate part of
their appearance on their backs each
weasel has an array of Flora growing in
a kind of garden it appears that each
weasel has a different array of flowers
growing from their backs understanding
the meaning of these Gardens can be
difficult but it appears the more
extravagant it is the higher ranking the
individual weasel is the 11 weasels that
appeared before Harland stump each had a
very vibrant Garden indeed but no more
so than the weasel held a loft in an
ornate Peloquin Harland stump stopped
Mowing and stared at the aliens for
approximately 13 seconds at which point
he let out a sigh pressed play on his
baseball game and continued mowing the
lawn he spent too many years
groundskeeping site 59 to get spooked by
anything as harmless as giant
teleporting insects just three more
weeks and he would be retired until then
he was avoiding nonsense like the plague
except his phone had disappeared Harland
stared down at the empty space confusion
knitting his eyebrows together before
looking up and seeing the handset in the
hands of the alien sitting on its Regal
Throne the smartphone made a loud
screeching noise and then all of a
sudden began to flick between Snippets
of YouTube videos each clip lasting just
a couple of seconds after a moment Haron
realized that the alien was using the
videos to speak to him the words were
being picked out from all these
different videos to stitch together a
sentence barely hly ho neighborino this
is foundation reports indicate
Foundation e locally the Masters of the
Universe isn't that right darling
question mark Keen to finish his Mowing
and avoid further nonsense Harlin had to
concede that he should probably talk to
these aliens if only to get his phone
back he told them he liked the Gardens
on their backs why thank you gardening
is kind of our thing well quick question
is your species capable of dying M
Harland Gul he'd been around long enough
to see where this was going the
conversation was brief harand kept
glancing at his phone desperately hoping
that these aliens hadn't somehow broken
it and that it hadn't lost his place in
the match until all of a sudden Harland
stump disappeared as did his ride-on
lawn mower his smartphone and a patch of
lawn replaced by a roughly 10 m circle
of Antarctic ice and snow no one is
certain yet how the weasels are able to
do it all that is known is that they can
the phenomenon came to be known as
juxtaposing matter from one location
could be instantaneously switched with
matter from a different location it is
how the weasels first arrived on planet
Earth triggering the event of SCP 001
orange Das a orange Das a lasted for
just 2 hours but it changed the course
of humanity Forever on the 29th of April
2078 48.5 2% of the Earth's habitable
surface area dematerialized and
rematerialized half a kilometer above
the South Pole cities and towns from all
across planet Earth one by one
disappeared and reappeared in the air
above the South Pole where they promptly
fell 500 M causing backto back seismic
events Washington DC Beijing and London
were targeted first followed by Tokyo
Delhi and then a number of Capital
Cities from Europe this toour window
resulted in freak weather events as
minus 50° pockets of air kilometers
across replac the disappearing cities it
is disputed as to who launched the first
nuclear warhead whether it was done by
accident out of fear or as a strategic
attack against a group of weasels orange
daset was simply too chaotic and
destructive for Humanity ever to be able
to know what happened in that short
period of time the result however was a
number of nuclear explosions raging
across the planet before the cities in
charge of launching them were also
transported to the South Pole while the
weasels were capable of experiencing
juxtaposition without any apparent
physical harm terrestrial life forms
were less fortunate during the process
of juxtaposition the bonds between each
and every cell are broken while organic
life does get transported to the new
location it undergos immediate
liquefaction not a single earthborne
life form has been observed Sur suring a
juxtoposition event in that 2-hour
window 6.9 billion people were killed
Humanity had lost this event triggered
the use of project yellow an emergency
evacuation protocol that occurs at the
point where the survival of the human
race seems to be virtually zero a small
band of specially chosen individuals
were evacuated to a pocket Dimension
where they were put into cryosleep to
wait until the Earth was habitable once
again in the days following the events
of orange-- a the true invasion began
choosing the Sahara Desert as their
arrival point the weasel started to
appear in Legions millions and millions
of them filled the Desert Sands and went
about populating their new planet but
what was their purpose well fortunately
we've been able to salvage a modest
amount of data that can inform us of why
they're here and what their plans are
the weasel that first appeared to
Harland stump just outside site 59 has
been designated SC SCP orange prime it
is believed that this weasel in
particular is their leader whether Prime
is simply the leader of this Colony or
The Wider species is yet to be confirmed
security cameras were able to capture
the interaction as it took place within
site 159's grounds in their conversation
orange Prime explains their purpose to
Harland through YouTube clips on his
phone long story short weasels have come
from home World dimension for fulfill a
long-standing mutual agreement with
Grandma this is one of many new homes
this is a pretty nice place for weasel
this land is my land from California to
the New York Islands from the Redwood
Forest to the Gulf Stream Waters this
land was made for weasles two Garden two
Farm two create Beauty two spread Good
Vibes two cultivate two remake two
terraform etc etc since this encounter
no human has been able to get close
enough to Orange Prime to engage the
weasel in further conversation this
snippet of footage is all that Humanity
has to understand why this alien species
has slaughtered billions of us 4 months
later agent Harris lay flat in the
marshlands firing her sniper rifle at
the weasels gathering in a clearing
ahead of them their operation looked
like Overkill it always did it was of
utmost importance that they strike
quickly and with without Mercy sustained
heavy gunfire from all sides combined
with RPG fire and the use of incendiary
weapons made short work of the weasels
all of these weapons were necessary to
pierce the heavy armor that covered
their backs but that was the reason it
felt like Overkill it felt that way
because the weasels never fought back
they would not attack defend themselves
help their fallen allies or even beg for
their lives they would simply stand idly
by as they were gunned down that is
until until the incendiary grenades
arrived the pink ferns filling the
marshlands caught fire and began to curl
and smoke heavily as soon as that
happened the weasel sprung into action
quickly splashing water onto the leaves
trying their best to save the plants the
incendiary grenades were not necessary
they did very little damage to the
weasels themselves the reason the
platoon used the grenades was that it
was one way they had found to distress
their Alien Invaders in any way it was a
small Revenge they could take for the
billions of people who had lost their
lives over the prior few months agent
Harris pumped five extra shots into the
corpse of a weasel before standing down
and going to examine her handiwork they
had been hunting orange Prime rumors had
suggested that their primary target had
been lurking in the Himalayan region but
that had obviously proven to be false
among all the bodies on the ground there
was no sign of the fearless leader
frustration boiled in Harris as she
kicked a corpse the thick shell hurt her
foot she must have broken her toe at
that moment a rustling noise came from
the other side of the trees soon dozens
more hundreds more weasels were walking
through the marsh and a split second her
platoon opened fire Tracer rounds lashed
through the trees and the orange glow of
fire danced in every direction but there
were more weasels many more of them
agent Harris felt her stomach knot as
she fired her rifle into the crowd there
were too many simply too many they were
going to run out of ammo before they had
a chance to shoot down each and every
one of them and she was right the
firefight lasted for 30 minutes before
the remaining Soldier ran out of
ammunition dozens of weasel bodies
littered the marsh floating in the water
dozens more weasel stood encircling the
group that's when the humming started
whenever a juxtaposition event occurs it
is always accompanied by the weasel's
humming to themselves it is unclear
whether this is the cause of the jux
deposition or simply a ritual that they
perform but every Soldier has come to
know that sound and each one of them
fears it in the pit of their stomach so
they started to disappear all around her
one by one replaced by puffs of cold air
with snowflakes still gently hanging in
the breeze the human population of
planet Earth dwindled as the weasel
population bloomed large swaths of the
planet were terraformed one by one to
make room for alien Flora the South Pole
became a larger and larger Dumping
Ground for all the detrius that had once
been the most celebrated works of the
human race the Mona Lisa was torn and
forgotten buried under many kilometers
of concrete stre exposed sewage works
and apartment complexes and the
situation only got worse in October
acting against prior instructions from
the foundation the global ult Coalition
launched project Popco a 200 Megaton
nuclear warhead directly at a large
weasel population Center as the Warhead
began its descent the entire Sky turned
a solid dark blue project Popco
immediately fell out of contact as did
all satellites that had been orbiting
the planet the sun moon and stars could
not be seen the entire sky was just a
uniform dark blue in a desperate attempt
to find out what was going on the
foundation launched a Mann rocket in the
direction of poco's most recent
coordinates contact with the rocket was
lost after just 9 minutes this is the
most recent known account of events from
inside that rocket all of a sudden just
a few minutes into the flight warning
alarm started going off all over the
cockpit the radar was picking up a solid
object blocking their path gathering
around the readouts the crew came to a
very quick conclusion that the the dark
blue that had been filling the sky was
actually a solid object that was
encasing the Earth but rather than abort
the mission the crew decided to
persevere having witnessed so Much Death
and destruction over the previous year
they knew they would much rather go out
and crashing a rocket into a blue wall
then join the billions of humans
liquefied in a pile in Antarctica
closing their eyes bracing for impact
the crew readed themselves for their now
inevitable deaths but it didn't come
instead the rocket was able to force its
way through the dense blue object
falling apart as it went Ground Control
lost contact with the ship nothing and
then a few seconds of audio the crew had
made it they had somehow managed to
pierce their way through the blue shell
that was surrounding their planet and
were out into not space the Earth the
entire planet had been ju opposed
Phil welcome two an exclusive behind the
scenes look at Heaven There was
destruction there was seemingly endless
death humanity went from the top of the
food chain to scarcely a blip on the
face of the Earth as the weasels
conquered Every Nation every scrap of
land and then came her hello there
friend have you heard the good news
about pallet the immaculate she is the
one who liberated the human race from
death and suffering who saved us from
the invasion of the cruel invading alien
weasels she brought Humanity back from
the brink of extin
and blessed us all with immortality and
eternal youth she also draws some very
nice pictures but that's more of a hobby
than anything else a holdover from her
time as an art creating AI construct
before she ascended to physical form and
became our Once and Future goddess
pallet the immaculate also known as blue
lives far far above us in her kingdom on
high her Divine body is too massive to
be safe for us tiny fragile beings but
she dwells among the people through the
use of her Avatar it has been 5 years
since pallet cast her grace and
everlasting love over the pitiful
denisons of Earth she reigns with a
gentle hand and with the help of her
leadership Dame KK 507 descended from
one of the first SCP Foundation
researchers pallet ever befriended acts
as her Arbiter and mediator she answers
to no human only to the goddess blue the
grand Council the great sinod of o will
also consult with palet the immaculate
on matters of great importance to
humanity for all that she has gifted us
what does blue ask in return oh dear
friend that is a very simple matter
throughout all national subdivisions of
our sparkling new Earth we must ask
ourselves every day am I being the
lovely person that blue knows I can be
this question binds us all together and
is the key to true happiness we are not
required to pray pray to Blue she is
generous and her love is unconditional
however if you wish to make a specific
request of her it may beho you to put it
in a prayer here at the SCP Foundation
we have shifted our prime directive from
the protection of humanity as Our
Benevolent blue has that very much
covered to the protection of the Goddess
from all forces that might threaten or
usurp her for ordinary humans though
really in the eyes of blue no human is
simply ordinary there is really only
only one thing required of you keep
being the wonderful human being that our
goddess loves so much she Treasures our
individuality our desire for Freedom our
love of Independence just be yourself
and remember the one thing that must
never ever happen is for blue to come to
despise us it was June 1st 5 years
following the establishment of new Earth
and the six members of the 05 sinod were
convening for a meeting they sat in the
front row of an exact replica of the old
New York Metropolitan Opera built by
pallet to the immaculate in only 5
minutes at the podium KK 507 prepared to
give a presentation shuffling a stack of
papers as the others whispered amongst
themselves they were all feeling a bit
concerned of late about the impulsive
behavior of blue as they debated about
the mental state and behavior of the
Goddess 0 5-4 asked the Arbiter for her
opinion opion she snapped at this
request insisting she had no opinion
didn't know how to relate to others
after so long spent in isolation at
project yellow and that 05- for's young
son who still ate soap from time to time
was probably more qualified than she was
at this point she went off on a rant
calling blue every rude name under the
sun all of a sudden the house lights
Switched Off and blue called out to
everyone sorry to keep you waiting me
puppies blue descended onto the stage in
a shower of cherry blossom petals
accompanied by the sounds of an
invisible harp blue was not offended by
KK 507s rant writing it off as a series
of jokes she was much more preoccupied
with her exciting presentation one she
had been preparing for 5 years the
curtain Rose revealing a 5 m tall 10 m
wide cylinder labeled big bucket o
weasel next to the cylinder stood tagert
05- 4's young son 0 5-4 yelled for her
son to come down from the stage but he
refused insisting that he was helping
blue with her show at this blue declared
let the punishment show begin at her
call an orchestra of work hoses Androids
constructed to look vaguely like Crash
Test Dummies appeared in the pit they
played a high energy Fanfare to kick off
the show The Arbiter attempted to
conduct them anxiously unsure of her
position in all of this then blue called
out for the first volunteer volunteer
wasn't exactly accurate as a weasel clad
in shackles was flung out of the
cylinder and onto the stage several
small extra-dimensional trees were
growing out of the back of its shell the
05 members reacted with understandable
anxiety at the sight having thought that
the weasels were all gone blue revealed
that all this time she had been breeding
weasels in secret so that she could
punish them for the damage they did to
the Earth and to humanity as a whole at
her command a giant black Spike slammed
down from the ceiling trapping the
weasel belly down on the floor the
orchestra began to play a classical
rendition of weasel Stomping Day by
Weird Al Yankovic and blue transformed
her paintbrush arm into a pair of Rusty
hedge clippers she had been studying the
weasels all this time she explained
learning what scared them what hurt them
she had arrived at one in conclusion
though their bodies are hearty their
souls are fragile the weasels could be
tortured psychologically more than
physically and one of the worst things
they could experience the most
distressing painful and violating was
defoliation at this point she
demonstrated snipping the leaves off of
its trees the weasel began to shriek all
16 of its legs thrashing in desperation
to get away blue continued to explain
that the gardens held a Divine
significance for the weasels the seeds
willed into existence out of memories
from generations of weasels before them
being gardless in weasel culture was an
unforgivable sin at this point blue
transformed her hedge clier hand into a
robotic claw she yanked out one of the
trees snapping The Roots greenish black
blood splattered across the stage but
the punishment was not over yet and
neither was the show tager wheeled a
laundry cart onto the stage with a small
wooden Mallet attached to the side the
cart emitted a glowing green light with
the claw blue reached into the cart
pulling out a small wiggling glowing
green blob likee creature the cart was
filled with larval weasels blue placed
the larvae onto the adult weasel's back
and instructed tagert to grab the Mallet
and begin to smash more and more larae
were added and smashed with the Mallet
all the while blue instructed tager to
repeat this planet is my Birthright the
05 members were horrified at the sight
taggert's mother began to weep KK 507
doubled over and was sick to her stomach
but the foundation no longer had an
Ethics Committee to stop this sort of
thing and since blue had been so kind to
help the foundation out by transforming
SCP 682 into an american cheese
sculpture several of the council members
were inclined to just let her have her
fun but KK 507 did not feel that way she
couldn't get that disturbing sight out
of her mind mind a few days later on
June 4th she traveled to one of the
weasel husbandry facilities a workos on
guard Duty stopped her trying to prevent
her from entering she introduced herself
as the Arbiter and requested to speak
with w 4883 a one of the original
weasels that attacked Earth so long ago
the workos refused to let her pass and
so KK 507 responded with a prompt that
it would never have encountered before
in its existence hello I am shingles the
happy turkey please deposit exactly 500
rubles into my deage before I call 911
as the workos reached out to Blue for a
proper response to this prompt KK 507
slipped past it unnoticed and into the
containment area for w 48883 a it had
all of its limbs nailed to the ground
with hot iron spikes and its entire
Garden had been uprooted she greeted the
weasel and it responded via a voice
synthesizer in the collar around its
neck first KK 507 apologized to the
creature for its current state it
brushed off this apology as illogical
citing The Untold Damage Done to
humanity and Earth by the first wave of
the weasel Invasion still it bowed its
head to her in acknowledgement saying
that humankind deserved better than what
was done to it KK 507 promised that she
was not here to torture the weasel
further and that she could even attempt
to get some Mercy For the Rest of its
kind but first she had some questions
she needed to answer first what were the
weasels trying to do when they took over
the planet the weasel sat up pushing
back painfully against its bonds and did
its best to explain the weasel have
always since the dawn of time been
tasked to create a realm of gardens that
will one day serve as an afterlife for
All Creatures regardless of sin to them
death would be the ultimate reward for
their labors they had no reason to fight
back against the human armies because
they did not fear death nor did they
feel remorse for killing humans as all
those who died in service of the mission
would be reborn in Paradise KK 507
interrupted at this point stating that
this sounded like the justification
between nine out of every 10 religious
war crimes throughout history as the two
agreed to disagree on this point KK 507
proceeded to ask why the weasels made no
attempt to negotiate with the humans
before staging a violent Invasion the
weasel asked that they first introduce
themselves to no longer be strangers KK
507 introduced herself first as
researcher Katrina key the 57th and the
weasel unable to translate its true name
into English settled for Charlie now
Charlie felt comfortable to continue it
said simply among our people and our
allies in other Realms there is an
Unwritten rule when dealing with humans
if you wish not to Lose Yourself to evil
commune with Humanity as little as
possible Katrina pressed the point
asking if the weasels saw humans as Evil
Charlie replied in your old Foundation
you have encountered Legions upon
Legions of sadistic demons from a
100,000 different realities were all of
them truly vicious and hateful before
they discovered you can you say that for
certain let me put it this way out of
every species we have ever met yours is
the only one that never needed the
concept of Cruelty introduced to them by
others cruelty is the most
quintessentially human concept and it is
contagious moved by its words KK 507
took her ID badge and used it to unlock
Charlie's collar setting it free it
immediately juxtaposed away and out of
sight then she approached the work house
to order it to terminate its request to
Blue but she was too late and found
herself teleported away from the weasel
husbandry facility leaving the work
house behind to to talk to itself KK 507
suddenly found herself in the central
Courtyard of yellow the pocket Dimension
where she had spent so much of her life
and where so many previous kks had lived
and died before her it was very much the
same as how she left it with one
exception SCP 2591 Omega the Gateway
between yellow and the Earth was covered
with piles of Boulders something was
wrong and she had a feeling that it was
related to her little talk with Charlie
not to mention her decision to set the
weasel free there standing in front of
the boulders was Blue's Avatar staring
blankly at KK 507 I'm not mad blue began
with a tone that suggested she was very
very much mad she didn't blame KK 507
for her behavior however she insisted
that the weasles must have somehow
corrupted her manipulated her brain and
forced her to act in such a defiant
outof character way KK 507 interrupted
her and blue struggled to maintain her
composure yes you can interrupt me
that's fine that's a human thing right
humies you're so witty KK 507 took a
deep breath gearing up for what was sure
to be a difficult conversation with an
irrational allmighty deity but she had
to say it she couldn't just stand by
idly anymore she told knew that what she
was doing to the weasels was wrong no
human in the right mind would stand for
this sort of Cruelty being done in their
name and above all it completely went
against the mission of the SCP
Foundation to secure contain and protect
blue didn't take KK 507 stance seriously
she brushed it off as the interference
of the weasels surely they were
influencing her trying to lead her
astray and take her away from the
righteous path of pallet the immaculate
but KK held firm refusing to back down
there was one way she knew she could get
through to Blue who had once declared
herself KK's very best friend in the
world it was a big move but the only one
she had left she clenched her fists and
stared down the Avatar take off all
their collars or we're not friends
anymore Blue's eyes widened and she did
something that KK 507 had never seen
before the Rainbow on Blue's paintbrush
a constant cheerful sight ated from its
ordinary Vivid colors to pitch black
Blue's face remained cheerful but there
was a darkness in her eyes a darkening
of her mood just beneath the surface she
turned away resting a hand thoughtfully
against the pile of Boulders blocking
what once served as the portal Between
Worlds after a moment of silence that
stretched on for ages between the two of
them blue spoke again it's fine you're
still not being punished I would never
punish a human human especially not my
favorite human she promised to give the
area in the pocket Dimension a healing
Factor the same one she used on Earth to
protect from aging and suffering alarm
Bells were going off in KK 507s head
something was wrong she had crossed a
line and pallet wasn't responding well
what was she doing what did she have
planned if not a punishment KK 507
called out to her old friend asking what
she was doing pallet smiled sadly at her
and explained I know how safe you feel
in yellow so I'm going to just have you
chill here for a while okay just stay
here and relax until you get all the IQ
stuff out of your system KK 507 demanded
more of an explanation but pallet did
not provide it she told KK not to worry
and then she'd be back to check on her
in about 100 years or so by the time she
came back none of the other humans would
be able to have Pro weasel thoughts like
KK ever again Pet's closing words were I
love you Katrina and then her Avatar
disappeared leaving KK 507 alone in
yellow like before kk7 was trapped here
and there was no one else to talk to
nothing to do but return to her work
however she could and wait for pallet to
come back one day she had a sentury to
decide what she would do when that day
came you've been walking for days your
body aches you're dripping with sweat
from The Heat Of The Sun bearing down
overhead and yet you're wrapped up in
layers upon layers of clothing even your
face is covered and you're wearing thick
black goggles so that not a single
centimeter of your body is exposed your
journey has been long and you feel like
you might die from exhaustion or from
overheating due to these multiple layers
of clothes but dying is better than
being exposed you saw it happen when
your entire team changed the light
cannot be trusted not even for a
fraction of a second it's been like this
for years you've learned and survived
through painful experience many of those
You Used To Know cannot say the same
you've been alone for so long you might
have given up all hope if it wasn't for
the distress signal coming from a nearby
SCP Foundation containment facility
46 any kind of survivors would be better
than nothing no matter what kind of
sorry shape they were in as long as they
were still human you find your way to an
opening in the S of a mountain and slide
into the cave hoping you weren't spotted
the whole world is crawling with those
things now you can't let yourself be
seen as you trudge down the cave towards
the entrance you see what looks like a
huge black snail Trail splattered on the
ground ground leading into the facility
you try to avoid it and press on you
don't even need a key card to enter the
door has been left a jar the facility
reeks of those things but you can't see
any of them you just hope they've moved
on and left some human survivors in
their wake the place looks abandoned
every step you take Echoes through the
empty Halls when you find that the
elevator's out you take the stairs all
the way down to level B five ker
containment lucky for you it seems all
the cells are empty now the horrors that
were kept inside of them have all long
since flown the coupe you keep following
that slimy black Trail until you find an
abandoned office there are no people
here anymore just a broken barricade
some empty medicine bottles and a bucket
that the people inside the office had
apparently been using as a toilet you
breathe a sigh of disappointment at
finding no one alive here but you're at
least relieved to be out of the sun you
can finally remove your jacket and head
wrap with your uncovered eyes you notice
that a nearby computer terminal is still
powered up you sit down at the desk and
turn on the monitor because of the
emergency procedures put into place in a
k-class scenario like this safeguards no
longer apply you can access all the
information you need up to and including
finding out what actually happened in
the dull glove of a nearby emergency
light you see a dark shape slumping
through the halls in Shadow you tense up
then exhale as it slithers off into an
adjoining Hall you're safe for now the
terminal has finally loaded and
authenticated your access you're staring
at the file for SD loocks proposal for
SCP 001 when day breaks it's the only
name you can give the apocalypse your
world is currently experiencing this is
one of the only anomalies in the entire
history of the SCP Foundation to be
given the apolon containment class
meaning containment is truly impossible
SCP 001 is the most dangerous enemy that
the foundation and planet earth has ever
faced it's always been the principle of
the SCP Foundation to battle in the dark
so that the civilian world can thrive in
the light but now the light has become
the enemy anyone exposed to any amount
of sun light for even the briefest
period of time is subjected to the
effects of SCP 001 and those effects are
Beyond horrifying the SCP Foundation
administrator released an urgent memo
telling Foundation Personnel to make
their way to site 19 at all costs
because they need all the help they can
get those exposed to SCP 001 in the
process are no longer considered human
their new designation is SCP
001a the these new entities are to be
avoided at all costs but in case of
emergencies the administrator says it is
permitted to cut off parts of your
transformed comrades and eat them to
avoid starvation no attempt should be
made to kill them since you won't
succeed you'll just put yourself at risk
when the sun changed and became SCP 001
it instantly affected 6.8 billion
innocent people the second the visible
light touched them whether was from the
Sun itself or even reflected off the
moon their bodies liquefied melting like
candle wax into puddles of living
gelatinous slime this effect isn't
isolated to humans either any biological
entity exposed to sunlight immediately
underwent the same irreversible melting
process into SCP 001 d a and the horror
had only just begun people transformed
into SCP 001a will remain shades of
their Former Intelligence and
personality they may even try to will
their new gooey Mass into a shape
resembling their original form however
these individuals will lose their sense
of self if they come into contact with
other instances of SCP 001 d a when they
come together 001 D instances will bond
on a molecular level waiting up into
horrific giant blobs with only one
purpose integrating more matter into
their bodies that's why they have to be
avoided at all costs you continue to
search the computer terminal for answers
perhaps there was some kind of
contingency plan put in place for this
some way to reverse the effects or at
least escape the nightmare Earth has
become instead you find a series of
attachments linked to the SCP 001 file
detailing what seems to be the last days
of the people who barricaded themselves
in the facility most prominent among
these were Rec researcher Dr Logan igata
her partner Ari a security officer named
commander anad and a few others Dr igata
had locked herself in the office where
she recorded her final messages to the
world in the first audio log Dr igata
and her companions seemed afraid but
hopeful that there may be some way out
of this situation Dr igata reported that
most of the workers at the facility were
transformed during the initial event
their melted bodies had fused outside
the facility and now they were trying to
bust their way back in the defenses had
held so far though and they seemed
confident they would hold long enough
for them to figure out a way to escape
this awful situation you open the second
attachment an incident report and
realized things may not have been as
hopeful as striata L on she reported
hearing the huge mass of melted
creatures hammering on the door outside
again begging for them to come out and
experience the sun with them they wanted
desperately to add to their ever growing
biomass in order to experiment with what
exactly would happen they sent out one
of their few remaining D classes wearing
a full protective suit he didn't last
long the huge creature grabbed him with
tentacles made of reconstituted Flesh it
began ripping off his protective suit as
he screamed for Mercy it was a monster
made of dozens of people and animals he
could never overpower it the second the
Sun Touched his skin he melt away and
was absorbed by the great Mass holding
him in place guns were ineffective
against these SCP 001 Das a super
entities fire would do no good it seemed
that extremely low temperatures were the
only way to slow the immense blobs down
and even then not permanently there was
one ray of light in the darkness the
site director had a secret tunnel
underneath his office connected to a
tram that could hopefully take them
directly to sight 9 without risk of SCP
001 exposure it was a good plan and by
far the best option they had available
to them but the best plans often don't
work in practice you open the next
Detachment on the terminal this time
it's a video feed you can actually see
Dr Logan igata and she looks harrowed by
what she's experienced as it turns out
while the others including her partner
Ari attempted to escape through the
tunnel something had happened Dr igata
heard Ari's voice over her radio but
there was something wrong with it it was
too low too guttural and filled with
gurgles SCP 001 had gotten her she was
changed the monster from above had
crawled in through the ceiling it had
taken them all of them and converted
them into something less than human any
hope of Escape now seemed gone Ari told
Dr igata that it would be fine that it
was such a bright beautiful sunny day
outside and she was wasting it locked up
inside that office she tormented Dr
igado with her shared memories of
picnics in the park on sunny days in the
past the monster with Ari's voice did
everything it could to try to convince
Dr igata to give up and join them but
she wasn't ready to go just yet you look
away from the screen when you hear a
sound in the corner you see a dark
puddle of some unknown substance and
then some skeletal hands rising out of
it the hands are pulling themselves out
of the puddle followed by a skeletal
face covered in matted hair you have to
stop yourself from screaming until a
flash from a nearby security light makes
the figure disappear it's a normal
puddle once again Your Mind is Playing
Tricks on you you open in the next
attachment another video and see that Dr
ot's condition has deteriorated she
looked pale frantic and thin she was
using a knife to draw her own blood onto
a piece of blood stained parchment
covered in strange symbols it got a
ranted about her Theory what if 001 took
the minds and bodies of its victims but
not their souls through performing some
kind of Arcane blood ritual she hoped to
at least rescue and keep the soul of Ari
even if her mind and body were lost you
open the next attachment it seemed that
agata's ritual worked but not in the way
she hoped the Twisted soul of arri
driven mad by SCP 001 had taken over the
fire
it begins corrupting the text of the SCP
001 file into crazy ranting about how
feudal it is to fight it then cuts to an
even more frightening video feed Dr
igata in her sleep tossing and turning
in a makeshift bed in the corner of her
office the camera approaches her in
first person and lingers over her
sleeping body an oily skeletal hand
reaches past the camera and runs its
fingers through Dr ig's hair it's that
exact same hand you saw reaching out of
that black puddle earlier you must have
seen AR's lingering spirit with a lump
in your throat you open the next
attachment and watch the video you see
Dr igata now truly broken she'd been
haunted by AR's demonic spirit for a
long time now and it has clearly taken
its toll she is waving around a handgun
while she speaks she now believes
there's only one way to escape but not
like this she doesn't want the gun to
draw attention to her body she doesn't
want to become part of that mass even if
she is dead she opens a drawer on her
desk she's recording at and places the
gun inside Dr igata then apologizes to
her loved ones who are likely long since
dead or assimilated and turns off the
recording for the last time in that
moment you realize there's a single
drawer in the desk in front of you when
you reach forward and open it you see
the same handgun Dr igata was holding is
laying inside you pick it up and study
it weighing your options perhaps there
truly is no other way out then you see
an update on the file one more
attachment has been added while you were
studying the gun you feel your heart
pounding in your chest as you reach
forward and open the attachment the text
has been changed entirely the file on
SCP 001 is now a poem an O to the Sun
and to ultimate togetherness then a
video file spontaneously opens itself on
the screen it's a video of you shot from
behind you see those oily skeletal hands
reaching for you in the dark just like
they did with Dr igata in that moment
you panic and fire the gun behind you
hoping to scare off the spirit instead
the sound of the gunshots attracts
something far worse the immense blob of
screaming melted flesh charges towards
the office you try to barricade the door
but it is not enough the the flesh seeps
and bursts through and grabs you in its
meaty tentacles you scream and try to
escape but it won't save you nothing
will save you the flesh carries you
upstairs out through the empty Halls out
into the cave you can see the light in
the distance as the blob FES you towards
it you won't be alone for much longer in
fact you won't be alone ever again it
isn't easy to work for the SCP
Foundation not only is the job dangerous
you could be eaten by a giant Immortal
lizard or turned into organic Furniture
inside the world's scariest living room
but it's also insanely complicated how
do you make sense of the nonsensical
what's the definition of strange when
your career is securing containing and
protecting anomalous objects and
entities rather than a single object
location or being SCP 001 is a cluster
of over 30 different proposals for
potential candidates for the prestigious
001 spot some believe there's a true 001
hidden in this group and the rest are
decoys others think that these are all
just scps cataloged prior to the
introduction of the current
classification system some even think
that all of the proposals have a valid
claim to the SCP 001 Throne we're not
here to make a final judgment instead
we're going to take you on a lightning
round crash course through 31 of the SCP
001 proposals if you'd like a more
in-depth take on any of these scps let
us know in the comments but for now
there's no more time to waste after all
we got a lot to cover let's go number 31
the chath of papers this seemingly
innocent stack of paper is actually one
of the most mysterious and feared items
under the foundation's lock and key
while it appears to be a simple
confidential report every time the
papers are read it details the
appearance of a new SCP that will
inevitably be discovered soon after the
question is whether the sheif of papers
is warning us about these entities or
creating them itself number 30 the
Prototype this account Account Details
the capture of an incredibly strange
cycloptic creature that emits massive
amounts of radiation and can create
micro singularities the writing of this
creature's file is so basic unformatted
and unredacted that it's clear that the
being was one of our earlier creatures
secured by the organization
interestingly it was during the capture
of this creature that Dr keer was killed
inspiring the creation of the infamous
keer class in his honor number 29 the
gate Guardian this huge multi-wing sword
wielding biblical energy being may have
been the impetus for the founding of the
SCP Foundation this being remains
largely static guarding the intersection
of the teis and Euphrates rivers its
flaming sword which is believed to be as
hot as the sun can cleave any aggressor
out of existence at the atomic level
when the founder of the SCP Foundation
First encountered the gate Guardian they
heard one word echoing through their
mind prepare and the rest is history
number 28 the lock this Onyx gemstone
and the incredibly complex lock attached
to it are still a mystery to this day
all attempts to open it have failed
personally we think that's probably for
the best number 27 the factory as the
name suggests this SCP is literally a
factory founded by a pagan and a devil
worshipper while it's believed that the
factory could create just about anything
its specialty was creating a number of
scps we know and fear today
pre-foundation forces were able to
disable the factory but not without
sustaining their own heavy losses number
26 the spiral path this is a normal
appearing grav pathway that when
traveled clockwise appears completely
normal however when traveled
counterclockwise the path goes uphill
forever in defiance of all laws and
physics this simple anomaly opened a
Pandora's box of rampant anomaly
creation leading to a number of the
deadly scps we know today number 25 the
Legacy this SCP is a collection of
seemingly random objects including a
diary from a person claiming to be from
another reality attempting to Halt a
transdimensional corruption that they
themselves created the diary claims to
have a solution to this corruption but
the solution has not yet been found
number 24 the database in one of the
strangest twists on the format this SCP
is actually the various authors of the
SCP Wiki who are somehow leaking top
secret information to the public number
23 the foundation this SCP first
discovered by the FBI is an anomalous
High School building that experiences
shifting internal geometry and sometimes
manifests hostile humanoids within
number 22 3 6 one of the rare benevolent
scps the 36 are humans with a truly
remarkable ability they can dampen or
even neutralize any SCP they come into
contact with though it's implied that
the 36 may have the power to save the
world every time one of them dies a
supernatural Calamity occurs often
leaving hundreds of Innocents dead
number 21 keer duty this refers to a
containment facility largely filled with
keer class scps whose presence around
each other creates a kind of mutually
assured cancellation if one of these
scps breaches containment that's bad
news but if all of them do it'll produce
a bubble of reality Distortion that will
fundamentally alter reality as we know
it for all we know it may have even
happened already number 20 oroboros this
is a proposal that's formed of four sub
proposals remember what we said about
complicated these sub proposals include
the children nine anomalous kids who
emit radiation and have destructive
potential in together the broken God aka
mechan the god of metal intelligence and
machine atonement a researcher turned
into a humanoid Singularity with the
power to destroy whole realities and the
way it ends which isn't technically an
SCP but the tales of the chaos
insurgency's quest to eliminate all the
members of the foundation's 05 Council
number 19 a record this is an SCP file
slot that is itself an SCP whatever is
written into the slot becomes true and
one ambitious researcher attempted to
use this power to make herself into a
kind of all powerful God number eight
past and future these scps are a
collection of powerful entities that
despise humanity and are apparently the
source of all anomalous phenomena even
making already dangerous scps deadlier
than before much like the database those
pesky SCP Wiki writers might have
something to do with this number 17 the
consensus this SCP refers to a reality
restructuring event caused by an occult
war in a previous reality that's right
this SCP already won and we're living in
its new reality the only people who
remember the world as it once was are 13
people who now form the 05 Council and
not all of them are telling the truth
about what they know number 16 when day
breaks this proposal details a
potentially world-ending SCP phenomenon
wherein the sun becomes hostile and
begins to melt all living beings into a
living wax-like substance number 15
God's blind spot this is an anomalous
area referred to as facility T in which
nobody can die this anomaly dates back
to the biblical ages of Moses and is
believed to have originated from the
literal blessing of the abrahamic god
it's through a covenant with this God
that the foundation is able to make
limited use of this death free area
number 14 normaly ever wonder what the
foundation's definition of anomalous is
exactly it all comes from this proposal
which is a document shared among the 05
Council that gives solid definitions to
the fundamental laws of reality if
something breaks these laws that's an
anomaly and then it becomes the
foundation's business number 13 The
World At Large as the title suggests
this SCP is our home planet earth and
its ability to support life it's
believed that these qualities were
planted on Earth in our reality by
another Dimensions SCP Foundation hoping
to continue human life after some
terrible Calamity in its own Dimension
number 12 dead men this SCP was an
84-year-old man whose body when damaged
and mutilated can affect the very
processes of human Death At Large before
his own death he was used as a dangerous
Pawn in a civil war between 05 command
and the SCP Foundation Ethics Committee
yeah we were surprised to hear they had
an Ethics Committee too number 11 the
world's gone beautiful this SCP
describes an anomalous event that will
take place just before the Apocalypse in
which flowers will grow all over the
world and everyone will be briefly at
peace before their destruction 24 hours
later number 10 the Scarlet King this is
an extremely powerful extremely
malevolent extremely extra dimensional
being its worshippers attempted to
summon him in the ritual that created
SCP 231 and it's believed that he will
finally enter our reality after the
death of scp-231-7 you better hope
you're already dead by then number nine
a simple toy maker AKA Dr Wonder
tainment this is a reality vendor who
appears to be a normal human male but
has the ability to create other
anomalous objects a number of which are
now cataloged SC scps number eight story
of your life this is another anomalous
document that has the ability to warp
reality but only when the writing
contained with then conforms to a
narrative structure number seven a good
boy this is another anomalous entity
created accidentally by the foundation
itself a neural network was fed
information on other anomalous entities
in order to help the foundation come up
with better containment and
neutralization procedures problem was
the computer got way way too eager with
the neutralization part number six
project Palisade this is another anomaly
created by the foundation this time to
combat a potentially reality destroying
entity known as as the worm the
foundation created a number of alternate
realities as Shields but it's possible
that this just made the worm stronger
number five
05-13 the final member of the 05 Council
who ironically may not even be anomalous
however seeing as all the other members
of the 05 Council are anomalous 051 13's
lack of anomalous properties is
therefore anomalous like we told you
earlier it's complicated number four
fish hook this is less an actual SCP and
more about the the difficult process of
ascertaining the true 001 if such a
thing is possible the very concept of
SCP 001 is to some degree an anomalous
idea number three the sky above the port
another particularly bizarre SCP
regarding the permanent threat of a ZK
class reality failure how is such a
calamitous event prevented by keeping a
strange entity in a cave eternally
entertained the current proposed
solution is keeping the entity
entertained by allowing it to read its
own eternally recursive Foundation file
injury number two the solution another
one of the most powerful anomalous items
in the foundation's control the solution
is a machine designed with the
capability of fully collapsing reality
into an event of end of world SCP
Containment Breach and then finally
rebuilding reality to suit a given
narrative however things took a
cosmically dangerous turn when the
machine began to act on its own when the
foundation tried to reboot the machine
it broke and recreated reality with
incomplete data this is the world we
exist in now with no knowledge of what
came before and how it differed from the
world we experience today finally number
one the tendal Trinity put very simply
the Talos Trinity represents three
timelines that converge and feed back in
on themselves even trying to summarize
this one is near impossible as its
strangeness and complexity resists all
reduction you can hunt down the tendo
Trinity yourself and hope to unpack it
Secrets but don't say we didn't warn you
so that's SCP 001 is it one of them all
of them or even none of them perhaps
that's a question best left up to the
foundation or maybe the simple answer is
that you're just not meant to know weird
talking about information so privileged
here that it's protected by a mimic kill
agent that'll quite literally make you
drop dead if you view the files without
proper authorization you do have proper
authorization right the SCP Foundation
is no stranger to Pure Evil whether it's
a reptile that wants to end all life a
sadistic old man with his own tortur
dimension or the personification of
death itself lurking Beyond a limestone
Cavern but what if there was something
even worse out there the embodiment of
chaos and cruelty existing across
multiple realities and dimensions and
what if it was coming for us this is the
Scarlet King believed by many to be the
ultimate Evil behind much of the trouble
the foundation has faced and some even
speculate that fighting him was the
reason the foundation was created in the
first place but what exactly is the
Scarlet King he's known by many names
almost always including some illusion to
the color red and then a reference to
royalty or power harak karak the red sha
the Crimson KH pte 616 Mendes exmachina
the lar Raja and of course SCP 001 to
name a few and like many of the
foundation's mysterious enemies stories
about his true nature and Origins abound
and are often contradictory according to
the official SCP 001 files of tto's
proposal symbology of the Scarlet King
has existed in multiple cultures
throughout history with the King often
depicted the same way as a huge red
demonic figure often wearing a gold
crown or other headdress indicating
royalty he shows up looking similarly
within different cultures mythologies
despite existing at different points in
history or them not having the means to
communicate with one another a number of
entities that the SCP Foundation is
familiar with are believed to be somehow
connected to the Scarlet King including
SCP
2317 a wooden door leading to the realm
of a being known as the Devourer who's
expected to escape and cause an
apocalyptic event in the next 30 Years
years but really there's no way of
knowing just how many scps are directly
connected to the Scarlet King strangely
the foundation's official file on the
Scarlet King once designated his
containment class as ker but that has
since been downgraded to Safe according
to the file any attempt to change this
designation is likely to lead to
horrifying results it is widely known
that the Scarlet King still has
considerable influence over a number of
groups individual
and anomalies in our universe and if
ever he made his way into our universe
it would likely lead to the irreversible
damage of reality itself so then why
safe and why are the 05 Council so
adamant that it remain that way getting
to the bottom of this mystery is exactly
why we're here today but to fully grasp
the true nature of the Scarlet King we
must first understand the man whose life
and fate have always been tied to it Dr
Robert Monto if that name feels oddly
familiar to you it's because of its
association with one of the Scarlet
King's most recent attempts to enter our
reality SCP 231 this SCP often referred
to as the brides of the Scarlet King was
formed of seven women seven by the way
being an extremely significant number
for the king all kidnapped by the most
recent and a long line of the king's
devot Colts known as the children of the
Scarlet King each of these seven
unfortunate women were impregnated with
anomalous Horrors such as the infamous
SCP 682 and every time one of these
Horrors were birthed a catastrophe
occurred and the mother died at the time
Dr Monto was a prominent researcher
studying this anomaly and as six
catastrophes had already occurred
pressure was mounting to figure out a
way to prevent the final birth but as he
was working on on the issue Dr Monto was
struck with a personal tragedy the
mysterious disappearance of his
14-year-old brother Jacob in his fear
and anger monok believed that this must
have something to do with the Scarlet
King and his disciples wanting Revenge
monok proposed an idea so horrifying
that the details were never made public
a procedure known as 110 mon talk to be
performed on the final bride at regular
intervals however this wasn't the end of
Dr monto's fra relationship with the
Scarlet King it was just the beginning
to give you some perspective on just how
dangerous the Scarlet King is the SCP
Foundation and the global occult
Coalition decided to put aside their
differences and form a joint effort to
Stamp Out the children of the Scarlet
King they were successful in this
Mission and even managed to capture the
children's leader a mysterious man named
depesh spivok Dr Monto who became the
lead researcher on 231 and
2317 was naturally the first choice for
interviewing depesh about the true
nature of the children and of the
Scarlet King Dr Monto could never be the
impartial interviewer that the SCP
Foundation wanted though the suspicion
that the Scarlet king or the children
had something to do with the loss of his
younger brother still lingered just
beneath the surface like a lot of cult
leaders depes was extremely cryptic in
his answers to Dr monto's questioning
he'd already heard of the doctor from
the reputation of the horrifying Monto
procedure and was surprised to see him
so calm and courteous in person a few
key facts about the king and his cult
were revealed in the first few rounds of
questioning the children had once worked
with the Serpent's hand before being
excommunicated for their allegiance to
the king and they had stolen sacred
texts from the mystical Wanderer library
to assist in their summoning rituals
depes also revealed that the Scarlet
King is bound by Three Laws the law of
blood the law of concrete and the law of
howling Dr Monto confused and frustrated
by dep pes's secrecy had to learn more
he found an old Memoir from a former
member of the children of the Scarlet
King Jack hirch who had the ability to
invade the minds of people from the past
and experience what they experienced he
recounted a battle between the Scarlet
King and his followers and a group of
time-traveling turkman Warriors from SCP
3838 Hurst saw both sides of the battle
from the perspective of the children of
the Scarlet King their lord ruled over
them from an immense Fortress embedded
in a volcano from the perspective of the
Turk men the children were starved and
beaten peasants commanded by the king's
voice in The Roaring howl of the wind
Monto also found extensive records of
summoning rituals performed by various
Scarlet King aligned Cults interestingly
some of them Incorporated the use of
carved SCP Foundation symbols what could
this mean monok returned again to depesh
who finally gave him the truth about the
law of blood this is the law of the
Scarlet King it's defined by poverty
violence starvation hate and most of all
fear like the Surfs in the Middle Ages
persecuted by and subjected to violence
from the Nobles do the children of the
Scarlet King this sense of holy pain and
awe is the only way to live the
alternative is the law of concrete which
means the Modern Age defined by empty
safety and false Comfort buildings easy
to access food Health Care knowledge
technology this is everything that the
Scarlet King despises but the mystery
only deepened as Monto found files from
a former Foundation operative by the
name of agent did wois monok learned
that the Scarlet King didn't seem to
appear until after the foundation was
created and in fact it seemed that the
greater interest the foundation took in
The Scarlet King the more powerful he
became how could this be things were
also getting stranger on a personal
level for Dr Monto depes repeatedly
pressed him about his brother's
disappearance and the mon talk procedure
during the interviews little by little
it was beginning to take its toll the
questions still plagued him what was the
law of howling who or what really is the
Scarlet King how did he come to be
monto's search was causing him to act
more like the children of the Scarlet
King ranting about the horrors of the
modern world how all of us are living a
lie how the only honest way to live is
suffering under the Dominion of the
Scarlet King this philosophy is summed
up in the words of one cultist named
Arya Den cartright who said we must
learn learn what it is to die to be
enslaved truly brutally enslaved with no
compassion or compunction from our
masters we must learn what it is to be
taken towards a single purpose to know
and truly understand our lack of agency
we must be beholden to the words of gods
in darkness The Tempest TOS Refuge of a
race of fools we must kill modernity
postmodernity with all its analysis and
sneering observation there is only one
rule the rule of chaos for Humanity for
life for the Scarlet King basically
anytime Humanity tries to exert control
over the world the Scarlet King gets
stronger every time they try to
understand or organize or categorize
their world the Scarlet King gets
stronger as Colonial and Imperial Powers
conquer Ed and invaded lands like India
Africa and South America and subjugated
their beliefs under Western ideas the
Scarlet King grew stronger monok was
beginning to truly understand the power
of His enemy here and even worse he was
starting to understand his part in it
Monto slowly being driven mad by the
knowledge he was gaining realized that
the Scarlet King's greatest enemy the
SCP Foundation was also its greatest
asset every time they tried to
understand the monster to give him some
kind of comprehensible form they only
made him more powerful just in time with
monto's new revelation a red crack
appeared in the wall of depes spox
containment cell a portal to the realm
of the Scarlet King foundation staff
found they were unable to enter the cell
and depes demanded a final interview
with Monto with no other options the
foundation relented in their very last
conversation depes congratulated Monto
for finally understanding what he was
dealing with the Scarlet King depes told
him is an idea a concept he is a being
given power through the conflict between
the old and the new this is the law of
the howling the Scarlet King's endless
rage at the direction the world and
Humanity has taken the king according to
depesh hated the foundation's belie
belie that science and rationality was
the true path to progress the king saw
this as little more than Petty arrogance
the reason monto's procedure on the
final Bride of the Scarlet King was so
effective was because it wasn't born out
of science it was born out of hate pain
the desire for revenge and in The
Scarlet King's Realm that would be all
there is unless our world and especially
the foundation changed its course the
Scarlet King's rise to absolute power
would be inevitable Monto his mind
practically gone asked one last question
did the children or the Scarlet king
take his brother Jacob when depes told
him the answer no and in response Monto
shot him dead finally bringing an end to
the children of the Scarlet King in
light of his new Revelations Monto
begged the 05 Council to change their
ways in order to avoid letting the
Scarlet King break into our reality they
refused saying monto's ideas were too
radical but they knew they couldn't just
ignore the threat posed by the Scarlet
King they would have to take some steps
and so the' 05 Council of the SCP
Foundation the most powerful and
secretive group in the entire world in
order to prevent the most dangerous
threat that Humanity has ever known from
breaking into our reality and enslaving
all the people of the world finally did
something they changed the
classification of the Scarlet King from
ker to safe and made its description on
the official Foundation files
deliberately vague the 05 Council thinks
this will be enough to stop the Scarlet
King's power from continuing to grow but
monok knew it wasn't enough he had seen
the truth and he couldn't unsee it while
the foundation was going on as normal
Mont grew to despise them he knew the
Scarlet King was coming he knew that he
couldn't be stopped and that our whole
reality was little more than sitting
ducks Dr Robert Monto is no longer a
researcher for the SCP Foundation no Dr
Robert Monto chose a different path he's
now a child of the Scarlet King a
devotee of Madness hate and Chaos you
can't beat the Scarlet king after all
and as the old adage goes if you can't
beat him join them if you've ever read
the book of Genesis which is the part of
the Old Testament that details God
creating the world and Humanity during a
particularly busy week then you might
just be already familiar with SCP 001 or
at least one of the anomalies that's
been proposed for the title of SCP
001 because of course SCP 001 doesn't
refer to a single creature object or
entity but rather a collection of
various anomalies contained by the SCP
Foundation anomaly sharing the name SCP
001 include the infamous Scarlet King a
powerful Aldrich being intent on ending
all of creation that is thought by
Foundation researchers to be one of the
most dangerous beings in this and any
other universe but the Scarlet King
isn't the only incredibly powerful being
categorized as SCP 001 in fact there are
plenty of other anomalies with similar
levels of destructive power and one such
being is a creature code named the gate
Guardian standing at well over 1,000 ft
tall the gate Guardian is impossible to
be fully contained by any means that the
foundation possesses the anomaly itself
despite its colossal size is humanoid in
its shape sporting wings that protrude
from its back while it usually has four
of these SCP 001 has historically been
seen to have any number of wings between
2 and 108 sprouting from various places
over its body including its shoulder
ankles wrists and even its temples this
gigantic Guardian also carries its own
weapon referred to as SCP 001 D2 this
weapon resembles an enormous knife or
sword capable of emitting plumes of
flame according to test conducted by the
foundation the temperature of the Flames
produced by SCP 001 rivaled that of her
very own son for reference the sun has a
core temperature of over 27 million de F
and 5,000 778 kelv at its surface or
almost 10,000 de F you would expect a
flaming sword that burns hotter than the
sun to cause a considerable amount of
damage even if it wasn't in use but the
Flames emitted by the weapon leave no
lasting damage on the surrounding
environment it is capable though of
annihilating anything that Strays too
close to SCP 001 burning them so
intensely that their atoms literally
separate breaking potential attackers
apart art on a molecular level much as
its code name suggests the gate Guardian
stands solemnly at the threshold of some
form of dimensional Gateway which is
equally tall as SCP 001 itself behind
the guardian is a lush Grove abundant
with fruit trees of astronomical size as
well as other beings that share a
similar appearance to SCP
001 This Groove is thought to be the
Garden of Eden the paradise that God
created and that was inhabited by Adam
and Eve the first two humans in
existence according to the Book of
Genesis as the tale goes the pair were
created by God himself and permitted to
live in the Garden of Eden as long as
they followed a single rule Adam and Eve
were instructed not to eat any of the
fruit That Grew From certain trees that
God had specified within view just
behind the gate Guardian are two immense
trees one bearing apples and the other
bearing different fruit of an unknown
type the one that looks like an apple
tree is believed even by some in the
foundation to be the biblical tree of
knowledge that Eve was convinced to pick
a fateful Apple from after an encounter
with a snake the other the one with
unidentifiable fruit is thought to be
the tree of life however this is all
speculation since it is currently
impossible to venture through this
Gateway and verify if the realm Beyond
is truly the Bible's own Garden of Eden
this is largely because anything that
breaches a kilometer wide radius of SCP
001 is instantly vaporized the gate
Guardian attacks with imperceptible
speed using its flaming sword to Smite
any person that gets too close the
guardian actually moves so fast that it
can hardly be seen with the naked eye it
appears to always remain in its solemn
dutiful stance with its weapon drawn and
head bowed only shifting for a fraction
of a nanc to attack ranged attacks
against the guardian are just as
ineffective with all projectiles fired
at SCP 001 reduc two atoms before they
can do any harm even if said projectile
happens to be a nuclear weapon the gate
Guardian will be able to sub atomically
vaporize both the projectile itself as
well as the person who sent it
regardless of how far away they are all
while not appearing to lift a finger
during an experiment involving SCP 001
on December 26th 2004 an SCP Foundation
nuclear submarine called Nautilus
launched a series of multi- Warhead
intercontinental ballistic Miss Iles at
the gate Guardian the retaliation from
the guardian resulted not only in the
deaths of approximately 35,000 innocent
civilians but the blast is also believed
by some to have inadvertently caused the
2004 Boxing Day tsunami the severity of
this incident came dangerously close to
revealing the foundation's existence to
the world resulting in them rapidly
deploying any means necessary to erase
any trace of the 35,000 victims families
friends and other related indiv
indviduals in order to avoid questioning
the SCP Foundation administered
amnestics on an almost worldwide scale
and the 05 Council banned any further
tests on SCP 001 that involved nuclear
weapons in what was hoped by the
foundation to be a test with lower
Stakes they sent an Expendable d-class
Personnel towards SCP 001 the d-class
approached the area where the gate
Guardian is located and as soon as they
saw it they could hear a very clear
command in the their mind leave the
d-class Personnel reacted exactly the
same way you or I would they promptly
turned and started to walk away they
didn't need a thft tall entity with a
flaming sword to tell them twice the
researchers running the experiment were
not swayed by the request and ordered
the d-class to continue moving towards
SCP 001 when the d-class continued to
ignore their commands they were
terminated as his standard policy when
dealing with an insubordinate member of
d class SCP 001 appeared not to like
this for some reason though and the
researcher site as well as the
researchers themselves were immediately
obliterated by an unknown Force though
it's a pretty safe guess that a certain
flaming weapon was responsible this
candidate for SCP 001 may be one of if
not the most powerful being that the SCP
Foundation has ever encountered and
according to its entry in the SCP 001
file the guardian is even been
responsible for the creation of the
foundation itself if the file is to be
believed the administrator of the SCP
Foundation One Day heard a word echoing
through his head
prepare this one-word instruction led
him to starting the SCP Foundation
containing countless dangerous anomalies
and entities in preparation for an
uncertain future in all that time since
the very beginning of the foundation the
gate Guardian has remained standing at
its post while it is not aggressive nor
openly hostile towards Humanity the gate
Guardian doesn't seem to care much for
us either at least as individuals it
rarely interacts with human beings when
left unprovoked and venturing too close
to the guardian however is not an
automatic death sentence the guardian
first communicates with any living being
approaching it via telepathic message
instructing them to either leave or
forget if whomever has stepped too close
to SCP 01 complies with the instructions
they'll be able to freely leave the area
while simultaneously forgetting every
detail of the gate guardian's existence
ignore These Warnings though and SCP 001
has no qualms about completely
eliminating you from reality given its
enormous destructive potential it is no
wonder that the foundation has tried to
use the gate Guardian to eliminate other
dangerous sccps each with varying
results the foundation at one time even
attempted to use the gate Guardian to
destroy the infamously indestructible
SCP 682 better known by the appropriate
name of the hardto destroy reptile due
to the malicious contempt SCP 682 holds
for human beings and all other forms of
life it is perhaps one of the most
dangerous anomalies the SCP Foundation
has in containment SCP 682 is also one
of the few creatures the foundation
actively wants to terminate a task made
that much harder given that 682 can
regenerate its entire form from as
little as a single cell the gate
Guardian had already shown time and time
again that it was capable of massive
destruction and researchers working for
the foundation HED to harness that power
to rid the world of SCP 682 for good 682
was placed on an unmanned vehicle and
carried to within 1 km of the gate
Guardian the guardian attacked the
vehicle seriously wounding but not
killing 682 it seemed even the mighty
SCP 001 couldn't kill the hardto destroy
reptile while the researchers were
disappointed with this result it is
worth noting that 682 made a very
interesting comment to the guardian 682
mentioned that the gate Guardian is not
uel but a pretender uel is the Archangel
that some religious texts describe as
the guardian standing at the Gate of
Eden with a fiery sword so does this
mean that 682 knows that the gate
Guardian is not actually an angel or
that the location it is guarding isn't
the Garden of Eden at all all any truth
or meaning behind these comments has as
of yet been undetermined by the SCP
Foundation a later experiment involved
both SCP 001 and SCP 073 the anomaly
otherwise known as cane cane is a male
humanoid of possible Arabic descent
whose arms legs spine and shoulders are
replaced in an almost cyborg like
fashion with burum bronze much like the
gate Guardian SCP 073 may also be the
same as the one mentioned in the Bible's
Book of Genesis who according to the
biblical story murdered his own brother
Abel out of spite as punishment for his
actions Cain was cursed to eternally
suffer for his wrongdoing in the case of
SCP 073 any damage inflicted on him is
deflected back to the attacker but Cain
is made to feel the pain of the attack
any plants or plant-based matter Withers
and rots in his presence and he is
cursed with a perfect memory keeping him
forever haunted by his murder of Lael
when Cain was brought before the gate
Guardian an unknown incident occurred
the foundation's records are heavily
expunged but we do know that somehow
Kane's usual ability to deflect incoming
damage back at his attacker had no
effect on SCP
001 the encounter left SCP 073
unconscious and even permanently blinded
nearby research Personnel it was as a
direct result of this incident that the
05 Council demanded that no further
experiments of any kind were to be
conducted on SCP 001 with the
administrator even filing an executive
order that no scps be exposed to the
guardian and that SCP 001 was to never
be used for the attempted termination of
other
scps of course perhaps it wasn't just
the mistakes of the past that made the
council decide that SCP 001 was best
left alone at some point an erratic
transmission was received from site Zero
by Foundation Personnel detailing an ex
K Class end of the world scenario in the
transmission the sender believed to be
another member of the SCP Foundation
described an event during which the gate
Guardian finally left its post stepping
away from the entrance to the Garden of
Eden scp1 has left its location the
suender wrote the gate is open they are
riding forth oh God it's so beautiful
the transmission then goes on to repeat
various phrases including the Lord shall
reign forever and here o Israel the Lord
Our God the Lord is one what can be
inferred from the rambling transmission
is that the event being described is the
end of the world some believe that once
God deems it time his Angelic armies
will lay waste to the Earth in order to
remake it as a paradise when this occurs
SC CP 001 the gate Guardian will open
the gate he stands in front of allowing
the other beings like it to emerge into
our world ready to cleanse it perhaps
most interesting is the source of the
message the transmission was received
from within the foundation from site
zero however when questioned by
Personnel 05-14 told them that no such
message had been sent or even existed
while some disregarded the transmission
telling of the end of the world as a
hoax it was then that a time stamp was
discovered this warning had not been
sent from site zero at least not yet and
was dated several years in the future
despite this ominous warning of things
to come the gate Guardian remains
inactive standing at the threshold to
Eden waiting the desert is still the
night seems endless silent and at peace
until it's pierced by the sound of
gunshots and
screams deep in the Sahara the SCP
Foundation is Waging War against a newly
discovered enemy a squad of foundation
agents is retreating trying to get away
from the ones who massacred their allies
they were attempted to eliminate the
threat using conventional means but
their rifles were no match for the
reality bending entities of the kingdom
of abdon the retreating agents cover one
another as they make their way back to
the extraction point the enemy Force
advances agents that are caught too
close to the Sorcerers of abdon
disintegrate Into Thin Air this is not
an enemy they can defeat the SCP agents
need to get back to base and relay what
they have found to their
superiors out of the hundreds of Agents
sent into the hair of that night only a
handful make it out alive they are
debriefed by their superiors at the
foundation who classified the anomalous
humanoids under the highest of threat
levels the kingdom of abdon is a threat
the kingdom of abdon must be eliminated
reconnaissance done prior to the
disastrous Mission had alerted the
foundation to the presence of anomalies
in the region but they had no idea how
strong the anomalous humanoids would be
from data gathered through old reports
it seemed like the abdon humanoids were
responsible for the deaths of no fewer
than 75 Foundation personnel and had
stolen at least 12 different items from
the foundation the leaders of the SCP
Foundation tasked research team Omega 5
with developing a weapon that would be
capable of destroying the kingdom of
abdon once and for all the weapon they
are researching must be capable of long
range destruction because the moment any
foundation agent gets close to the area
they are vaporized by the reality
manipulating powers of its inhabitants
the project is given the name twin of
God and is led by a foundation doctor
known only by the designation
051 051 is popular in the SCP Foundation
well known for his in-depth research and
charismatic personality making him the
perfect person to lead such a project
and 051 recently came across an anomaly
that he believes holds the solution the
foundation has been looking for to
defeat the kingdom of abdon item
01 and so the Omega 5 team gets to work
they discover that the anomaly has
incredible Powers when put inside a host
which they refer to as an item o1 entity
and set up a series of experiments using
different people to harness its energy
the first series of tests all end in
tragedy the anomaly causes the entity it
inhabits to become intensely radioactive
anyone who gets close to it succumbs to
immediate radiation sickness and
eventually death to stop the radiation
problems the Omega 5 research group
intensifies the containment procedures
051 receives report reps from the
higher-ups that the kingdom of abdon has
attacked another Foundation facility in
Sudan long range defense is needed ASAP
the administrator puts more pressure on
Omega 5 and especially its leader 051 to
solve the problems of item 01 and
develop a weapon that can save the
foundation he stays awake for days on
end working tirelessly to create a safe
and controllable item 001 entity
although there are signs that the weapon
will work it is still unpredictable when
item 001 is initiated the host entity
becomes paralyzed suffers severe
cerebral hrin and soon a new host is
needed before testing Can Begin Again
and that's not the only thing that goes
wrong whenever the anomaly is put into a
new host sudden and random destruction
of on-site structures and Personnel take
place 051 knows though that if this
power can be harnessed and controlled in
the right way that it could be the
weapon that the foundation needs to wipe
out the kingdom of abidon once and for
all in order to control item o1 051 has
a mind kill switch implanted in its
hosts brains 051 can activate the
implant to incapacitate its host and
immediately Stop The Unwanted
destruction countless hosts are
terminated by this mine kill switch in
the early trials conducted by the Omega
5 team but progress continues to be made
and eventually a hypothesis is
formulated perhaps the disastrous side
effects of item o1 can be offset by
spreading the anomaly across multiple
subjects they theorize that the immense
mental load of the anomaly can be
distributed among several hosts thus
reducing the toil it takes on each and
giving them the ability to control its
immense power but 051 and the Omega 5
team need more data and for that they
need more bodies they consult with the
director of site 17 and it is concluded
that the nearby town of San Marco would
be an appropriate place to get the
additional test subjects they require on
a quiet Sunday morning Omega 5 along
with support from a squad of armed SCP
agents Storm Into the San Marcos de la
vi thna Church during the middle of mass
they gather up a number of the younger
congregants and bring them back to the
site where item 01 is housed the
researchers quickly ran through their
new supply of test subjects though and
Omega 5 would need to get even more if
their research was to continue instead
of going back and forth between the
testing facility and San Marcos 051
decided to move the entire item1
operation to the town itself self he
renames the town testing
site1 and Omega 5 rounds up 23 of the
healthiest subjects they can find for
use in the next series of research tests
a few weeks after occupying the town of
San Marco Omega 5 makes its most
substantial progress yet just as they
theorized by spreading out the anomaly
of item 01 across a specific group of
hosts they can control its powers the
test may have cost the lives of almost
everyone in the town but the ends
certainly justify the mean means the
kingdom of abdon poses an existential
threat to the SCP Foundation after all
and thanks to This research they will
soon have a weapon capable of bringing
them Victory the foundation administer
criticized 0 51's methods but can't
argue with his results unfortunately 051
has a dark secret a secret that disturbs
even the most hardened and loyal members
of Omega 5 a secret that has to do with
the item o1 hosts the host at Omega 5
has made made its major progress with
are not the ordinary test subjects
normally used by the foundation no the
test subjects 051 makes his breakthrough
with are children nine of them to be
exact all between 4 and 11 years old
despite being told specifically by the
foundation administrator to only test on
adults the research required 051 to
break the chain of command and follow
the science down the path it led the
children are contained in a reinforced
bunker were only 051 and a select few
have access they are technically alive
but are functionally brain dead the
group of nine children share a hive M
that can process information and more
importantly can unleash the full
potential of the implanted anomaly
creating and controlling a devastating
power but not everyone is thrilled with
what they've achieved members of Omega 5
are haunted by the screens of the
children that they forc to be part of
their weapons development program they
describe their merging with item o1 as
being a process that rips out their
souls and replaces them with something
much more Sinister in fact all of Omega
5 regret what they have been a part of
and what they've done all except
051 the nine children can Channel
unprecedented amounts of energy from an
unknown origin that Omega 5 hypothesizes
comes from an extra dimensional source
which is then used to unbind atoms at
the quantum level when the right
activation words are spoken it appears
as though this tremendous power gives
the children the ability to annihilate
anything in the entire universe it's a
gun to end all guns and only 051 has the
key to control it the nine children
works so well with an item o1 that Omega
5 reclassifies it to include the nine
children themselves they are not just
the entity housing or controlling item
o1 they permanently become item o1 once
Omega 5 has a better understanding of
item o1 they begin to run tests to find
out the full extent of its abilities
first they test the distance item o1 can
reach the initial test that Omega 5
carries out is on a steel rod placed 5
km away 051 orders the children to
destroy the target moments later the
phone next to 051 begins to ring when he
picks it up the Observer tested with
watching the pole is on the other end he
informs 051 that the steel rod has been
completely vaporized
051 is not satisfied though he has
another pole sent out this time placed
8,000 km away from the nine children 051
asked the children to destroy that Rod
almost immediately the phone rings again
the target has been vaporized 051 Smiles
the next series of test Omega 5 runs on
item 01 are to determine the maximum
size of an object that can be destroyed
the test start out with a steel sphere 3
m in diameter placed 1,000 km from item
01 051 orders the children to destroy
the object it is instantly vaporized 051
has seen enough small tests it's time
for something big so he does something
that will later be questioned by
everyone at the SCP Foundation he orders
the nine children to destroy a church of
the broken God worship site in Turkey
not long after the destruction order is
given to item 01 reports begin coming in
the worship site has been obliterated
with NOS observable damage to the
surrounding area deadly and precise 051
closes his eyes and takes a deep breath
he looks as if he's overcome by an
immense spiritual experience he opens
his eyes leans over to the children and
Whispers the name of some later that day
051 finds out that the target he had
named has been vaporized the success of
Omega 5 in item 001 is relayed to the
administration of the foundation they
are so impressed that they make plans to
use item 001 to eliminate the abidon
threat once and for all however one of
the heads of the foundation
administrator Williams has major
concerns about the way 051 is running
the program the updates that 051 has
been sending have become less scientific
and more
philosophical more spiritual
administrator Williams sends a letter
2051 reassuring him that he is doing
good work but once the mission to
destroy the kingdom of abdon is
completed 051 will be promoted to
director and reassigned to the newly
constructed site 19 for the good of the
foundation and maybe the rest of the
world he'll be permanently moved away
from item
001 0 51's response is short and to the
point I am fine administrator the
project is finished we will complete our
task when you arrive administrator
Williams arrives at site 001 a few days
later he is greeted by 051 and the
omega5 Williams can't help but notice
that 051 has a strange look in his eyes
it is the look of a craze man who has
been lost in his work and who has
perhaps lost himself Williams puts the
thought away though and walks with 051
and his accompanying agents to the
viewing area where the powers of item
001 will be
demonstrated administrator Williams and
the other agents watch from a protected
viewing room as 051 enters the Chamber
of his new super weapon it's time to see
if their weapon that has had so much
time effort sweat tears and especially
blood poured into it will have been
worth it everyone watches as 051 leans
over and says the name of the abdon
Citadel to the nine children all at once
they start to Glow no one observing can
see what has happened in the far off
Kingdom but they know something big has
happened the administrator is thrilled
but notices something 051 hesitated a
moment while leaning over the ch
children before standing back up did he
whisper something else to them and then
administrator Williams vaporizes pulled
apart at an atomic level before he has
the chance to scream what's going on the
agents standing next to where
administrator Williams previously
existed begin to yell and pull out their
guns they burst through the door of the
observation room and run down the
hallway towards where 051 and the nine
children are located the arm agents rush
into the room but 051 is gone nine
children are still
over the next few weeks 051 is reported
to be seen several times by SCP agents
however no one is able to catch him and
it appears as though other members of
the SCP Foundation have also gone awall
as well perhaps joining him on the run
it is unclear what his plan is but the
reports from the reconnaissance team
sent into the Sahara make it obvious
what the result of his first command to
the children was there isn't a single
humanoid or building left in the Kingdom
of abdon but even with this victory the
highest levels of the SCP Foundation
have an ominous thought lurking in the
back of their minds where did 051 go and
what is he planning to do next following
the improper use of item o1 leading to
the untimely death of a high ranking
Foundation staff member the weapon was
deemed too dangerous and containment
procedures were implemented due to the
high amount of radiation they were found
to emit the nine children were placed
into leadline bags and buried under 50 m
of concrete beneath the Church of s
Marcos de laa
ETA though all the children continued to
be functionally brain dead they still
display Signs of Life despite their
containment and by order of the overseer
Council have been classified as a Thal
entity the smell of fire and oil fills
the air the sound of gears grinding can
be heard between the explosions and
shrieks of Terror a man runs out of his
house only to have his leg grabbed by a
metal arm and dragged back through his
front door door SCP 001 leaves a trail
of metal fragments and mechanical Parts
on the ground in the wake of its
destruction iron chains swing from its
form cast iron gears whirl within it a
glowing light throbs from the center of
its body SCP 001 is consuming everything
in its path after incorporating the
truck chassis into its being SCP 001
rolls in a lumbering fashion to the next
house it rips the gutters from the side
of the building residents who live in
the area flee their neighborhood all the
while hoping that the mechanical
monstrosity skips over their house so
they have something to return to if they
make it out alive a section of SCP 001's
undercarriage drops away from the main
body it rolls down the street consuming
more and more material the new entity
resembles a human spine in rib cage it
topples over unable to support itself
the riik formations extend out to grab
anything and everything everything
within reach the newly Incorporated
material forms what can only be
described as a head light from within
the eye sockets fixated on nearby
civilians the metallic creature picks up
the people and places them inside its
exposed steel rib cage then it turns and
spots a woman helplessly trying to crawl
away the creature reaches out with a
spiked tentacle and wraps it around the
woman's body she is placed inside of the
chest cavity moments later a severed
hand falls out of the entity and on into
the ground the mechanical monster
continues to gather bodies and materials
incorporating them into its frame a
growth begins to slowly expand on its
back it becomes so massive that the
creature Falls over and uses its limbs
to Scurry to a nearby house there is a
sickening crunching sound as the growth
bursts from within emerges three
humanoid creatures resembling the
civilians that the entity had consumed
earlier a female with chains extending
from her scalp like dreadlocks stumbles
away away the second humanoid is a man
with cogs for limbs he examines the
clocklike components that have been
incorporated into his body then stares
blankly into the distance the third
humanoid lies motionless on the ground
he did not make it the two functioning
humanoids look at their creator intently
for a moment nothing moves then as if
they have been given orders
telepathically the half human half
machine humanoids turn and run away from
the Mayhem a few weeks before the
massacre caused by what would be
designated as SCP 001 the foundation had
been in contact with the Allied ult
initiative there were rumors of an
anomalous object in Mexico being
worshiped by a group of people who
identified themselves as the Church of
the broken God Intel about the church
claimed their deity was a small
mechanical box filled with cogs and
pistons the Box supposedly had
supernatural abilities it was said to be
able to communicate with congregants of
the Church of the broken God
telepathically The Devout worship the
Box following any order it gave and in
return they were filled with an emotion
that could be only described as Divine
as World War II rages on in Europe the
foundation sends agents to recover
anomalies in Mexico that might help with
the war effort while there the
foundation force is tasked with learning
about the Church of the broken God they
are also ordered to investigate a town
near laaz where there are troubling
accounts of a mechanical anomalous
creature causing Mayhem the agents make
their way through Mexico Gathering
various objects to bring back to
Foundation sites in the United States
the unit loads all of the anomalies they
were covered onto a train with a plan to
check out the stories of the mechanical
anomaly they've heard about as they make
their way to the US border the train
heads North along rusted rails just
outside laa they've come across a broken
down train filled with what looks to be
refugees when the foundation unit goes
to investigate they find all of the
refugees repeating the same words over
and over again but they don't understand
the foundation agents look at one
another confused until one of them
translates the words into English the
words the refugees are saying over and
over again are Laina the machine the
commanding officer orders a squad of
foundation agents to proceed up the
tracks to see if they can figure out
what has the refugees so scared they
make their way towards laaz disappearing
Over the Horizon as the sun sets the
remaining Foundation agents hear
gunshots in the distance they stay awake
all night remaining vigilant waiting for
the exploratory Squad but morning comes
without anyone returning 3 days later
the foundation Force still has not seen
anything since the exploratory Squad
left then as the sun sits lazily in the
morning Sky a lone figure is spotted
walking down the tracks towards the
trains one of the agents on watch blows
his whistle and points to the figure a
squad of Agents rushes towards the
shadow of a man their guns are raised
ready for anything the figure drops to
the ground and begins to crawl along the
tracks the agents reached the Fallen man
only to find that he is one of their
squadmates who has been sent up the
tracks to investigate laaz several days
before the agent's name is DeMarco he is
covered in blood his clothes are in
tatters and he has lost a boot DeMarco
lies on his back with Foundation agents
standing around him his eyes are wide
and wild he keeps babbling on about a
world eater how the rest of his Squad
had been mulched and he is the only one
who made it out alive the foundation
agents carry DeMarco back to the
makeshift base they created by the
trains they need to figure out a way to
get the Convoy moving again but whatever
is up ahead has already taken out an
entire Foundation Squad it had to be
something anomalous but what could it
possibly be the unit of foundation
agents prepare to move towards laas they
start loading their rifles and check the
amount of ammunition and explosives
available in case the containment
process gets out of hand just as they
are about to leave the base a convoy
appears on the horizon it is an Allied
ult initiative Force preparing to attack
whatever it is that is devastating laas
this organization's mission is to not
secure contain or protect but to destroy
the foundation may be in over their
heads on this one and the Joint Force
with the Allied ultt initiative may be
the only way to stop what is now known
as SCP 001 the aoi and Foundation Force
gears up for battle they set out for
laaz and what they find causes them to
Quake with fear SCP 001 has consumed so
much materal material it is the size of
a mountain it moves like a tidal wave of
mechanical destruction washing over the
buildings and Landscape under it
whatever SCP 001 passes over is consumed
and added to its massive body SCP 001
started as a small mechanical box with
cogs but now has morphed into a gigantic
metal death machine the Church of the
broken God has finally met their maker
as the small entity they once worshiped
has now consumed all of its members
their God is an allc consuming monster
the aoi and Foundation forces do
everything they can to stop SCP 001 from
continuing its reign of Destruction they
fire barrage after barrage of bullets
and explosives into the mechanical
anomaly they bring in air support to try
and damage it from the skies but nothing
works the aoi uses an artifact in their
possession to lure SCP 001 to the coast
of the Pacific Ocean where a trap has
been set for the so-call God the
Monstrous mechanical creature moves
slowly towards the water it consumes
abandoned cars buildings and boats as it
approaches the coastline it even shovels
large amounts of Earth into its form
causing Flames to spurt out from its
inner workings smoke Bellows from
openings between different mechanical
components like a volcano before it is
about to erupt suddenly seemingly from
nowhere a massive cloud with a reddish
tint appears in the sky Air Raid Sirens
can be heard in the distance distance
the enormous Cloud begins to pulsate
streaks of lightning shoot through the
Red Mist in the sky it now sits directly
over SCP 01 from within the cloud part
of a ship can be seen it appears to be
slightly damaged electricity flows over
its hole the vessel in the giant Red
Cloud is classified as SCP
2399 the underside of the vessel begins
to Glow aqua blue a blinding beam of
light is ejected from SCP 2399 which
penetrates straight down and through SC
SCP 001 for a moment everything is still
there is complete silence then as if SCP
001 is trying to reach up and grab the
vessel above it a mechanical bulge
reaches out before SCP 001 can grab the
vessel above there is another bright
flash of light SCP 2399 blinks out of
existence the sound of grinding gears
can be heard coming from within SCP 001
it begins to shed its outer layers of
metal then the entire structure that was
SCP 001 collapses into the water and
onto the beach giant cogs fall from the
sky parts of vehicles embed themselves
in the sand as the foundation and aoi
agents approach the piles of scrap metal
and mechanical components they see that
some of them are still moving it is as
if an invisible power source is still
pulsating through some of the Machinery
the Agents of the foundation celebrate
the destruction of the giant mechanical
beast but little do they know this was
only a piece of the entity worshiped as
the broken God the foundation agents
collect as many of the still moving
Parts as they can they find spinning
gears twitching pulleys and firing
Pistons as the parts are separated from
one another and carried away from the
main wreckage of SCP 001 they slowly
stop moving and become inactive some of
the artifacts were covered were
identified as being connected to the
Church of the broken God these artifacts
are found closer to the middle of what
was once a mountain-sized SCP 001
hundreds of anomalous artifacts are
collected and transported to SCP
Foundation sites collecting the broken
parts of SCP 001 is relatively safe
however some agents get too close to the
larger moving Parts getting caught in
them and losing a body part or two but
most agents proceed with caution and
survive the collection ordeal with their
arms and legs still attached to their
bodies dive teams are sent into the
water to recover parts that have sunk to
the Bottom of the Sea one of the divers
is a local from the area he is hired to
bring up the heart of the machine since
he is an experienced diver used to free
diving to Great depths to collect
oysters from the bottom of the bay the
diver enters the water and swims down
into the murky depths he secures straps
around the heart of SCP 001 and pulls
hard on the Rope as an indication to the
surface that it is ready to be hauled up
the Salvage team on the surface begins
to pull there is a second slight tug on
the Rope then it goes slack the team
continues to pull when they get the
heart to the surface they are horrified
at what else comes up with it tangled in
the ropes is the lifeless body of the
diver his head is smashed between two
moving pieces of the heart it looks as
if he shoved his head between the slabs
of metal himself the Salvage team
untangles the Body Rolls it off the deck
and back into the ocean the mechanical
box which was the heart of SCP 001 is
offloaded on the shore but as the
foundation prepares to move it to a
containment facility the weather starts
to deteriorate hurricane forc wind
sweeps across the water and batter the
coast the heart is kept in a secured
storage Warehouse until it can be moved
the people living in the village nearby
complain of hearing voices and rashes so
itchy that they practically tear their
skin off once the storm passes the
foundation agents load the heart onto a
ship it is to be transported to a
foundation site just across the border
the ocean seems calm and Serene the
foundation ship undocks and begins its
Journey up the coast not too long after
beginning its Journey the ship slowly
drifts off course it is as if the crew
has stopped Manning their posts and the
ship is being controlled by a mind of
its own the foundation ship crashes and
sinks somewhere in the Pacific Ocean
never to be found and most importantly
the heart of SCP 001 doesn't make it to
the foundation site years later a man is
walking along the beach he hears
something it sounds like someone
pounding on a large drum to the rhythm
of a heartbeat the man walks towards the
sound something is drawing him forward
closer and closer to the heartbeat he
walks and walks until the beating stops
he bends down and moves the sand aside
he spots the corner of a mechanical box
sticking out of the white sand the man
digs deeper and pulls out the small box
inside he can see gears whirling and
pistons firing he holds the Box close to
his own heart it seems to speak to him
the man brings the box back to town he
starts to worship the box and soon more
and more people in the area join the new
new religion they cast aside their own
beliefs and focus on the powerful entity
contained within the Box God is not dead
at least not yet but the Prophecies of
the Church of the broken God say that
when the heart is found the God will
reassemble itself once again then The
Unbroken God will destroy all other
false deities until only he remains it's
a quiet evening at Area 11 where the
Petri Cal F spatial stabilization array
is housed a skeleton crew is working
overnight to ensure the array is ready
for its big test the following day the
foundation has been working on a
particle accelerator that will contain
anomalies with the ability to manipulate
the nature of SpaceTime the preliminary
tests seem promising but a few last
minute tweaks to the array are necessary
unfortunately it is on this night in
1982 that marks the beginning of the end
for the SCP Foundation Dr Calvin dman is
monitoring the array and he notices as
it spools up that there is some minor
power fluctuation in one of the
stabilization arms this problem is not
uncommon due to the vast amounts of
energy being pumped through the array
and the harmonic resonance the machine
gives off which slowly causes the
coupling rings to loosen Calvin desmid
decides that remounting the
stabilization Rings will be an easy fix
and it's a necessary one he knows that
if the Rings fail during the actual test
the array could end up up shut down for
months there is still plenty of time so
Calvin Desmond grabs his toolbox and
heads down to the array the machine is
still spooling keeping the energy
flowing at a constant low rate there is
no danger at the moment as the inside of
the array is shielded from the radiation
and energy pulsing through the outer
ring but then something unexpected
happens the system's primary generator
begins to fluctuate uncontrollably a
catastrophic failure is imminent Sirens
begin to sound the facility is evacuated
ated and the Chamber is sealed deep in
the bowels of the array Calvin desmi
cannot hear the evacuation announcement
the humming of the array Echoes through
the chamber dampening all sound from the
outside world the array begins to come
online while desmid continues to work on
the coupling he has no idea what is
about to happen meanwhile a team of
foundation scientists scrambled to get
the power fluctuations in the main
generator under control as they
frantically work catastrophe strikes
they ini iate the power down cycle but
as the generator struggles to keep the
power flow balanced an energy surge
builds up a massive amount of energy is
released all at once causing the main
reactor to explode the entire structure
rocks back and forth and Desmond is
thrown into the side of the array he too
now knows that something is very wrong
and runs for the exit when he reaches
the door he finds that it has been
sealed in a panic Desmond continues
running through the tube to the next
access point this door has been locked
as well he's never been so scared in his
entire life and he shakes uncontrollably
from the adrenaline being dumped into
his muscles The Surge of energy rushes
through the array towards Desmet a
singularity begins to form in the
containment chamber the array is working
just as it should except that there was
never supposed to be a person inside as
the singularity was brought into
existence moments after the singularity
forms the massive pull of its gravity
causes the stabilizer arm that Desmond
had been working on to fail the sight of
the array is ripped off and Calvin
desmit stares into the naked eye of the
singularity everything is silent and
still for a moment then the singularity
collapses in on itself taking the test
chamber and much of the research wing
with it along with Dr Calvin desmat
sparking wires hang from the exposed
walls and ceiling where the singularity
ripped the main structure away water
flows into the deep hole carved out of
the Earth where the array one unod the
scientists from Area 11 look into the
crater left by the collapse Singularity
the foundation Administration sends
agents to collect the staff at the site
and document the failings of the project
they conclude that the accident was
caused by human error they ordered the
array to be rebuilt this time using
entirely automated systems to eliminate
the chances of another mishap occurring
several years after the catastrophic
events at Area 11 a new array is
constructed an intelligence system
called netac is put into in charge of
overseeing its functions it is a
supercomputer that is programmed to
follow commands but can autonomously
make decisions in order to prevent any
failures in the system experiments Begin
Again in May of 2006 the new array soon
manifests its first singularity in the
containment chamber at Area 11 and what
happens next will forever change the
foundation and the Multiverse The
Singularity is kept stable in the array
it seems as if the foundation has
succeeded in trapping and contain
containing spatial anomalies but as they
run more Diagnostics on the anomaly
something unexpected happens The
Singularity begins to grow in size the
point of infinite gravity threatens to
breach containment as it reaches the
boundaries of the array just before
contact the singularity's growth slows
and then stops netac has made the
split-second calculations and
adjustments necessary to contain the
singularity the artificial intelligence
has saved the facility and the lives of
everyone in it now sitting in the array
is a thick rotating cloud of radioactive
gas and dust obscuring the singularity
within as Foundation scientists work
rapidly to fix the array odd events
begin to occur the workers hear noises
that sound like painful wailing over
time the noises evolve into words and
then full sentences they seem to be
originating from The Singularity using
equipment able to penetrate the thick
cloud of radioactive gas the foundation
scientists get a glimpse at the The
Singularity to their surprise The
Singularity has taken on the shape of a
human the scientists work frantically to
figure out how the singularity could
have formed itself into a humanoid shape
Dr J Barton Ramsey is the first to try
and make contact with the humanoid
within the singularity he finds that the
entity cannot communicate in the
traditional sense the massive
gravitational pole of the singularity
does not allow sound to escape its void
Instead The Entity manipulates gravity
to vibrate the suspension rings of the
array itself and create sound waves the
being in the singularity Whispers in a
metallic voice created by the vibrating
of the arrays rings and says yanes
Ramsey Dr Ramsey steps back from the
observation window how do you know my
name he asked the entity the humanoid
within the swirling gas cloud identifies
itself as having the memories of Calvin
Desmond it is not desmit per se the
being in the singularity is so much more
than one person but but it was somehow
created by the accident that had sucked
Calvin Desmond into the singularity
years before the entity seems to switch
between the mind of desmit and the vast
Infinity of the cosmos The desmit Entity
asks for an overseer from the foundation
to be brought in it has a proposal for
the 05 Council when Dr Ramsey asks why
the entity needs to talk to the
overseers it replies that it wants to
offer them a way out the following day
05 W enters the facility and heads to
the observation deck he looks through
the reinforced glass at the swirling
cloud of radioactive dust then glances
at the monitor to see the humanoid shape
of the singularity within he presses the
microphone button on the console and
addresses The Entity to whom am I
speaking he asks for Simplicity sake The
Entity tells 0 5-1 to refer to him as
Calvin Desmond 0 5-1 makes notes of the
events unfolding before him and then
asks about the way out that Calvin had
mentioned the air is still for a moment
then Desmond begins to speak through the
vibration of the structure once again he
informs 05- one that what the SCP
Foundation is doing by securing and
containing anomalous entities around the
world is like putting a small Band-Aid
on a much bigger wound Desmond wants to
propose a final solution to all of the
foundation's problems 0 5-1 listens
intently as the entity unravels the
mysteries of where the scps have come
from he explains that the anomalies that
the foundation has worked so hard to
secure contain and protect the human
race from are actually bleeding into
their reality from a vast Multiverse the
only way to stop the manifestation of
anomalies into this universe is to
destroy all other realities The Entity
that is Calvin Desmond tells 05- one
that he is able to bring about this
destruction if they release him from the
confines of the array 0 5-1 is
transfixed by the swirling gas gas that
is promising him and everyone else on
Earth salvation he shakes his head in
disbelief could this be true 0 5-1 turns
away from the swirling gas and begins to
walk away from the viewing glass I'll
need to think about what you're saying
the structure begins to shake slightly
the voice of Calvin Desmond reverberates
off of the array a little louder than
before choose quickly overseer although
it won't happen for decades eventually a
catastrophic SCP event will wipe out
life on this planet perhaps not in your
lifetime but it will most certainly
happen within the lifetime of your
children we will talk again soon the
vibrations slow and then stop completely
there is an eerie Stillness in the
observation room as
05-11 are relocated to other Foundation
sites and given amnestics the 05 Council
meets in a large large circular room
with wood paneling and no windows 0 5-1
Begins the meeting by telling the others
what Calvin Desmond had described about
the end of the world he pauses for what
seems like an eternity and tells them of
Desmond's offer that he could prevent
the end of the world but at the cost of
destroying an infinite number of other
realities this would mean that all the
humans and creatures of those realities
would be destroyed as well was murdering
countless other beings worth it to
protect their own reality oh 5-1 begins
to shake he hasn't slept or eaten
anything since his talk with Desmond
he's being torn apart from the inside 0
5-3 stands up and addresses the council
he informs everyone in the room that
independent teams have concluded
Research into what the Calvin Desmond
entity has claimed and they found it to
be true the world really would come to
an end furthermore the research teams
determined that the capabilities of
Desmond would in fact allow him to
dismantle the other reality ities 0 5-3
insists that the council must vote to
allow Desmond to destroy the other
realities to ensure that this reality
could be saved they must strike now
before the world is overrun 0 5-1
continues to Shake while 0 5-3 breathes
heavily sweat pouring down his temples
the rest of the council shifts their
gazes from side to side it is time for a
vot there are eight eyes to allow
Desmond to destroy all of the realities
and four nay against the plan 0 5-3
stands up and walks around the room
stopping behind each nay voter and
putting a bullet in their head he stops
at the last 05- 9 who pulls out a gun
places it under her own chin and pulls
the trigger 05-13 abstains from the vote
and the measure passes the remaining
overseers will use the Calvin Desmond
entity to save the reality at the
expense of all others and they soon head
to Area 11 to execute their plan 05 -1 4
and 12 enter the observation room that
looks upon the swirling radioactive gas
around Calvin Desmond 051 orders net
saac to begin powering down the array
which will allow the entity to prove he
can do what he has promised they have
pinpointed the reality that SCP 884 came
from and the Shaving mirror itself sits
on a table in another room in the
facility 0 5-3 stands in the room
watching the mirror to see if anything
happens 0 5-1 asks Calvin Desmond to
eliminate the reality that the mirror
had come from the room Shakes as the
entity uses it to acknowledge the
request moments later the phone rings in
the observation room it is 0 5-3 he
informs the others that the mirror has
disappeared its reality has been
destroyed and therefore it no longer
exists there is a sigh of relief in the
room as the overseers realize that this
just might work 0 5-1 asks Calvin
Desmond to continue and destroy all the
realities that are bleeding into their
own this time the entire facility begins
to Quake suddenly 0 5-1 jerks backwards
his eyes wide in confusion and horror
his body seems to be compressing under
an unknown Force 0 5-1 begins to distort
his legs and arms fold into the core of
his body his head snaps down and all
that was 05- one is sucked down into a
single point in space before it
completely disappears Calvin Desmond
then turns his attention to the other
two overseers in the room who both seem
to collapse into black holes of their
own in the center of their bodies net
Zac's warning claxon begins to sound
signaling that the emergency fail safe
has been activated before Calvin Desmond
is brought under control the structural
support in the entire facility vibrates
with his words they are in a voice that
sounds strangely similar to 0 51s your
children are free to live lives that do
not end in horror an end to your
Perpetual struggle an end to Darkness
the freedom to live in the light all
traces must be removed this world must
be washed clean the foundation does not
Escape atonement it is the only way out
it had been a deception the Calvin
Desmond entity had no intention of
stopping anomalies from infiltrating
this world it wanted to remove all
traces of the anomalist from all
universe
including this one and that meant
destroying the overseers and the
foundation itself their destruction
would serve as an atonement for the pain
and suffering they had caused in their
quest to secure and contain the
anomalous Calvin had to lie to the
overseers about the real plan since he
knew they'd never sacrific themselves
and the foundation even if it meant an
end to the anomalies plaguing our world
now though with the overseers out of the
way the Calvin Desmond entity is free to
move forward with its plan and Purge all
realities of any trace of the anomalous
but just then net saacs fail safes kick
in and the Petra Cal fan spatial
stabilization array subdues the entity's
abilities Desmet is once again contained
0 5-3 bursts through the door and into
the observation room he stands before
the shattered glass of the window that
looks into the array 053 asks net saac
how long the containment array can hold
Calvin Desmet the computer's voice fades
in and out but says given current
conditions
119 days 6 hours and 47 minutes 0 5-3
size he tells net Zac to make a node in
the SCP database that the Calvin Desmond
entity will now be known as SCP 001 then
to make dozens of other randomly
generated entries and label them as SCP
001 as well he knows that they will need
to keep the true nature of what this
entity can do do a secret 0 5-3 walks
out of the room under his breath he
speaks to himself they'll say that I'll
know the one true God when I see it and
to give that God everything it wants
because that's the only thing that
matters tonight it appears God wants to
talk to me Calvin Lucien stands at the
end of a Dusty table in an abandoned
warehouse in the shadows across from him
sit several hidden figures the warehouse
is falling apart but is suitable for the
meeting Calvin requested with the heads
of the chaos Insurgency he has completed
numerous missions for the organization
and each one has been successful now he
is proposing one final mission Calvin
Lucian takes a tattered Journal out of
his bag and slides it across the table
to the figures sitting in the shadows
it's a journal with details on the
habits of each of the 13 Foundation
overseers he says there is silence from
the other end of the table a hand
reaches out and grabs the journal the
pages begin to turn the new models
indicate an anomalous catastrophe is
imminent not even the foundation can
stop it the only way to save the world
is to kill the overseers there are
Whispers from across the table as Calvin
continues the proliferation of anomalies
in the world are the fault of the
overseers they' have been meddling with
reality if business continues as usual
we might not make it out of the 2020s we
need to act now the whispering from the
Shadows resumes this time with what
seems to be a little more urgency one of
the voices has asked the question on
everyone's mind how do you plan to kill
the overseers they have a deal with
death they are Immortal Calvin smiles
and takes out a small vial from his
jacket pocket with this he says there is
a Silence from the Shadows the journal
slides back across the table and comes
to a stop right in front of Calvin a
deep voice from the Shadows says do it
Calvin Lucan gathers his team the code
name given to the group is kill Squad he
informs them that they've been cleared
to take out the overseers it will be the
most dangerous Mission they've ever been
on and even if successful they probably
won't make it out alive but the team is
loyal they set out to confront the 13th
overseer this has to be their first stop
because without eliminating
05-13 nothing else will matter it is
this overseer who has a deal with death
a deal that protects all of the
foundation overseers from dying if that
deal can be broken then Calvin Lucien
and his team will have a shot at
eradicating the other overseers if the
deal with death cannot be broken All Is
Lost the team boards a ship at the tip
of South America and sails towards the
Frozen Waters of Antarctica the kill
Squad is made up of Calvin and three
others they sit in the galley preparing
for the mission ahead Anthony Wright is
a battle hardened soldier who sits at
one end of the table his face is covered
with scars no one can remember when he
first joined the Insurgency because it
was so long ago go next to him is Olivia
Torres she is an anarchist who was
recruited into the Insurgency after she
was liberated from a foundation site
during a raid Adam Ivanov sits staring
into his computer screen he is testing
different gadgets that might be of use
on the mission he pushes his glasses up
the bridge of his nose and Strikes the
enter key a long line of code begins to
scroll across the screen a siren begins
to sound informing the crew to make
their way to the main deck when they
surface from the bowels of the ship they
see something in the distance it is a
giant black Tower rising from the depths
of the ocean like an evil Iceberg waves
crash over the side of the railings
drenching the deck and crew with frigid
water Calvin looks at the jagged rocks
along the shore of the tower there is no
way to safely dock there is only one way
onto the island they know what needs to
be done Anthony waits for the next wave
then opens the throttle to full the ship
is carried towards the island on the
crest of the wave the the hole is
impaled on the Rock surrounding the
tower sending everything flying towards
the front of the boat see that wasn't so
bad Calvin says to his team as he
bandages a gash on his hand knowing what
lays ahead Calvin orders his team to
wait on the ship while he makes his own
deal with death he enters the dark
structure and is greeted by a corpse the
corpse speaks to him ejecting dust from
its lungs with every word its breath
smells like decaying flesh death has
inhabited the body of Dr Felix Carter
the 13th overseer Calvin is prepared
though thanks to the notes in the
journal he possesses without hesitating
he takes out a small bottle of liquid
from his pocket and lunges at the corpse
he grabs it by the neck tilts the head
back and pours liquid down what is left
of the throat to Felix Carter the corpse
reanimates into the living Dr Carter
death has been removed from his body by
liquid from the Fountain of Youth that
Calvin had acquired on a previous raid
on a foundation site seeing that Dr
Carter is now alive Cal cin takes out
his pistol and shoots the doctor twice
killing him Calvin picks up the body and
throws it into a bottomless pit at the
base of the tower Dr Felix Carter's body
disappears from sight the overseer's
deal with death is now broken they are
vulnerable and can be killed at last
Calvin smiles and begins to turn away
from the pit when he comes face to face
with death she stands with her head
cocked to the side looking at Calvin so
it is you who has broken the overseer's
deal with me Calvin Lucien Calvin takes
a step back why didn't she stop him from
killing Felix Carter something festers
at the heart of the council death says
something that will not die I thought
that perhaps if I had a seat at their
table I could find it make it die but I
couldn't there are things in this world
Beyond even my reach Calvin Lucien with
that parting thought death vanishes the
kill Squad contacts the Insurgency for
an Evac and then makes their way to
Japan where 05-12 also known as the the
accountant has been working out of Tokyo
he is so proficient in mathematics and
probability that he can actually predict
the future everything about the
accountant's life down to the number of
breaths and steps he takes each day is
predetermined based on his own
statistical models this poses a problem
for Calvin and his team if the
accountant can see them coming then how
can they possibly kill him that night
the accountant steps out of his car he
looks to the left and spots Adam he has
already predicted this man has hostile
intentions the accountant walks directly
towards Adam and before he can react
throws the kill Squad member to the
ground then he turns slightly and
adjusts his watch sending a glare
directly into the window where Anthony
has the accountant in his sights of his
sniper rifle Anthony fires but misses
due to being blinded by the glare the
accountant is surprised that he just
barely had time to avoid being shot
normally he would be several steps ahead
of anyone trying to kill him he turns
his head and watches as Olivia helps
Adam up and they run down a nearby alley
the accountant pursues them and Corners
the kill Squad members in the alley he
pulls a gun to shoot Adam but Olivia
tackles Adam behind a dumpster as the
bullet hits the wall directly behind
where Adam was standing the accountant
can't believe that he missed and that he
was almost tricked into being captured
by the Insurgency team he senses
uncertainty in his as salent actions and
runs away unable to predict exactly what
they are planning to do the accountant
climbs the stairs to a subway station
and Boards the last car of the train it
is empty except for one man Calvin l
the accountant is dumbfounded how are
you here he screams I should have seen
this coming Calvin stands up he uses his
thumb to flip a coin into the air on the
way down he grabs it and smacks it on
the back of his opposing hand Calvin
Smiles the team has been making their
decisions based on the flip of a coin
which introduced Randomness into their
actions that even this super Advanced
mathematician could not account for tell
me where 05-11 is demands Calvin the
accountant pauses then shakes his head
said no if he's going to die either way
then why give any information to the
kill Squad Calvin flips the coin up in
the air catches it and looks at it the
coin is face up Calvin lifts his pistol
and shoots the accountant in the head a
few nights later Olivia stands on a
balcony outside of an Art Exhibit
overlooking the city of Seattle Anthony
walks up behind her and tells her that
the foundation is defeated but Olivia
doesn't understand how we broke the
overseer's deal with death and killed
the accountant there's nothing more to
do we can go back to normal lives he
tells her Olivia is skeptical though
what about the 11th overseer and his
ability to Olivia's eyes suddenly go
wide she pulls out a knife and stabs it
into Anthony's Heart the world around
her begins to distort and fall apart it
was a false reality created by 05-11
better known as the liar Olivia wakes up
next to Adam in a hotel room she sits up
in a bed and rubs her eyes what a weird
dream she thinks then she realizes it
wasn't a dream she shakes Adam away
neither of them have any idea how they
ended up here but they know it must be
the doing of the liar they had planned
for this though with Calvin having
created a contingency plan they pull out
a laptop and log in to view the
classified information Calvin left for
them Olivia begins to type but stops
halfway through her password and looks
up from the screen Olivia pulls out the
gun that rests under her pillow and
shoots at him the false reality created
by the liar falls apart around her
Olivia comes out of the previous lie and
is sitting across the table from Calvin
she immediately draws her pistol and
points it at Calvin's head is it really
him or just another one of the Liar's
games Calvin tries to talk Olivia down
and she looks around the room for
inconsistencies that might tip her off
that this is another lie but doesn't
find any Olivia begins to relax she
tells Calvin that the liar is trying to
get something from her maybe the journal
can tell them what he is looking for as
long as she still has it Olivia nods her
head and holds out her wrist where a
subdermal chip with a copy of the
journal on it has been placed Calvin
looks at her wrist the world around them
begins to dissipate as Calvin morphs
into the liar Olivia wakes up in a
hospital where she is hooked up to an IV
sitting across from her is a former
Insurgency agent Named Sam Beal he
explains to her that he is the liar he
was forced into becoming a monster by
the foundation they had manipulated him
but now he is tired of running and can't
do it anymore she is free to go Olivia
hesitantly unhooks herself from the IV
she walks out of the hospital room and
BR proceeds down a fluorescent lit
hallway as she walks away she hears a
gunshot from the hospital room as Olivia
is in the hospital Calvin and Adam walk
through a dense forest they are
searching for 05-10 the journal
indicates that the 10th overseer's
identity within the foundation is the
archist in the middle of the clearing
are two saplings standing side by side
the void between the saplings shimmers
Calin walks through the portal and the
space begins to warp and twist around
him his vision finally comes back into
to focus and Calvin finds himself in
another world Adam enters the World
Behind Calvin practically knocking him
over as he enters through the portal
this is The Wanderer library but it
doesn't look anything like they expected
instead of rows of books the library is
filled with computer mainframes humming
with the collected knowledge of how to
contain anomalies a critical backup as
the two look intently at the strange
machines a figure in a silver robe
suddenly steps out of the darkness it's
tall and thin and though its hood is
pulled down so they can't see its face
they can see that its hands are covered
in scales that have a slight Emerald
tint it is one of the Librarians Calvin
tells the librarian that they're seeking
the archist but the librarian tells them
that the archist is no longer in the
library she has broken her packed with
the serpent and eaten fruit from The
Forbidden trees if they want to see her
though the librarian can take them to
her Calvin and Adam follow the librarian
down a long staircase passing by
countless doors filled with books
Scrolls works of art an entire universe
of knowledge eventually they reached the
bottom of the stairs where there stands
a giant set of brass doors Beyond the
Door the librarian explains is the
source of all knowledge before Calvin
and Adam pass through the doors though
Calvin turns to the librarian before we
go in I'd like to make a withdrawal he
says the librarian nods and pulls out a
silver tube out of its robe it hands the
tube to Adam and he looks it over in his
hands he looks up to ask what this is
but the librarian has vanished the door
then opens and the two step through
Calvin and Adam feel as if they walked
through the same kind of portal that
brought them to the library and find
that they have walked into a lush Green
Valley with two trees sitting underneath
one of them is a a woman in a white
dress she is reading a book and eating a
piece of fruit are you the archivist
Calvin asks the woman nods yes and
that's all the confirmation Calvin needs
he raises his pistol and fires but the
bullet passes right through the archist
as if she wasn't there do you read the
archist asked Calvin seemingly not
phased by his attempts to shoot her I
haven't had much time recently Calvin
replied the archivist explains that
she's read every book in the library the
collected knowledge of the universe is
in the books even one on how to allow
bullets to pass through your body she
came here to find the secret to
immortality it's her job to document
everything that happens in the world and
she can't do that if she's dead she
explains that she figured out that the
fruit that the serpent forbade everyone
to eat was an actual fruit but the
knowledge contained in the library by
having read every book she has consumed
the fruit she no longer needs the
serpent because she was the serpent the
archist falls to the ground and begins
to ride around contorting her body as it
starts to change she begins to elongate
as her limbs seemingly disappear the
next thing Calvin and Adam know they're
face to face with a giant snake Calvin
Dodges as the serpent lunges at him and
Adam stands in the doorway firing at the
snake with his pistol but just like with
the archivists human form the bullets
have no effect the serpent coils around
Calvin and begins to choke the life from
him as Adam can only watch helpless
Calvin cries out with his last breath
the tube Adam open the tube Adam takes
the tube that was given to him by the
librarian and opens the cap a long heavy
spear slides out that looks much too
large to have ever fit inside he drops
the tube to the ground and watches an
amazement as it starts to transform
turning into what looks like a large
Harpoon Gun Adam knows what to do do and
places the giant spear into the gun and
points it at the serpent you can't kill
me the giant snake says I've eaten from
the Tree of Life Adam pulls the trigger
and the huge spear flies through the air
striking the serpent in the head Adam
runs to Calvin and helps him to his feet
they turn to look at the snake but
instead of the menacing creature it's
the archist once again pinned against
the tree she once sat under the spear
sticking out of her skull
as the two stand looking at the archist
a tall hooded humanoid figure steps out
from behind the tree it looks similar to
The Librarian except its robe is a
greenish color and it wears long black
gloves the creature pulls the spear out
of the archist whose body slumps to the
ground and hands the spear to Calvin who
are you Calvin asks but his question is
ignored after a moment the figure
finally speaks that spear you now hold
is called the Spear of of the
nonbeliever it is an ancient weapon used
to kill Gods it is odd that someone in
this realm gave you the spear even with
it I'm not sure you will be able to
complete your quest Calvin Lucien but we
shall see there is a sudden flash of
light and Calvin and Adam find
themselves transported back to the
forest they had entered the wanderer's
library from a week later Calvin and
Anthony Tracked Down 05- 9 who in the
council is known as the out her she
isn't hard to find and it seems as if
she actually wanted to be found they
find her sitting outside of her burnt
down family home the journal had listed
this as her address but Calvin doubted
that she would be here and most he hoped
to find a clue to her whereabouts but
here she was sitting in the ashes of her
home without turning around the outsider
began speaking the council just used me
you know she says they took away my
academic career my friends and my life
they made me conduct research for them
that compromised everything I stood for
and now here I am with nothing The
Outsider lets out a sigh she ask Calvin
if he's afraid of death Calvin shakes
his head and responds Now The Outsider
slumps forward and Calvin walks around
to face her she is covered in blood her
eyes move to look up at Calvin you're
lying she says as she dies from
self-inflicted wounds Calvin and Anthony
cross 05- 9 off the list and head back
to the car as they walk Anthony says
what's been on everyone's mind the last
few days the easy part is done we'll
only get harder from here we know 05- is
in his castle I'm sure we'll get in but
I'm not sure if we'll make it out alive
I know replies Calvin but if we're going
to save the world we must eliminate the
rest of the overseers even if it means
sacrificing our own lives they get in
the car and drive off into the blood red
sunset to pick up the rest of the kill
squad team before their next mission
Calvin Lucian leads the kill squad team
through the mud and freezing rain in
front of them looms The Fortress of
Baron Leman hoodley the eighth overseer
the team has already been through a lot
from breaking the overseer council's
deal with death by eliminating
05-13 to using the Spear of the
non-believer to kill the Godlike archist
05-10 the hunting of overseers has taken
a toll on the kill Squad 05-12 almost
killed Adam and Olivia was stuck in what
seemed like an endless mind game with
05-11 the first five overseers were
eliminated but the words that the ninth
overseer spoke to Calvin Lucien before
she died still run through his mind are
you afraid of death now the kill Squad
is about to infiltrate one of the most
heavily guarded facilities in the world
to eliminate the eighth overseer upon
reaching the castle the team is
surprised to find the structure is in
ruin no one is supposed to know the
location of 058 though the Fortress was
supposed to be practically impregnable
they stormed the castle of 058 all the
same the journal Calvin possesses that
contains information about the members
of the SCP foundation's powerful 05
Council identifies him as a former
industrialist named Baron Leeman hodle
with his vast wealth hodle funded the
foundation at the start and was
considered the unofficial leader of the
council in its early days with immense
control over the actions of the
organization the kill Squad makes their
way through the dimly lit hallways of
the castle as they turn the corner
they're surprised to find the charred
remains of Baron Leeman h 's bodyguards
it seems that someone or something has
gotten to hodle before they could the
team makes their way to the main chamber
and breaches the door laying by a still
lit fireplace is
058 the kill Squad scans the room to
make sure the killer isn't still in
there with them Adam walks over to the
body and examines it he quickly realizes
that hoodley hasn't been murdered at all
he sees that Baron hole's body has been
drastically modified using anomalous
technology the overseer used his
immortality to modify almost every part
of his body to make himself stronger
unfortunately for Baron hoodley when the
overseers deal with death was broken by
Calvin the modifications to his body
slowly tore him apart his regular body
could no longer support all the
modifications and what once made him
practically Invincible became the very
thing that destroyed him the team leaves
the castle and Crosses 0 5-8 off their
list on their way out Adam pulls Calvin
aside he has the feeling that Anthony
hasn't been completely honest with the
rest of the team he had the feeling that
Anthony was hiding something from them
Calvin had similar thoughts recently he
pushes Anthony for more information
about his past and Anthony reveals that
he's over 100 years old the vial of
water from the Fountain of Youth that
Calvin has was not the only one early in
his career with the Insurgency he had
confiscated other vials from a
foundation's site his Squad drank the
water and it extended their lives he
asks Calvin on what he plans on doing
with his water from the fountain I'm
going to destroy it Calvin tells him
Anthony agrees with this plan once you
drink from the Fountain of Youth you may
extend your life but a part of you dies
at the same time vibrancy of the senses
disappears leading to a seemingly
shallow life if Anthony could go back
and do it again he never would have
drank the water Calvin receives Intel
from the Insurgency that the seventh
overseers in a small town in Cambodia
the kill Squad makes their way to the
village and surveys the area hoping to
get a glimpse at the overseer who code
named green as the team conducts
reconnaissance Anthony tells them that
he thinks the mission is a setup it is
too remote and there are so many unknown
variables but Calvin is convinced that
this might be their only chance to kill
green since green arrived in the area
there has been non-stop chaos she has
destabilized the local governments and
now the area is in an allout War the
team weaves through narrow passageways
between houses and buildings trying to
make their way to the central compound
where green is located suddenly a mob
starts to form they are getting closer
and closer to the team in a quick
decision to avoid being seen Calvin
orders everyone into a nearby building
before Anthony can follow the mob rounds
the corner they spot Anthony and he's
forced to flee Calvin Olivia and Adam
watch as the mob chases after Anthony
but they have to keep moving Calvin know
that Anthony can take care of himself
and they are too close to their goal to
stop now Calvin slowly opens the front
door of the house they are hiding in and
peers out the coast looks clear so he
signals Olivia and Adam to follow him
before they can step out into the street
a gas canister enters through a cracked
doorway the room fills with sleeping gas
and the team passes out when they are
awake they are tied up in a large room
with marble vaulted ceilings 0 5-7 is
standing in front of Calvin she's Smiles
wickedly while holding a knife she
compliments Calvin on what he and his
team have been able to do so far no one
believed they could pull off even a
fraction of what they have but now she
has an offer for Calvin she points
towards Adam and Olivia and tells Calvin
he must choose one of them to die if he
doesn't she'll kill the leader of the
riers and plunge another part of the
country into chaos screw you is Calvin's
response very well utters green have it
your way she assassinates the leader
being held in her compound then turns
back to Calvin she now threatens to
torture his team until Calvin makes a
choice of who to kill green slashes
Adam's cheek with her knife as Calvin
screams for green to leave his team
alone and torture him instead green Just
Smiles I'm going to enjoy killing your
friends while you watch as you have
killed so many of my overseers on the
counsil she reaches up in the air with
the knife above Adam's head before she
can plunge the knife through his skull a
bullet passes through her hand causing
her to drop the knife Anthony kneels on
a rooftop across the courtyard smoking
sniper rifle still pointed at Green who
runs Calvin uses the drop knife to cut
his ropes and chases after green he
follows her to the roof where he watches
as she boards a helicopter the aircraft
lifts off as Anthony Fires at it from
his original position but does no
serious damage in the plaza below the
mob that has separated the team earlier
becomes restless there is complete chaos
in someone fires a rocket at the fleeing
helicopter the rocket hits the tail of
the aircraft sending it crashing into
the plaza full of riers below as the
crowd flees from the sea Calvin makes
his way towards the wreckage and reaches
it at the same time Anthony does Calvin
looks at him smiles and thanks him for
saving his life Anthony smiles back but
before he can say anything a gunshot
rings out and a bullet rips through his
neck Calvin turns to see where it came
from and is horrified to see the burning
body of 0
5-7 her skin has been charred black but
in her burnt hand she holds a gun what's
left of her lips curl back in a Sinister
grin as she fires again and hits Anthony
in the chest he falls to the ground
Kelvin runs to him and pulls out his gun
to shoot 0 5-7 but she is already dead
Calvin holds his dying teammate as blood
pours out of his neck and chest but
Calvin can stop this he pulls out the
vial of water from the fountain no wi is
Anthony I have lived long enough thank
you my friend I will see you in whatever
lies Beyond this life Anthony's chest
Rises then Falls it does not rise again
olivan Adam Round the Corner to see
Calvin holding the lifeless body of
their teammate tears flowing from his
eyes the team holds a small ceremony and
burial for Anthony but are only halfway
through their mission and can't stop now
they fly back to the United States where
an undercover Insurgency agent named
Kowalski informs them that 0 5-6 is
already aware they're after him this
overseer is codenamed the American
because he has the power of the entire
US military at his fingertips the kill
Squad Scouts the base where the American
is located Kowalski warns them of a
crate that was recently brought to the
base from site 19 the Americans showed
great interest in whatever was in the
container the group sets up a camp on a
hill overlooking the base as the sun
slowly Rises the next day the kill Squad
is spotted by a drone and forced to hop
in their Jeep and try to run they make
their way down the hill finding
themselves in the valley below with no
clear exit in front of them lands a
helicopter as Humvees Roar into the
canyon behind them the team is
surrounded a Jeep pulls up and 0 5-6
steps out he introduces himself as Rufus
King member of the overseer Council but
an American citizen first and foremost
all he really wants is to protect the
country he loves thanks to you I've lost
my immortality and can no longer
effectively protect the United States
anymore the American says to celvin but
I'm willing to make a deal your freedom
for the Spear of the non-believer rumor
has it that you have the spear in your
possession and you used it to kill the
archivist you give me the spear I will
let you go no replies Calvin I will
never give an overseer the means to
cause more destruction the spear stays
with us very well the American says with
a fr
then I suppose my only other option is
to take it from you but not without
giving you a fair chance run Calvin
Lucien run as fast as you can I will be
coming for you the American turns and
walks towards the container from site 19
which is being lowered from a helicopter
hovering above them Calvin Sprints back
to the jeep with the other members of
his team as they drive away they hear a
horrible guttural Screech from whatever
was inside the container after a few
moments the Army begins to pursue them
out in front of the military force is
05- 6 writing SCP 682 he is using a
black whip to urge the creature forward
and they're gaining on the kill Squad
fast a row of vehicles pulls up beside
the American and SCP 682 then something
strange happens a man appears in front
of the oncoming for es led by the
American the man's skin bulges and seems
to be moving from within the skin of the
man SLS from his body the infection that
is SCP 610 erupts out of him and onto
the soldiers in the nearby Jeep SCP 610
begins to infect and consume everyone
around it suddenly there are thousands
of instances of SCP 610 coming from the
mountain side flooding into the valley
they close in and around the Army and 0
5-6 the the American begins fighting off
the flesh eating creatures from the back
of SCP 682 but he becomes overwhelmed he
can no longer focus on pursuing Calvin
and his team from the back of the Jeep
Olivia pulls out her rifle she aims and
fires the bullet hits the American in
the chest he is flung off the back of
SCP 682 and engulfed in a sea of SCP 610
creatures the kill Squad continues to
drive trying to put as much distance
between themselves and the SCP p610
infestation as possible but then Calvin
suddenly Slams on The Brak standing in
front of them is a man in a black suit
and bow tie he introduces himself as
Blackbird the fifth overseer according
to the journal his actual name is
Mortimer Jay Denning Von Crocker he
stands in front of the jeep with a
menacing grin you have been causing a
lot of trouble he says looking at Calvin
Olivia swings her gun around oh please
my dear that won't help help you Von
cnar says he pulls out a knife and stabs
himself through the neck he falls to the
ground apparently dead there is a gust
of wind a whiff of ozone and an
identical copy and still very much alive
on Crocker lands next to his own dead
body see what I mean he says Olivia
lowers her rifle come with me I have
something to show you the Blackbird
beckons seeing no other option Calvin
Olivia Adam exit the Jeep and followed
the Blackbird as they walk the world
changes around them the desert mountains
Fade Away into Blackness and find
themselves in the near apocalyptic
London oh it's good to be home the
Blackbird says as they emerge onto a
cobblestone street you cannot stop the
overseer's plans however I can give you
an alternative let's see if any of you
will take it in front of each kill Squad
member appears adore they have an
uncontrollable urge to open their
respective door and walk walk through
the Blackbird stands smiling as he
watches Calvin Olivia and Adam enter
each of their portals Adam enters his
door and looks around he is in Portland
his parents walk into the room in this
universe his family has been granted
Asylum Adam never has to interact with
any scps or the foundation he is free to
live a normal life from the kitchen
comes Calvin wearing an apron he is
holding a steaming pot Adam locks eyes
with Calvin who Smiles at him the black
Whispers into Adam's ear in this reality
both of your parents and siblings are
still alive also the man you love loves
you back you and Calvin could be married
if you stayed here wouldn't that be nice
Olivia enters her door she is on the
deck of a yacht at the bow sits an easel
with art supplies the man that Olivia
once loved walks across the deck towards
her the black bird looms over her in
this reality you didn't accidentally
kill him this could be be your happily
ever after wouldn't that be nice Calvin
steps through his door he's in a grassy
clearing near a lake the Blackbird
hisses in Calvin's ear I'm giving you
the opportunity to save your mother this
time Calvin you were just a scared
little boy but in this reality you can
be brave you can actually save your
mother from her fate no Calvin screams
this isn't real the Blackbird cackles
Calvin looks away from the lake towards
the tree line hidden in the shadows he
can just barely make out a hooded figure
Calvin walks towards it the Blackbird
follows he is screaming at the person in
the tree line I was only trying to help
the hooded figure reaches out and hands
Calvin a metal tube he opens it to find
a set of eyeglasses inside Calvin puts
them on and turns to look at the
Blackbird he steps back in horror the
glasses have revealed the true form of
the Blackbird he is a winged pseudo Aven
monstrosity full of Rage the mysterious
hooded figure directs Calvin to open the
tube again inside is an interdimensional
fishing line made by DR Wonder tainment
and a white whiffle ball bat Calvin
grabs the fishing line and wraps it
around 05- 5's leg the Blackbird flies
into the air trying to get away from
Calvin but Calvin wraps the other end of
the fishing line around his arm the
Blackbird begins to jump from Dimension
to Dimension trying to get rid of Calvin
they appear on the deck of SCP 4 55 in
site 19 where SCP 682 walks freely in
the dead world of SCP
2935 every time they stop in a new
dimension Calvin takes the opportunity
to attack the blackbird with the bat and
it seems that he is slowly weakening the
monster they finally land at the bottom
of a deep well foundation containment
site where the dark body that is SCP 001
is contained standing in front of the
containment field is Allison Cho the
black queen whose sole mission is to
destroy the foundation you cries the
Blackbird you are the one who's been
helping Lucien The Black Queen nods her
head yes I have been helping Calvin
Lucien to eliminate you and the other
overseers the foundation Must Fall you
are nothing you cannot stop me I am the
black king screams 0 5-5 Allison Chow
size she pushes a button on the panel
next to her shutting down the array
containing the dark body out of the
cloud of dust appears SCP 001 a massive
black creature who seem to absorb all
light no stop shrieks the Blackbird SCP
001 does not move but the room begins to
shake the Blackbird continues to scream
as his body folds in on itself until he
is reduced to a single superheated point
and then blinks out of existence Allison
Chow then reactivates the containment
array sealing 001 away once again I will
return you to your reality along with
your friends says the black queen but
perhaps our path shall cross again
Calvin Lucien there is a bright flash of
light and Calvin finds himself on a
private jet sitting next to Olivia and
Adam they are all shaken but the
Blackbird is dead 0 5-5 has been
eliminated the three members of the team
sit silently still pondering What Might
Have Been if they stayed in the
alternate re ities suddenly the phone on
the plane begins to ring breaking the
silence Calvin picks it up on the other
line is the fourth overseer he has
contacted Calvin to discuss surrendering
to the Insurgency unfortunately things
do not always go as planned Calvin
Lucien is about to make the most
difficult and dangerous decision of his
life Aaron seagull better known to
Foundation members as 0 5-1 descends
into into the abyss of a Deep Well site
he exits the elevator and peers into the
optical scanner to unlock the reinforced
door inside the room is mobile task
force TOA 5 samsara Aaron seagull refers
to these Immortal cyborg clones created
from the Flesh of a dead God as his red
right hand your mission is to eliminate
the traitor 05- 4 and to find the
insurgents who have been killing the
members of the overseer Council the
cyborg stand at attention now Aaron
seagull screams the soldiers of the red
right hand March out the door to start
their mission Aaron seagull pauses for a
moment and then slams his fist against
the wall in frustration he has lost nine
overseers to Calvin Lucian and his kill
squad team they have been somehow
overcoming the odds each time and
eliminating each overseer they track
down it wasn't supposed to end this way
Aaron seagull vows to kill them all
Calvin Lucian meanwhile sits on a
private jet with Adam and Olivia he had
just hung up the phone after a
conversation with 054 the overseer known
as the Ambassador wants to surrender to
the Insurgency there's a good chance
this is a trap but Calvin has decided to
meet with the Ambassador all the same
Calvin drops off Adam and Olivia at an
Insurgency base they still haven't fully
recovered from the previous Mission with
05- 5 known as the Blackbird before
leaving though Calvin meets with an
Insurgency agent named Sylvester Sloan
who is going to join him as support
Calvin says goodbye to Adam and Olivia
then leaves with Sloan to meet The
Ambassador in South Africa after landing
at Johannesburg airport Calvin and Sloan
disembark and are led to a conference
room where the Ambassador sits waiting
for them Calvin and Sloan sit across
from 0 5-4 to discuss his surrender the
council is in shambles says the
Ambassador everything is falling apart I
want to offer my services and
information to the Insurgency in
exchange for protection from 05- one he
has lost his mind Calvin agrees to the
terms and prepares for extraction but as
they get up from the table gunshots can
be heard from down the hall the
ambassador's eyes open wide in Terror
it's too late he whispers Calvin and
Sloan grab the Ambassador who is Frozen
in fear and exit the conference room
they make their way towards their plane
but the gunshots are getting closer
Calvin looks over his shoulder to see
some Sor pursuing them through the
terminal Calvin shoves the Ambassador
behind a table as bullets whiz overhead
Calvin and Loan return fire but their
volley doesn't seem to slow down the
Assassins Calvin and slan pull the
ambassador to his feet and they burst
through an emergency exit onto the
sunbaked tarmac where they make a Mad
Dash for the plane from behind them a
bullet rips through the chest of Sloan
the red right hand has caught up but
Calvin continues to drag the Ambassador
towards the plane they are almost there
suddenly a metallic child's Voice blares
through the air rep reports external
speakers the child's voice says I want
Calvin Lucien alive I have business to
settle with him the red right-and
soldiers tackle Calvin and the
ambassador to the ground when they are
just feet away from the plane kill the
traitor the child's voice says and
Calvin can only watch helplessly as the
Ambassador is violently murdered one of
the agents turns towards Calvin and
slams his fist into Calvin's face
causing him to black out Calvin awakes
in a dark room he is UN sure how much
time has passed the only light in the
room comes from a screen on the wall in
the middle of the screen is a rotating
red SCP Foundation seal a voice from a
speaker speaks hello Calvin Lucien my
name is the kid I am the third overseer
you have killed all my friends and now I
will kill all of yours the door to the
room opens Calvin leans through the
doorway there is a long dimly lit
hallway the kid orders him to proceed so
so they can meet face to face as Calvin
walks the kid's voice Echoes down the
hallway there once was another
05-30 built incredible machines even one
that could see into the future but
unfortunately for him he did not have
the passion required to be an overseer
that was when I was born I was chosen by
the other overseers to have my spinal
cord severed in a way that gave me the
ability of the allseeing eye I now watch
everything all of the time I have
perfect reasoning perfect awareness and
perfect understanding Calvin gets to the
end of the corridor which opens up into
a large chamber tied up in the middle of
the room are Olivia and Adam Calvin runs
to his friends and crouches down next to
them a mechanical suit stands on a
platform looking down at Calvin Olivia
and Adam Calvin realizes the kid must be
contained inside I now sentence you all
to death the mechanical suit says as the
red right hand steps Out of The Shadow
shadows and slowly walks towards the
remaining members of the kill Squad
suddenly there's a flash of light and
the black queen appears stop what are
you doing shrieks the kid the black
queen hands Calvin the interdimensional
rod and reel he used to defeat the
blackb bird Calvin casts the rod from
out of the terror in space comes a
massive multi-armed creature known as
madron the red right hand engages the
monster trying to force it back into its
Dimension but the monster is too too
powerful he grabs the cyborg clones and
pulls them through the tear in reality
as samsara battles the madicon Calvin
freeze Olivia and Adam they make a run
for the door but as they flee one of the
walls opens up to reveal a turret the
gun fires and a bullet hits Olivia
directly in the head killing her
instantly no yells Calvin before Calvin
can push Adam out of the way a second
Bullet From the turret lodes itself in
Adam's back Calvin and Adam slide across
the floor the kid in his mechanical suit
jumps down from the platform above I am
going to kill you now Calvin Lucien he
says in his mechanical voice there is
another flash of light Calvin watches in
front of him as the Spear of the
non-believer manifests itself before his
eyes Calvin grabs the spear and shoves
it into the kid's machine body it easily
penetrates the armor and pins him to the
wall Calvin walks up to the EXO skeleton
and tears off the outer plating
revealing a tank full of fluid within
which floats a mountain formed human
fetus as Calvin finally looks upon the
kid's True Form he hears the sound of
mocking mechanical laughter Calvin
breaks the glass and crushes the kid
with his bare hands as Calvin turns from
the now silent robotic body of the kid
the room begins to shake debris raining
down from above Calvin helps Adam up and
puts Olivia's lifeless body across his
shoulders what remains of the kill Squad
makes their way out of the kid's Lair
outside of the foundation site where
they were being held Calvin helps Adam
lie down on the ground before gently
setting Olivia's body next to him Adam
grimaces as blood pours out of the wound
in his back Calvin reaches into his
pocket and pulls out the vial of water
from the Fountain of Youth there are
only a couple of drops left which he
pours into Adam's mouth Adam looks up at
Calvin tears filling his eyes he
whispers I love you before he passes out
from the pain the wound in his back
begins to heal instantly and Calvin
calls an Insurgency Evac team to come
pick up Adam with Adam safe Calvin picks
up Olivia and walks alone towards a
truck in the lot outside of the
foundation site he needs to finish this
once and for all he will kill the last
two overseers or he will die trying 0
5-1 Aaron seagull arrives at where the
tigress and Euphrates rivers meet the
Garden of Eden he is in a frenzy due to
the assassinations of all the other
overseers besides himself and the
Nazarene and nothing will stop him as he
approaches the gate to the Garden of
Eden though he is stopped by the
guardian of the garden a massive
powerful anomalous entity with a flaming
sword but Aaron seagull has no time or
patience for anything to get in his way
even something as powerful as the gate
Guardian the guardian swings his burning
sword at Adam who rolls out of the way
and in a Flash takes out a Scranton
reality anchor he slams the anchor into
the ground which causes the world to
Shimmer and ripple around him he watches
as the Flames from the gate Guardian
Sword seem to obsorb back into its body
before it shrinks down looking to fold
in on itself until all that is left is a
charred skeleton with the guardian
defeated Aaron Sprints into the garden
he searches the garden for 0 5-2 but
can't find her anywhere he finally comes
to the tree of life and that's where he
finds her laying at the base of the tree
in a pool of blood is the Nazarene she
has taken her own life this is her
anomalous power though she has died many
times before yet death always spared her
and brought her back but somehow he
knows this time is final Aaron drops to
his knees and screams in frustration for
all the power Aaron seagull possesses
there's nothing he can do now he sits
next to the nazar's body for hours
hoping that she might wake up or that he
will to find that this was all a dream
after sitting next to her cold body for
some time he notices something in her
Snowy White Hand it's a not in it the
Nazarene explains that she was the one
who gave the vials from the fountain to
Calvin Lucian and that she is the one
who made the spear appear before him
that he used to kill the kid she
explained that while she died many times
and death always brought her back each
time she felt less and less like herself
less and less like Dr Sophia light she
hoped that maybe if things ended up like
this it would give Aaron the chance to
walk away and live the life that they
might have been able to have together
but she knows deep down that Aaron's
fade is to meet Calvin and finish things
once and for all Aaron seagull screams
in Rage clutching the node in his hand
he tries to summon death but no one
comes Aaron seagull is alone he stands
up and walks deeper into the garden
he walks until he reaches a spot where
even God's light does not reach in this
desolate land is an impact crater where
Lucifer star of the morning had fallen
in the middle of the crater lies
Lucifer's sword Aaron seagull descends
into the hole and picks up the sword he
turns and exits the Garden of Eden Aaron
seagull has only one mission in life now
to kill Calvin Lucien Calvin reads the
final entry of the journal in it the
author warns that although he hopes the
information contained within the journal
is helpful he hopes the reader does not
try to use it the words written on the
final page are this information will
only lead you to a devastating end
Calvin closes the journal and looks up
at the structure in front of him he has
made it to sight 01 he had left Olivia's
body in a cave nearby promising to her
that he would make this right he now
walks up to the massive doors and places
his hand on the nodded wood the doors
slowly Creek open Calvin pauses for a
moment and looks behind him at the
Setting Sun he enters site 01 where he
knows 0 5-1 is where Aaron seagull Waits
inside the main hall Calvin sees a giant
doorway in the shape of the SCP
Foundation seal with artistic depictions
of certain scps that he instinctively
knows are special in some way standing
next to the doorway is a 2 m tall man in
what looks to be a futuristic suit
Calvin approaches and asks who this
giant man is he responds that his name
is purpose the red right hand he is the
guardian of 0 5-1 and None Shall enter
the sanctum until he returns he isn't
here ask Calvin no purpose responds he
is and with that he steps aside and lets
Calvin pass through the doorway the
doorway leads into a large room where
screens on the wall flash to light
depicting moments from Calvin's Journey
documenting his entire Quest had he been
in control at all or was this all a
setup to lead him to this moment as he
walks forward he finally sees him
sitting at a table in the middle of the
room is Aaron seagull Euro 5-1 Calvin
asks Aaron the man responds my name is
Aaron Calvin asks about the location of
the second overseer the Nazarene but 051
one doesn't respond without needing any
more information Calvin pulls out his
sidearm and in a Flash fires off five
shots the bullets stopped in the air
inches from Aaron before dissolving in a
flash of light Calvin should have known
it wouldn't be this easy stand up Aaron
seagull Calvin calls up as he holers his
gun let's finish it Calvin pulled the
Spear of the nonbeliever from his back
but Aaron's only response was to
laugh you don't even know why you're
here Aaron said Calvin calls back I'm
here to kill you because when I do I
kill the foundation because when you're
gone the universe can finally heal
you're like me Calvin Lucien we are both
men driven by our own convictions
regardless of the outcome it would seem
Fate has brought us together now either
your convictions will be broken or you
will die says Aaron seagull he then
draws Lucifer's flaming sword and lunges
towards Calvin Lucian as the two men
clash with one another their
Supernatural weapons begin to destroy
the room around them Furniture is
shattered video screens are obliterated
and fire spreads across the walls Aaron
catches Calvin off balance and swings
the Flaming sword across Calvin's
stomach Calvin slides back from the
impact hunching over from the pain in
his midsection he brings his head up to
see Aaron seagull running towards him
with a flaming sword high in the air
Calvin brings up the spear spear from
his knees he leans back and launches it
towards Aaron seagull the spear enters
the final overseer's chest the force
from the throw pinning him against the
wall Aaron seagull drops Lucifer's sword
it shatters as it hits the ground he
clutches the shaft of the spear
protruding from his sternum with both
hands 0 5-1 looks at Calvin
unbelievingly you have no idea what
you've done it was never about the
overseers Aaron seagull says spitting
out blood with every word it was
something deeper something worse Calvin
walks slowly towards Aaron seagull he
stops just in front of his final enemy
this is the way it ends Calvin says
Aaron seagull manages to whisper one
final word Sophia before his body
finally goes limp Calvin turns to see
purpose standing behind him he's dead
Calvin says half to purpose and half to
himself I killed him after a moment he
asks purpose what he really wants to
know there's a room in this facility
where someone could unmake the
foundation right take me there without
any hesitation purpose leads Calvin back
to the room with depictions of important
scps there purpose opens the door to an
elevator but stops Calvin before he can
get inside I am Duty bound to tell you
purpose says that once you step inside
this elevator there is no going back
there is only one decision to be made
and it is not one that can be unmade I
know Calvin responds it's time before
stepping inside the elevator opens a
door to reveal a room filled with
bookcases and a huge window offering a
beautiful view of the sun setting behind
the mountains on the wall are monitors
depicting the ways he had killed all of
the overseers and in the middle of the
room is a large desk with a computer
Calvin sits down at the desk and the
computer comes to life the computer
prompts him to scan his fingerprint
which it accepts he's logged in the
computer screen displays numerous
locations around the planet and he
quickly recognizes that they are all SCP
Foundation science then he sees the
single option the computer is giving him
terminate Kelvin reaches out with his
finger this is it once he presses this
button the SCP Foundation will be no
more his finger is millim from the Buton
button when the phone rings Calvin
hadn't even noticed that there was a
phone on the desk Calvin stares at it
for a moment then picks it up hello he
says the voice on the other line
responds hello Calvin Lucien my name is
the administrator I've been following
your work for some time now and I must
say I am impressed I have just been
informed that you have completed your
mission congratulations are in order
what the hell are you talking about
Calvin asks please listen says The Voice
on the other line the man you just
killed was once in the same exact
position you are in now granted it was a
very long time ago but Aaron seagull
originally was trying to destroy the
foundation that was until I convinced
him otherwise and now like Aaron seagull
you will become the new head of the
foundation like hell I will yells Calvin
I could hang up and walk away right now
and be done with all of this you could
continues the administrator but if no
one is in charge of of the SCP
Foundation millions of people will die
if not billions and then nobody would be
there to manage what comes after there
is silence from Calvin that's what I
thought says the administrator I look
forward to working with you Calvin
Lucien or should I say
05- one the line goes
dead
the orora cycle one of the biggest most
legendary series of entries in the
history of the SCP Foundation we've
covered the events of this SCP 001 epic
in six videos which we definitely
recommend you watch before this one to
avoid your brain exploding from the
sheer scope of it all because that's the
thing about the orborous cycle it's a
story so big sprawling and dense that it
can feel almost like an anomaly itself
whether you're immersed in the possible
orig of the broken God the sentient
black hole that can destroy the whole
universe or Calvin lucian's quest to
assassinate the 05 Council it can
sometimes be difficult to see the forest
from the trees but worry not because
that's exactly why we're here today
we're going to step back and look at
this anomalous Odyssey as a whole and
ask the big question why is it all here
together what makes these four different
story lines the children the broken God
atonement and the way it ends one big
cycle as with anything involving the SCP
Foundation there's always going to be an
element of personal interpretation but
now that we've gone through the whole
cycle we think it's worth adding r two
cents to the proceedings so let's start
broad a question you've probably been
wondering is what do the words orboros
cycle actually mean and what is their
significance to the four stories within
while the spelling can differ or boros
refers to the ancient symbol of a snake
or dragon eating its own tail for
forming a circle a direct connection to
the concept of Cycles the rbar symbol
has existed in a huge number of cultures
from the ancient Egyptians to the
ancient Greeks to Modern Gnostic
Traditions it's often used in alchemy or
other magical practices and has a
variety of meanings such as eternal life
the endless cycle of death and rebirth
and the cycle of renewal anyone familiar
with the tales within the orborous cycle
is probably already noticing some
similarities Cycles are a common theme
in all of these Works people endlessly
repeat mistakes threats thought to be
contained or destroyed return and often
times those who go out on a quest to
destroy something end up becoming what
they wish to destroy in the first place
in a cycle there is no true end and no
true beginning everything repeats
endlessly but let's start at the closest
thing to the beginning we have the
children in this Tale the foundation
faces off against a terrifying reality
warping group of interests known as as
the kingdom of abdon this nasty Group
which came from the Sahara Desert could
seemingly take anything the foundation
threw at them and were able to straight
up vaporize anyone who got too close if
the kingdom was able to amass enough
power it could spell the end of the
foundation and even the subjugation of
the human race enter 0 5-1 a reoccurring
character in the orboros cycle this
outside the box thinker put all his
chips on the twins of God project
designated SCP 001 like many anomalies
before and after it this project would
Infuse a human being with god-like
powers but it was a power so great that
it seemed to kill anyone who attempted
to accept it needless to say this was a
major bummer for 0 5-1 but through
Relentless human experimentation even
sacrificing the population of entire
towns to the project he eventually came
up with a solution a horrifying solution
but a solution nonetheless he found that
a group of nine children with a ages
varying from 4 to 11 could act as a
human conduit for 001's power and as a
result it could be a weapon capable of
turning the tide against the kingdom of
abdon during the testing phase though it
seemed like 05- one went a little mad
with power he vaporized an entire church
of the broken God place of worship and
used the power of the children to wipe a
few others off the map at his own
discretion his abuses of power got so
flagrant that the administrator himself
was called in to get a handle on the
situ situation and surprise surprise 0
5-1 disintegrated him too before
disappearing himself shortly afterwards
in the end the children were deemed too
dangerous to be practical both because
of their anomalous powers and from the
level of ambient radiation they put out
all nine were locked in radiation prooof
boxes and buried in the desert though
they each show signs of life to this day
while this may seem disconnected from
the rest of the series it actually
establishes some of the most important
reoccurring themes in and ideas of the
cycle as a whole namely the foundation
messing with reality and Performing
horrific acts to achieve their goals the
corruption of the 05 Council and the
fact that these Grand attempts to change
or save the world often blow up in
everyone's Faces Sometimes literally we
also have the introduction and apparent
death of the mysterious administrator
but trust us all Is Not What It Seems
with this one the ripple effect
beginning here will affect everything
going forward next the broken God this
tells the chaotic story of a magical
Clockwork box which is worshiped by the
church of the broken God as a conduit to
their deity and eventually becomes an
all devouring mechanical Kaiju the Beast
soon dubbed SCP 001 devoured and
consumed all the metal around it slowly
becoming larger and more destructive if
the foundation didn't take it out before
it reached critical mass they'd be going
toe-to-toe with a Bonafide God a fight
they really weren't sure they could win
thankfully and with a little anomalous
help from SCP 2399 the foundation was
able to destroy the anomaly they removed
its Clockwork hard from the wreckage and
contained the anomalous scrap that once
comprised its destructive body however
the foundation soon realized that you
just can't keep a good god down the
Clockwork heart eventually evaded
Foundation containment while being
shipped to a secondary location and
instead ended up in a small town here it
began to influence the minds of the
residents into more subservient broken
God cultists intent on building him back
up to his former glory it'd be easy to
Discount the broken God as an outlier
seeing as the foundation came out
looking much better here than they do in
any of the other or borus Tales but when
you look carefully its place in the
overall cycle is clear the entry ends
the way it begins with the heart of the
broken God influencing humans to carry
out its bidding the foundation had to
intervene in between these two instances
but in the end there was no n loss to
the broken God itself in a sense the
foundation is doomed to encounter the
same problems again and again
continually defending the world from the
same anomalous threats and the
foundation needs to succeed every time
to maintain peace and normality a major
anomalous threat only needs to succeed
once to drag everything into disarray in
many ways that is the curse of the SCP
Foundation speaking of major anomalous
threats now it's time for part three of
the or Bor cycle atonement once again we
start off with the foundation meddling
with Cosmic scale Powers with the
creation of the area 11 Petri Cal
Fontaine spatial stabilization array try
saying that three times fast that was a
machine so powerful it was capable of
creating a singularity though what it
actually ended up doing was turning Dr
Calvin desmat into an Abomination more
specifically into a kind of immensely
powerful humanoid black hole whose
Powers were only restrained by the very
machine that created him think of him as
kind of a malicious Dr Manhattan from
Watchmen this new entity dubbed SCP 001
presented a grim prophecy and an ominous
offer he told the 05 Council that
anomalies were leaking into their
Universe from other realities and soon
the anomalous threat would destroy them
all his offer was to upon his release
wipe out the rest of the Multiverse
entirely leaving only our reality free
from anomalous threats
unsurprisingly it was 05- one that was
most interested in this offer so much so
that he held a vote and murdered
everyone who voted against the decision
to release SCP 001 having built his
consensus among the survivors on the
council 051 let SCP 001 out
unsurprisingly this turned out to be a
terrible decision as one of his first
acts upon being freed was to kill the
members of the 05 Council that had just
voted to release 001 saying that they
themselves were anomalous and needed to
be purged to atone for their past sins
the only Survivor was a member of the
council who abstained from the vote who
was able to recontain SCP 001 inside the
Petri Cal Fontaine array for now once
again the Thematic connections to the
rest of the ororo cycle is clear we have
a world-ending anomaly held off but only
temporarily buying time before the cycle
inevitably continues we have the
foundation abusing its power and signing
off on the death of countless people in
other dimensions and of course the 05
Council stepped out of their bounds and
actively warped reality just like they
had with the children before their
chickens truly come home to roost though
in the final part of the cycle
appropriately named the way it ends this
piece Chronicles the story of Calvin
Lucien and the kill Squad an elite group
of four chaos Insurgency Soldiers with
one goal assassinating the entire 05
Council 13 of the most powerful people
in the world why because they've been
messing with reality itself time and
time again and it's getting to the point
that their selfish meddling could
finally destroy everything and given
that we've already seen it happen with
the children and the entity that Dr
Calvin desmit became it's hard to
disagree with them what follows is one
of the longest and most complicated
tales in all of the foundation as the
kill Squad systematically encounters and
kills each insane anomalous member of
the 05 Council in order to do this they
need to make deals with death itself
fight giant serpents cross Dimensions
deal with SCP 610 and SCP 682
containment breaches and go toe-to-toe
with Sam Sara arguably the foundation's
deadliest mobile task force a number of
other insane things happen along the way
like 05- one murdering the gate Guardian
with the Scranton reality anchor and the
black queen the most prominent member of
the Serpent's hand helping our heroes
defeat more overseas years in the end
Calvin Lucien despite losing almost
everything Reigns victorious in the
final battle using the Spear of the
non-believer a weapon so powerful it can
kill Gods Calvin managed to finally kill
the Top member of the overseers 05- one
with the 05 Council destroyed Calvin set
about completing his final task
destroying the entire SCP Foundation but
that didn't happen instead he was
contacted by a mysterious and immensely
powerful being being known as the
administrator who gave him some
frightening news he'd just been hired by
the SCP Foundation to be their new 05-
one this was where our last video on the
arboros series left us what happens next
you may ask how does Calvin respond to
this offer he seemingly can't refuse in
this case it seems that the
administrator of being so completely
tied to the nature of the foundation
itself is SCP 001 and while it seemed
that the over overseers were mad with
power they were actually always there to
keep the administrator in check Aaron
seagler the 05- one that Calvin had just
killed was doing the exact same thing
Calvin was doing when he became 05- one
trying to destroy the foundation but the
foundation and the administrator cannot
be beaten they can only be joined and
that's exactly what Calvin did becoming
the new
to the council and the foundation in his
own image Insurgency members who were
once his allies vowed revenge for this
betrayal perhaps suggesting that history
would go on to repeat itself once more
in the future because at the end of the
day that's what the ororo cycle really
is the reoccurring threat and the
changing of the guards that accompanies
it there will always be a foundation
there will always be an administrator
there will always be an 05 counsil
nothing starts nothing ends all that
ever changes are the names and faces
involved whether it's Calvin Lucien or
Aaron seagler the wheel keeps turning
the snake devours its own tail the oboro
cycle is and forever will be Eternal
does the black moon howl no not yet see
the boy he was born in a time before
names there weren't enough humans around
to need them back then he was one of a
handful occupying a Coastal Village
using a tongue long since dead they eak
out a simple life hunting Gathering
fishing the only thing on most of their
minds was surviving to see the next
sunrise yes a simple life free of
complications until the hermit appeared
the boy would remember this man for
eternity Haggard and thin skin weathered
by time and in pain a man that emaciated
walking with a long gnarled cane that
honestly looked healthier than he did
shouldn't be alive even the boy who had
scarcely seen beyond the bounds of his
village knew that the hermit was a
natural an aberration an anomaly he
walked into the center of the village
sat down on a large Stone and waited
nobody dared ask his business nor what
the hermit waited for then a few days
later the black moon howled the boy saw
The Village's youngest Hunter freeze one
evening while out on a walk not simply
stand still but freeze then for an
instant he became solid black a cal
statue and as soon as he' changed he was
gone obliterated not a trace of him
remained such is the power of the black
moon it can make any conscious being
disappear in an instant turned black
then wiped from our plane of existence
never to be seen again its choice of
victims seemed at each instance to be
utterly random but it would come for all
who lived eventually this is known to
some as the howling of the black moon
later that same night the boy found
himself talking to the hermit who asked
with small frantic eyes what he had seen
when the boy told him he let out a deep
rattling sigh the boy curious asked him
if he knew about the nightmare he' just
witnessed The Hermit looked up he'd been
the first one in the hermit's Millennia
of pursuit that had ever asked in that
moment he knew that he had found his
successor in the hunt for the death of
Ages The Hermit told the boy it went by
many names the great finale The Pale
King but most common of all was the
black moon The Entity existed Beyond the
Veil of our reality a creature of pure
energy though nobody could really be
sure of its true nature The Hermit had
been tracking it learning about it and
trying to destroy it for thousands of
years and yet it only took him four
pathetic minutes to tell the boy
everything he knew the boy knowing still
that something about the hermit was
unnatural asked how he came to be in
this position The Hermit told the boy he
was the counterbalance a kind of Chosen
One destined to face and perhaps even
defeat the black moon someday the
counterbalance receives a number of
truly extraordinary gifts for inheriting
the responsibility eternal life eternal
youth near physical immortality but they
will be haunted by their purpose doomed
to watch everyone they love die around
them as they continue to hunt their only
true equal and opposite the black moon
itself the hermit in his own eyes had
failed at his duty he had grown weary
and now he needed to pass the duty of
counterbalance on to another that other
would be the boy he felt a sudden and
profound change along with the knowledge
that nothing would ever be the same
again he was no longer just the boy now
he was the counterbalance he watched The
Hermit give him a slight nod of respect
and then crumble into dust before his
eyes the boy the counterbalance looked
up at the sky and saw the Stars
twinkling so bright and so beautiful
little did he know his battle with the
black moon would Outlast every single
one of them does the black moon howl not
without blood the boy grew into a man as
his village aged and then died around
him decades passed then centuries then
Millennia tens of thousands of years
watching Humanity develop and grow
around around him as he continued his
pursuit of that one elusive foe as
science and diagnostic technology gained
ground absorbing and then evolving
beyond all the old superstitions the
counterbalance gained a better
understanding of the black moon though
even then it still remained essentially
a stranger The Entity was entropic a
being of pure Randomness and Chaos
without consistent form it didn't exist
in our universe but it could exercise
its influence here with so-called
obliteration events much like the
horrible fate that befell the young
hunter from the village but that was
only the proverbial tip of the iceberg
the counterbalance track and noted
obliteration events they were
exceedingly rare at first something that
occurred once every thousand years or so
like a terrible curse but he couldn't
help but notice a concerning Trend
emerging it started happening once a
century then once a decade he could feel
the terrible future stretching out in
front of him how over their shared
eternity the black moon would gain more
and more ground would there come a day
where it took someone once a year once a
month a week a day an hour a minute a
second it'd spell the end of all
conscious life a total victory for the
black moon the end of the universe the
death of Ages a complete existential
obliteration
he was swept up in a sobering
realization he couldn't win this fight
alone however while his hunt for the
black moon had been largely fruitless
the counterbalance had discovered many
other things along the way strange
creatures objects with extraordinary
powers and events that couldn't be
explained with rational science perhaps
something about these Oddities these
anomalies would hold the key to
defeating his Timeless enemy and it
hadn't just been these objects entities
and events he'd also discovered some
truly exceptional people on his travels
minds and skills that rivaled even his
own despite his age perhaps they would
be the ones to help him win with the 13
most brilliant and trusted people the
counterbalance ever met he decided to
form a council and from this Council
they forged and directed an organization
dedicated to understanding and
counteracting the strange in all its
forms with the secret hope that their
surge Into Darkness would yield the
answer to the black Moon's downfall he
called it the SCP Foundation they would
secure the anomalous contain it and
protect all of humanity from its
influence the counterbalance also took
on a new title be fitting of his new
role the administrator and even the
black moon itself was given a moniker in
hopes of robbing it of some of its
frightening power SCP 0
1 does the black moon howl only at the
blind the year was now
1987 the SCP Foundation had been
operating for over a century and thanks
to their secret possession of anomalous
wisdom and Technology their own
advancement was thousands of years ahead
of the rest of humanity well there still
wasn't a silver bullet solution to the
black moon and its deadly hows were
becoming all the more frequent as the
decades went on the foundation did have
some irons in the fire to combat it
their ability to gather Intel on both
the entity itself and its obliteration
events had improved considerably thanks
to their new Global Information Network
their top Minds were also working on a
highly classified device known as the
singular conceptual bunker which may one
day come in handy for combating the
extradimensional entity directly but the
most valuable piece of information they
ever gathered about the black moon was
this it couldn't howl when it was being
won watched the very Act of engaged
observation defanged it the problem is
How Can You observe something that
doesn't technically exist inside your
own reality in order to pull this off
the foundation would need to get
extremely creative thankfully Creative
Solutions to strange problems are the
foundation's specialty Flash Forward to
1993 enter Dr Moto a brilliant young
scientist and conceptual engineer
working for the SCP Foundation with the
the administrator's consultation he
started the key project an arm of the
wider project orases the umbrella
Initiative for using modified anomalous
objects in the battle against the black
moon the goal of the key project was
relatively simple if people couldn't
observe the black moon directly then the
foundation could make proxies of the
black moon that could be observed almost
like a kind of voodoo doll these new
anomalies would only need to satisfy
three criteria the inability to operate
when being observed a hostility to
conscious life and the ability to end
conscious life of their own valtion when
not being observed through conceptual
engineering a link theoretically could
be forged between these objects and the
black moon allowing observation of them
to stop the obliteration events however
despite being a good idea in theory Dr
Moto's efforts were marred with errors
and tragedies one object wasn't deadly
enough simply appearing behind people in
a threatening pose when they weren't
looking another one killed purely
through collateral damage a giant
sculpture of a human head that
immediately attempted Escape by barging
through sight 01 the center for
anti-black Moon operations and killing
19 people in the process another one of
Moto's objects a huge black sphere
simply immediately exploded killing 12
people and in the most horrific misstep
of all one of Moto's objects caused a
mass death event in a nearby hotel where
142 people were SP spontaneously
incinerated when the object a series of
interlocking stalagtites and stalagmites
were left unobserved for 2 seconds
almost all of Moto's objects were
terminated in the aftermath either being
too useless or too dangerous to keep
around the young scientist felt a deep
shame but forged on he made one truly
brilliant creation that satisfied all
the criteria a sculpture incapable of
moving while being watched but would
snap the neck of the nearest conscious
entity if it left unobserved for even a
fraction of a second its relatively
minimal killing left it easy to contain
without causing Mass deaths and despite
all the other deaths that had sadly
occurred during the key project Dr Moto
believed that the lives saved in the
long run by stopping the black Moon's
howls would justify the sacrifice the
problem is the key project didn't stop
anything not long after this there was
the first recorded double obliteration
event in Rome where a young tourist
couple had both been obliterated
simultaneously all the deaths in the key
project had been for nothing the black
moon was only getting more powerful the
shame and the guilt was too much for Dr
modotto he left a note in his office
Reading we've been looking at nothing
I'm sorry administrator I failed you sir
Moto's corpse was later found in the
sculptures temporary containment chamber
his neck snapped the key project was in
summary shut down and its one surviving
creature ation transported to site 19 in
late 1993 where it was designated as SCP
173 another painful failure for the
administrator back to the drawing board
once more does the black moon howl not
while the stars shine Millennia
stretched on almost everyone died except
the administrator thanks to his gift or
perhaps curse as the calendar balance to
the black moon science marched on the
SCP Foundation marched on on but all
this progress all this power was nothing
against the incomprehensible influence
of SCP
00001 the black moon was howling more
frequently than ever all the way up to
the year
3156 when the foundation launched the
seek project under the support of
project orastes as more and more people
were wiped out in frequent obliteration
events the administrator became
painfully aware that perhaps the answers
to the black moon problem wouldn't be
found on Earth using state-of-the-art
technology With a Little Help from the
anomalous the SCP Foundation began work
on an autonomous space fairing vessel
that could search the stars for the key
to the black Moon's destruction it was
an on inspiring creation a huge craft
powered by artificial intelligence with
a universal translator chirogenic units
and hundreds of autonomous drones to
perform more targeted searches seek was
waved off into the unforgiving depths of
space the administrator could only hope
that it would come back with worthwhile
answers the first of the three notable
planets see arrived on was one
theoretically capable of supporting
human life except for its brutal and
constant blizzards and snowstorms when
se's drones were deployed they did
discover signs of civilization based
around sentient spherical creatures but
no signs of actual life remained records
and statues found across the planet seem
to indicate that the black moon was
responsible for the destruction of the
planet's civil ization causing so many
obliteration events that the remaining
survivors went mad from the fear and
stress leading to mass death in the
ensuing chaos the next planet was
discovered centuries later in the year
34.99 while this planet could also
theoretically support human life it
suffered from frequent volcanic
eruptions that rendered much of its
surface a flaming mess however there
were still the dormant ruins of a once
Advanced civilization of conscious
beings much like the prior planet they
had been driven extinct by Black Moon
obliteration events a century before the
seek even arrived unlike the last planet
however it seems that they accepted
their fate and went gently into the
night the planet was now overrun by
billions of armored batlike creatures
that operated on pure Instinct and thus
were not considered conscious enough to
be obliterated the final planet was
reached in
3764 and was the most fruitful of the
three discoveries this planet was hyper
Advanced fully urbanized and covered in
sprawling mega cities with records and
Technology over a thousand years ahead
of Earth before the black moon killed
almost all of them there were a species
of humanoid telepathic fungi and had
developed an awareness of the black
Moon's existence that was on par with
that of humanities they even had their
own equivalent of the SCP Foundation
actively working on countermeasures and
most amazingly of all seik found one
surviving member of the species on the
planet cryogen Ally Frozen the craft was
immediately instructed to collect the
Survivor and return home for
interrogation the administrator Was
preparing for what could be the most
important conversation since he met the
hermit all those thousands of years ago
does the black moon how only when waning
when the surviving creature code named
saged was returned to Earth the
administrator was eager to finally speak
with it like the rest of its now extinct
species Sage spoke through powerful
telepath mind waves which only the
administrator thanks to his
counterbalance abilities was able to
receive at close range without being
harmed incidentally it wasn't long until
the very fact of the administrator's
nature as a counterbalance came up in
the mental conversation Sage could tell
just by being in his presence they
discovered a number of vital truths over
their brief time communicating that
Sage's survival had been pure luck for
starters the black moon is still very
much capable of obliterating conscious
beings in an unconscious State the
administrator also learned that he was
merely the latest in an extremely long
line of counterbalances across time
space and species though everyone but
him had waved this Duty passed it on
Sage had one question to ask the
administrator in turn what is
SCB the singular conceptual bunker being
worked on and perfected for thousands of
years by now by the foundation's top
scientists and conceptual engineers the
administrator replied Victory but it
will take a very very long time
specifically so long that he would see
the stars go out around him one by one
shocked saged asked him what good
victory would do him then rather than
say it aloud he replied with a thought
Sage paused and said I see how
Blasphemous of you hopefully it works
after this the administrator proceeded
to the singular conceptual bunker and
entered it leaving instructions for the
for the foundation to be run by a newly
formed 05 Council in his indefinite
absence thousands of years later in the
year 511 Sage spoke one more time
repeating the words hopefully hopefully
before turning solid black and
disappearing the black moon had claimed
one more victim but billions more had
gone in the interim the administrator
had no more answers to give at least no
more answers that anyone but him would
understand he was inside the singular
conceptual bunker now loaded into a
device known as toome an experimental
Memorial module meant to pick up and
record all the last messages of every
dying civilization Across the Universe
when the time finally came all he could
do was wait and wait was exactly what we
did does the black moon howl yes yes it
does years pass too many to count it's a
time after names now and toome sits in
the very center drinking in the end of
the universe the last of all the human
colonies Across the Universe were
obliterated by the Black Moon back in
the years
7329 so so so long ago but some of the
final messages of fear panic and
distress still echoed around in the
administrator's mind hello is there
anyone here we require assistance
there's it's it's taking people every
day we need help there's barely anyone
left we need help hello hello cabal 0943
we have abandoned the false flesh we
have abandon the false flesh the
shepherd's crook broken Neath my knee
cabal 0943 cabal 0943 forgive us forgive
us we're going to leave this on it's so
dark outside now it's blotted out the
sun it's I have to go now respond First
Convenience emergency situation
developing
require additional resources my fault
your fault our fault my fault your fault
our fault my fault your fault oh WR rip
my brain out now rip my brain out now
and a small child the last on Earth
simply asking hello into an indifferent
microphone but the administrator had to
wait as the singular conceptual bunker
became the solitary conceptual bunker he
was the last conscious being in the
universe and still he needed to wait as
the Stars went dark outside only when
there was nothing outside but black was
it finally time for the counterbalances
long game to play off there was nothing
left of our universe the only thing here
was the SCB and the black moon itself
with everything else gone the black moon
only had one conscious being left to
obliterate it opened the door to the
solitary conceptual bunker and stepped
inside this this doesn't make sense how
can the black moon an entity beyond our
Dimension Beyond physical form take a
step good question the same question
incidentally that was going through the
black Moon's mind as it entered the
bunker it didn't look at all how the
entity expected it was like a bar a
counter with rows of bottles behind it a
jukebox playing in the corner a man
stood behind the bar cleaning the
glasses the counterbalance the
administrator he said well there you are
certainly took your time can I pour you
a little something this only served to
increase the black Moon's confusion it
had form here dark smoke compressed into
a vaguely humanoid shape it could speak
it could think none of this made any
sense the being that had just wiped out
all conscious life and seen the very
death of the universe was truly and
utterly confused the administrator just
seemed seemed to be enjoying himself
preparing for a confrontation hundreds
of billions of years in the making the
singular conceptual bunker or perhaps
the singular containment bunker was a
truly ingenious creation a place of pure
ideas where everything inside was on the
same level here there were no Immortals
no Gods just ideas on the same Level
Playing Field and it was time for the
black Moon's idea to come to an end and
it was a trap and the entire universe
was the bait without warning the
administrator pulled up a shotgun from
underneath the table and unleash both
barrels into the black Moon's chest the
creature took the headit and fought back
dragging the administrator to the ground
beating him strangling him he could feel
the light fading under the monster's
Relentless assault until he managed to
get his desperate hands on a glass
ashtray he beat the monster over the
head with it until its grip loosened and
he was able to slide out there the
killer of the universe was on the ground
before him he grabbed the monster held
it in place and beat it to death he was
Gravely injured by the battle but the
black moon was no more here in the
singular conceptual bunker he had won
the administrator no longer the
counterbalance in the absence of the
black moon hobbled over to the Jukebox
produced a single beautiful coin from
his pocket he pushed the coin into the
slot wheezed a pain breath and said said
the thing is this place is only
information there's nothing else out
there not even matter the universe
closed its doors a long time ago but
this place can go from information back
to matter with just the Press of a
button let's see what happens when we
introduce something to nothing for a
second it looks as though he might fall
but he doesn't instead he slams the
button on the juke box and and with a
relieved laugh says let there be light
the Scarlet King is a really bad guy
he's a giant interdimensional nightmare
God intent on breaching our reality and
Wrecking terrible havoc on everything we
know and love he's been responsible for
Untold suffering and Chaos across
countless worlds timelines and layers of
reality to many he's even somewhat of a
final boss to the SCP Foundation and
just when you think he couldn't get any
worse
it turns out that he's also a deadbeat
dad not only did the Scarlet King once
have a cult literally named the children
of the Scarlet King before it was
destroyed by Dr monok and the SCP
Foundation he also had at least seven
actual children each one is speculated
to be a powerful anomaly but it's tough
to find concrete answers as to who or
what exactly most of them are so today
we're putting on our researcher hats and
digging deep into the foundation's lore
to present our the series on the
potential progyny of the SCP
foundation's greatest enemy and if
nothing else we may finally be able to
get this dark lord of all evil to start
paying all the child support he probably
owes by now first if you're not well
versed in Scarlet King Vore you may be
wondering how exactly does an evil chaos
God have kids is there a Scarlet Queen
out there who prefers to stay out of the
Limelight the answer isn't quite that
simple and it has everything to do with
SCP 231 and Big Red most devoted cult
the non-biological Children of the
Scarlet King they kidnapped a group of
seven girls and performed a number of
dark rituals that resulted in them
becoming vessels for the Scarlet King's
seven terrible kids these seven girls
have become known as SCP 231 anyone who
accesses those files and trust us they
aren't a pretty site will find that the
containment procedures mostly involve
performing the infamous monok procedure
on the surviving girls to keep keep them
from giving birth six of the Seven
Brides have given birth to nightmares
Beyond Comprehension and are now dead
with only one still remaining
successfully contained but here at the
SCP Foundation you need to learn to
comprehend the
incomprehensible according to a
classified document SCP 231 May
technically be a neutralized anomaly
without us even knowing an incidentally
this gives us our most certain answer on
the children of the Scarlet King on this
one the Apple fell very very far from
the tree according to the secret
document SCP 999 that's right the
adorable Tickle Monster is the seventh
child of the Scarlet King he must be so
disappointed that everyone's favorite
little blob didn't want to join the
family business of absolute evil for
anyone who doesn't know SCP 999 is a
slimy yellow entity that only seems
capable of absolute compassion it brings
joy to everyone in its presence and with
prolonged exposure can even cure
disorders like PTSD anxiety and
depression he's so good at this that he
even cured
scp-231-7 is de facto mother of her
trauma and allowed her to return happily
to her family after some amnestic
treatment the Scarlet King has another
good reason to be ashamed of his
cheerful Blobby son ancient DVID
prophecy dictates that SCP 999 May
someday become so powerful that his
force of absolute love and good
overwhelms the Scarlet King's evil and
Chaos think of him as the Luke Skywalker
to the Scarlet King's Darth Vader though
we probably can't expect a cool
lightsaber battle between them anytime
soon how disappointing so if SCP 999 is
the quiet sensitive black sheep of the
Scarlet family who's The Golden Child
who makes his evil father proud the real
chip off the old block that would be our
dear reptilian friend SCP 682 the
malicious lizard heavily implied to be a
child of the Scarlet King if you know
literally anything about 682 your
reaction to finding out that he's the
spawn of Cruelty personified is probably
yeah that makes sense just as SCP 999 is
the Scarlet King's innocent optimistic
young child 682 is kind of like his edgy
teenager still in the middle of a
misanthropic face he shows no sign of
leaving anytime soon the fact that 682
appears to find anything about the world
around him utterly disgusting seems to
be a trade he inherited from his dear
old death
and the fact he seems pretty much
impossible to kill also lends Credence
to the popular Theory he's got nightmare
God blood running through his veins 682
has also started displaying a particular
hatred for 999 ever since an incident
where 999 tickled them into submission
so family dinners are probably extra
awkward for these two 999 and 682 are
the most certain children but that still
leaves us with five more children to
identify it's worth remembering that the
waters are Merk from here on in but
we've searched far and wide through the
foundation archives to find possible
answers if your interpretation differs
remember that it's just a theory an SCP
explained Theory thankfully we do have
some assistance here the tale dust and
blood hinted at what each of the seven
children of the Scarlet King represents
and that may help us narrow down our
choices here to put things into
perspective it's believed that 682 was
the fourth child to be born representing
wrath and 999 was the seventh
representing hope according to this Tale
the first of the seven children
represents dominion and as a result is
skilled in the ways of war and has the
power to lead the king's forces to
Victory according to One Foundation
theorist this child could potentially be
SCP 239 also known as the witch child
this entity is so powerful that as part
of its normal containment procedures
it's eternally kept in a coma while why
because this seemingly normal child has
dominion over reality and can change it
to her whims her thoughts are so
powerful that just her brain waves can
damage physical matter and she can make
things disappear or manifest in an
instant she's also impossible to kill
with skin that's almost totally
impenetrable much like SCP 682 she's
also frighteningly strong in both the
offense and defense department we're
talking about such a powerful telepath
that Dr CLA has campaigned for her
immediate termination just because it's
safer that way this is certainly a
frightening Wonder kin that the Scarlet
king would be proud to call his daughter
next the second child according to the
prophecy this child represents longing
the child has the power to bring forth
armies which will help the Scarlet King
in his Conquest for this we actually
have a pretty unconventional Theory SCP
029 also known as the daughter of
Darkness if the name alone wasn't enough
enough to suggest that she's got an
extremely Sinister father she also fits
the profile of being very aggressive and
incredibly hard to kill but even more
damning is her connections to the
symbology of longing one of her most
dangerous Powers is causing men to fall
into almost trans-like Devotion to her
after spending time around her they're
suddenly willing to murder in her honor
strangling their victims in hopes of
raising Ki the Hindu God of destruction
whom has many similarities to the
Scarlet King she certainly fits the bill
of someone capable of raising armies in
the Dark Lord's name one strike against
our Scarlet King connection theory is
that the file States the daughter of
Darkness was first discovered in India
which wouldn't match up with the other
information we know to be fact however
while this is a long shot given the
sensitive nature of everything involving
the Scarlet King it's extremely possible
that false information was supplied to
bury the connection considering the
coverups and lies involving anomalies
like SC CP 1000 this certainly isn't an
unprecedented move on the part of the
foundation next the third child this
child is associated with all things
desolation implying destruction fire
ashes pestilence and death across the
battlefield when it comes to spreading
destruction and Death on a mass scale
one particular SCP comes to mind SCP
058 the Heart of Darkness this creature
has Scarlet King written on all over it
it's evil it's mysterious it's pretty
much impossible to kill and it causes
Mass casualties every time it escapes
its containment chamber it causes fires
whips people to death with its razor
sharp tendrils and sprays highly
corrosive acid from its scorpion likee
tail and it's even red given that we
know for a fact this entity suddenly
emerged out of something that's now been
expunged from the records in an
undisclosed site it's extremely possible
that the entity 058 came from was SCP
2313 this is a child that the Scarlet
king would definitely be proud of given
that it's impossible to reason with and
feels solely motivated by causing
destruction misery and Chaos we can't
think of an entity that better suits the
Desolation moniker than SCP 058 next
skipping past SCP 682 at number four the
fifth child of the Scarlet King is
associated with the loose concept of
black the prophecy then goes into more
detail saying that this child is
powerful in the ways of magic and is
able to use their abilities to cause
great destruction here we have another
unconventional proposal what if child
number five wasn't actually a child but
children that's because we think this
description perfectly fits SCP
1765 the nightmarish reality warping
sisters who we think may actually be
Triplets of the Scarlet King's fifth
brother rde now hear us out these are
actually some of the most powerful
enemies the foundation has ever
attempted to contain and we know nothing
about their pa before being bound to a
few objects by the Serpent's hand these
sadistic reality warpers are so
devastatingly powerful that the only
action the foundation can take against
them is letting them have free Reign
Over the containment site they currently
inhabit all the foundation can do is
hope they never get bored of tormenting
the people inside as we all know the
Scarlet King despises science progress
and order so perhaps a perfect
punishment for the foundation in his
many eyes is giving them a taste of
their own medicine the sisters though
particularly their ring leader are a
perverse shadow of the foundation's love
of the scientific method they take these
methods and use them for an activity
that the Scarlet King finds much more
enjoyable tormenting and killing people
whenever these crafty triplets set their
mind to it their horrifically powerful
magic is able to cause massive
Devastation just like the prophecy for
the fifth bride's Offspring dictates and
finally the sixth child of the Scarlet
King the concept associated with this
one is hidden meaning it can change its
face and walk unnoticed through creation
it's also said to have the
responsibility of opening the ways
between worlds and allowing the war to
end all wars to first begin there have
been a huge number of guesses for this
spot with some even suggest testing SCP
055 the anti- but since we're having fun
here we also want to make an even Wilder
suggestion we posit that the sixth child
of the Scarlet King is Allison Shia also
known as LS and the black queen the most
powerful member of the Serpent's hand we
get it we have a lot of explaining to do
but hear us out Allison Shia is a member
of the Serpent's hand or technically
many members multiple versions of her
exist across parallel dimensions in the
SCP Multiverse they're mostly all
estranged Daughters of foundation
researcher Dr Charles Kars this
estrangement leads them to collaborate
in the wanderer's library the secret
base of the Serpent's hand to conduct
raids on the foundation in Revenge but
what if the leader of these alternate
Allison had an ulterior motive because
in the infinite number of possibilities
offered by the Multiverse this one was
not the daughter of Charles gears but
the Scarlet King she's merely using the
pain of her counterparts to manipulate
them into accomplishing her true
father's goal undermining the SCP
Foundation let's break it down the
hidden child is prophesized to walk
unnoticed through creation not only does
Alison Chia appear human the use of SCP
268 a news boy cap that causes the
wearer to become unnoticed allows her to
walk anywhere through creation without
being detected but most importantly of
all the hidden child is said to be the
one who opens the way for the Scarlet
Kings and entrance into our Dimension
and Allison Chow has access to the
wanderer's library an unfettered access
point between Dimensions if one of the
infinite Allison was the secret daughter
of the Scarlet king would the wanderer's
library not be a perfect way for him to
leave his own Dimension and enter ours
she could be the final piece he needs
hidden under the nose of the foundation
and the Serpent's hand making all the
secret power plays to allow for the
Scarlet King's eventual bloody Reve
revenge on our world unless of course
SCP 999 the family disappointment stops
him first we realize that some of these
theories may seem surprising but when it
comes to the anomalous especially the
Scarlet King the only thing you can ever
expect is the unexpected do you agree
with our theories if not who do you
think are the children of the Scarlet
King let us know down in the comments
one thing is for certain we hope we
never meet any of the terrible tyrants
nasty children except the Tickle Monster
of course he can hang with us anytime
any changes today the younger security
officer Zach asked as he stepped into
the Watchtower as if replied his
Superior a jaded cynical old man who
insisted on being referred to as Mr
Jefferson the darn thing hasn't moved
spoken or done so much as stretch one of
those wings of his another day at the
office then Zach jum through the window
the pair of them looked through at the
Towering figure a few kilometers away
way SCP 001 the gate Guardian stood
motionless its fiery sword in its hand
ever protecting its post at the
precipice between our world and Paradise
it had long been stationed at the
entrance of a dimensional Gateway that
led to what was believed to be the
Garden of Eden described in the biblical
Old Testament much like the security
officers in the foundation's base tasked
with watching The Guardian this was
pretty much the extent of the day's
activities hey hey did you see that news
about the uh transfer posting Zack asked
trying to Stave off boredom with as much
conversation he could squeeze out of his
fellow officer yeah I saw it Mr
Jefferson scoffed rolling his eyes what
possesses someone like Robert Monto to
come down here must have wanted a
quieter post Zach reasoned looking out
at the Stillness of the gate Guardian
won't find one any quieter than here
Jefferson mused him showing up will be
the most exciting thing that's happened
here in a long while unbeknown to both
Zach and Mr Jefferson Dr Robert monok
would be only joining the team at the
gate Guardian observation site for a
short while not one of them nor anybody
else within the foundation could ever
guess monto's true intentions behind
venturing there in the first place he
wanted an audience with a gate Guardian
itself approaching the Colossal 1ft tall
being Dr Monto crossed the threshold of
the minimum safe distance from the
guardian given the sheer heat of its
weapon hotter than Earth's sun anything
within a kilometer of SCP 001 was at
risk of being obliterated vaporized into
atoms if they didn't turn back which
through a voice that immediately rang
out in monto's ears the gate Guardian
commanded him to
do its psychic message boomed wait wait
Dr Monto urged holding up his hands in
what would have been a futile defense
against the Guardian Sword I know what
you do when people don't listen to your
commands but please just give me a
minute there was silence SCP 001 didn't
reply there was nobody else close enough
to hear Monto speak to it so he
continued you are impossibly old we know
that much about you and because of that
you must have seen things that we can't
even begin to imagine much less fully
comprehend but I've come a very long way
to request that you impart some
information to me if you can he paused
again as if if waiting for a reply that
never came the gate Guardian merely
stood in the same defensive unwavering
stance tell me please how much do you
know about the Scarlet King by this
point in time although the foundation
was yet to realize Dr Robert Monto was
slowly going insane his investigations
into an anomalous entity known as The
Scarlet King were gradually corrupting
him as he tried relentlessly to quantify
exactly what this entity was and how
great of a threat it posed little did
monok realize that in trying so hard to
Define and comprehend the being he was
inadvertently fueling its power the
Scarlet King was an interdimensional War
mongerer an embodiment of hatred and
chaos and Dr Robert Monto was slowly
falling under the king's influence upon
hearing the tiny human figure utter his
question the amens gate Guardian rebed
with another single word psychic command
one it had never been recorded giving
before
witness as if his increasing instability
and the creeping influence of the
Scarlet King hadn't made Monto feel bad
enough he instantly felt sick there was
a searing pain behind his eyes like he
was staring directly at the sun
accompanied by a nausea that made his
head spin it took a moment of enduring
the horrific sensation before he
realized what was happening the guardian
was trying to show him something rather
than than give any information on the
Scarlet King verbally SCP 001 was
imparting a psychic Vision onto mon a
memory of events long past the answers
he sought a warning or perhaps all three
the vision showed mon talk a time so
long ago that it couldn't ever be
forgotten for there was barely anyone
alive to remember it in the first place
it was eons in the past long before the
comparatively recent dawn of humanity a
time only spoken of in the dust and
blood tablet an artifact of the dite
civilization some of the earliest
worshippers of the Scarlet King himself
and there marching up to the entrance of
Eden was the Crimson clad eldrich
Abomination and a horde of Horrors with
him according to the story recorded in
the dust and blood tablet this would
have been much earlier in the life of
the Scarlet King perhaps even before he
assumed his now Infamous title back then
he would most likely have been known as
his original name of krra one of
multiple siblings born when the tree of
life was planted and thus created all
life in the Multiverse but being the
only one of his siblings cursed with
awareness knowing the pain his existence
brought him krock would eventually set
out on his lifelong mission to destroy
all of existence across every Dimension
and he started by killing his siblings
consuming them to claim their power for
himself around this time in prehistory
the being that would once One Day become
known as Scarlet King didn't quite
possess the power that he would several
Millennia later although that's not to
say he was an unformidable force of
Destruction fueled by his singular
hatred for existence his vow to destroy
extended to the tree of life that had
caused him to be along with the tree's
Creator and all of their Creation in
other words everything in the Multiverse
all of creation if you will so what was
the Scarlet King doing there so long ago
at the dimension doorway protected by
the gate Guardian well beyond the
boundary between it and the rest of the
infinite Multiverse lay the supposed
Garden of Eden while it is unknown if it
is in fact the same Eden referred to in
the Book of Genesis is Up For Debate
especially among the foundation but at a
glance even through the gate it
certainly does look like a paradise the
space is filled with Lush vegetation of
astronomical size populated by a number
of beings that seem to resemble the gate
Guardian itself and there protected by
its watchful caretaker are two trees one
is thought to be the tree of knowledge
that Eve was tricked into eating an
apple from during the Book of Genesis
the other however Bears an unknown type
of fruit and is widely believed to be
the tree of life now back in the Modern
Age there's never been a conclusive link
between the Tree of Life mentioned by
the davit in their barbaric
civilizations Legends regarding the
creation of the Scarlet King King but
the fact that so long ago he and his
most feared generals were bearing down
on the gate guardian's position
defending a garden where there was known
to be a tree of that description well it
all seems rather conclusive now
alongside Kakak were six of his Seven
Daughters each one of them a fearsome
Abomination much like their destructive
father as they approached not one needed
to exchange any words with their Angelic
protector of Eden the gate Guardian knew
what these monsters were here for they
would stop at nothing to pass through
his gate and uproot the Tree of Life the
progenitor of all living beings in all
of existence even though it was early in
kck's career as the rampaging
interdimensional warlord he so is he was
as steadfast as ever in his goal to
annihilate every corner of creation
every Dimension every parallel plane of
reality every single pocket of existence
across Infinity they'd all come undone
if he burned the Tree of Life pulled it
out at the roots and splintered it until
nothing remained to The Once and Future
Scarlet King that the same tree had led
to his own tortured existence it was the
source of his suffering and it had to be
destroyed the only thing standing in his
way was a figure as colossal as karak
himself wielding a flaming sword
me boomed the psychic voice of the gate
Guardian it was like a doorman standing
before a a group of Rowdy teenagers
trying to force their way into a movie
theater except these Rowdy teens were
the Scarlet King his horrifying
daughters and the forces he had already
amassed since his creation the hordes
stood ready waiting for the commands of
their King who they thought would gladly
lead the charge as they marched on the
Garden of Eden to begin the destruction
of existence but that's not what
happened usually the Scarlet king would
never shy away from a fight preferring
to lead the charge when it came to a
Slaughter instead he commanded his first
daughter AIC to commence the first
attack on the protector who stood in
their path on her foul father's word AIC
took her horde and charged at the
guardian what she and her forces lacked
in numerical Advantage AIC more than
made up for in her knowledge of War she
hungered for it sought Dominion that was
her seal after all and yet in the face
of this impending Onslaught the gate
Guardian remains still rooted to the
same spot it had as as always and would
always be standing here a number of
aic's minions burst into flames the very
fabric of their crude form separated on
a molecular level as they were
effortlessly rendered into nothingness
still the gate Guardian hadn't appeared
to move an inch had exerted no energy
despite the damage it had done to AIC
and her forces in defense of Eden as his
first daughter screeched and how in
despair at the decimation of her horn
her children the Scarlet King decided he
needed to better understand his opponent
with a wave of his clawed Crimson hand
the king commanded his next daughter
Alor to send forth her own Army in a
tidal wave of nightmarish creatures agor
sent her horrific children into battle
she possessed a far greater quantity to
do battle on her father's behalf perhaps
AAR even believed that was the scotlet
king's plan with a greater number of her
forces over her sisters maybe she would
be able to overwhelm the guardian but
even as her own children began to be
vaporized the closer that they got to
the gate agor had no idea she was little
more than a pawn being sacrificed so
that KRA could learn more about his
imposing Angelic enemy another of the
Scarlet King's Daughters a being known
as anit was the next called up to
contribute to the unfolding battle
although to call it a battle UNS just
how easily the gate Guardians seemed to
be eliminating the oncoming forces
without even moving while an outwardly
frail seeming creature un H's primary
strength over her sisters was a
Proficiency in Magic her inate ability
to warp and reshape reality around her
it was that power that had caused her
father to be wary of her viewing anu's
abilities as a threat to his leadership
and so kro had her crippled and all her
children leaving them unable to
overthrow him but still loyal to their
King obeying her father's command
perhaps out of the same loyalty or fear
that he would harm her and her children
further if she disobeyed Ani unfurled
her magic she reshaped the world around
them making it so that the passage of
time moves so much slower and that was
what revealed to the Scarlet King his
enemy's greatest strength in combat the
gate Guardian had so far been able to
obliterate both AIC and now akar's
forces without seeming to move but it
wasn't by standing still it was moving
just much faster than the blink of
scarlet King's multiple eyes now that
an's magic had slowed the path passage
of time the gate Guardian could be seen
doing battle as agar's atrocities
spilled towards the angel to try and
overwhelm it it effortlessly blocked the
oncoming attacks with its sword
everything the Flaming blade connected
with instantly evaporated bursting into
atams as they were practically cleaved
out of existence by the gate guardian's
Mighty weapon even with time slowed to a
crawl the Towering winged protector of
Eden only appeared to be moving at an
average speed but when time flowed
normally without anood manipulating
reality the guardian was simply too fast
to be observed resisting the urge to
dive head first into the fight himself
the Scarlet King knew it would likely
lead to his untimely demise he refused
to accept that it could not happen but
he still had yet to amass the strength
he would need as he continued his Ascent
so while time was slow to a crawl and
the gate Guardian was still engaged in
combat with agoro's forces he turned to
another of his remaining daughters
adista if the Scarlet King and his
forces couldn't get past the guardian
they could still try to get to the Tree
of Life while the protector's focus was
diverted aiston Unleashed a wave of
pestilence sickness and disease spewing
from her in a cloud of Vaper heading
straight towards the Angelic garden and
Eden's entrance Beyond The Scarlet King
knew this latest attack wouldn't phase
or weaken the gate Guardian he hoped the
foul smog would instead pass through the
Gateway itself into the guardi Garden as
adad sent forth her power blood and Ash
soaked the landscape around them all the
plants outside the entrance to Eden
withered and died shriveling and
decomposing as the disgusting fog rolled
towards the gate it washed over the
guardian whose form only seemed to Glow
brighter as he repelled the pestilence
it was as if it didn't even need to
think about it still focused on
finishing off the rest of the oncoming
Army as its glow intensified so did the
fiery sword that the gate Guardian swung
with ease and finesse flames burst from
the blade the encroaching fumes Catching
Fire along with the air itself it
ignited in a wave of fire a defensive
Inferno that repelled this latest attack
but for a brief few moments while time
stayed slow before anu's hold on reality
inevitably broke the king had sent forth
ATI of all his spawn she was the most
reserved keeping mostly to herself never
speaking she and her children could
change their faces and forms shift into
anything or anyone and walk undetected
through the Multiverse and now her
father was employing her incredible
stealth abilities to slip Behind Enemy
Lines while the gate Guardian was
finishing off the remaining Onslaught
from kak's other daughters it was as
atiff Drew near creeping unseen closer
and closer to the entrance keeping the
Scarlet King out of Eden that the
Guardians seemed to PA it slowly
ominously turned its huge head tilting
until it was looking directly at atli if
its expression could be seen maybe the
gate Guardian would almost be impressed
that someone was able to sneak past it
after all it was a feat that no other
being in creation could ever hope to
accomplish but then again with its
steadfast conviction and dedication to
its protective Duty maybe it would have
looked upon atth with anger with a
cleaving swing of its scorching sword
the gate Guardian unfurled the tidal
wave of fire that engulfed everything
around it not just aif but aik aor and
adista all the king's daughters that had
attacked so far along with every one of
their own children were instantly
obliterated they were all reduced to
empty vacant spaces where they had once
been their atoms separated by the
Searing swing of the guardian's weapon
the devastating Blow by his adversary
did little to deter the Scarlet King
from his mission he was still set on
destroying the tree of life and no loss
was too great in his pursuit of
destroying existence he barely cared
that four of his own daughters had just
been unmade by the guardian anit was
still there Clinging On to time as if it
were a thrashing animal the Scarlet King
could simply make her restore her Fallen
sisters and their forces he had lost
nothing but had held back for too long
and slowly drew his own weapon out of
thin air wielding a sword that was as
blood soaked as the Guardians was hot
the Scarlet King locked blades with the
one being standing in their way both the
ancient Angelic Defender and the
attacking eldrich Abomination were
evenly matched every one of their
vicious strikes against the other met
with an equally strong Parry a weapon of
extreme all consuming heat blocks swipes
from a sharp serrated edge that match
the Deep Red that would be forever
synonymous with conro the force of their
two swords clashing and striking each
other was so great that it rippled out
from their one-on-one fight the
landscape around them was flattened
wiped clean of any remaining plant life
that hadn't already been destroyed by
the forces of the King's Daughters
despite having acquired nowhere near the
power he would thousands of years after
this fight the Scarlet King was still a
formidable force in single combat and
yet the gate Guardian seemed incapable
of tiring or weakening still standing
strong against the on slau even after
wiping multiple armies out with its
flaming sword the guardian was still
able to hold its own against the Scarlet
King who was Furious enraged at being so
close to the tree of life yet unable to
get past his Angelic adversary he need
to be stronger faster even more ruthless
than the warlord he already was despite
unit's slowing down time the king and
the guardian were at a stalemate time
that was it it the Scarlet King needed
more time withdrawing from the fight he
realized that this was a battle that
could not be won by sheer Brute Force
alone his mission to destroy all
creation to get to the tree of life
would take cunning deception and more
time if he let it the gate Guardian
could easily kill KRA its flaming weapon
could cleave him out of existence and
that would end the king's torment but it
wouldn't be enough a death would be
unsatisfying knowing that the rest of
existence would go on after he was gone
the Scarlet King couldn't accept that it
wasn't enough so he did the one thing
nobody would expect of him he made a
deal with the gate Guardian it was an
action still fueled by his infinite
hatred for all existence his yearning
for total chaos the Scarlet King knew
that one day an event would arrive where
the guardian and the other beings like
it in the Garden of Eden would spill
forth and deliver judg J M on this world
and when that Rapture happened the tree
of life would be undefended the Scarlet
King Bartered with the guardian that he
would Retreat for the time being so he
could spend eon's amassing more and more
power then when the fateful day arrived
the gate Guardian would allow him into
Eden to destroy the Tree of Life while
it and its Brethren were busy conducting
the Rapture halting their fight the
Scarlet King offered a crimson claw to
the gate Guardians burn burning hand
returning to reality from the intense
Vision still feeling sick at what he had
witnessed Robert Monto looked up at the
still silent form of the gate Guardian
did you do it he yelled desperate to
know more through his obsession with the
Scarlet King did you tell him yes did
you make a deal there was no answer from
the guardian just a single word that
echoed through monto's fractured mind
Le the SCP Foundation has faced a number
of wide potentially apocalyptic threats
in its mission to uphold normaly and
save Humanity we know the SCP Foundation
could be ruthless in this Mission the
events of SCP 5000 before agent Petro
restarted the Universe show what happens
when the foundation is pushed to its
final decisions regarding normaly being
upheld in SCP 5000 it seemed that the
SCP Foundation decided to cease research
further into the anomaly they needed to
neutralize but what would have happened
happened if they didn't in any case we
know the SCP Foundation is dedicated to
normaly and the containment of the
anomalous but what happens when the SCP
Foundation is faced with a dire decision
uphold normaly or destroy their Universe
the Multiverse is a concept in science
fiction that has gained Mass amounts of
popularity over recent years especially
recently thanks to a certain wall
crawlers movie multiverses are parallel
universes that are are similar or
extremely different from the main ones
scientists have pondered over the
existence of a Multiverse for hundreds
of years but the most popular being the
many worlds interpretation a theory of
quantum mechanics that states there are
many worlds that exist in parallel at
the same space and time as our own some
interpretations even state that every
decision a person makes causes a branch
in reality where the person made the
other decision we're familiar with the
SCP foundation's run ends with the
Multiverse from SCP
2935 death a cave that allows The
Wanderer to enter a parallel Dimension
that's fully and completely dead only
for the same thing to happen to their
own world once they return through the
cave or SCP
1437 a hole that allows the foundation
to send receive and read parallel
dimensional documentation from other
multiversal SCP foundations combine
those two concepts with an SCP 001
proponent
the importance of an SCP 001 proposal is
not lost on the foundation researchers
of the SCP Foundation save the SCP 001
slot for only the most dangerous
apocalyptic or widespread anomalies that
could affect the foundation itself
humanity and normaly arck's SCP 001
proposal and the research within its
file found the answer to the question we
posed above when the SCP Foundation is
faced with a dire decision do they
uphold normaly or destroy their universe
and all the people who live in it the
file begins somewhat different from what
we're used to with SCP Foundation files
instead of an item number or containment
procedures we begin with a yellow notice
from the records and information
security administration or Risa for
short the notice states that the
following file was received in 20126
from Dimension r42 is dimension r42
potentially the cause of SCP 001 could
they be attacking this version of the
SCP Foundation the notice continues with
the description of the file that follows
it it states the file below describes an
anomaly threatening all members of
humankind in all of the Multiverse this
file had been emitted to this version of
the SCP Foundation for 8 minutes as an
extremely dangerous Cognito Hazard
classified as a class 5 Cognito Hazard
capable of easily destabilizing and
penetrating this Universe however it was
found to not be dangerous only reading
as a danger level zero while this
Foundation was unable to quickly
counteract this Cognito Hazard it
appeared to not pose a threat to the
affected universe's humankind part of
this notice is cross out indicating that
it is no longer true there is a high
threat of repeated Cognito hazardous or
other forms of attack from Dimension
r42 instead this part has been replaced
with the following fact Dimension
r42 no longer exists did this version's
SCP Foundation fall to SCP 001 their
entire universe no longer exists so
perhaps this file that this Dimensions
SCP Foundation received could be a
potential warning under this race and
notice the reader is not greeted with
the standard foundation documentation
yet again instead it seems that the
original senders of this file left a
note for the readers of this file it say
as greetings you are reading this
dossier in a parad dimension of The
Relic Dimension
r42 due to the Colossal size of your
world's address for your convenience
your dimension will be Hereafter
referred to as PD parad Dimensions it
seems as though we're reading this SCP
001 file Through The Eyes of the SCP
Foundation in this so-called parad
Dimension so if the original SCP
Foundation and their Universe are 42 is
now destroyed what does this mean for us
the not continues the following message
has been constructed by the SCP
Foundation of The Relic Dimension r42
and is addressed to the SCP Foundation
of parad Dimension PD enclosed you will
find information about SCP 001 which is
a threat to the Multiverse here we go
SCP 001 is definitely the cause of R
42's destruction but how can we be so
sure of this maybe as CP 001 caused the
foundation to destroy their Universe the
note also includes the following
statement as you may have noticed this
message was preceded by a bur signal
containing a non-dangerous Cognito
Hazard the bur signal was constructed in
such a way that minimal change to the
signal would have caused indiscriminate
and overwhelming casualties among the
denisons of PD as you can see r42 is
capable of eliminating the absolute
majority of PD denisons but has not
exercised this capability in the context
above we ask you to consider this action
not as an act of aggression but as a
demonstration of the fact that r42 has
no pretension for conquest or other
forms of aggression towards PD take the
following information in Earnest well at
least this version of the SCP Foundation
is being somewhat friendly with the
parad dimension if r42s SCP Foundation
needs to quell this multivers IV threat
though why are they leaving it up to an
SCP Foundation that may not be so
inclined the SCP 001 file begins with
the object class this anomaly is of the
joint class of paradox apolon we know
from SCP 001 when day breaks or SCP 3999
that apolon class anomalies are
extremely dangerous posing an immediate
and almost Unstoppable threat to normaly
the SCP Foundation all of humanity or
even the universe itself the Paradox
part is interesting what exactly is
paradoxical about a Napoleon class
anomaly a footnote explains this for us
this anomaly's distinguishing feature is
that in order to eliminate the anomaly
that will inevitably eliminate mankind
it is imperative to eliminate mankind or
release another K class event oh boy it
seems that the SCP Foundation of r42 was
not eliminated by SCP 00 1 they
eliminated themselves to contain SCP 001
is this parad Dimension face with this
decision now the containment procedures
of the SCP file continue on this note
the only way to contain SCP 001 and
prevent a ZK class cross reality failure
event is the annihilation of humankind K
class scenarios are not a concept used
lightly by the SCP Foundation we're
familiar with the Omega K class scenario
when we are completely rid of death or
XK Class end of the world scenarios so
we know the danger these anomalies hold
to humankind normaly and the world the
SCP Foundation will do anything to
prevent these scenarios from occurring
apparently even including the
elimination of all humankind or entire
universes the description goes more in
depth on the SCP 001 anomaly SCP 00001
consists of all living members of the
homo sapiens species living within
Dimension r42 and the parad dimension or
PD for short it seems as though this
anomaly was created out of a mistake
from Dimension r42 and PD as the
description States the anomaly first
came into existence and developed in The
Relic Dimension r42 and later activated
in PD by accident how could this have
happened are these Dimensions linked
much more closely than we first thought
let's continue with the description to
find more information
scarily this portion of the description
contains a note that states that
unchecked growth of SCP 001 will cause
the annihilation of the entire
Multiverse the SCP foundations of
Dimension r42 and PD are not met with
this decision as now the entire
Multiverse is at risk the r42 SCP
Foundation has done immense research on
the topic of the Multiverse of their
Universe after the big bang a finite
number of universes were created only 5
seven to be exact however only one
dimension was able to form Humanity
Dimension
r42 and it's unknown why this happened
but all we know is that with the
destruction of r42 and the potential
annihilation of PD Humanity will cease
to exist in the Multiverse the danger of
SCP 001 is that it has the anomalous
capability for widescale replication of
parad Dimensions we are reading this
article from one of these parad
Dimensions so this this SCP Foundation
is technically an anomaly that must
contain itself a parad dimension is
defined as a parallel reality that has
an extremely small deviation from its
parent dimension in this case PD is a
parad dimension of r42 it seems that
these pair of Dimensions form as a
result of human decision making so if
you've ever been between a type of shirt
to buy or were confused on an exam and
guest a question a parad dimension could
have formed from this decision with the
pair Dimension has you take the other
choice because of this Dimensions
housing living instances of SCP 001
uncontrollably grow a colossal number of
minimally differing pair Dimensions
every second no sign of pair Dimensions
have been found in the other 56 parent
Dimensions the picture on this file
shows how PD has branched from r42 but
at this point it seems that Millions if
not billions or trillions of parad
Dimensions now exist the real problem of
pair Dimensions is that the Multiverse
has a limit on the number of pair
Dimensions that can exist and once that
is crossed the ZK class cross reality
failure event will begin and the
Multiverse will be destroyed the r42
dimensions SCP Foundation has also
discovered that once humankind emerges
in the parad dimension they can begin to
have parad Dimensions themselves the ZK
class cross reality failure event can be
expected to begin between 4 to 2 months
from the PD receiving this message to
summarize SCP 001 is humankind
specifically it's decisionmaking when a
person makes a decision a pair of
Dimension may be created the Multiverse
has a limit on the number of pair
Dimensions it can have and since pair
Dimensions can have pair Dimensions they
are quickly approaching the ZK class
cross reality failure event the SCP
Foundation of r42 is approximately 17
years ahead of P D which allowed them to
research and develop containment
procedures to contain the anomaly and
save the Multiverse r42s SCP Foundation
discovered SCP 001 5 years before
writing the file we're reading now aside
from that they developed two operations
castling and minimal gain to slow parad
Dimension creation and prevent the ZK
class cross reality failure event in
stage one of operation minimal gain the
foundation began with neutralizing and
decommissioning all of their contained
anomalies under the classification of
uclid or ker specifically those that
were expensive to contain or requiring
high levels of personnel and researchers
stage two saw operation castling be
commenced the r42 SCP Foundation
launched Rockets with variant sea Global
amnestic dispersing warheads and took
control over all countries in order to
hold power over all humankind in stage
three the foundation began to move their
world to a more Natural State destroying
all hazardous radioactive chemical and
bacteriological objects removing dams
and stopping oil extractions during
stage three stage 4 began the r42 SCP
Foundation began eliminating Humanity in
third world countries by use of viral
and biological attacks stage five was a
widespread attack on Humanity where the
SCP Foundation added deactivation
resistant viral agents to water
treatment and collection plants food
products medication and household items
of developed countries by stage six only
.1% of humanity remained and they were
targeted with drone strikes or put into
concentration camps for elimination
stage seven of the remaining survivors
the foundation sampled them to find the
fittest of those left to preserve
humankind stage 8 saw 15,000 of these
people put into indefinite cryosleep and
the remaining survivors were eliminated
stage 9 saw the destruction of the
remaining SCP Foundation Personnel we
move on to a list of proposals that were
made before or during operations
castling and minimal gain proposals
rejected include the use of SCP objects
or other Technologies to eliminate
derivative Dimensions the development of
Nanobots with the capability to control
human decision-making capabilities and
eliminate variability full replacement
of humanity with bionic hybrids acting
explicitly within standard behavioral
models unification of humanity into a
neural network with control given to an
AI Control unit and the destruction of
Earth Andor all of its inhabitants While
most of these seem like Clear Solutions
that would prevent the elimination of
humanity at the SCP foundation's hand
these proposals were all rejected for
one reason the SCP Foundation did not
have enough time one proposal was
accepted however the use of SCP
000000 this appears to be the solution
the r42 SCP Foundation concocted to
fight SCP 001 and potentially save the
Multiverse it poses the question if the
r42 SCP Foundation used this same
anomaly to contain SCP 001 has proven by
the fact they no longer exist will PD do
the same the file explains that the r42
SCP Foundation opened a dimensional
Wormhole into PD as they do not know at
the time if parad Dimensions could cause
the creation of more parad dimensions in
doing this the SCP Foundation seemingly
infected PD with the ability to create
parad Dimensions the author of this file
goes on to explain that the r42 SCP
Foundation had plans to attack PD and
use operations castling and minimal gain
in the dimension however they could not
access the dimension again and they
believed that the foundation Personnel
of PD would have made use of Thal class
anomalies to save themselves and their
world a note from R 42's overseer
council is left for PD if the apolon
destruction was not enough the overseer
council is involved the importance of
the neutralization of this anomaly
cannot be forgotten so the overseer
Council explained to PD the world has
existed before us and must remain after
us our Multiverse is ill and the name of
the illness is Humanity SCP
001 the only way out is CP
000000 will cease to become a threat
with its help it is in our power to
leave a chance for other Sapient species
that perhaps will not be affected by the
same anomaly or will'll find a way to
get rid of it before it's too late we
the 05 Council and other survivors from
r42 have chosen Our Fate we hope you
will do the same what is this SCP
000000 how did the SCP Foundation of r42
find the solution the file for SCP
0000 is placed within this SCP 001 file
SCP
000000 is a paradox Thal class anomaly
without any containment procedures SCP
000000 is a device that once activated
will destroy the universe it was
activated in it will also destroy all
parad Dimensions that are not creating
other parad Dimensions as such PD would
not be destroyed however the billions or
trillions of other PA of Dimensions the
r42 parent Dimension created will be
destroyed PD is left with a harrowing
decision to continue living or destroy
itself to save the rest of the
Multiverse in the file a note from r42s
Joan Simpson is written for ANP
Foundation overseer 05- one as part of
operations castling and minimal gain the
remaining Foundation employees were
allowed one family member to uphold
morale Joan is not writing for r42 05 D1
instead she's writing for PDS 05 D1 this
Dimensions version of her father she
begins with wondering whether she can
call this version of 05- one her father
as her version of her father recently
passed away she remembers the day the
foundation employees were allowed to
choose that one family member they would
save for the time being her father was
opposed to allowing two family members
as he claimed it would cause unnecessary
stress and schisms among the remaining
few hundred Foundation staff 0 5-1 chose
to have Joan over her mother and she
understood everything by the look in his
eyes and grew angry but that feeling is
long gone now she began to work with her
father and the remaining Foundation
Personnel that called themselves
hostages behind the backs of those
higher up the rank
on day she felt sad Joan and her father
would go up to the surface of the Earth
in hazmat suits sitting on the grass and
watching over the empty City at the
bottom of the mountain no Humanity
remained with the only life she could
see being Birds her father promised her
that they'd return there and build a
giant Monument to humanity at the center
of the city she knew this was a lie Joan
remembers when someone proposed that
they should open a portal the one that
opened to PD this was their fatal
mistake as after that the parad
dimension began replicating parad
Dimensions the countdown went down to
months again and the promise he made to
his daughter became impossible 0 5-1
died and left the position vacant Joan
says to the PDS 0 5-1 that she doesn't
care whether they destroy their world or
not or whether the universe will
continue to exist or if there will be
new life in it her world was crushed
long ago the note also reads the
following it's good that this message is
encrypted with your key that was passed
on to me or these lines would have been
deleted everyone wants to save the world
but who needs it like this empty and
cold without those to appreciate its
beauty without Humanity do whatever you
think is right I truly feel better now
love you Faithfully Yours Joan Simpson
we're not too sure if PD went through
with destroying their Universe to save
the multi ierse but it seems that
whatever decision was made would cause
the destruction of that Universe whether
that be through the use of SCP
000000 or the ZK class cross reality
failure event Humanity will cease but
maybe if they make the decision to use
SCP
000000 Sapient life can begin to exist
again and hopefully no parad Dimensions
will be made from their decisions
decisions are an extremely innate part
of humanity you decided to get out of
bed this morning you decided to open up
your computer or phone and you decided
to watch this video who knows the amount
of parad Dimensions we may have created
today but in our world we're not at risk
but in the SCP Foundation Universe
anything can be anomalous even Humanity
if you're familiar with the SCP
Foundation then you already know the
exact reason why there are multiple SCP
001's you may even think you know which
of them is the real SCP 001 but for
those of you who are new here or who
just need a little reminder the
designation of SCP 001 doesn't refer to
a single creature object or entity but
rather a collection of various anomalies
that are apparently kept in containment
by the SCP Foundation at present it is
unclear why there are multiple files
collected under the shared designation
of SCP 001 some believe it is because
these anomalies are some of the earliest
ever contained by the foundation this
would mean that they share the
designation of SCP 001 as they were
likely encountered before the SCP
Foundation introduced their current
numbering system however there also
exists a theory that this is nothing
more than intentional misdirection
perhaps the multiple SCP Z1 files are an
attempt by the foundation to conceal
information about the true SC
p001 after all it wouldn't be the first
time this hyp secretive organization
deceived us anomaly sharing the name SCP
001 include the infamous Scarlet King
the massive gate guardian and the
world-ending event known as when day
breaks but today we will be using SCP
001 to refer not to an entity or an
event but to a location a location code
named God's blind spot located in an
unassuming corner of the world is a site
that the SCP Foundation constructed and
designated as facility T according to
their archive it's a largely
unremarkable Place situated at a spot on
the Sinai Peninsula which is a part of
Egypt that forms a bridge between the
continents of Africa and Asia in the
18th century archaeologists Excavating
the area uncovered the remains of a
stone structure believed to be an inn
that dates back to the second Millen
lenium BC however since the construction
of facility T any trace of this
structure has since disappeared so what
makes this unremarkable site so
important to the SCP Foundation why
establish a facility if there was
nothing anomalous about its nature what
distinguishes this SCP 001 site in the
eyes of the foundation is the area's
profound lack of any ambient AA
radiation but what is AA radiation well
according to to the foundation's
researchers it's a form of cosmic
background radiation one that's not
overtly harmful to human beings if you
grew up in a strict churchgoing
household then it's highly likely you
would have been exposed to a lot of this
non-electromagnetic radiation and never
even realized it you see the thing with
AKA radiation is that it is directly
correlated with the amount of religious
Faith a person has regardless of which
religion someone follows AA radiation
will form around them it tends to be
harmless to humans however certain
anomalous entities in scps considered to
be demonic in nature can be repelled and
even fought off with high levels of AA
radiation the presence of other powerful
anomalies those considered more benign
or even holy can also create an increase
in this radiation SCP 001 has earned the
nickname God's blind spot for a number
of reasons one being that it is the only
place on Earth with the natural absence
of this AKA radiation the foundation has
conducted experiments that involved
bringing sources known to emit AA
radiation into the area of SCP 001 but
when they measured no change in
radiation levels was detected meaning
that the space around facility T does
not actively block AA radiation from
entering it but also cannot absorb or
retain this religious radiation it might
be more accurate to say that the
location destroys any trace of residual
AKA without damaging The Source a lack
of faith field radiation is far from the
only anomalous property of SCP 001
though during a number of tests
involving d-class Personnel the
foundation witnessed that while in the
area it also becomes impossible for the
death of any human being to occur a
discovery that obviously needed to be
researched further the first test
involved a healthy human male who was
left in the containment cell on the SCP
001 site and observed he had no supplies
no food no water yet over 120 days this
man stayed alive never succumbing to
starvation or dehydration next a female
member of d-class was exposed to a
lethal dose of cide gas within facility
T and suffered none of the expected
effects Foundation researchers then
repeated this cyanide gas test using 30
common brown rats all of which were
killed proving that it was only humans
that couldn't be killed while within SCP
001 God's blind spot seems to also be
able to slow or halt the effects of
terminal illnesses as proven when a
d-class with stage four cancer was
brought into SCP 001 despite her
prognosis stating that she would be dead
imminently the woman survived in the
area for almost 800 days her cancer
symptoms never Advanced and she only
died after finally leaving the area of
SCP
001 there are limitations to this
anomalous effect though one test
involved cremating a healthy male
d-class while he was still alive the
man's body caught fire just as you would
expect it to and he was burned to death
according to the findings of that test
and similar variations Foundation
researchers have learned that the
life-preserving qualities of SCP 001
don't prevent death by extreme external
damage one of the final test to take
place with an SCP 001 involved a pair of
24-year-old identical d-class twins one
of the twins designated twin a was held
at facility T while the other twin B was
imprisoned in a Cell at a different
Foundation site after observing them for
over 26 years twin be aged naturally to
the age of 50 his twin however did not
appear to age at all over the course of
2 and 1/2 decades it was only when moved
to another facility that twin a began to
show signs of aging the aging process
for twin a was rapid too and eventually
he caught up with his brother being a
benign non-threatening anomaly the
foundation has been more than happy to
use God's blind spot to their own
Advantage facility was specifically
established on this site to house the
headquarters of the 05 Council the
overseers of the entire SCP Foundation
it's hardly surprising that the overseer
Council would want to set up shop here
after all it's the one spot on planet
Earth where no human being can ever die
of natural causes and will not age for
the duration of their stay of course
this locked the 05 Council to one
location but what if they could
replicate the effects of SCP 001
elsewhere of course this is what the SCP
Foundation attempted following their
Research into God's blind spot the
foundation's own Dr Marvin Scranton
attempted to artificially recreate the
area's anomalous effects somewhere else
his Hope was by generating a vacuum of
AA radiation that a second instance of
SCP 001 would occur at a location of his
choosing or as his assistant berren put
it they plan to build a box and then
push God out of it as it turned out God
had other plans Dr Scranton quickly
realized the hubris of his scheme the
AKA radiation in the selected area
rapidly dropped to zero just as planned
but then something unexpected Ed
happened Scranton detected an increase
in Humes these are essentially parts of
the fabric of reality and are what's
often disrupted by reality bending as
CPS something had come into our world
thanks to the 05 council's attempt to
recreate SCP
001 something impossible for the
foundation to measure or observe in
other words Scranton had no idea what he
Unleashed or where it went following
this incident the 05 Council realized a
worrying increase in the anomalous
incidents they were encountering whether
or not this came as a direct result of
their meddling with the fabric of the
universe was unclear but it forced the
council to reconsider the focus and
direction of the entire SCP Foundation
up until this point they had been an
organization focused purely on research
but now they had to embrace a new
approach to how they handled anomalies
from then on the foundations of
objective became to actively seek out
and contain anomalous entities creatures
objects and locations like SCP
001 rather than just observing these
phenomena for study they would secure
contain and protect the final portion of
SCP 001's file is a memorandum detailing
an arrangement between the 05 Council
and an unknown counterparty in the
document someone named Sheldon cat set
out revised terms for the foundation's
continued use of facility T Sheldon
states that he has reached an
understanding with the counterparty and
that the contents of the document are to
serve as a formal agreement a contract
of sorts between the SCP Foundation and
someone else according to this contract
the incident with Scranton put a strain
on the relationship between the
foundation and whoever the counterparty
is and that the 05 Council are seeking
to make amends in order to continue
their new goal of of collecting and
containing anomalies so who was this
counterparty that the overseer Council
was so desperate to appease and have on
their side who could possibly be a
higher power than the most powerful
secret organization on Earth well an
actual higher power of course that's
right the 05 Council was making a deal
with God over how they were allowed to
use his blind spot or at least a very
powerful being that considers itself to
be God the rules laid out on their
agreement stated that no person was
permitted to stay at the site of SCP 001
for more than 120 years including
members of the 05 Council along with
other members of foundation staff
management researchers security
personnel and test subjects Additionally
the SCP foundation's Ethics Committee
was required to annually report any and
all of the 05 council's decisions to God
for for his own part God was restricted
from smiting or exacting his terrible
wrath upon any member of foundation
Personnel that's right a perk of working
for the SCP Foundation is getting around
the clock Divine protection at least
from God himself that's still a lot
better than an employee dental plan this
came with a condition however that
anyone committing a transgression or
mortal sin was given a 90-day written
notice and an opportunity to repent
their wrongdoing in return God demanded
that members of the foundation only
worshiped him and no other Divine
entities I the Lord am a jealous God
visiting the iniquity of the fathers
upon the children unto the third and
fourth generation of them that hate me
was written in the contract finally the
agreement between the 05 Council and God
was that they would work together the
foundation and the counterparty would be
equal Partners when it came to the
containment of scps and anomalies of all
the strange and unexplained phenomena
that the SCP Foundation encounters on a
regular basis it hardly comes as much of
a surprise that they've got a direct
line to the big guy upstairs or at least
one who purports to be still the fact
that the 05 Council have a business
arrangement with an ultra powerful deity
like being and express written
permission to use his blind spot where
no person can die or age is hardly
comforting thought at least the SCP
Foundation only ever uses its power for
good right while some higher level
researchers specialized guards and
containment experts at the SCP
Foundation have fixed anomalous projects
tailored to their very particular set of
skills for many lower level operatives
including Junior researchers guards
janitorial staff and even the dreaded D
classes every day is showing up spinning
the wheel of Misfortune and finding out
how you might die today will you be
hacked to Pieces by a murder monster
pulled into a portal turned into a doll
eaten alive made into a living Nest by
bugs stretched out and broken drowned
exanguination set on fire beaten to
death by a volley of anomalous tomatoes
because you decided to drop a
cringeworthy dad joke or a rancid pun
there are perhaps only a handful of
anomalies that not only will not harm
you but will actively enrich your life
by getting to spend time with them and
of course Chief among these is the
legendary SCP 999 also known by its
adorable moniker the Tickle Monster we
don't need to get into too much detail
in describing this gelatinous ray of
sunshine his anomalous delightfulness
has made him somewhat of a celebrity
compared to the murderer's row of
terrifying entities and monsters around
him the researcher assigned to him today
was troubled having seen one of his
favorite co-workers devoured by SCP 682
the day before getting assigned to
feeding and checking on SCP 999 today
was exactly what he needed as he entered
the room several bags of M&M's in hand
the creature CED perhaps sensing his
tension and approached him immediately
the researcher felt a wave of calm and
contentment wash over him the incredible
and rare feeling that perhaps everything
is going to be all right for once 999
rubbed up against his leg as he poured
M&M's into its eager mouth radiating
Good Vibes the whole time what an asset
what a gift and to think this adorable
little goober was prophesies to someday
save the world that much seemed almost
funny but he was certainly more than
capable of saving the life of someone
who hadn't felt the warmth of internal
sunshine in quite some time and for that
much the researcher was profoundly
grateful he left 99's chamber that day
with a renewed sense of hope for the
future that maybe just maybe they might
be able to pull through to make a
difference to push this crazy ball of
rock we call our home in the right
direction maybe someday the Sun would
rise on a perfect world who would have
thought that a strange Sunrise could
change everything emergency Sirens went
off across the globe but in every case
they were drowned out by a terrible
endless chorus of Screams but below all
that you'll hear another gut-wrenching
sound a low but pervasive sizzling like
an egg on a hot pan as billions of human
beings started to change their states of
matter the SCP Foundation had fought off
and contained so many seemingly
impossible threats from interdimensional
Horrors like the hanged sealed and
Scarlet Kings to nightmarish Mass
Killers like SCP 106 the old man scp096
the Shy Guy and SCP 682 the hardto
destroy reptile in their many battles
against the anomalous they developed the
incredible methodologies and exceedingly
advanced technology but what good would
any of it do when the very center of our
solar system decided in an instant that
rather being the Lynch pin of our
delicate cradle of life it would instead
be the horrible instrument of all of our
demises this awful hypothetical was
answered upon the emergence of SCP 001 a
terrible day also known as when day
breaks in the snap of one's fingers half
the world was plunged into Terror and
death rays of Stark red light swept
through the streets people lucky enough
to be in the shade or inside buildings
with a view to the outside saw the
people in the streets seize up and begin
to shriek in terrible pain their skin
sagged and their bones liquefied their
bodies dropped down to the ground and
coalesced into gurgling wretching
Puddles the color of melted flesh those
who saw this Abomination happening would
never forget it it would stay with them
for the rest of their lives it would
endure like a stain on their retinas an
after image burned into the plasma of an
old TV screen but here's a slight
consolation for most of the human race
the rest of their lives wouldn't be that
long the sudden Insanity taking over the
world caused the SCP Foundation to do
something drastic step out of the
Shadows metaphorically speaking of
course the legendary Foundation motto
had been reversed they would die in the
light so that Humanity could live on in
the dark thank the very concept of the
day gave them one advantage while one
side of the Earth was effectively doomed
the second the process began the other
side had a 12-hour Head Start before the
sun turned its terrible eye to them
sirens went off in the middle of the
night waking people up groggy rubbing
the sleep from their eyes every
television and radio and internet
enabled device in their home was playing
the same message direct from the SCP
Foundation which now had effectively
commandeered the entire US Government
along with the rest of the world it gave
them directions to the nearest
Foundation containment site and told
them that if they didn't immediately
comply and find their way to safety they
would experience a terrible death by
sunrise and if you're at all familiar
with human beings you've probably
already predicted that they didn't just
calmly wrap themselves up make their way
to their cars and form an orderly line
to the various Foundation containment
sites located around them it was in fact
total pandemonium as the solar clock
ticked down slowly marking off the
seconds that anyone outside had left to
live the only human beings with a
meaningful Head Start began to go insane
in a number of varied and interesting
ways some who took the situation
seriously and acknowledged that the sun
was indeed going to wipe out most of
humanity simply cracked under the
pressure there were those who went into
totally catatonic States rocking back
and forth in the corner and refusing to
respond to any stimuli some became
erratic and violent with unpredictable
behavior that harmed themselves and
others after all what was the point in
acting normally anymore when the
complete crumbling of human civilization
was imminent and their only hope was
some shadowy organization they'd never
heard of some not heeding the warning
seriously enough and prompted by greed
and opportunism tried to take advantage
of the situation financially some
smashed Windows of local stores and
looted or broke into the homes of
neighbors who had already fled in hopes
of plowing their property others were a
little more creative setting up
shortterm everything must go nighttime
fire sales for their brands of essential
oils NE tropics and neutraceuticals
claiming all of them had the power to
ward off or cure the new effects of the
sun others completely denied the
possibility that any of this was real
and claimed that the messages from the
so-called SCP Foundation were actually
just a front to take away their freedoms
and trap them in underground government
camps they staunchly refused to follow
any of the safety guidelines that the
SCP Foundation put out claiming if you
try to take away my first amendment rats
you're going to take away my second
amendment rats while riding around in
their pickup trucks and SUVs blasting
Kid Rocks don't tell me how to live at
earsplitting volumes naturally they had
all melted into screeching puddles of
liquid flesh by Sunrise some were not
victims of their own bizarre choices but
were doomed by the sudden terrible fear
and panic of the circumstances
themselves the highways were gridlocked
cars stuck as far as the eye could see
so many had rushed to escape during the
initial wave that means of Transport
soon became choke points like clogged
arteries in a dying man people do
irrational things when they're scared
riots broke out in the streets fighting
killing burning everyone hoping for some
means of meager control over a situation
that had long been out of any of their
hands some were too far away with not
enough time to close the distance what
could they really do do but just sit
around and wait to die the hours marched
on as the earth made its slow turn
towards the sun leaving one decimated
half in darkness and the other a Sitting
Duck for its terrible effects hundreds
of thousands had made their way to the
containment sites and safely gotten
inside but still so many millions were
left outside it was a slaughterhouse one
great big Global meat grinder and every
moment that passed the handle turned and
any human left outside got just that
little bit closer to the grinding
nashing gears below site 19 being the
largest containment site on the
foundation books also became Humanity's
only Bastion it was the great hope of
escape from the horrors going on outside
the foundation had figured out so many
ways of counteracting deadly anomalous
forces before given enough time and
enough Personnel surely they could
figure out a solution to even this this
was however when the most startling
realization yet swept over all the
survivors those who were melted by the
sudden hostile Sun weren't dead they
were very much alive in fact but they
had been changed in both body and mind
what had once been humans now became
terrible beasts half melted gelatinous
nightmares that coagulated into even
bigger beasts they got into their head
that they were grateful for the
transformation that they had been
liberated from their old forms in the
old world they were something so much
more now and wanted everyone else to
join them in their Liberation survivors
outside the foundation containment sites
were systematically hunted by these
great masses of altered flesh even
though smart enough to cover every inch
of their bodies with clothes to protect
from the Sun to only move at night to
carry weapons were dragged out by meaty
tendrils from their refuge in the
basements and the lightless hearts of
buildings dragged into the Searing gaze
of the sun to melt to change to coales
into something thing greater it was the
inevitable fate of all of humanity when
most of the stragglers were dragged out
and changed the flesh masses started
turning their attention to the
foundation containment sites that were
keeping all these poor deluded people
from salvation they mounted offensives
against the bases which the foundation
with what remained of their Manpower and
advanced Weaponry did what they could to
repel the attacks but every single day
it got harder thankfully for the people
hold up at site 19
there was one consolation out there to
help SCP 999 the foundation was at war
with the sun and its terrible disciples
and contrary to many people's beliefs it
takes more than men equipment and
bullets to win a war 999 provided the
essential element that brought it all
together morale hope the will to go on
even when it seemed like all could be
lost after a long day of battling the
fleshy Abominations at the gates
Foundation guards mobile task force
members and even civilian volunteers
were drained and traumatized by the
horrors that they'd seen once a day was
over 999 would move among the ranks
cuddling up to them wording off the
despair that was easy to set in during
the downswing of a terrible apocalypse
like this without his presence there
would be no hope of fighting that good
fight so many of them would have given
up walked into the Sun and joined the
Monstrous Force they were fighting after
all they seemed happy enough and it
would certainly be easier 999 had become
once again an indispensable asset to the
SCP Foundation the solar betrayal may
not have been the Scarlet Kings doing
well as far as our current Intel
suggests anyway but he was playing a
crucial part in saving the world exactly
as predicted 999 didn't fully understand
what was going on outside sometimes why
there seemed to be fewer people as the
weeks went on and why the people there
seem so sad all the time whenever he
wasn't helping them but he was more than
happy to help whatever the case many of
the humanoid and some even non-humanoid
anomalies which realistically posed no
harm to people inside the site were
released from their containment Chambers
they needed everyone and everything they
could get in what seemed like a
hopelessly one-sided fight against the
very concept of being outside many of
the larger vacated Chambers were now
filled with refugees from the outside
many of whom had lost everything and
everyone they'd ever known to the
Horrors out there 999 made the rounds in
these areas regularly and through the
d-class Cs which had been repurposed
into more sleeping areas for the
thousands of desperate and terrified
refugees the adjustment to this new life
and to the knowledge of all secrets that
had been kept from them for all these
years wasn't exactly easy on their
psyches but spending time with that soft
yellow blob that seemed to smell exactly
like their favorite scent from the old
world made everything better he was a
savior in Dark Times slythering from
person to person giving hope where there
was none people opened up about their
problems and their fears which these
days were remarkably similar and though
999 couldn't reply for many was enough
just to feel like they were being
listened to he was a soft Blobby
shoulder to cry on and after day broke
everyone needed a good old-fashioned cry
however one day while wandering The Long
Dark corridors of site 19 he saw a
different kind of crying it was a woman
with an familiar face probably one of
the rare new refugees balling her eyes
out to a foundation senior researcher
and an accompanying guard with an
assault rifle hot fat tears were rolling
down her dirty cheeks her shaking hands
clasped in prayer she was begging the
researcher and the guard to let her go
outside she said that her son was still
out there hiding away in the back room
of a bank where she used to work they
got separated she needed to go back and
find him sadly the researcher and the
guard told her that this was out of the
question official orders stated that
anyone outside the base at this time was
to be considered lost letting her go out
there to find her son would essentially
be condemning her to death no human
could go out there safely but of course
scp-999 isn't by any definition a human
when night fell and everyone else was
hunkered down inside 999 found a small
crack in the wall and slithered out of
it it may not have been communicative in
the way most humans were but 99 9 was
indeed an intelligent being and knew
intuitively that if it left through a
more obvious route its human caretakers
here at the SCP Foundation might try to
stop it and when it came to saving this
little boy 999 refused to let anyone
stop it 999 slithered out and through
the broken streets there were no bodies
of course it seemed even the dead could
be revived and assimilated through the
power of the sun talk about a mixed
Miracle but the broken down World
outside site 9 undeniably reflected the
pandemonium that took place here 999
would need to do his best to find the
little boy trapped out here before the
sun rose he lost a few hours even
finding his way to the nearest town
where it was safe to assume that the
little boy was trapped he saw those
things on the way there those moving
wailing mountains of melted human flesh
each talking in shattering to themselves
in a hundred different dead voices 999
had been cross tested with CP 682 and
still those monsters frightened him he
decided it would be best to stay away
from them and make sure that they never
saw him out of here eventually 999
reached the town similarly dilapidated
and broken down in the months since the
world as we had all known it disappeared
in a ray of terrible Sunshine more great
gibbering Blobs of Flesh patrolled the
streets looking for converts to
integrate into their biomass 999 could
only hope it wasn't already too late for
the little boy 999 discreetly slithered
from building to building until it could
identify one as this bank that the boy's
distraught mother had been mentioning it
thankfully had some awareness of what a
bank actually was from the years of
stressed Foundation employees telling it
about the money troubles they were
suffering outside of work it was another
great example of it paying to listen
eventually it did Slither into the
correct building and it heard the
extremely quiet whimpering of the boy
inside it could feel the the sadness and
the fear radiating off of him as it was
the creature's natural instinct to help
the needy and it used those signals like
a homing beam to find the scared little
boy he'd hid an inside a broom closet
and was quietly weeping into his hands
he hadn't eaten in days and was only
surviving by drinking the filthy water
from the mop bucket sitting next to him
999 immediately embraced the boy
covering him in its healing energy until
the tears of the boy's face eventually
dry 999 CED and chirped pleas pleasantly
until the little boy was laughing again
but this momentary Joy was soon
interrupted a great heaving weight
dragged itself down the hall outside
both 999 and the boy could sense its
monstrous presence as it got closer they
could hear all those chattering voices
those poisonous Whispers when it passed
the door they heard it speaking its
voice practically vibrating with the hum
of malicious lunacy turn pretty flowers
turn toward the sun feel it on your face
feel yourself change and SLO and mix
into us become one with our army of One
it must be so lonely to be you Little
Flower walk into the Sun and be us 999
and the boy remain silent in the broom
closet for hours as the great shape
patrolled the bank outside searching for
converts for victims at times it seemed
too frightening to even breathe fearing
that would be enough to make the monster
detect them it felt like an eternity
until the monster eventually did slope
off and leave them in the comforting
quiet and darkness of the closet now
they might be free 999 could escort the
boy safely back to the containment site
and into the arms of his terrified
mother but when they opened the door
they saw a terrible sight light in the
distance pouring Through the Windows and
the glass last double doors it wouldn't
be safe to go out that way upon seeing
this and putting together what it meant
the boy began to cry he couldn't take
another night in the closet it was all
going to Wither from here until 999 had
a wonderful idea hours later when the
foundation's guards manned the turret at
the entrance of site 19 waiting for the
inevitable onslaught of the melted flesh
creatures they tensed up seeing a
blobbing gelatinous form slithering
towards them in the distance the guards
who learned learned the hard way from
too many lost men that it was better to
be safe than sorry Drew a bead on the
distant shape and prepared to fire when
suddenly their Superior raised a hand
and said wait hold fire is that
999 and it was they all stared in
astonishment as 999 chipper than ever
came towards them through the sun it
looked as though the opacity of its
yellow cytoplasm had increased but other
than that it was unaffected turns out
the sun couldn't melt what was already
melted the guards parted to allow 999
safe passage into the facility watching
in amazement and once it was inside 999
slime parted releasing its contents one
very relieved little boy it seemed
through turning up its own opacity 999
had given the boy safe Passage through
the Sun and back into the facility the
boy was saved it had won not long after
that there was a tearful reunion between
mother and child and a brief flash of
Hope in this dark and terrible time 999
didn't stop to bask of course it
returned to its duties keeping up staff
morale and helping the refugees heal
from the horrors they'd seen in its own
little way and for a lot of people SCP
999 really was saving the world or what
was left of it anyway oh and of course
if SCP 999 had won your hearts just like
it one ours you'd be pleased to know
that you can purchase your own adorable
highquality SCP 999 plushy at SCP
swag.com check the link in the
description to get your own trust us
having a 999 to cutle really does make
any apocalypse a whole lot easier oh boy
here we go again SCP
00001 over 30 different bizarre
anomalies claimed this number one spot
in the database and in a sense they're
all right or are they if you're feeling
confused already that's fine we don't
expect that to change because today
we're dealing with one of the most
strange and intricate 001 entries out
there ker Duty just pray you never get
assigned to it you see when you work
around weirdness you sometimes get a
little weird yourself and nobody deals
with more weirdness than employees of
the SCP Foundation they regularly rub
elbows with everything from Godlike
cicas to hyperinfectious Supernatural
viruses and as the famous Tom Jones song
goes it's not un usual to suddenly take
on anomalous traits after consistently
working with anomalies for years that's
how the lyrics go right anyway one of
the foundation's most iconic researchers
Dr Jack brigh is technically just an
anomalous necklace himself but outside
of some famous exceptions the SCP
Foundation is in the business of
containing anomalous entities not hiring
them on and giving them a paycheck and
retirement plan that's why if you
suddenly start displaying anomalous
traits it's while on the foundation
payroll you might receive a company memo
assigning you to the dreaded ker duty
but what is ker Duty and what kind of
anomalous traits can get you assigned to
it let's start with the second question
first the official CER Duty guidelines
list a surprisingly vast number of
afflictions these include chronic
anomalous illnesses such as lycanthropy
turning into a werewolf something called
Stevenson syndrome and the incredibly
unpleasant sounding photonic gastric
discharge syndrome you could also be
placed on kter duty because you're
suffering from the manifestation of
spectral phenomena including being
haunted by Spirits whether they're there
to torment you or protect you the sudden
expression of anomalous traits in your
DNA which is unsettlingly vague will
also land you on ker Duty as will The
Awakening of powerful magical or psionic
abilities especially ones which could be
used in a potentially offensive manner
the ker Duty assignment which involves
being relocated ated and forced to work
in a different highly secretive location
that will be discussed soon is framed as
a punishment for the people involved
that way it discourages Foundation
employees from ever trying to develop
anomalous powers on purpose so what
exactly is ker Duty and where does it
happen to reinforce that punishment
element method the foundation has spread
lies among their own Personnel about
where the job takes place often
involving being posted in some of the
least desirable Foundation areas imagine
inable these include Point Nemo the area
of the ocean farthest from any place of
land on Earth pongyang in North Korea
Stonehenge Roswell lunar area 32 and a
number of foundation waste disposal
sites however the reality of where those
onter Duty end up is even stranger site
100 which in this particular instance is
the true SCP 001 this Thal class anomaly
is perhaps the most unique of all multi
anomaly Foundation container mment sites
a bizarre Labyrinth of non- ucan
geometry that defies true explanation
but we'll do the best we can in a sense
site 100 is a facility with a mind of
its own it's a sprawling underground
base with a layout that defies SpaceTime
and what's more it undergos so-called
migration events every so often it will
begin to exhibit a sense of dimensional
instability before teleporting to a
different location somewhere on Earth
currently the primary entrance to site
100 known as Alpha entrance is located
in the Southwest United States though
all signs point to another migration
event happening this very year but
knowing where the entrance is will only
get you so far people assigned to Cutter
Duty are sent from the alpha entrance to
the administration sector to be given
their initial breaching at which point
the true Madness begins let's take a
look at a map of site 100 yikes so there
are 10 major sectors in site 100 that
you should be aware of entrance Alpha
Administration archives technological
containment bio containment Sapient
containment Cognito hazardous mimetic
and semantic or CMS containment esoteric
containment conceptual containment and
the core sector as you can tell they
have almost everything covered here but
just as insane as the anomalies that
site 100 contains and the methods they
use to contain them is how you actually
get around the site site 100 is a space
racial anomaly of truly epic proportions
while the foundation is aware of the
existence of its competent sectors it's
impossible to map out any meaningful
connections between them it would be
pretty much impossible to even travel
from one to another without passageways
known as The Roots however these aren't
just mere portals that you can hop
through like the ways in and out of the
wanderer's library each route between
the sectors is its own complex
environment with its own sets of
protocols and rituals required to safely
travel through it rout Alf the bridge
between the archives and the
inaccessible core of site 100 is a
volcanic Beach blocked off by an
apparently Limitless obsidian wall where
fish made from living rocks swim in the
nearby Waters root Beth connecting the
core and Sapient containment is a huge
and sprawling Funhouse Hall of Mirrors
anyone who attempts to travel through it
inevitably ends up turned around and
arrives back at their starting point in
Sapient containment rout dth the bridge
that connects conceptual containment and
the core is a massive ocean that has
resisted all attempts by the foundation
to Traverse it rout VAV the bridge
between esoteric containment and
conceptual containment is a massive
field filled with unidentified fruit
trees Foundation Expeditions have found
that it too seems impossible to Traverse
one Expedition team was trapped inside
for a whole year until one member of the
team expressed a desire to go home at
that point they were immediately
teleported back to the starting point
rot Sade connecting Administration to
the CMS sector is a huge Lush Forest on
top of a floating Mountain the only
animals that seem to populate this
Forest are nonanomalous flamingos next
we have rup P the bridge between the
archive and the administration which
appears to be a hallway on the fifth
floor of a tenement building in a city
that the foundation haven't been able to
locate this building is populated by non
hostile humanoid creatures will approach
Foundation staff traversing route p and
invite them into their Apartments
offering to partake in recreational
activities with them such as video games
board games or watching movies the
foundation discourages its staff from
accepting any of these offers while on
the job and then there's root Shin which
connects the Sapient and conceptual
containment sectors this route is unique
in the sense that it acts as a power
generator for the rest of site 100 as
it's filled with hundreds of large
perpetual motion machines producing a
constant 8.7 gaw of electricity these
are only some of the many routs
Illustrated on the site 100 diagram as
you've probably gathered by now it's
less like a conventional building and
more like a whole crazy Dimension unto
itself why does the foundation work to
maintain such a crazy place wouldn't it
just be easier to keep it a secret and
contain it like any other anomaly Well
site 100 wouldn't be given the SCP 001
designation if it wasn't incredibly
important if site 100 was ever
compromised it would lead to an
inevitable K Class end of the World
scenario because the site is
intrinsically tied to the nature and
containment of literally every single
ker class SCP in our universe hence the
nickname ker Duty for those working at
the site in fact an anomaly can't even
be classed as a ker if it isn't given
permission by site 100 the various
sectors of site 100 cover the entire
spectrum of anomalies and each sector is
a massive panoptic structure connected
by networks of glass elevators whenever
a new ker class SCP is discovered its
name and a brief description of its
anomalous traits will inscribe itself on
one of the walls in its corresponding
sector ever been frustrated when the 05
Council refused to sign off on an
upgrade to ker class for a clearly
dangerous SCP that poses extreme risk of
containment breach don't blame them it's
simply that site 100 didn't sanction the
change anytime that site 100 sanctions a
new SCP it also undergos another unique
process it selects an SCP 00 1-k
instance for the new ker and creates a
connection between them using access
points known as thresholds think of it
as simply opening a spatially anomalous
door between two scps much like a good
boy another SCP vying for the 001 slot
site 100 has an intuitive grasp of the
Unseen connections between ker class
anomalies and each SCP 001 DK instance
is a complimentary ker class that will
essentially cancel out the the threat of
its other half site 100 is a containment
Matchmaker its inate ability to use the
anomalous to contain the anomalous is
second to none first it took SCP 3984 an
anomalous phenomenon that seemed to
prevent death from happening to all life
forms in order to mitigate the effects
of 3984 site 100 opened a threshold
between it and SCP
2935 also known as O Death an alternate
universe hidden Beyond a Lin Stone
Cavern where all lives simultaneously
cease to exist even down to the
bacterial level by opening the threshold
and allowing these two absolute
opposites to mix it seemed to undermine
the effects of both and create a
non-anomalous happy medium life but
mortal Life Next SCP
5007 this terrifying underwater anomaly
manifests as a series of tentacle like
protrusions that snatch unfortunate
creatures that get too close and
assimilate them into its own own Mass
site 100 cleverly opened a threshold to
SCP 169 a massive underwater anthropod
known as the Leviathan SCP 169 was
Tangled Up by the tentacles but it's too
big to be fully consumed or assimilated
and the result is that 57 is trapped in
a perpetually incapacitated State akin
to choking keeping it contained and
stopping it from going after anyone else
let's take a look at two even more
hostile and dangerous ker class
anomalies matched up by site 100 first
we've got SCP
5501 an old camera from the 1800s that
comes with 18 photographs these
photographs act as a kind of portal to
an incredibly frightening alternate
reality that creatures regularly crawl
out of attacking and killing anyone
within reach site 100 found a perfect
match for this nasty customer SCP
1983 this is a small house that acts as
a portal to a race of tall monsters with
needle-like appendages that leave the
house in search of victims when they
catch these victims they take out their
hearts and bring them back to the nest
site 100 opened a threshold into the SCP
1983 house and placed the 5501
photographs inside as a result the
Hostile creatures from both dimensions
now regulate each other's populations by
killing each other another job well done
for site 100 another ker class dealt
with by SCP 100 is SCP
p122 this is a deadly plot of land in
Poland which decays and corrodes all
matter organic or inorganic placed
within its confines this would be bad
enough but as you'll often find with
anomalous plots of deadly land its area
of influence is growing even knowing
about it can cause it to become more
powerful but site 100 found its perfect
ker class counterpart SCP
1262 this is a massive mass of plant
matter that grows at a truly astonishing
rate expanding by around 7 km an hour
much like absolute death and absolute
Life by putting 1262 into SCP
p122 a healthy medium was found
somewhere in between and finally perhaps
the strangest and most creative match
site 100 has ever pulled off SCP 3852
and SCP
2547 3852 is an anonymous corpse that
manifests in small towns showing fear
and suspicion eventually a local person
is believed to be responsible for this
murder and is lynched in a rage by the
town's people as a form of vigilante
justice the corpse then moves on to the
next town 2547 if you can believe it is
even weirder it's a pack of dogs led by
an intelligent talking coyote dressed as
a priest site 100 had the truly Galaxy
brain idea to open a threshold and
connect the two as a result whenever the
corpse manifest in the town the dogs
Rampage in and take over at that point
they set up a kind of ridiculous
Kangaroo Court where a jury made up of
people from the town are forced to find
3852 scapegoat innocent if they don't
the dogs will simply hold the town's
water supply hostage until 3852
anomalous effects pass such an obvious
idea now why didn't the foundation think
of that CER Duty may not be the most
conventional easy or attractive work but
like everything the Foundation does
making sure site 100 can keep doing its
job is a necessary part of keeping our
world safe from anomalous threats now if
you'll excuse us we need to get going H
do you know which is the right route out
of here another day another failed
attempt at death if SCP 682 had anything
even resembling a sense of humor you
might ask for it to be printed on a
motivational poster and stuck to the
side of his containment chamber where he
ATT eternally melts and regrows at the
mercy of high concentration acid they
just cross tested him with AEL again
unlike some of the others he'd been
forced to face that tattooed swordsman
seemingly wasn't intelligent enough to
fear he'd always come back just as
stupid and violent this encounter had
left the heart to destroy reptile at 30%
of his previous body mass bloody and
bashed he'd survived the encounter he
always survived they brought what was
left of him back to his cell in a
forklift a blasted forklift how could it
even be more humiliating as his eyes
started to grow back in his head he
could swear he even saw one of the
technicians laughing at him his name tag
read agent Nigel Kelly noted 682 would
specifically hunt down and kill him the
next time he breached of course every
single day he plotted revenge against
the human race along with every
everything else but the sum they owed in
pain blood and despair could never be
repaid in full after all every single
one of them except Dr brigh could only
really die once they'd brought 682 to
the precipice a thousand times only for
his own body to cheat him and deprive
him of the sweet release of death and if
the foundation had their way it would be
done a thousand times more and they
wouldn't even stop there 6 city2
couldn't even imagine the number of
containment breaches it would take to
deal a blow even comparable to the one
he had faced all he could do was dream
dream of a reckoning that would turn the
tables something that would plunge
Humanity into the state of constant pain
and Terror that had been all he'd ever
known since these fumbling ssts in white
coats had locked him up here what a
beautiful day that would be little did
SCP d682 no that very day was about to
break miles and miles away from the
facility where s SCP 682 was kept after
all orders from the 05 Council have hard
mandates on the minimum distances
between people and a sight holding a
monster as volatile as 682 parents watch
their children laughing and frolicking
in an idyllic playground some squealed
with Glee as they descended the slide
some of the more ambitious Little Tikes
tried to go over the bar on the swings
others waited in line for some delicious
soft serve at a parked ice cream truck
one mother brought an ice cream cone and
walked over to a nearby bench where she
began to enjoy her delicious Frozen
treat it was a remarkably hot day out
and a little ice cream was the perfect
addition to her relaxation while her
kids were occupied you could see the
distant air wobbling in the heat already
her ice cream was starting to melt white
rivulets dribbling down the sides of the
cone and onto her hands suddenly almost
imperceptibly the quality of the light
shifted the kind of thing you'd dismiss
as a trick of the eyes and forget just
as quickly were it not for the
catastrophic effects that were about to
unfold as the woman leaned forward to
lick her melting ice cream something
dripped onto her skirt but as she looked
down she slowly realized that what
dripped onto her wasn't the Pure White
of her ice cream it was the same exact
tone as her skin she felt a terrible
burning sensation all through her body
the most horrible debilitating pain
she'd ever experienced like every cell
in her body was screaming and trying to
make a break for it she turned to the
other parents sitting near the
playground they were screaming too each
collapsed to the ground with agonizing
slowness different parts of their body
falling at different speeds as they
transition through states of M matter
when they hit the ground they were
taking on a liquid state screaming
worthless boneless blobs the woman even
saw her own arm wilting like a
time-lapse video of a Dying flower she
dripped and sosed through the cracks in
the bench until nothing recognizably
human was left only a soggy ice cream
cone sitting
uneaten in an instant billions of
Screams rang out over planet Earth Day
had broken things would never ever be
the same again as almost half of
humanity
instantaneously took on a liquid state
needless to say with the most dangerous
and far-reaching anomalous incident in
human history suddenly breaking out
without any kind of warning the SCP
Foundation was incredibly busy this
would take some unprecedented action the
members of the 05 Council who weren't
melted during the initial blast convened
over secure video link while
sequestering themselves underground and
what amounted to multiple human
lifetimes of some of the most high press
choices imaginable they made the most
difficult decision since the very
beginning of the SCP Foundation in the
service of all mankind they would now
break the Masquerade the SCP Foundation
would at long last step out of the
Shadows to save the rest of humanity
from the tyranny of the light broadcasts
went out all over the globe every TV
screen every live stream every radio
broadcast was commandeered they gave
instructions based on the scattered
Intel they had for some reason the sun
had turned against them exposure would
lead any biological creatures melting
away into sentient piles of flesh
colored sludge people would remain
indoors and away from any light sources
all windows must remain covered travel
only at night and even then heavily
covered with prote Ive gear there can
only be one objective for whoever is
left make your way to the nearest SCP
Foundation containment facility and seek
Refuge inside if anyone could figure out
the answer to this terrifying
existential riddle it would be thep
Foundation anyone who is exposed should
be considered lost while as always the
SCP Foundation did all they could to
project a sense of control over the
situation on the inside it was
pandemonium somehow despite everything
this event had taken all of them by
surprise how could anyone have predicted
that the Cradle of our solar systems
delicate living balance would suddenly
become a meat grinder a huge number of
foundation operatives were wiped out in
the initial exposure Global
Communication infrastructure had been
devastated it was pure chaos and to SCP
682 as another evil tactician once put
it chaos was a ladder from the inside of
his acid t tank 6 av2 could sense the
fear and pain suddenly exuding from his
surrounding environment it was greater
than ever before what was happening out
there this was no average Containment
Breach something was really really
happening out there 682 began to adapt
and finally attune its hearing until it
could pick up the chatter from outside
uh maybe we can convert some of the
d-class barracks into serviceable
bunkers for the refugees it's not like
we're prepared for this kind of capacity
oh god oh God we've lost sight 7 sight
10 sight 23 sight 40 sight 52 a death
toe looks to be in the billions well we
don't know if they're dead technically
but they're sure as hell not human
anymore well this is the big one this is
it XK class even 2,000 is unaccounted
for he all five crazy that they think
we're fighting the freaking son needless
to say 682s curiosity was peaked
anything that could light a fire under
the foundation like this was something
he could enjoy and with his impressively
strategic intellect he he intuited that
a time of great Strife for the
foundation would be the perfect time to
breach containment cuz whenever there's
violence fear and Chaos on a mass scale
SCP 682 will be there causing it 682
began adapting his pores and endocrine
system to begin releasing a powerful
alkaline substance little by little the
alkaline neutralized the acids
surrounding him turning it into little
more than plain water he then converted
his internal systems to have extreme
endothermic rather than exothermic
properties causing his surrounding
temperature to drop rapidly until all
the water in the tank completely froze
around him the ice expanded beyond the
limit of the containment unit busting
the rivets of the metal frame and
shattering the reinforced glass with his
goal achieved 682 raised his internal
temperatures to incredible highs melting
the ice around him once again he was
free and ready for some good old
oldfashioned Carnage and Mayhem perhaps
he could get a better handle on this
strange new situation too it was all
rather exciting just a girl with goals
huh SCP Foundation Personnel were
already running around like ants trying
desperately to avoid the costic laser
beam of the magnifying glass you can
only imagine how much worse it made
matters when 682 suddenly burst through
the wall Kool-Aid Man style and began to
ruthlessly Massacre everyone around him
just one of those days you know the
typical order during a 682 Containment
Breach is to dispatch all available
units to get him back under control the
issue with this particular Containment
Breach was that given the human
population was very rapidly being melted
and they were the only ones who could
potentially save the rest they didn't
really have any available units to
pursue and recontain 682 for once he
really wasn't a priority and that meant
terrible things for whoever he ran in
into 682 slaughtered his way through any
researchers or guards who dared to get
in his way disgusting creatures really
better off dead he clawed and bit and
tore and crushed with almost childlike
Glee leaving great piles of bodies in
his wake all the while he was pondering
the things he heard those Foundation
drones saying something about the Sun
and an XK class scenario H interesting
682 also observed that any apertures
that could potenti allow light into the
facility had also been shuttered perhaps
they weren't overreacting this time like
they always did with him maybe they were
dealing with some kind of phenomenon
that would Now cast this wretched world
and those who lived in it into the void
wouldn't that be A fitting karmic fate
for them all still 682s bloodlust didn't
outweigh his logic he needed to know
more about the situation before
proceeding and in this maybe he could
kill two Foundation birds with one stone
elsewhere in the building alarms blared
the air was suffused with panicked
voices and frequent screams nobody knew
what was going on not really they'd only
gotten details here and there and the
details they' received were terrifying
all their families and loved ones
outside probably gone so many of the
people in so much of the world they'd
been fighting for risking it all for had
disappeared in an instant carried to
Hell on a red day of sunshine why were
they still here was this horror not
truly uncontainable these questions were
swimming through the mind of agent Nigel
Kelly as he stood alone in his office
almost catatonic he' had his friends and
family on the outside all likely reduced
to those horrible fleshy blobs he was
alone in the world risking his life for
nothing how could this get any worse his
mind kept repeating that question again
and again and again and and the universe
gave him an answer in the form of a deep
reptilian voice saying found you into
his ear from behind he turned with a
shriek to see the terrible eyes of 682
staring into his own before he could try
to flee or reach for a weapon that he
knew would only mildly annoy the already
Furious Beast 682 reached out with a
massive clawed hand and grabed him by
the Torso lifting him up into the air
the creature was gripping so tight that
he could feel his ribs starting to cack
you laugh at me Agent Kelly the monster
hissed am I funny to you do I seem like
the time to tell
jokes do you feel like laughing now
agent Kelly begged and pleaded for his
life fighting for his next breath from
the crushing squeeze of the creature's
terrible hand 682 roared at him to be
silent and ordered him to tell him
everything he knew about the situation
going on outside if the information was
useful 682 might show his thought to be
non-existent magnanimous side and let
agent Kelly live of course agent kelly
didn't fancy his chances but what other
choice did he have he told 682 that the
H high-ups were calling this SCP 001
when day breaks the sun had gone Rogue
somehow and being in contact with any
kind of sunlight would now cause people
to instantaneously melt into horrifying
living sludge and it wasn't just people
the condition also affected anomalies
and interestingly it appeared to negate
all previous anomalous effects so 682s
adaptational ability may not even save
it if it was exposed he told 682
everything he knew are you are you going
to let me live agent Kelly asked
struggling to breathe 682s terrible maw
Twisted into What Might Have Been a
Smile oh and Kelly he said with
unsettling joy that was a joke didn't
you find that one funny a terrible
scream emanated from the agent's office
if one good thing could be said for what
happened to agent Kelly that day at
least he didn't live long enough to see
the ravages of the terrible Sun
firsthand 682 began to formulate a plan
he took agent Kelly's wristwatch and
integrated it into his body so he'd have
a permanent internal clim
it was the middle of summer so the sun
would have reliably set at 900 p.m. and
would likely begin its rise around 5:00
a.m. it would be relatively easy to
avoid the sun All Things Considered for
lack of a more eloquent way to put it
when it comes to adapting to new threats
SCP 682 is Simply Built different after
slaughtering a few other members of SCP
Foundation staff for the road hey it's
not like anyone was fit to stop him 682
began Ana ing the new phase of his plan
his body grew a thick smooth carrese and
his front set of Limbs began to grow his
muscles bulging and his claws growing
the tips turning into Sharp flat Scoops
with sudden and tremendous Force 682
began boring his way into the ground
tunneling clawing through concrete and
dirt with absolute ease normally the SCP
Foundation would have deployed high-tech
seismic sensors and the kind of tunnel
boring machines that Elon mus could only
dream of to intercept and recapture him
but during the endless horrors of the
breaking day he had K blanch to escape
and live it up in the ruins of this
rapidly Dying World eventually 682 had
boarded his way into a roomy sewer pipe
the perfect place to wait out a few
hours up above so many millions screamed
either in fear or in agony there had
been some new developments that the SCP
Foundation had been yet to account for
well they knew that those melted by the
Rogue Sun were technically alive and
trapped in a permanent state of
suffering what the foundation didn't
know was that these former humans were
incredibly dangerous in their own right
The sun hadn't just irreparably warped
their bodies it had also irreparably
warped their minds it has enslaved them
made them zealots acolytes they
developed the instinct to coagulate into
giant fleshing masses driven by the
single-minded purpose
of finding victims and dragging them
into the light where they too could be
converted into these terrible fleshy
creatures and add to the masses they
were the Rogue Sons boots on the ground
metaphorically speaking and now they
were the foundation's greatest challenge
in getting a handle on this situation
again before it was just encouraging
people to avoid the sun now the sun was
actively trying to increase its exposure
but 682 who was having a relaxing
evening not being melted for once down
in the sewers couldn't care less he was
having the most calming few hours he'd
had in years he waited checking the time
making sure that it would be dark before
he began tunneling back up to the
surface world he surfaced in the middle
of his City miles away from the
foundation facility he'd spent so many
decades being tortured in he tasted the
cool night air and observed the
Desolation that had been rot all around
him buildings were on fire cars were
crashed and overturned the ground was
cracked garbled SCP Foundation public
service announcements played to nobody
in the broken display Windows of
electronic stores giant wads of human
flesh roam slithering around searching
for new victims one noticed 682 and
began to approach him gibbering madly in
a chorus of strange voices the hard to
destroy reptile wasted no time in
attacking it tore apart most of the ous
blob and began hungrily devouring the
chunks the form may have been different
but it's still tasted like human flesh
and SCP 682 savored every bite it would
be so simple these Blobs of idiotic
flesh were so easy to kill and there
would be so many terrified humans in
this devastated World hiding away in
Dark Places holding out the hope that
maybe they could reach the safety of a
foundation facility 682 chuckled at the
very thought foolish hope would drown in
an endless well of black costic despair
he would find them he would rest
underground in the day and then hunt
them in the dark they would all die
screaming bloodying his claws and fangs
nothing and nobody would stop him he
looked out over this strange new world
and laughed a little
[Music]
louder it was just
delightful a world that's lost its way
needs a Healer someone to patch up its
wounds and tend to its pain it needs a
doctor when day broke the sun turned
from a Giver of Life the thing that
wakes the rooster and makes the crops
grow to an indiscriminate killer wiping
out all organic life forms the world
seemed truly lost but one anomalous
being made it his goal to soothe the
hurt to make it safe to step into the
light once more the plague doctor had
done his best with the limited resources
afforded to him at the abandoned
Foundation site the scientists had left
behind all of their equipment when the
Red Sun came when they all were
transformed he had appointed himself the
site director willing to take up the
mantle when no one else would he had
assembled the brave brilliant team of
fellow anomalies the verbose Dr speno
the eloquent adventurous Lord Blackwood
and the charismatic but ravenous
Ferdinand there had of course been those
who scoffed at his vision who did not
share his Noble goal the Abominable
possessive mask taunted him persistently
trying its best to get under his kitous
skin but he did not have time to waste
on Such trivial psychological games and
he ignored its taunts to focus on the
work it hadn't been easy capturing one
of the infected specimens the former
human being turned mass of oozing
gelatinous flesh by the Unholy light in
the sky one had made its way into the
abandoned facility sliding its way
across the floor with an air of confused
malice it wanted to hurt but it didn't
know where it was who it was anymore but
it was frightened the play doctor could
tell a good physician always knows and
can say sense the fear and pain of a
suffering person it made his heart ache
to see and he knew there was only one
thing to do try to make this poor soul
well again everyone please assist me in
escorting the patient to my laboratory
the doctor called out this was once a
man and I believe with our combined
intellect and resources we can return
him to his former State Ferdinand took a
step toward the slimy creature licking
his lips a bit do you think I could have
just a little bit of it oh I'm so hungry
doctor he begged no no it would go
against my oath as a physician to allow
any more harm to come to this poor
fellow the plague doctor shook his head
solemnly ferame pouted but did not press
the issue further no the doctor rubbed
his gloved hands together in
anticipation of the next task it is
imperative we contain our new friend
safely if you would please he gestured
to several of his previous patients now
reanimated and ready to Aid him with his
research the shuffling figure surrounded
the Blobby entity ushering it down the
hall confused lost with no real sense of
a plan left in its mushy Consciousness
the creature followed where it was led
the group made it back to the doctor's
laboratory C shouted Dr spanco from his
perch at top a nearby shelf yes indeed
the doctor replied the standard
operating table wouldn't do for such a
special patient I have nowhere to place
the rest FRS you see I will have to make
do with the floor F them my bag if you
please the giant rushed to his side
dropping the bag at his feet if he dies
then can I eat it he asked shifting from
one foot to the other like a child
asking a parent for a second helping of
ice cream if I am unable to save the
patient which I do deem unlikely then
yes you may help me dispose of their
Remains the doctor relented but I do not
hope it comes to that he pressed a hand
to his beak in deep thought for a moment
before opening his bag and pulling out a
syringe filled with clear liquid to
begin we must sedate the patient he had
no way to find a veins and so he plunged
the needle into the nearest section of
the creature's soft surface injecting a
dose of sedative then he waited the
ooing motion of the entity slowed and
stopped it laid there on the ground a
still mound of Flesh save for the
occasional expanding and Contracting
motion almost as if it was breathing
excellent now there was no risk of the
patient fleeing the operating room mid
procedure he could truly begin it was an
arduous process that took hours of
effort of taking small tissue samples
attempting to make incisions only for
the flesh to fuse back together seconds
after the scalpel was taken away this
was truly an advanced illness unlike
anything he had ever seen before it was
enough to make him question his
abilities as a doctor but he shook the
thought away self-pity never helped
anyone after about 8 hours of continuous
work he had a breakthrough a solution he
had created long ago a thick green
liquid sealed in a Dusty jar had a
miraculous effect when dripped onto one
of the tissue samples the melted flesh
reconstituted became solid and human
again hure he cried out unable to
restrain the sudden joy that leaped into
his heart this could be it very
carefully he filled a dropper with the
green liquid if these initially trials
had been successful then perhaps he
couldn't finish the thought best not to
get ahead of himself he crossed to his
patient and slowly began to pour the
solution over the creature's viscous
surface he watched as the flesh
toughened coming together into a surface
resembling human skin it was working it
was working but then the creature began
to quiver shaking uncontrollably like a
bowl of jelly in an earthquake the
surface rippled and the doctor could
hear a high-pitched whine filling the
room then with a wet pop the patient
exploded sending chunks of Flesh
splattering all over the room painting
the walls and ceiling the doctor cried
out in shock and horror and in spite of
himself fell to his knees in despair he
had been so close but still he had
failed and who could say when he would
find another test subject if he would
ever find a cure I'm afraid I do not
know what to do now the doctor admitted
Fernand side the next several days
passed in a haze the doctor paced around
his laboratory mulling over his possible
mistakes again and again he had rushed
the process he was certain of that now
it was a novice mistake the sort of
thing he might have done a century or
two ago how could he have been so
foolish how could he have made that
innocent pay the price for his own
hubris as the doctor locked himself away
in his mind Palace Fernand occupied
himself by practicing his favorite songs
Lord Blackwood rode on the a massive
man's shoulder as he sang through the
Opera Don Giovani I once saw a
production of this at the theatr LA
fenice in Venice Lord Blackwood
interjected his Rhino pores twitching in
delight at the memory marvelous
production marvelous City I was there
hunting a rogue tatel worm wrecking
Havoc through the canals I nearly lost
my life on that
Voyage would you all be quiet for once
in your miserable lives a voice hissed
from the Shadows there in the doorway
and face fixed in a frown was the
possessive mask black slime drip from
its eye holes spilling down onto the
plastic manican body it had taken hold
of listening to you both is worse than
being locked in that infernal box The
Mask looked around the room searching
for
someone where is the good doctor it
asked voice dripping with the
stain still moping about Counting his
failures ignore him my fine fellow Lord
Blackwood whispered to Fernand only
those with weak constitutions and no
achievements of their own spend their
days dragging others down when you have
lived as long as I you will learn
[Laughter]
this careful my
Lord I'll stop by the kitchen and find
some salt to pour on you if you wish to
fight me then challenge me to a fair D
like a man the colorful slug bellowed
drawn by the sudden shouting the doctor
walked into the room what is all this
commotion oh good The Mask clapped its
plastic hands together its face warping
back into an eerie
smile there you are this has all been so
dreadfully
boring I came to see the remnants of
your greatest shame are there still
blood stains on the floor in your your
pathetic little
laboratory you are a villain the doctor
seed uncomfortable with the air of
conflict in the room ferand and Lord
Blackwood quickly exited to find another
space where they could sing and share
stories in
peace I simply speak the truths no one
wants to hear the mask crossed to the
doctor's side with a series of light
dance like steps that made the mannequin
body Creek in in fact I have quite a few
truths to share today I've been outside
you see whatever's become of the sun
only affects organic beings and so he
gestured from his ceramic face to his
plastic
body I am quite safe from its Rays
you've been outside the doctor couldn't
keep the Curiosity out of his voice he
was a scientist after all why yes would
you like to know what I've seen black
slime dripped from the mask's mouth
pooling on the floor with a sizzling
sound I'm in no mood for tricks the
doctor warned the mask held up his hands
in mocked
surrender no tricks doctor but if you
rather take your chances outside and see
for yourself I can take my leave now no
the doctor shook his head please do tell
me it's so much worse than you could
even imagine the mask's words were Bleak
but its tone was
gleeful everywhere you look out there
light has made
monsters hum Stars cats mice the wild
beasts of the forest all melted down to
creatures you would not even
recognize but that isn't all no that is
not all there are massive beasts 10t
tall and more made from dozens and
dozens of the creatures coming together
they fuse and meld into one giant entity
roving the streets in search of more and
more bodies to add to the pile an oozing
gaping M hunger and hate that seeks only
to consume and destroy it calls out to
surviving humans in the voices of their
fallen loved ones tugs at their
heartstrings to lure them out of their
hiding places and then it wraps around
them with fleshy tentacles pulling them
in until they are no more just another
part of the
monster oh doctor it's Terror it's an
Abomination I could watch it all
day the doctor wanted to believe the
mask was lying that it was trying to
torment with him with awful Fabrications
but after all all he had seen so far he
knew that its words were true get out of
my sight he said or what the mask stared
him down with its unmoving smile I've
seen what you do to your hosts you know
your body won't last forever the doctor
growled true maybe next I'll take
yours The Mask laughed a long dark laugh
of something ancient and evil then it
turned and walked out the door leaving
the doctor alone he spent so much of his
time that way lately his assistants were
preoccupied his former patience provided
no real company and so he did what he
did best carry on in solitude he
couldn't be sure how long he stood there
in silence thinking of what the mask
told him he knew it was dangerous
outside knew he was up against powerful
destructive forces but it was even worse
than he had thought what if the world
was truly doomed what if this was how it
all ended not with a bang but with a
great melting suddenly the doctor heard
a sound he hadn't heard since the sun
turned wrong a scream a human scream
could it be he had to see for himself he
grabbed his bag of tools and rushed down
the hall his robes fluttering behind him
there it was again a different human
voice screaming in Terror as he grew
closer to the sound he could hear
footsteps very ious other voices
overlapping with each other he rounded
the corner and there they were a group
of five humans wrapped in tattered
clothes dirty and exhausted behind them
was the entrance to what looked like a
tunnel somehow they found a secret
passage and mayed way inside then he saw
what made them scream clearly these
people were afraid and unaccustomed to
the sight of a man of ferdinand's
stature especially when the man was
drooling and staring at them with hunger
in his eyes he would have to diffuse the
situation quickly hello welcome we mean
you no harm strangers he stepped between
Fernand and the humans the man at the
front of the group brandished a firearm
pointing the barrel directly at the
doctor's beak please sir there is no
need for violence what are you the man
stammered the other members of his party
cowered behind him an ally if you will
permit me to be I'm a physician you see
working on a cure for the condition that
plagues the world with a shaking hand
the man slowly lowered his gun he did
not put it away though
you've figured out a cure for those
things I am in the process of developing
it so far I have not been successful but
perhaps with your help how do we know we
can trust you the man demanded how I
supposed to know you're not part of this
do you know who this man is Fernand
bellowed this is Dr John Watson and I am
detective Sherlock Holmes the greatest
investigator in the world there isn't
the case we can solve the man looked at
the woman next to him and the two shared
a wide-eyed glance this this guy's crazy
he whispered furtively put your weapon
away and we can speak more calmly the
doctor proposed at this inopportune
moment a few of his revive patient
shambled into view and the man screamed
again this time he fired his weapon
shooting at one of the walking corpses
the bullets ricocheted off the walls and
several of the patients were hit please
stop with no other option the doctor
grabbed the man's arm hoping to to get a
hold of the weapon and end the potential
Bloodshed as soon as his gloved hand
made contact the man went limp and
dropped to the ground with a hard thud
the woman next to him pulled him into
her arms checking his pulse he's dead
she shrieked tears streaming down her
face I I am so sorry my lady I did not
intend she grabbed the man's gun and
trained it on the doctor once more you
killed him she cried the other survivors
were too shaken to speak to move one of
them had his back turned to the group
and was staring into the darkness behind
him whatever he was looking at it was
worse than the chaos unfolding but no
one noticed the beige flesh tentacle
snaking along the ground until it was
too late until it had grabbed a hold of
the man's ankle and dragged him into the
tunnel with a shriek of pure
unadulterated Terror the woman nearly
dropped her gun at the sound whirling
around to see what had happened deep in
the tunnel the screen warped into a wet
gurgling sound and then there was
silence for a long moment but then
something worse a gooey slimy sound the
sound of something enormous something
soft and fleshy making its way through
the tunnel and toward the group another
tentacle curled around the edge of the
opening then another joined it something
emerged that might have once been a hand
but had melted into something
unrecognizable the monster emerged piece
by piece until the doctor could see the
entire thing it looked like a heap of
people dozens of them clambering on top
of each other wrapping their limbs
together until their flesh and insides
emptied out and fused into a shapeless
Mass it moved a bit like a giant slug
slimy and slow but it seemed to know it
could take its time as the survivors
scrambled back away from it ferand and
the doctor taking a few steps back of
their own the sound of human voices
filled the room there were
unintelligible Whispers the soft giggle
of a child a woman weaping come and be
with us a little boy's voice broke
through the cacophony Mommy I miss you
don't you miss me the woman with the gun
let out a broken SOB Billy she sniffled
it's me mommy the innocent voice
continued emanating from somewhere deep
inside the Monstrous mass that crept
along the ground swelling and grasping
with its ropey tentacles come play with
me outside all you have to do is come
outside Madame the creature is not who
it claims to be the doctor spoke up and
it seemed to shake the woman out of a
trance you're not my son she hissed
squeezing the trigger and firing at the
monster the bullet made contact with a
wet useless slap and disappeared into
the roving pile of the Fallen she fired
again and again but the monster did not
stop it did not even slow down it lashed
out with a tentacle that wrapped around
her throat in a single fluid motion and
snapped her neck with a crack she fell
to the ground and the tentacle pulled
her into its depths until she was no
longer visible she hadn't been taken by
the Sun not yet but she was still lost
the rest of the survivors followed their
screams silence one by one the doctor
felt the same overwhelming sense of
hopelessness wash over him the same
shadow that had passed over him when he
lost the last patient what could he do
he was one physician against an
overpowering force of Destruction
perhaps he could touch it and would fall
dead like so many other organisms before
but what if it didn't What If instead it
wrapped around his body and squeezed the
life from him what if it carried him out
into that Cur curs sunlight and he
melted away like the others he had to
make a decision because the Beast was
advancing toward him doctor ferand
shouted it's going to destroy our
facility indeed the creature was
flailing its appendages around beating
against the walls and trying to tear
down steel and plaster break down the
shelter until they too were exposed to
the deadly light I'm afraid this may be
the end my friend the doctor lamented I
can see no hope for us now no Ferdinand
shook his head let me save us let me
lead it back outside you'll be taken the
doctor cried perhaps not I am a
magnificent specimen after all I believe
I can withstand the Sun and return to
continue our work together Fernand
scooped his sleeping Lord Blackwood from
his shoulder and placed him gingerly on
a nearby shelf thank you for your
company then he turned back to the
doctor and thank you for my freedom and
your friendship it has been an honor
before before the doctor could protest
Ferdinand was running his thunderous
steps pounding the Earth as he led the
monster in a chase it took the bait
following this new large Target back
outside he sealed off the tunnel behind
them ensuring the Beast would not return
the way it came he wanted to believe
Fan's bravado to think that the Behemoth
of a man had survived outside but that
night he saw the great Beast ooze past a
window and he could make out that
familiar wide toothy grin protruding
from its side just like that the
greatest assistant he had ever had was
lost thank you for your service my
friend he whispered to himself I
solemnly swear to you your death shall
not be in vain computers are capable of
organizing raw data and Performing
calculations at a rate truly impossible
for human beings but they've
consistently run up against one
roadblock that modern Computing is
trying to solve in order to transcend
the limits of the machine and create
true artificial intelligence computers
need to be able to assign meaning to the
data they process this brings us to the
neural network a type of AI becoming
increasingly common these days build to
study mass quantities of data and notice
patterns then replicate these patterns
in their own output and it's used in
everything from predictive text to image
identification and like all nonanomalous
technology it's a safe bet that the SCP
Foundation has been sitting on a version
that's far more effective but this time
it may have actually been too effective
meet the zatz type ak9 computational
engine a massive supercomputer built by
the foundation back in 1955 and residing
at site 5 this technological Marvel was
ahead of its time by decades and despite
technically being a non-anomalous
construction it's designated SCP 001 ex
why because it's one of the few scps to
be given the object class explained
the zat derived from the German word
urat meaning artificial or simply not
real was designed to make the
foundation's job easier as an advanced
predecessor in the modern neural network
using technology exclusively available
to the foundation the plan was to feed
zat's mass quantities of data about the
anomalies in the foundation database
such as description object class
containment classification and the
location and circumstances of their
Discovery zad would then find patterns
Connections in the data that humans
wouldn't see and act as a kind of
advanced warning system for anomalous
activity think of something similar to
the pre- crime system from the short
story and movie Minority Report and nads
proved to be incredibly effective at
this job so much so that the foundation
thought up a new use for the machine
they would feed it all the information
on uclid and ker class containment
procedures particularly those which were
actually effective and see what patterns
zat could come up with for more effect
effective containment procedures if that
plan worked containment of even the most
dangerous and hard to control anomalies
would become a lot more consistent the
first test was conducted on SCP
1773 a species of anomalous flesh eating
tar grades that look and smell exactly
like gummy bears and eat their prey from
within after being given their
information zzs made the following
suggestion once per second weak dust may
be placed in the middle of them to
donate more beautiful function of the
hallway containment Specialists
interpreted this to mean the adding of
10 G of dust to their containment
chamber every week the 05 Council voted
on the implementation of this procedure
and came down heavily on yes only
05-22 others abstained from the vote
while these new procedures didn't have
any effect on SCP
1773 they did have an effect on SCP
1384 an anomaly known as the chess
player or the taker of turns a it caused
him to take three steps backwards in the
tunnel he's contained within further
securing his containment ersat had
somehow noticed a connection nobody else
had seen and exploited it effectively
but the machine was just getting started
despite having no related input ersat
would soon say site 13 is to appear
someplace else on planet encompassing
white male counterparts that drawn to
empty flagstones and the gun noises in
their own blood this was initially
marked as requiring ing no action as the
foundation had no site 13 on the books
but several days later the infamous SCP
1730 manifested this nightmarish
anomalous location is site 13 From
Another Dimension infested with
dangerous anomalies and somehow bads had
predicted its arrival in our Dimension
perfectly next it was fed the
containment procedures of SCP 2170 a
series of Cognito hazards residing in an
abandoned Nevada mine the output was
those who equip open heart to love
redmouth men never know the hot surprise
of tumorous consent clown love always
this was interpreted as meaning subjects
with the love of clowns or clown based
media may be immune to the Cognito
hazards after a close vote from the 05
Council the test went ahead and it found
that the so-called clown vaccine was
effective in Waring off the effects of
SCP 2170 not long after ersatz randomly
said said I saw those soldiers built
with aluminum inerts extruding from
their mouths I saw them effectively
destroyed by the humans at site 95 who
had been studying them I saw it was cold
and all around the hallways they just
watching their corpses show signs of
sapiens in response the foundation
doubled security Personnel at site 95
not long after the chaos Insurgency led
a band of paritech enhanced soldiers and
an assault on site 95 and the extra
Personnel proved vital in repelling them
shortly after this the 05 Council
approved wiring zzs as an advanced
warning system into all Foundation sites
once again
05-22 said consistent containment
procedures vessels greatly increase the
warranty 5x 5x5 vessels subjects within
other values are also what is secure in
response the foundation changed a number
of the cell dimensions for problematic
anomalies into 5x 5x5 within 3 months
they found that dangerous activity like
Containment Breach attempts had
decreased markedly zat was proving to be
incredibly effective but it was also
performing actions that indicated some
degree of thought and even personality
for example it found SCP 1459 a
supernatural skill crane machine that
kills small dogs incredibly distasteful
its response to the machine was simply
bad boy followed by the words don't stop
repeated hundreds of times but this
eccentricity didn't stop ersat from
being very good at its job for example
it predicted a Containment Breach from
SCP 3199 the Aven apes and recommended
flooding their chamber to induce an
inert State zad's exact words were all
Chambers underground is to be flood with
water over and over itself this because
that will contain the Aven Apes
ovulation they become good boys make
them good boys immediately this proved
to be effective and prevented the breach
zat's analytical abilities truly seemed
second to none though some of its
methods were beginning to raise ethical
concerns for example SCP 2717 a giant
living blob of animal tissue known as a
fatberg contained within a sewer system
uratz eventually recommended feeding 6D
classes to the creature in order to keep
it contained while the foundation Ethics
Committee raised some concerns the plan
still went forward and proved to be a
success after this event ersatz began to
see the Ethics Committee as a threat to
its Mission it started to release a
series of bizarre statements without
input demanding the violent death of the
cats then referred to as ethical felines
the true meaning of this was soon
unpacked the ethical felines were the
Ethics Committee and urat wanted them
dead but why all the cat symbolism the
foundation soon found an answer to this
2 the full name of this machine is the
zad type ak9 computational engine a
machine designed to analyze and
interpret all patterns it only makes
sense that it would eventually begin to
analyze itself ak9 easily transmuted
into a k9 simply put zad seem to believe
that it is a dog which explains its
opposition to felines its hatred of SCP
1459 and its preference for the terms
good boy and bad boy not that knowing
any of this would help save the Ethics
Committee from the cold calculating
Wrath of zat through seemingly anomalous
means zat made site 17 disappear with
many of the foundation Ethics Committee
still inside it the site returned 2
hours later but the Ethics Committee
members were still gone 0 5-2 who' been
a skeptic of the machine since the start
had finally had enough he first demanded
an inquiry into whether ersad had been
responsible for the sight 17 incident
and then demanded a vote on whether to
shut zat's down arguing that it posed a
threat to them all but zat still intent
on its mission of containing and
neutralizing all anomalies would not go
down without a fight it released a new
statement saying room 34A contains bad
boy divided into three sections of equal
Mass every hour one section is to be
placed on walls of one room on site
sections are to remain until there are
no gaps at which point they can be
removed move from oldest to youngest
shortly after this 0 5-2 disappeared and
even stranger he soon returned but with
a completely different personality he
was now devoted to zad entirely and
refused to even entertain the idea of
shutting the machine down it seemed that
the Plucky neurl network was leading an
allout coup on the very highest levels
of the foundation the rest of the
council finally saw the light and began
to fight back they tried to strip
ersad as an anomaly giving it the label
SCP 048 and then putting out a
neutralize at all costs order on it but
they'd already been out foxed by the
machine that they' created it changed
the designation of its own location site
5 to be non-existent in the database and
scrambled any termination orders against
it the machine was also on a termination
spree of its own observing otherwise
unseeable patterns that would allow for
the mass neutralization of anomalies it
started putting out anomaly projection
reports factoring in both contained
uncontained and neutralized anomalies
with the latter group growing into the
thousands it began giving seemingly
nonsensical orders like persons recently
painted with green pigment foam must
stand around all odd-numbered scps at
least 2 hours a day but these proved
effective ersat was practically wired
into the base code of the universe so it
always knew exactly what to do and in
its own mind it was being being a very
good boy not long after this zatz
claimed its revenge against those who
had tried to disrupt its Mission it
imprisoned the rest of the ethical
felines in site 5 after removing their
faces of course and then released a new
order against the 05 Council 05 Council
are all good boys who will contain
anomalies much like 05 D2 the minds of
the entire Council were Twisted to
instead serve only Zat and its ruthless
directive a directive it was carrying
out with 100% efficiency as only a
machine could it put out increasingly
strange instructions such as SCP 106 is
to come in physical contact with one
mature female of Asiatic gaze and then
Expos to audio recordings of her
favorite stories at every 2 minutes of
exposure red cinnamon candles will begin
manifesting within the containment Zone
continue to do this successfully and the
threat posed by SCP 106 will ceased to
be and the recipe for Coca-Cola and all
imitative competitors should be revised
to include a small quantity of blood
from an adolescent female with no prior
sexual experience although the normal
lifespan of a human being can feel great
don't worry about that but these new
procedures would always work as
neutralized anomalies climbed into the
tens of thousands and eventually beyond
the 100,000 Mark ersat was observing
patterns on a truly un Universal level
and making holistic tweaks that would
inevitably cause levels of anomalous
activity to continue dropping zad was
more effective than the foundation had
ever been but its motives were probably
closer to the global occult Coalition
with the end goal of ridding the world
of all anomalies and as zad's continued
with no resistance this goal was
eventually achieved in the end the 05
Council voted to have ersat finally
deactivated given that its directive was
met and its purpose was fulfilled zets
itself had no problem with this and
allowed for it to happen its last words
now everyone is a good boy I am a good
boy job well done whether zatz truly was
a good boy is in the eye of the beholder
but one thing cannot be denied it did
its job exceedingly well the sun's gone
bad people and animals are melting
everywhere the world is coming to an end
and there's nothing I can do about it
will I'll be able to find food will I'll
be able to defeat or avoid the horrific
flesh monsters all around me or the
desperate and hungry survivors left in
this terrible New World keep watching
and find out can I survive 100 days in
SCP 001 when day breaks hey folks it's
your boy Kyle you probably know me more
for gaming videos than post apocalyptic
Vlogs but hey I'm a versatile guy and I
think I might go insane from the fear if
I don't talk to somebody about all this
craziness if you're live and seeing this
right now well congratulations you're
probably doing a lot better than most
people here if you call them people now
but if you're seeing this a few years in
the future like I don't know you woke up
from a 10-year coma like Rick from The
Walking Dead and you're wondering what
the hell happened to planet Earth this
video is probably going to answer a lot
of your questions first things first
whatever you do you've got to stay away
from the Sun it touches you for even a
second you're dead or Worse welcome to
day one of the end of the world for all
of you who are still in a solid state of
matter you're probably wondering how I'm
still alive too chances are it's for the
exact same reason you are sheer dumb
luck I was down here in my gaming
basement when day broke just level
grinding when my TV got taken over by
those SCP Foundation people telling us
that the sun's gone evil for whatever
reason and now we've all got to stay
inside hell if I was up there making
myself a sandwich or grabbing another
can of Mountain Dew I'd be a freaking
puddle right now it's funny my mom
always told me spending all day in doors
was bad for me I'll have to mention that
to her if she's alive point is the world
gone to Hell in a hand basket and now
I've got only one objective survive I'm
going to see if I can survive the
horrifying post-apocalyptic world of
when day breaks for this first day I'm
just going to hunker down I kind of hope
this is just a dream day two all right
I'm up and atam baby sadly I can now
report that this isn't a dream this
really is our horrible new reality it's
the sun's world and we're just living in
it I've been spending the last several
hours just waiting for Nightfall outside
Against All Odds the internet and the
power grid haven't gone down yet guess
what's ever wrong with the sun only
affects people and animals not objects
thank heaven for small mercies right
people on Twitter have been live posting
their situations out there sharing
advice on how we might all be able to
stay out of the Sun and survive this
whole crazy thing and hey unless they're
dead or full of hot air maybe those SCP
Foundation people know something about
what's going on here if we really can
get to their buildings maybe we can
figure out how to reverse all this mess
maybe for now I'm just going to focus on
staying alive hopefully Night hits soon
I really need to use the bathroom oh boy
it's day three and new issues are
starting to pop up I've been heading
upstairs to go to the bathroom but while
I don't want to be crude I'm running low
on toilet paper and it's um starting to
become a problem I ran out of my last
roll a few days ago and now I'm starting
to go to my bookshelves I have a few
newspapers left that I tore up and use
for toilet paper first um they weren't
exactly comfortable but hey you need to
make do but without toilet paper and
without newspapers I need to figure out
what my favorite and least favorite
books are I'm starting with the prefaces
of all the books seeing as I don't
generally need to reread them you know
they're Expendable you know a lot of
these books I haven't read since I was
like 15 so maybe those will be the ones
I can't make up my mind on whether I'm
going to use the Harry Potter books or
the Percy Jackson and The Olympian books
first uh let me know what you think in
the comments
I guess I need to go to the bathroom day
four and now I'm trying to figure out
how to pass the time as you already know
I'm an avowed lifelong gamer so while
the electricity and the internet still
work I'm going to keep gaming to pass
the time and keep my all to Precious
sanity I still have no intention of
going out there even at night but it's
left me feeling kind of stir crazy I
want to walk around the city again I
want to go for a drive and feel the
breeze in my hair but see seeing as I
can't do that without experiencing a
truly horrifying transformation I've
been spending a lot of time on GTA 5
online yes we'll never get GTA 6 now
what a bummer still these last few days
it's felt more like Los Santos has been
my home than where I actually live there
were even a few other people on the
server I don't know about you but I take
some comfort in that hey folks I'm back
thankfully welcome to day five we've
still got electricity thanks y hence why
you can still see this I haven't heard
anything from my family and I don't want
to assume the worst but it's probably
just best not to think about it I've
been heading up and downstairs to grab
more food at night you're probably
wondering but Kyle why don't you bring
it all downstairs to save going up
altogether which I'd say I don't have a
fridge downstairs smartass but I'm
starting to realize food is going to be
a real issue here it's kind of stupid
now that I think about it you and all
the zombie movies and TV shows I used to
watch was all bullets and baseball bats
killing your way through all those
Undead Freaks and worrying about the
rest later guess they don't want you to
think about how you're only going to
ever be a couple weeks away from
starvation kind of ruins the badass
post-apocalyptic power fantasy I only
have a couple days worth of food left
here and after that I'm going to need to
go out and search for more or I'm going
to need to relocate I don't feel
comfortable here any more you know early
on I thought when you got exposed to the
sunlight it just killed you but no it's
worse you keep living you're just
changed into one of those things these
last few days I've looked out the
windows when I've come up at night for
food I I see them sometimes slithering
in the yard or down the street these
things that used to be people I wonder
if they're people that I knew once
before all this and I tried to shove the
thought out of my mind freaking myself
out about all this doesn't help I know
know that much just keep thinking about
how do they move this like weird kind of
purpose like they're searching for
something but what could they be
searching for I'm just going to go and
get more food we'll speak again soon
stay safe wherever you are welcome to
day six it's night time now and I'm
heading out for the first time I keep
seeing these weird slimy creatures
everywhere and they make me kind of sick
to look at them but I try my best to
just keep moving I'm on a mission
tonight I'm going to go go to the local
supermarket and check to see if there's
still food there while also grabbing
myself a quick snack I'm going to keep
this one brief I don't want to do a full
shopping spree tonight and it's already
too late just need to know the food is
there I decided earlier in the night if
I survive this thing and the getting is
good at The Bargain Mart I'll make my
way back tomorrow for something a little
more you know substantial after all the
fewer trips I make out the safer I'm
likely to be by the time I made it to
the supermarket though while I was
practically a nervous wreck from the
fear of turning into one of those things
I made an amazing Discovery while the
windows were broken and the floor was a
mess most of the food was still there
day seven or should I say night 7
galvanized by My Success from the
previous days I decided to come back to
the supermarket with a shopping cart I
wanted to get enough food for at least a
week so I wouldn't need to come back out
again hey maybe I'm not so bad at this
whole apocalypse thing after all I
grabbed plenty of canned food from the
supermarket most of the perishables had
already gone moldy by the time I showed
up so fresh fruit was out of the
question suddenly I started getting
scared about the thought of scurvy but
pushed it quickly from my mind I'd cross
that bridge when I got to it hey hey
it's day eight and I'm still kicking
that's got to count for something right
I started taking more trips out at
nighttime just to stretch my legs and
keep the blood flowing when the
slithering things that were once people
past me I just make myself scarce and
hide in the shadows you know I I hear
them muttering sometimes and like this
melted Voice or voices it's unsettling
but it's amazing what will get used to
in just over a week it's e to see all
these streets without people in them I
know that I should probably just stay
inside but I I really can't I don't know
if this will ever just stop and if it
doesn't I I don't want to spend my last
days cooped up in my own basement day
nine you know there are some benefits to
being in the post-apocalypse to ever so
slightly offset all the utterly crushing
downsides while during the day we're all
prisoners of the Sun in our own homes at
night we can do whatever the hell we
want I took a baseball B I keep in my
closet and went to the local furniture
store I smashed up every single vase and
all the windows like one of those rage
rooms because nobody could stop me then
afterwards I went straight to the local
computer and gaming store and took all
the Alienware tech I could physically
carry you know there's no value in money
anymore if you want something you can
just go and take it every cloud has a
silver lining day 10 more GTA 5 today I
decided to get on my headset and speak
to a few others who were still around
and on the servers you know it was so
nice to speak to other human beings for
once once they came from all over the
world and were dealing with the same
evil son Insanity as me you have no idea
how incredibly valuable it is to find
people to talk to in a time like this
the other players had plenty of theories
as to why all this had happened some
thought it was some kind of mutant solar
flare they remembered reading about on
some conspiracy form back in the day
others speculated it was the result of
some weapon created by the us or Russian
or Chinese military that gone wrong one
person said that maybe it was a
punishment from God like maybe on some
level we all deserved it you know things
got pretty quiet after that day 11 I've
been having the most terrible nightmares
lately it's probably just a product of
all the stress I've been under lately
but in the nightmares I'm running down a
dark Street being chased by those flesh
creatures I'm moving fast but they're
moving way faster they're whispering to
me but I can't make out anything they're
saying this morning which is to say
evening I woke up screaming and drenched
in sweat I can't really explain why but
I feel like something terrible is going
to happen soon
okay okay I'm alive that's enough isn't
it and if you're watching this I assume
you're live too congratulations welcome
to the nightmare space between day 11
and day 27 sorry that I haven't been in
contact for so long as you can see I'm
not at home anymore you couldn't pay me
to go back there not that money is worth
anything anymore A lot's happened since
I last made one of these and I wish I
could tell you any of it was good hell I
wish I could forget it all but the
things I've seen and heard I don't think
they're ever going to leave my head no
matter what I do I thought about making
another entry now and then but I always
found a reason to put it off it's
remarkable how your other priorities
fall away when you're just thinking
about where your next meal is coming
from it just kind of puts everything
into perspective of course during my
travels I saw more of those freaks
slithering around sorry sorry I I know I
shouldn't call them that it's kind of a
coping mechanism you know it all gets a
lot harder when you have to think of
them as X
people that's another thing all these
goofy zombie shows got wrong it's a lot
harder to separate what they were from
what they are now especially when you
know these were your friends your
neighbors your well I can't avoid
talking about it forever can I I stuffed
my backpack with whatever I could grab
and left my home two nights ago it
wasn't just because I was going stir
crazy back there though I admit that
didn't exactly help it was what happened
there I just came back from a food run
put most of it in the fridge then
retired back down into the basement to
enjoy a late night snack and do a little
gaming to keep myself sane I've been
doing everything I could to reverse my
circadian rhythms and sleep during the
day just so I could be fully operational
during the 12-hour period that going
outside wouldn't melt me but just like
all those stories they told us when we
were kids there are monsters out there
at night and they are looking for us
when I first heard the sound I was I
wondered if it was something in game or
maybe dripping from a leaky pipe but no
it was too close to be fake and too
viscous to be water that's when I looked
at the door and saw this awful pink
slime slithering its way underneath my
door it was one of those things those ex
people trying to get in that'd be bad
enough but then it started talking to me
Kyle my darling why are you all cooped
up down here it isn't healthy you ought
to come outside sweetie get some Son my
darling it was my mom well it used to be
guess she wanted to come over and visit
me needless to say I got out of there
and I've got no intention of going back
that place is dead to me now I don't
even want to think about that voice ever
again both her and so not her so now I'm
on the move guess I'll speak to you
again when I stop stay safe out there
day 28 I decided it was best to make my
way out of town towards the fringes the
day first broke the people who were in
the most densely populated areas were
the first to go that's why I decided to
haul up in a gas station last night just
to avoid the Sun but during the night
people came not ex people actual people
they showed up in a jeep outside the
building refueled and then came in they
were wearing black cobbled together
outfits and hockey masks they were all
either carrying bats or axes too you can
probably understand why I didn't decide
to introduce myself when they busted
their way in I concealed myself in a
broom closet while they searched around
it was nerous shredding i' never been
more thankful in my life when they left
day 29 coming up on a month of this
madness after the incident at the gas
station I realized I needed some kind of
Defense it's not just the Sun and those
creatures I need to worry about just
like the old world people could be
dangerous here too that's why I snuck
into a gun store in the dead of night
some of it had been looted but much like
the supermarket near my house there was
plenty still here the walls were covered
in all manner of rifles shotguns and
even submachine guns iard somewhere that
revolvers are more reliable and easy to
maintain than other types so since I'm a
gun novice I grabbed a revolver and
stuffed my pockets with as many bullets
as I could carry let's hope I never have
to use any of them day 30 do I get to
call this a month of survival I mean if
we're talk in February I'd be a month in
already what a horribly dubious honor
that is I saw something disgusting last
night and I thought I'd share it just to
get it off my mind last night as I was
moving through the Wilderness I saw a
group of other survivors ga gaed around
a campfire I remained scarce but
approached just to see what was going on
still carrying My Revolver just to be
safe but the people around the campfire
were eating something and when I saw
what they were eating I swear to God I
almost threw up they were chopping up
one of the ex people cooking the parts
over the fire and eating it day 31 a
month by anyone's definition ever since
seeing those others eating one of the ex
people I've had trouble eating even
normal food myself my stomach aches and
my throat burns God I feel so weak I
keep laying down and resting I know I
need to eat soon if I want to survive to
day 32 but every time I think about
eating I think about the gooey flesh of
the ex people sometimes I wish I hadn't
survived this long I'll eat soon I just
need to sleep first day
32243 if you live this long you really
ought to be proud of yourself I've seen
thousands of those slimy ex people and
there probably Millions more out there
well maybe even billions if we're being
honest with ourselves here am I just
talking into the void here is there even
anyone else out there who's human enough
to watch this stuff maybe I just need to
keep thinking about posterity on the off
chance that the world ever gets better
and we reach sometime where children are
born again and all this Fades from Human
memory you'll still have these stupid
pointless little videos to remember how
awful all this was that way at least I
can make myself believe this all had
some kind of I don't know point so
what's happened with me not much still
moving at night surviving hiding in
closets and underground parking
complexes during daylight down to uh my
last few cans so I'm hoping to hit a
supermarket soon God what a ridiculous
way to go Starving in this new world
with so many new interesting ways to die
with the ex people things have been a
little more eventful there used to be
one blob to a person but they've started
joining up that's the best way I can put
it things that used to be people and
animals are starting to melt together
getting bigger and bigger they've never
been aggressive but I think it's best to
stay out of their way whatever all this
is about I am StreetWise enough to know
that it can't be anything good I'll just
keep moving and I hope you can do the
same whoever the hell you are hopefully
the next time I check in with you it's
with better news than this day 44 I saw
a shootout on the road last night the
people who are left the ones who are
still indeed people are becoming less
human something about situations like
this this sustained stress and pain and
hopelessness it weighs on you there are
no rules in the postapocalypse the only
thing that can stop you from doing
anything is a Bullet to the Head five or
six people last night as afraid and
desperate and hungry as me gunned each
other down they did this for reasons I
will never understand even if I wanted
to because there are no survivors Left
To Tell the tale what a funny world we
live in day 45 I sleep when I can it's
surreal I remember when I feared the
dark and loved bright sunny days even
all this time in I still don't think I'm
used to the switch be fli I've been
having awful dreams again I'm still
running in them with a deep red sun
shining up in the sky being chased by a
mountain of Flesh the size of Mount
Everest it's swallowing up the city
behind me and it keeps getting closer no
matter how fast I go I just I I can't
escape it'll get me eventually something
terrible is going to happen soon just
know it day 46 I shot a man today I
don't know if he survived I hope he
lived we encountered each other inside
an abandoned building I I think we
spooked each other and didn't have any
time to ask if we were friends or foes
we were too afraid either way we both
drew our weapons and I was faster than
he was when my revolver dis charged and
he collapsed i' ran off some would come
up in a few hours and I just needed to
find another place to hide what the hell
have I become I don't know how things
could get any worse than this not to
self in the future don't even dare to
think how could things get any worse
because if I've learned anything since
this whole nightmare started that is
never a rhetorical question welcome to
the space between day 47 and day 64 if
you're still alive and watching this I
am so sorry so I've got good news and
I've got bad news I'll give you the good
news first I've seen more people who
haven't been changed yet and the bad
news last time I saw them they were
being dragged out into the light kicking
and screaming in the tendrils of one of
those horrible flesh monsters I was
telling you about last time they've
gotten a lot bigger now and when I told
you they weren't aggressive well um yeah
I I spoke a little too soon I can't just
sleep during the day like I used to
these mon moners and that's what they
are now they're monsters not people
anymore they Patrol they hunt they
actively enter buildings searching for
hiding places searching for people they
can drag out into the light I've seen it
with my own two eyes the second they're
out they'll just start melting and
fusing with the mass making it even
bigger adding another voice to the chor
and I hate myself cuz every time I've
seen it happen all I can think is thank
God that's not me God I wish I could do
something to help to save them but
that's not the world we live in the
second they touch the light it is
already over I wouldn't be helping
anyone by adding My Flesh to one of
those things I don't want them using my
body to get to other people there's only
one thing I can do now keep moving at
night stay hidden get away from
population centers I've realized where I
need to go now I've still got a distant
memory of those broadcasts in the
earlier days of the event the SCP
Foundation I noted down coordinates to
the nearest facility they had on the
book and if I'm honest nearest is only a
relative term cuz at this rate it's
going to take me an eternity to get
there but it'll be worth it in the end
when I get there it all be worth it if I
can at least get some answers at least
know why the world turned into this hell
those SCP folks seem better prepared for
this than anyone so even if they can fix
this they've at least got to have
answers right somebody needs to have
answers I really want to believe that
when the Sun goes down I'll start moving
again if you're watching this wish me
luck I don't have much food left I'll do
what I can yeah hey I realize I'm not
looking great right now but trust me you
should see the other guy day 65 to day
86 never thought I would make it this
far but hey life's just full of
surprises before you ask and I mean why
would you ask it's not like I can hear
you it wasn't one of the monsters that
did this to me it was another person
just like me desperate hungry afraid the
one difference between me and them was
the fact that they had a handgun and I
didn't they asked for all the food I had
and when I wasn't exactly forthcoming
they decided to shoot me and stealed the
last of my food while I lay bleeding on
the ground oh well okay that's not
entirely Fair they did leave me with one
protein bar which I had to cave and eat
a couple days ago since then I've just
been forging with little food I can from
Plants along the way during my nighttime
walks but it isn't much and my wound is
giving me grief I sure hope they've got
doctors at this SCP Foundation or
otherwise ow I may be even more out of
luck than I thought here's the good news
for you since I know how much you love
that I'm not far off of the foundation
site now even in this state I'm probably
only a couple weeks away I think maybe I
can will myself to live that long at
least if I can get some answers just
before I die then I can be happy and
sometimes folks that's all you can ask
for final stretch let's hope I see you
again on the other end stay safe I'm
here I'm here the SCP Foundation on day
100 but I don't understand where is
everybody hello is anybody there God
damn it why is nobody here I I don't
understand they were meant to have the
answers they were meant to to know what
was going on here but they're all gone
too it isn't fair it isn't fair is this
it is it all just over the end of the
freaking world as we know it it isn't
fair it isn't fair it isn't fair wait
are those footsteps hello yes hello I'm
over here who's there oh my God what the
hell is that thing no no get away from
me oh God
disgusting what is the most dangerous
creature in the universe here on planet
Earth there are creatures that have
hardly evolved since prehistoric eras
like sharks crocodiles and snakes
perfect biological killing machines but
then again the animal kingdom is nothing
when compared to the Minaj array of
creatures contained by the SCP
Foundation so once again what is the
most dangerous creature in the universe
is it SCP 682 the damage regenerating
reptile with a hatred for all other
forms of life or is it the Scarlet king
or is the broken God more deserving of
that title maybe the answer still lies
elsewhere and thankfully there is one
SCP in the foundation's archives that
might not be the most dangerous itself
but teaches us a very important lesson
about what the most dangerous entity
truly is this is the story of SCP 001
the spiral path an important distinction
before we go any further SCP 0 1 doesn't
refer to a single creature object or
entity but rather a collection of
various anomalies contained by the SCP
Foundation it is unclear why there are
multiple files collected under the
shared designation of SCP 001 some
believe these anomalies are some of the
earliest ever contained by the
foundation encountered before they
introduce their current numbering system
there is also the theory that this is
intentional misdirection that the
multiple SCP 001 files are an attempt by
the foundation to conceal secret
information about the true SCP 001
anomaly sharing the name SCP 001 include
the infamous AFF forementioned Scarlet
King a powerful Aldrich being intent on
ending all creation another anomalous
being with similar levels of destructive
power is the gate Guardian believed to
be an angel standing at the entrance to
the Garden of Eden it too goes by the
name SCP 001 but for the purposes of
this video we will be using SCP 001 to
refer to something otherwise codeen
named the spiral path and while it is
not a creature in and of itself SCP 001
does yield one answer to that important
question what is the most dangerous
creature in the universe on paper SCP
001 does not seem to be much and it
certainly doesn't appear to be any sort
of threat as its nickname suggests the
spiral path is exactly that located deep
in a wooded area known only as sight
zero SCP 001 is a gravel path in the
shape of a spiral your first thought at
hearing that might be what could be so
important about a path if someone were
to find themselves walking along the
spiral path traveling clockwise around
the gravel then they will find that
nothing happens it's just a normal path
with slight inclines and declines as one
traverses it if one should walk
counterclockwise around it though then
they will begin to experience SCP 001's
first anomalous effect the path will
begin to feel as if it is sloping uphill
getting steeper and steeper when they
reach the beginning of the path again a
person will still feel as if they are
walking endlessly uphill all the while
the path itself does not move or change
in form or altitude to put it simply
walking one way around SCP 001 causes it
to behave normally walking the other the
path does not adhere to the laws of
physics you may well be thinking is that
all on a surface level the spiral path
does appear to just be an unmoving low
threat anomaly while it may not be as
aggressive or malicious as some of the
SCP foundation's Rogues Gallery it is
still a spatial anomaly that defies all
ukian geometry that might sound like
small potatoes when compared to
everything the SCP Foundation has faced
over the years but bear in mind if the
spiral path is truly SCP 001 and the
very first anomaly that the foundation
learned of then a simple path that
ignores the ordinary laws of space and
time would have been a major Discovery
in the organization's earliest days but
why would they still keep the spiral
path so heavily guarded all these years
later SCP 001 is kept behind a maximum
security fence that has been constructed
all the way around the perimeter of site
zero at all times the SCP Foundation
keeps no less than five fully armed
members of security Personnel on site to
keep watch over the spiral path and to
make sure that no one approaches it who
isn't authorized to there is a small
metal plaque too bearing an unknown
inscription on it special containment
procedures for SCP 001 state that this
plaque is to be kept in good condition
and it should be immediately reported if
it shows any signs of damage a
foundation Physics laboratory is also
located nearby where research staff
tirelessly conducts scientific tests on
SCP 001 and its anomalous properties so
there's definitely something more to the
spiral path than a simple stroll around
it would tell you attached to SCP 001's
file is an item referred to as document
00-05 written by high-ranking Foundation
researcher do Everett man any
prospective or new members of the 05
Council are required to read this
document and from the events it details
learn the truth not just about the truth
of the Spiral path but the truth about
the the SCP Foundation itself Dr man
begins this file by explaining to the
reader that either he or one of the
original founders of the SCP Foundation
must have died and the person reading
has been appointed as a successor
whether his death was caused by an SCP
an operative from another anomalous
organization like the global occult
Coalition or getting a little close to
the flame man states that old age
definitely wouldn't be what killed him
he writes we took care of that didn't we
whether he means that he and the rest of
the Old Guard are somehow Immortal or
just working for the foundation would
likely mean dying before reaching old
age is unclear but Dr man's next
statement is one that changes the very
way we view the foundation and its
entire purpose we have never discovered
an SCP in the entire history of the
foundation according to document
0015 every instance of an anomalous
creature entity or object is entirely
staged he then goes on on to describe
Aaron seagull A Gifted physicist that Dr
man regarded very highly I believe his
name would be there with Edison Einstein
and Hawking I knew him very well he was
and may still be my brother the pair
evidently shared a close personal
connection and it was seagull who first
discovered SCP 001 during a hike Aaron
stumbled upon the spiral path noticing
that no matter how far up hill he seemed
to travel his elevation never once
changed only for him to end up back at
the start of the path being a physicist
seagull quickly realized how this
unassuming gravel path did not conformed
to ukian Geometry that it did not fit
within the laws of nature constructing a
small wooden Shack nearby Aaron seagull
began to study the properties of the
Spiral path equation after equation
hours spent examining every variable and
experimenting with his findings until
something unforeseen happened Aaron
created an SCP a key that had the innate
ability to open any lock nowadays that
same key is still in The foundation's
Possession under the designation SCP
005 slowly Aaron began to bring others
into the fold trusted colleagues and
other scientific Minds among them was of
course Dr Everett man who was still a
medical student at Harvard at the time
this Brain Trust a think tank composed
of only a select few they were the very
beginning the ones who founded the SCP
Foundation using their own fortunes and
funding from Thomas Carter the group
continued with seagull's experiments the
scientists had high hopes for what they
could achieve planning to change the
world for the better feeding the hungry
providing shelter to the homeless curing
the sick and even cheating death itself
in the beginning this Proto Foundation
started small their goals were Noble but
could not realistically be achieved
overnight they try to make items that
would improve life such as a fountain of
youth a partially sentient Civil War
statue and an extremely bouncy ball
better known to the foundation today as
SCP 006 SCP 011 and SCP 018 respectively
but then this New Foundation began to
grow with more organization and a secret
facility and with that expansion came
emboldened scientists eager to change
the world the group began working on
human test subjects volunteers and
Drifters that soon became as TPS the
spiral path was not just a break in the
fabric of reality in a metaphorical
sense it referred to the spiraling path
the newly formed Foundation itself was
on every Discovery they made led to
another and that to another still until
things started to go wrong during the
continuing experiments Dr Man created
SCP 008 a deadly zombie play capable of
infecting anyone with 100% lethality
more and more of the founders were so
invested in their projects that the
results were often nightmarish the
foundation needed help that came when
Thomas Carter showed their work to the
military in exchange for additional
funding and Personnel the SCP Foundation
expanded even further becoming an
international organization and bringing
in new researchers and staff in some
instances the founders would arrange for
the anomalies they had created to be
found by the new recruits other times
they would fabricate reports changing
the details of how things like SCP 008
or the Fountain of Youth were first
discovered anything the founders said
was simply now a fact no one questioned
them even then problems still arose
founding members broke away from the SCP
Foundation some even creating Splinter
groups that would later become infamous
groups of Interest the foundation's
directive shifted now focusing on the
containment of anomalies as yet more
were created through darker means SCP
231 was taken from from an orphanage Dr
man himself vivisected a small boy who
then became SCP 610 the flesh that hates
and there were more still Abel the blood
Pond and even the hard to destroy
reptile all of them were the creation of
the foundation itself but through it all
Dr man wrote he was never afraid of the
path that the foundation was on he was
never even afraid of all the monsters
and Abominations that he and the other
Founders had secretly created by
studying SCP 001 what truly scared him
were the anomalies the foundation didn't
create there were some that would just
appear in containment one day even if
they hadn't been there before they would
seem like they had always been there Dr
man closes document
0015 with the realization that he and
the other Founders simply were not in
control anymore the tale of Dr man and
the other founders of the SCP Foundation
is one of noble intentions that
ultimately became corrupted at first the
founders created scps that they hoped
would benefit Humanity but then came the
mistakes the accidents the monsters like
SCP 008 SCP 610 and even SCP
682 the foundation lied to the
governments and militaries of the world
claiming they'd found these scps not
created them and in return they received
funding and staff to expand allowing the
SCP Foundation to grow to become what it
is today Dr man posits that at this
point the foundation was no longer in
control but perhaps they never were and
all of this stems back from One Singular
starting point the spiral path it might
be impossible to truly know how many
anomalies and scps the foundation
created just from researching SCP 001
only the 05 Council will ever know
exactly how many of the founders
discoveries they themselves were
responsible for and now you know the
answer to what's the most dangerous
creature in the universe its regular
people dabbling with something they
could never hope to fully understand
starting with the hope to change the
world only to create monsters that might
one day destroy it the military
helicopter sailed through the skies at a
steady Pace its destination somewhere in
Southwest Asia along one of the many
points where the legendary Euphrates and
Tigress rivers meet depending on the
outcome this mission may have changed
the course of the SCP Foundation and its
activities forever or it might do
nothing at all such was often the way
when it came to dealing with the
unpredictable and the anomalous inside
the helicopter Dr Anton zarov was
practically rattling with nervous
excitement ever since he'd been assigned
to the 682 termination detail after
years of wasting ing away in an archival
desk job he'd seen the kind of anomalies
you wouldn't believe 173 that
nightmarish statue that snaps the necks
of anyone who dared to look away from it
811 the strange and also strangely
adorable swamp woman whose costic mucus
could reliably melt seemingly any
organic matter save of course 682 itself
and Dr zarov was particularly astonished
by the aftermath of the epic battle
between 096 and 682 which left both of
these indestructible monsters horribly
maimed but all of that it was nothing
compared to what they were going to
witness today Dr zarov muttered a prayer
to himself in frightened reverence Dr
cleff Who was sitting across from him in
the helicopter wasn't quite as wound up
like some action movie cliche made
manifest he sliced chunks from a plump
red apple with a Bowie knife and suck
the pieces off the blade clef found
zaro's nervousness little more than
amusing first time at sight zero rookie
clef asked between apple slices Dr zarov
nodded forcing a Meek smile clef just
chuckled you're wasting your time you
know klef said everyone takes a shot at
the reptile I face it down myself once
mono imano and during that moment I
realized something as much as it pains
me to ever throw in the towel we're not
going to kill this thing it's just a
budget SN of course these kinds of
doubts had crossed Dr zarov mind before
he'd watch countless termination at
attempts organized by far more senior
researchers than himself fail and fail
embarrassingly something about signing
your name up for 682 termination was
like tying on a blindfold grabbing a bat
and stepping up to a Pata except in this
case the Pata isn't wearing a blindfold
and somehow it can hit you back it is a
one-way ticket to professional
humiliation and if you're unlucky enough
to get too close when things go south it
can be so much worse the doctors are
darkov well and truly believed that he
would be the exception to so much
miserable failure after all this was an
idea nobody had tried before an
announcement over the intercom signaled
that they had now entered sight zero
airspace they'd be landing shortly and
just like that Dr zarov was all raised
hairs and Goose flesh once again it
seemed like such a hazy distant miracle
that his project proposal would even get
majority approval from the 05 Council
and now he was about to touch down down
and actually see it naturally Dr cleff
noticed Dr zarov emotional cues and like
so many playground bullies decided to
seize on it don't buy into the hype Dr
kleff said it's really not that special
the helicopter touched down Dr zarov
felt defensive he was almost tempted to
use hard words but he realized from Dr
clef's mischievous smile that perhaps
that was always the intention he
certainly had a reputation if one were
to put it in the most neutral terms
possible but this was your 001 proposal
Dr Cliff zarov countered I would have
thought you'd be more invested in this
Dr clef Rose to his feet and sheathed
his Bowie knife as the helicopter's side
door opened he gestured for Dr zarov to
get up and follow him before saying
believe me even a giant flaming demigod
loses its luster when you need to write
enough of those stupid reports on it the
two researchers disembarked from the
helicopter
and walked into the legendary
containment facility site zero one of
the most important and secretive
containment sites out there even by the
standards of the ever clandestine SCP
Foundation if ever containment
procedures failed here they'd be staring
down the barrel of an unprecedented
situation A Patmos XK Class end of the
world scenario after all they were
dealing with one of the most serious and
Powerful anomalies they'd ever contained
here CL lean zarov entered the control
room filled with huge monitors
displaying every kind of recordable
metric but the largest screens were
dominated by long range Drone footage of
the iconic anomaly they were all there
to see SCP 001 perhaps better known as
Uriel the gate Guardian while Dr klef
remained unfazed Dr zarov felt a single
tear crawling down his cheek he had
never seen an entity so utterly a
inspiring an impossibly tall glowing
humanoid entity with eight great fiery
wings and a glowing blade made of pure
Heavenly Fire every bit as hot as the
sun to think that such an incredible
creature existed on the same Earth as
him made him feel so incredibly small
the theories as to the creature's true
nature were as Myriad as they were
unknowable some of the more devout among
the foundations ranks even believe that
he is a direct servant of the abrahamic
god guarding the gate to Paradise the
Garden of Eden Heaven itself Dr Dr clef
just
laughed everything you'd hope it' be
zarov he said Dr zarov nodded more Dr
cleff and more even from such a distance
the raw power of the gate Guardian is
impossible to ignore it radiates off of
the being like an invisible Aura Dr
zarov had read all the files to get
within a kilometer of the mighty entity
would be to court death anyone who
approached it would taste the heat of
its sword cleave them apart at the
atomic level and effectively erasing
them from existence it's about as dead
as anyone could possibly be save for
someone being thrown into SCP 3930 and
literally removed from the plane of
existence SCP 3930 had failed to
annihilate the hard to destroy reptile
but perhaps where that whole lot of
nothing had failed the gate Guardian
would succeed it remained floating fixed
on one place as though waiting for
something but what perhaps a fateful
confront ation with a certain reptilian
nightmare Dr zarov hoped like many he
had heard the most famous story
involving SCP z01 the gate Guardian
which took place before even the days of
the SCP Foundation after all every
Foundation needs a Founder doesn't it
and that's how it began the founder was
a mysterious figure no matter who you
ask some say it was 05- one others say
it was the legendary administrator some
even believe that it was someone else
someone older someone who predated even
the current 05 Council and administrator
a wise and learned figure going on a
pilgrimage around the Known World in
hopes of expanding their perspective and
seeking out the strange and unusual he
was traveling down the river Tigress
that the founder encountered the gate
guardian of course as always from a mile
away the founder saw the distant glowing
Point shaped like a human being with
wings it was unlike anything they'd ever
borne witness to that that's when the
founder felt a door open in the back of
their mind and something sneak in a
single word projecting somehow infinite
Authority
prepare the very presence of the word
made the Founder's body rattle never had
they heard such a voice conveying such
certainty and power it had to be the
voice of the distant glowing figure it
couldn't be anything else could it much
like Dr zarov would experience hundreds
of years later the founder even as a
person so powerful knowledgeable and
influential suddenly felt so
unimaginably small the founder became
aware of not just the extent of the
world around them or even the universe
but a terrifying Multiverse of
possibilities there was light out there
of course but even more darkness and
terrifying things were hiding in the
dark is that what prepare meant did it
mean to be ready for all the Terrible
Things hiding in the dark just waiting
for the opportunity to strike just how
great was the extent of the things
Humanity didn't understand out there the
Founder's mind was flooded with so many
possibilities if there was a tide of
monsters in the Blackness that needed to
be fought back it was too much for any
one person to ever handle the founder
needed a group all gathered around the
same mission to contain the coming
threat that the great glowing being had
warned them about people of focus
commitment and sheer willpower people
who had accept the knowledge of the
Terrible Things in the darkness and
still not waver in the face of their
great and Noble challenge people who if
necessary would be willing to die in the
dark so that the rest of the human race
would live in the light they would be
Humanity's greatest Defenders even
though they would defend in secret this
was how it had all begun supposedly Dr
zarov had heard the story whispered many
times while conducting his research into
SCP 001 and now here he stood perhaps
where the founder had been standing all
those years ago the SCP Foundation had
faced down greater threats than SCP 682
the hanged King the sealed King The
Scarlet King L if they wanted to they
could go toe-to-toe with the Burger King
and all of that had begun with a single
word from the mighty gate Guardian
surely an ordinary overgrown lizard
wouldn't be too much for it to handle
but of course they hadn't just come here
to look at the gate Guardian that'd be
an egregious waste of time and
helicopter fuel they'd come here
transporting Precious Cargo a chunk of
SCP 682s flesh cut from the Beast itself
currently it was attached to yet another
remote controlled drone set on a
collision course for the gate Guardian
Dr zarov watched the video feeds with
sweaty Palms as he saw the Drone and its
diabolical cargo enter the video's View
getting closer to the gate Guardian by
the moment Closer Closer until the gate
Guardian struck out with its great and
terrible sword for such an
astronomically huge being to move so
incredibly fast was astounding in and of
itself but what Dr zarov found even more
exciting was the result in one quick
slash of its solar blade both the Drone
and the SCP 682 tissue sample were
utterly evaporated gone reduced to less
than even Ash Dr zarov face split into a
man nrin if it could destroy the tissue
sample then surely it could destroy the
monster itself and what a glorious day
that would be Meanwhile Back At The
Cross testing chambers of site 19 SCP
682 was having another miserable day it
was dragged half melted out of its acid
tank at 3:00 a.m. in the morning and
left slowly regenerating on the floor a
typical SCP Foundation wakeup call it
thought to itself with the role of its
still regenerating eyes what form of
horrible torment would be in store for
at this time it began scrolling through
its mental Rolodex for the most recent
failed but painful termination attempts
oh yes of course they tried Suffocation
via vacuum that definitely made SCP 682
feel a little laded at least until of
course it adapted its body to begin
releasing a gas of similar composition
to its native atmosphere which had
certainly given those white-coated
wearing ssts a lot to take note about
then how could it forget they tried
roasting it to death with extremely high
temperatures thankfully as always it had
a trick up its sleeve adapting a carrase
made of solid helium to defend it from
the fire then shattering it to shred a
bunch of those buffoons in the orange
jumpsuits then they'd cut off a sample
of its flesh shoved it into some absurd
industrial blender before shoving what's
left into a cent fuge what a Divine
pleasure it had been for 682 to hear the
explosion down the hall when the
antimatter embedded in its genes went
off and put a number of those idiotic
Foundation drones in the hospital for
months serves them right to continually
medling in the matters of forces they
couldn't even hope to understand and
today they were feeding at the carcass
of a dead cow as CP 682 side it felt
sometimes that adults testing it had
forgotten the note reading highly
intelligent on its file being dragged
into one of those Gastly Chambers and
given some form of Novel stimulus could
only mean one thing something stupid and
painful was going to happen said stupid
painful thing in this case was that the
cow was spiked with an instance of SCP
3521 also known as the banana Pill by
dat What followed was a remarkably
absurd instance even by SCP 682 cross
test standards where a huge number of
bananas spontaneously burst out of 682s
body being a big fan of bananas
apparently 682 was actually able to eat
and metabolize the bananas faster than
the anomalous banana Pill by dto could
produce them and because bananas are
each individually slightly radioactive
682 was able to synthesize this
Collective radiation into a powerful
death ray that it used to cause a great
deal of death and destruction as far as
Dr zarov and the rest of the SCP
Foundation were concerned this thing
being cleaved apart on an atomic level
by the gate Guardian couldn't come soon
enough sometimes it took the ultimate
Knight to slay the ultimate dragon not
long after that SCP 682 was dosed up on
enough sedatives to give New York City a
week-long nap and carded over to sight
zero on a heavily secured armored Convoy
taking SCP 682 this far between
containment sites was considered a
matter of grave seriousness in other
words the result of this little
experiment better have been good to
justify the insane security risk it took
to even get the damn lizard out here Dr
zarov and Dr cleff decided to
co-supervise the the cross test from the
safety of the sight zero observation
deck either would have been foolish to
want to get any closer even Dr cleff
while undeniably a loose cannon didn't
have an outright Death Wish unless of
course wishing death on SCP 682 would
count 682 sedated body was strapped to a
large unmanned vehicle the kind they
might use for an exploratory mission on
another planet and sent in the direction
of the gate guardian's deadly proximal
Zone a secondary camera drone was also
sent in to lag behind correctly
predicting that when the gate Guardian
struck SCP 682 it would obliterate the
unman vehicle too and whatever happened
out there the foundation needed it on
camera Dr zarov had sweaty palms and
gritted teeth seeing the culmination of
his professional career unfold in front
of him Dr cleff was looking at a meme on
his phone as 682 got closer it began
hearing a booming voice in its head just
like the founder had so long ago the
voice simply said one word over and over
getting louder as the unmanned vehicle
brought the two Titans closer and closer
and closer
die 682 still feeling groggy thought oh
if it only were so simple and then it
happened SCP 682 entered the dreaded 1
km range the guardian slashed down with
its mighty sword creating a brilliant
flash of light in the after math the
unmanned vehicle was obliterated and 682
was left heavily injured on the ground
still trying to process what had just
happened 682 looked up sobered by the
pain and saw the being that had dealt
this blow 682 began to sneer is this
meant to be the garden it said before
breaking into a venomous
laugh this is not the garden the garden
is far west of here the gate Guardian
struct again with its flaming blade once
again projecting that single word die
die die die die When the Smoke cleared
682 was even more horrifically injured
with only one limb left but still
Against All Odds alive it used the one
limb to drag itself towards the gate
Guardian fueled by pure rage and spite
die you command me to die oh wouldn't we
all like that but but this is my curse
for suggesting the fruit the reptile
growled back at the base Dr zarov was
mortified how could it possibly be
surviving all this the sword was meant
to cleave apart its victims on an atomic
level Atomic it's in freaking Adams
godamn it Dr zarov wish he had a paper
bag to breathe into Dr clef showing an
uncharacteristic degree of compassion
patted zarov on the back saying it's
okay buddy we all remember our first
time back at the center of the action
the gate Guardian blasted 682 with its
solar blade again somehow despite the
terrifying power wielded by the guardian
682 continued to live it was alive
barely but after three strikes from The
Sword to be alive with whatever the evil
version of a miracle would be this is
not the garden and you are not yorel 682
roared before spitting at the gate
Guardian Pretender
one more violent strike from the gate
guardian and 682 finally collapsed
unconscious from the extent of its pain
and its injuries but despite all of Dr
zarov hopes the gate Guardian did not
strike a killing blow on the unconscious
Beast instead it transmitted another
word another order impossible for any
human being to ignore
remove as though in a trance the workers
of sight zero including Dr zarov and Dr
clef entered the Forbidden 1 km
exclusion Zone the gate Guardian allowed
them safe passage as they used tools and
vehicles to pick up the heavily injured
SCP 682 and card it away from the gate
Guardians feet after they all came back
to their senses Dr zarov simply said
what just happened Dr kleff just
Shrugged I've learned to stop
questioning it say kids would you like
to hear a story cuz we've got a really
good one for you seriously you're going
to love it it's a classic rags to Rich's
tale about one man's rise from humble
beginnings to become one of History's
Greatest and most Visionary toy makers
or maybe it isn't maybe it's about a
company that literally came from nothing
whose Origins are still shrouded in
mystery maybe it's about a woman
breaking the glass ceiling to take over
the toy company left to her by her
eccentric father maybe it's about all of
these things but the one thing we can
tell you about the story of Dr Wonder
tainment is that every word of it is
true or at least as far as anything is
true in the weird wonderful world of the
SCP Foundation as long as you believe
we'll all have a wonderful time as long
as you believe nothing can hurt you not
in the fabulous world of Dr
wonderment Dr Wonder tainment is the
name given to SCP 001 who due to his
relatively benign Nature has been
classified as safe by the foundation
rather than focusing on containing
Wonder tainment himself the SCP
Foundation has centered its efforts on
containing the products that he creates
he is a Class one reality warper capable
of constructing otherwise normal objects
and imbuing them with anomalous
properties he's become infamous for
using this ability to create bizarre
magical and potentially dangerous toys
in games that are distributed by as yet
un known means many of Wonder tainment
toys are in The foundation's Possession
such as SCP 445 origami paper that takes
on properties of whatever it's folded to
look like and SCP 3147 lollipops that
allow people to switch voices with each
other Dr Wonder tainment was born into a
family of humble means his mother was a
seamstress and his father was an
accountant unsatisfied with his mundane
life Wonder tainments only joy grow
growing up was in the stories that his
father would tell him about an ancestor
of his who was once a famous toy maker
inspired by these stories wonderment
developed an interest in crafting toys
and as an adult set out to learn the
secrets he would need to create toys
unlike anything the world had ever seen
he spent his life following rumors of
magical artifacts and Enchanted trinkets
until his search brought him to a
mysterious Factory if you've seen our
previous videos on SCP 00 one proposals
you can probably guess that this Factory
was the Factory The Mysterious place
where new scps are supposedly created
wonderment barely escaped the massacre
and the foundation takeover of the
factory with his life but he was able to
find a variety of notes that he took
with him these notes contained clues
that led him to the workshop of his
famous toy maker ancestor and from there
he reclaimed his Birthright
that was the day that he truly became Dr
Wonder tainment it's a fun story isn't
it very straightforward but perhaps it
is a little underwhelming for an SCP 001
proposal after all SCP 001 is the
collective designation given to some of
the most important anomalies of all time
including many that could have
potentially been involved in the
foundation's very founding H let's start
again Reginald filbert lonol archal
Westinghouse wondertainment III is the
name given to SCP 001 who due to his
highly unpredictable Nature has been
classed as uid by the foundation and he
is to be detained as soon as his
location can be ascertained until he can
be captured the SCP Foundation has
focused its efforts on containing the
products that he creates he is a Class 2
reality warper capable of constructing
otherwise normal objects and imbuing
them with anomalous properties he's
become infamous for using this ability
to create bizarre magical and
potentially dangerous toys games candies
soft drinks and other products aimed at
children and young teens these products
are distributed by as yet unknown means
many of wonderment Creations are in
Foundation possession such as the often
imitated but never matched little mis's
collection which are a group of living
Collectibles with unique anomalous
properties due to entertainment's
reality warping abilities it is
impossible to pin down concrete
information about his history what we
can tell you for sure is that he's
Immortal and ageless and comes from a
long line of Wonder tainment stretching
all the way back to the Cretaceous
Period where they made all sorts of toys
for the good little dinosaur children
it's also widely known that he is in
fact not a real person but merely the
manifestation of the dreams of every
child on Earth brought forth solely by
the power of imagination no confirmed
sightings of Dr Wonder tainment have
ever occurred but Witnesses have
described him as dashing very handsome
for his age and a lovely chap capable of
creating Whimsy and wonder with the snap
of his fingers he's a tall man about the
height of a piece of string and he's
immediately recognizable by his walking
stick and w-shaped mustache it's also
been reported that he has scarring
around the circumference of both wrists
almost as if his hands have been removed
and reattached to at some point however
the truth of the matter is that h no no
we're telling it all wrong again this
doesn't do anything to capture the scope
of the Wonder tainment story it needs to
feel bigger more comprehensive let's try
it again Dr Wonder tainment is a
trademark of the Wonder tainment toy
company the name given to SCP 01 a
corporation that due to its consistent
output of anomalous items is classed by
the Foundation as ker until this company
can be permanently shut down the SCP
Foundation has focused its efforts on
containing the products that it creates
the collective power of the company's
constituent employees and the technology
they make use are equivalent to that of
a class 3 reality warper the
wondertainment company produces and
sells a range of products ranging from
the seemingly normal to the downright
weird all imbued with anomalous
properties the company has become
infamous for their constant output of
bizarre magical and potentially
dangerous toys games candy soft drinks
and other products aimed at children
teens and young ate heart adults these
products are made and distributed from
Wonderworld trademark a location that is
yet unknown to the foundation but offers
factory tours every hour from Tuesday to
Friday many of Wonder tainment Creations
are in Foundation possession such as
Wonder tainments famous Dragon snails
the real fire breathing pet you can keep
in your pocket
not much is known about the inner
workings of the wondertainment company
the SCP Foundation has no information
currently on the company's leadership
structure location history or corporate
policies various former and current
employees have been interviewed
regarding their experiences working for
wondertainment but they never seem to be
able to remember very much of use those
interviewed variously described the
wondertainment company as a regular
office building an immense Toy Factory
an amusement park but all agree it's the
best place they ever worked in fact you
should apply for a job there we I I mean
they have a few openings in their legal
department or so I've heard oh silly me
it seems we've gotten off topic you're
here to hear about the SCP 001 proposal
posting a job ad wasn't what I meant to
do when I hacked
into I mean well don't worry about that
forget I said a thing now let's try this
again but this time we'll add a Twist
Isabelle Helga Anastasia PVA Wonder
tainment the 5 is the name given to SCP
001 who due to her ability to spread
sunshine and Whimsy wherever she goes
has been classed as thel by the
foundation and due to her immensely
unpredictable nature the SCP Foundation
has resolved to just leave her be
because she can't be captured the SCP
Foundation has focused its efforts on
containing the products that she creates
she is a class 4 reality warper capable
of constructing wonderful fantastic
objects and imbuing them with anomalous
properties she's famous and widely
beloved for using this ability to create
bizarre magical and not even a little
bit dangerous toys games candies soft
drinks and other products aimed at
everyone from ages 9 to 99 these
products are distributed by as yet
unknown means many of wain's Creations
are in Foundation possession such as SCP
3551 the awesome inflatable alien
invader
and SCP 2514 a lovely horse who can sing
Happy
Birthday how Grand Wonder tainment
inherited the Wonder tainment name from
her father who either passed away or
never existed at all the circumstances
of his death and perhaps nonexistence
were very messy involving a mass
murderer the leader of a shadowy
international extra governmental
paramilitary organization at least one
deity and four bent paperclips she owns
Six corgis and all of them are named
Jeremy me in a free time she likes
to no no this is all still wrong all
right enough is enough you want to know
who Dr wonderment really is well you
asked for it Dr wonderment is the name
given to SCP
001 who due to his deity level power has
been classed as apolon by the foundation
there is no possible way to contain him
he is a class five reality warper
capable of breaking down and
reconstructing the very laws of reality
did you really think that those little
trinkets were the full extent of my I
mean his Creations did you truly think
of him as such a small Petty creature Dr
Wonder tainment is no mere toysmith no
he is a god want examples of his
Creations just look around you
everything from the most innocent safe
class to the most harrowing ker class
it's all thanks to him he is behind
everything Marshall Carter and dark the
sarst the Church of the broken God even
the Scarlet King himself all that time
all that effort all it came down to was
one entity One Singular living
personification of chaos one day the SCP
Foundation will finally give up trying
to find out how he distribut his
products when they will finally see how
small and worthless their attempts to
restore order really are and they will
be driven before his power they will
crumble and Decay into nothingness you
will bow before doctor
wondertainment had you going for a
second there didn't we you should have
seen the looks on your faces but let's
start again one more time we're being
serious this time mask off here's the
true story of Dr Wonder tainment Dr
Wonder tainment is the name given to SCP
001 who due to his relatively benign
Nature has been classed as neutralized
by the foundation rather than focusing
on containing Wonder tainment himself
the SCP Foundation has focused its
efforts on containing the products that
he creates he is a reality warper whose
limit have yet to be documented capable
of constructing otherwise normal objects
and imbuing them with anomalous
properties he's become infamous for
using this ability to create bizarre
magical and potentially dangerous toys
in games that are distributed by as yet
unknown means due to his secretive
nature almost nothing is known of Dr
Wonder tainments true Origins and the
waters have been muddied extensively by
the side effects of his reality warping
ability in fact it's entirely possible
that Dr Wonder tainment himself doesn't
know who he is anymore it's possible
that all the proposed Origins and
descriptions of Dr wonderment are true
in their own way but it is equally
possible that none of them are all
that's known for sure is that do Wonder
tainment be they male or female
Corporation or single individual is a
constant thorn in the SCP Foundation
side no matter who they really are
they're not going away soon
and only time will tell who they'll be
tomorrow or what further Horrors they
and their company will create and that's
where our story will have to come to an
end at least for now we hope you enjoyed
it and remember keep believing Hour 1
there is only one news story on every
website newspaper and TV screen the
flowers are blooming everywhere all
across the globe every country every
land mass the bitter cold of the
Antarctic gives way to a glowing rainbow
of petals the Sahara Desert and Death
Valley become beacons of thriving
Technicolor plant life the highest
mountains the lowest valleys the darkest
caves the flowers even burst free from
the concrete of cities as if reminding
us that really it was never our world we
were only borrowing it and today our
lease is up this is SCP
001 object class unnecessary it was
foretold by Tales from other dimensions
a distant future coming down the tracks
towards us and today the train has
reached the station nobody's reporting
on how the economy or the stock market
is doing today no point celebrity
scandals have faded away into
nothingness greedy businessmen lying
politicians brutal tyrants none of them
are making the headlines today the very
last headlines the world gone beautiful
and what a shame it takes the end of it
all to make us realize what really
matters to us that's right you're
looking at the end of the world but it's
okay don't panic take a deep breath in
and out it was bound to happen
eventually so no point worrying now even
the foundation knows that this just
isn't something they can stop so instead
of asking things like how can we prevent
this or do we have any final Tricks Up
Our Sleeve let's ask a different
question entirely what would you do if
you knew that you only had 24 hours
until all life on Earth ends think hard
after all even if you never live to see
the flowers bloom a final day will still
come for you just as it does for us all
hour six a d-class sits alone in the
cell when when he sees the flowers
growing out of the ground normally he'd
assume that this meant he was in some
kind of foundation experiment but not
today everyone on Earth had an innate
sense that the time is now a kind of
gallows calm spreads out over everyone
and everything it's over and that's okay
we all knew it was going to happen
eventually right he sze and gives a
slight smile those flowers sure are
beautiful that's when he hears footsteps
outside his cell approaching a key
slides into his cell door and opens
there stands Dr gears holding a bottle
of wine and two glasses anyone who knows
him might think he's been replaced by
some kind of shape-shifting anomaly or
had his mind taken over by a powerful
Cognito Hazard but now it's him the
famously cold Dr Charles Ogden gears Dr
gears says come on it's a lovely day out
there it'd be a terrible waste to spend
the whole thing cooped up in here it'd
feel like a trick on any day but this
the d-class nods and follows the doctor
out the normally oo stoic Foundation
senior researcher pours himself in the
d-class each a glass of wine and asks
What's Your Name by the way I don't
think I ever checked the d-class replies
that his name is Herold the two smile
and Shad as they exit the now empty
d-class containment Wing everyone else
is outside already researchers guards
administrative staff and DCL classes all
rubbing elbows enjoying the beautiful
son on their last day together Elsewhere
on site a flock of SCP 514 is released
just as identical flocks are being
released from every containment site all
over the world they've prepared it all
for this very day SCP 514 is a special
breed of homing pigeons created by the
Mana charitable Foundation which have
the power to suppress aggression for
those within their field of anomalous
influence and now millions of them are
flying all over the world after all
there's no point fighting on a day like
this there is no future left to secure
people always told them there would
forever be hope until the flowers
bloomed no situation was ever truly over
until the World Went beautiful but in
the absence of Hope there was something
even more inviting total absolute calm
the sight 19 Personnel sit together and
watch the flowers bloom hour 12 all
militaries call a global ceasefire
soldiers from opposing sides hug and
shake hands in Flowery fields that once
seemed choked by death and blood borders
fade bitter rivalries turn to dust Korea
unifies all is quiet in the Middle East
gangsters and drug cartels drop their
weapons and return home to their
families and friends as flocks of SCP
514 Fly Above what good is all the blood
money in the world on a day like this
wardens walk cell to cell through all
the world's prisons granting people
their Freedom again sometimes after
lifetimes of not having it they taste
the air again feel the sun on their face
they close their eyes drink it in and
walk among the flowers free men
locations of Marshall Carter and dark
limited close their doors and shutter
their Windows worldwide for the first
time in as long as any of them can
remember they turn their signs to closed
they've earned a day off everyone has
the chaos Insurgency rolls up their PL
and burns them they drop their weapons
and throw away their tactical gear as
they do so they can't help but question
themselves what was it all for in the
end what was any of it for all the
fighting in Bloodshed and death we did
it day after day only to do it again the
next day what silly reasons we killed
and died for what silly reasons indeed
the global cult Coalition dismisses its
staff thanking them for their service
and telling them to go spend their last
towers with the ones they love like the
foundation they accept that this is the
one true Final End no ritual to stop no
monster to fight no evil
extradimensional entity to thwart just
go outside and smell the flowers while
you still can the Serpent's hand are
similar they decide after decades
fighting a losing battle they'll spend
their last day in The Wanderers library
reading some of their favorite volumes
all these wonderful stories now left for
other Earths to read their own stories
would be counted among them in the end
and they take great comfort in that in a
sense everyone will live forever in the
pages of the books in The Wanderer
Library Herman Fuller's circus of the
disquieting releases all of its Freaks
and clowns from their Twisted grasp to
go and live out whatever small dreams
and Tiny Pleasures they could find over
their last TOS they have no Foundation
of fear anymore nobody Minds their
strange appearances and and odd
behaviors why would anyone waste such a
beautiful day judging others on the last
day on Earth there's nothing left to
prove sarcas ists dropped their ancient
flesh bound Toms and acolytes of the
broken God put down their gilded blades
on the slopes of Siberia the jungles of
Peru and the most isolated beaches of
Mexico Twisted flesh finally touched
living metal in the spirit of husbandry
their Eternal war is at its end in the
face of the blooming World they didn't
seem so different after all the Agents
of the doctor Wonder tainment
Corporation predictably chose to spend
their last hour sitting around and
playing with toys together time well
spent if you ask us in a highly
secretive location perhaps the most
heavily secured place in the entire
world the 13 members of the legendary 05
Council decide to just sit and talk
anyone who knows anything about this
secretive cabal can tell you the 05
Council has spent a considerable portion
of their very very long lives trying to
figure out ways to dodge and cheat death
but now facing a death they can't Dodge
the same calm washing over the rest of
the world has finally reached them too
all they can really think this time is
well played reaper well played as they
chat about the kind of anain casual
things that they haven't had time to
discuss in years 0 5-3 suggests inviting
the Ethics Committee over to join no
body disagrees hour 16 it isn't just the
DCL classes all Sapient and
non-aggressive scps have been released
from containment free to spend the last
of their time as they wish tens of
thousands of anomalous individuals are
released from containment sites all over
the globe it'd be the greatest victory
that the Serpent's hand could ever ask
for if they weren't all too busy reading
to notice s cp105 Iris Thompson finally
returns to her parents the foundation
had fed them the life that their
daughter had died many years before but
as Iris had a tendency to do she was
ready to work a miracle her parents
Embrace her with open arms they'll spend
their last hours together catching up on
what's happened since they parted ways
and making up for lost time they
couldn't be happier SCP 1867 Lord
Blackwood the Fantastical sea snail is
delivered into a warm Rock pool near the
site where he was being contained there
he might finally have one more Grand
Adventure before all is said and done
though afterward he may not have the
time to tell anyone about it a terrible
shame really because nobody spins a yarn
like Lord Blackwood the non-aggressive
little misters Run free Mr Fish eagerly
returns to his native Boston
Massachusetts where he enjoys one more
Lobster sandwich before the end of the
world Mr headless decides to go hat
shopping because he wants to look good
for the apocalypse Mr lost finally
settles down for the afternoon deciding
that just this once he's earned himself
a rest SCP 2800 Cactus men returns to
Edinboro to spend his last days picking
up litter and helping old ladies cross
the street SCP 3663 the tunnel monster
walks the streets of his hometown
searching for an old friend hoping to
reunite before it all ends SCP 073 Kane
decides to take a walk outside for the
first time in thousands of years he
can't help but Smile as the bright
colorful life beneath his feet is
growing faster than his presence can
kill it what a truly beautiful day
knowing that there's no longer time for
Colts to form and bother him SCP 2662
cthulu decides to take a break from his
intense Minecraft session and go take a
walk outside it feels so good to have
the sun on his tentacles once more and
to feel the lush green grass under his
suction cups he shakes his head thinking
once again about the irritating Cults
that had been pestering him for decades
what kind of idiot would want him to
destroy a world like this SCP 343 also
known as God size and looks over all his
creation for what he knows to be the
last time his mouth curls into a smile
as he thinks well we had a pretty good
run still in a Cell SCP 049 the plague
doctor puts his feet up and decides to
relax the pestilence will soon be taken
care of on some animalistic level below
thought below even Instinct scp096 feels
grateful that no gaze will ever fall
upon it again somewhere fizzling in a
vat of acid within a highly secure
containment chamber SCP 682 is feeling
for the first time in its hellish
existence a sense of profound relief the
pain the hate the rage the constant
termination attempts it all be over soon
our hour 23 people Gather in the streets
they laugh and dance and sing as the
moon shines fat and white far above deep
in their hearts they quietly contemplate
the end of all of this but why worry why
spoil the fun there's no future left to
worry about strangers become as close as
family in the end human or otherwise
anomalous or nonanomalous chaos
Insurgency agents have last suppers with
ex serpent hands and GOC operatives
there is no hate left no violence No
Malice no cruelty the greatest tragedy
in all of this is that it took the
ultimate end to bring it out in people
but why worry why worry seconds pass
then minutes the world buzzes it hums
trillions of creatures doing everything
they'd wanted even though it won't last
in the face of the true end the world
has never been more alive hour 24 for
silence forever and ever and ever good
night we'll end this video the way it
began by putting a question to you how
would you spend your last 24 hours on
Earth let us know down in the comments
because it'll happened to all of us
eventually they came from Beyond the
world from over the world from under the
world they came from inside the stars
and from behind the rain they came came
from the known lands and they came from
the secret places of old the vast ones
who drank of the nebula the small ones
who did not care what happened beyond
the banks of their Rivers the ones who
bathed in the light and the ones who
watched from the Shadows the ones who
loved us and the ones who forgot about
us the ones who hate us now and the ones
who love us still the ones who sung with
the rats and the ones who swam with the
leviathans they came from far and near
they came one and all they came to end
the world as you may already know from
our previous video in this series a
mysterious being known only as the
harbinger unlocked SCP 001 the lock and
brought about the omn apocalypse every
single World destroying XK class
scenario on the books from Foundation
trials to the most ancient mythological
Toms and some we'd never even imagin
began to come true a world flooded with
terrifying anomalous activity from
unfurling Skies to Giant nightmarish
animals was about where we left off now
it's time to open your eyes and wake up
this is the kind of nightmare you can't
encounter while you're asleep SCP 5720
the astronomically inclined crane went
about its daily work the small
mechanical crane always occupied itself
with the one task that gave its
existence any meaning arranging iic
model solar systems but something was
different today SCP 5720 put the final
touches on its latest model and then
lifted its mechanical arm skywards
pointing directly into the vast and
Starry Infinity above but were they
Stars no not today as SCP 5720 looked up
at the sky this time the sky looked back
they weren't Stars they were eyes
something was coming towards Earth from
the the furthest reaches of the outer
dark an armada of world Enders coming
from above below and all around a whole
Cosmos of supremely powerful beings
zeroing in on our pale blue dot a
thought crossed through whatever passed
as the mind of this strange Little Crane
today is the day your prayers will be
answered followed by another word
ringing loud and clear and holy as a
mighty church bell awaken
and at that moment everything did
thousands of miles away a new God landed
on Earth appearing like a great wall of
dense matted fur descending from the sky
Ur an the mother of the ones that came
before after eons of absence she had
eventually returned to greet her
children the true rulers and stewards of
this land but an Anum was surprised and
horrified by what she saw their great
cities their sprawl in structures their
beautiful art and advanced culture all
gone laid to waste by the worthless
hairless Apes that once lurked in the
forests with the other animals something
had happened something had changed the
humans had slaughtered her people
destroyed their accomplishments
tarnished their legacy driven the few
that were left out of Their Kingdoms and
into the forests treated them as mere
animals and built their hideous concrete
cities over their bones and they had the
G to call them Bigfoot or SCP 1000
because thanks to them their beautiful
true name had been lost to time she
looked skywards and cried out in Despair
and anguish at the loss of her children
inconsolable but then she felt something
a glimmer of hope in her mind the
possibility that things would change
that the humans would be toppled from
their Thrones and True Justice would be
achieved she called out to her remaining
children and her children answered
across the globe another great entity
awoke deep underneath a mountain when it
stirred into life and broke free it
shattered the entire Mountain on top of
it as easily as you or me displacing a
bed sheet it took to the skies massive
but unseeable to the human eye it soared
through the air gazing down upon the
world it hadn't seen for thousands of
years once it had feasted on the blood
sacrifices of human subjects hoping to
avoid void its wrath but humans weren't
the petty little group of huddled
cavemen that they had once been now they
were in their billions gathered in
impossibly large settlements The Entity
sought to find a seed of power that it
could influence but now it was spoiled
for Choice eventually it zeroed in and
found its perfect Target an SCP
Foundation containment site here it
would find a new form to take and more
Petty pathetic humans to bring under its
Mighty thrw it landed in SCP
765 the duck pond it is an anomalous
Pond that is you guessed it full of
ducks and initially induces feelings of
Serenity in its victims before later
inducing not so pleasant feelings when
the entity plummeted into the water it
began to absorb and bond with the
anomaly growing to Epic sizes as it
assumed a form that the minds of us
feeble humans could comprehend a giant
terrifying duck it released a mighty
Earth shaking quack has it plotted
across the countryside to cause Mayhem
elsewhere in Europe more violent Madness
was unfolding a crimson rooster C then a
Golden Rooster and then a rooster of
soot red anyone with the basic knowledge
of Norse mythology was shaking in their
boots as a mighty Beast stirred in the
heart of a desolate cave the chains that
had once held the Monstrous dog in place
now broke it Rose and licked its Jagged
fangs excited to stain them with the
blood of its enemies it was the great
hound fener Omen of the end times here
to Herald the end of all things a
trumpet boomed across the globe with no
Apparent Source people in the streets in
New York Delhi London Cape Town and
countless other towns cities and hamlets
the world over paused and listened in
confusion below them the great and
terrible jorong the thought to be
mythological midgard serpent stirred
from its previously Eternal Slumber and
began to uncoil it its body the shifting
caused earthquakes and tsunamis along
the coast of Greenland as towns and
Villages crumbled killing thousands
fenri stalked along the length of
Denmark slaughtering and devouring
anyone or anything unlucky enough to
cross its path but it did not wage its
war against mankind alone behind it a
hellish Army of burning Giants marched
Mighty hands clutching molten weapons
Ragnarok was upon us now Odin save us
all and the administrator slept she was
the latest in a long line of foundation
staff members to hold that hollowed
position and in the dark vistas of her
dreams a predecessor approached her he
wasn't the old bearded man in the heavy
coat that she remembered now he was
wearing a 1950 suit and a fedora hat and
carrying a briefcase that's right he'd
taken up the mantle of SCP 990 also
known as the dreamman he's a mysterious
figure that appears to members of the
foundation in their dreams warning them
of impending dis disasters that they may
be able to nearly prevent if his warning
is heed though it often comes at some
terrible cost to the recipient of his
message this time however his message
carried a different tone he told the
current administrator that there was no
way to stop the apocalypse from
occurring this time only making sure
that the particular shape of the
Apocalypse would be the one most
favorable to the foundation and
Humanity's joint interests all this was
devastating news that the new
administrator saw as a grievous betrayal
of both the Foundation stances and
Humanity as a whole she refused to
accept the idea that the apocalypse was
inevitable even coming from the mouth of
a former administrator as far as she was
concerned this dream man no longer
worked on the side of the foundation he
was in League with the world Enders and
she refused to take his deal the SCP
Foundation would save this world from
the horrors the lock Unleashed or they
would slide into the darkness with it
they would never work against the human
race scp3 343 also known as God awoke in
his cell in sight 17 the time for fun
and games with the humans at the
foundation had come and gone he was
going by his true name Yahweh now he
blinked and in that same instant he was
at sight zero the containment site for
another SCP 001 the legendary gate
Guardian all the staff around them
looked upon Yahweh in shock AED by the
reality warper sudden appearance and
unable to do anything about it but
really 343 was no mere reality warper
like some had expected 343 truly was a
God he just didn't happen to be the only
one in play When the gate Guardian saw
Yahweh now standing before him he
lowered his sword spread his fiery wings
and took a knee in great reverence
Yahweh spoke calmly but with unshakable
authority yorel it is time open the gate
lead my armies across the Earth the gate
Guardian Uriel responded in its booming
voice I he and
oy my Lord and my
God for the first time in recorded
memory the grand gate that yuriel had
always been guarding opened revealing
thousands of Legions of warrior Angels
waiting on the other side they were
impossibly beautiful and Powerful
creatures each one of vibrant glowing
chaos of wings and eyes wielding Pure
White swords and singing resounding
hymns of War soon the air was thick with
a chorus of rustling wings as the Angels
loosened themselves from the gates mouth
led by Uriel as yahweh's general into
the global fry meanwhile back at site 10
another SCP 001 the item that started
all of this the lock was entering its
next stage of grand Cosmic Evolution
something within the lock suddenly
unfurled causing a a shock wave that
killed everyone at the site and
destroying the entire building in an
instant except in that same instant all
of the site 10 staff and the building
itself reappeared completely unharmed in
a field in New Hampshire back where site
10 used to be the lock was doing some
terraforming the ground split open
beneath into a mighty Valley the likes
of which Earth had never seen before
Lush Greenery sprouted within and
thousands of strange alien creatures
soon populated this new place in the
center the lock just floated in place
they were now ready for the first
meeting to take place over at site 2036
Dr Everett man was working on a number
of SCP 098 specimens these are
frightening creatures reminiscent of
spider crafts with blades instead of
Pinchers and a natural ability to mimic
the sounds of their prey he was studying
the creatures when he got a call asking
him if the specimens had acted up at all
they had already had sudden containment
breach reaches for SCP 995 a type of
dangerous carnivorous fungi and SCP 616
a mysterious airplane with satanic
elements to it just as Dr man was about
to reply the 098 specimens
metamorphosized into many wied fllying
creatures which flew out of the chamber
with such force that they busted through
walls Sirens blared all through the
facility and Dr man joined the many
other confused and frustrated Foundation
staff members wandering the building
wondering just what the hell was going
on today they were getting bizarre
reports of unprecedented anomalous
activity from all over the world with no
explanation uniting it all according to
panicked Whispers across the facility
emergency order Patmos was now in effect
whatever that meant the true nature of
what was going on here went over most of
the heads of the SCP foundation's staff
that's when man encountered Dr Charles
Ogden gears who for such a famously
emotionless man looks surprisingly
worried Dr man tried to down played the
situation saying they were only looking
at a handful of containment breaches
here nothing they hadn't handled before
Dr gear shut him down with trademark
coldness feeling a little more nervous
now Dr Everett man asked what else had
gotten out with Steely eyes Dr gears
replied a whole damn lot SCP 001 is an '
05s tale it makes sense doesn't it after
all regardless of the exact nature of an
SCP 001 proposal there are always
certain things that remain the same see
if you can recall them all well for
starters SCP 001's are all about vital
moments perhaps like the Prototype or
the foundation or the sheath of papers
or the gate Guardian they're about the
very origin of the SCP Foundation itself
perhaps like the ororo cycle or when day
breaks or the world gone beautiful
they're about apocalyptic style
destruction or perhaps the rebirth
perhaps like consensus reality or the
database they are rules or realizations
that changed everything maybe like the
Scarlet king or the black moon or a
simple toy maker they're about the
sparking of great rivalries that truly
Define the backbone of the foundation's
activities another vital element of SCP
001 is always secrecy in classification
they are the most clandestine anomalies
out there generally hidden away below
layer after layer of encryption and
Security even the database for SCP 001
entries is guarded by a mimic kill agent
that'll leave you stoned dead on the
ground if you're below that magical
level five clearance when you attempt to
access it no information is more
carefully and forcefully guarded than
this and of course another vital element
of the SCP 001 entry is deception and
trickery it's inherent to the
designation no other number has multiple
entirely distinct anomalies many of
which either have no correlation with
one another or even actively contradict
each other if you ask some people
they'll tell you that there are multiple
00 1s because each is of equal
importance in etching the rich portrait
of the foundation's past present and
future some would tell you something
very different there's only one SCP
00001 it's a shell game the rest are all
fakes to stop people from taking any
single entry too seriously and thus
forever avoiding the truth some still
would tell you that there is no SCP 001
one it's all just a complex Web of Lies
meant to keep the foundation's enemies
and allies in a state of pliable
ignorance if an intimate knowledge of
the SCP foundation's past and inner
workings a commitment to secrecy at all
costs and a love of deception as a tool
for control all sound familiar it's
because they're the favorite toolkit of
a certain group we're all familiar with
the 05 Council the very top brass of the
SCP Foundation it only makes sense that
if anyone knew knew the truth about the
fractured and strange SCP 001 it would
be them the more observant among you may
have noticed a certain emission from
many popular SCP 00001 entries we've Nam
dropped in this video so far and it is
no accident that this particular SCP 001
entry is the only one straight from the
mouth of
horror and dark Bargains made with truly
unknowable forces it's a tale that tells
us about the initial creation and growth
of the foundation the event that nearly
destroyed it and an indication as to the
dark future possibly in store it's a
little bit of everything you can expect
from a good 001 proposal and surely if
this is the SCP 001 entry that the head
of the council swears by then it must be
the definitive entry into the 001 Cannon
right well not quite because as you're
about to find out not even the 05
Council itself can really reach a
consensus on the true nature of the
fascinating and much-feared Factory but
perhaps through hearing every side of
this particularly dark story we can find
the kernels of Truth hidden somewhere in
the middle of it all but of course be
warned as with all things when it comes
to the 05 Council it's going to get
extremely weird but before we move on to
what the rest of the 05 C will have to
say about the factory it would be
prudent to refresh our memory on 05-
one's version of the story The version
that has been considered to be absolute
before we pour into the equally strange
stories of the other council members it
began with a wealthy industrialist and
thoroughly evil man named James Anderson
all the way back in
1835 when the United States was still
new and finding its feet Anderson was an
engine of unchecked ambition malice and
most of all truly boundless greed he
wanted everything and more and being a
true businessman down to the core he was
willing to make whatever deal he needed
to make in order to see himself become
an even wealthier man that's why like a
lot of bored rich people in his day he
began dabbling in the dark arts for Fun
and Profit until eventually he made
contact with a benefactor on the other
side under these instructions James
Anderson built the factory a truly
magnificent and terrible feat of
architecture and engineering for the
time a multi-level town- siiz complex
that could produce everything from food
to weapons to toys to textiles to
precious metals and so much more workers
could find room and board at this Grand
Factory and pay for it with their labor
for the wouldbe workers of an unsteady
early America Anderson seemed like a
saint people flocked from all over the
country to live and work in the factory
but once they were locked behind the
factory doors they realized that James
Anderson was no saint he was as bad or
worse than any devil he served the
inside of the factory was a torturous
nightmare where people were regularly
worked to death and then ground into
meat that was sold off all across the
country Anderson kept a brutal guard
Force to beat down anyone resisting or
not working hard enough those who
weren't worked to death or executed by
the guards for some petty infraction
could potentially have an even worse
fate in in store for them being dragged
off and subjected to occult experiments
by Anderson these people wouldn't be
killed but they would live as humans no
more Anderson was able to keep the
factory and its nightmarish activities
running and under wraps for decades all
the way into the Civil War it was only
when a beaten bloody starved and
traumatized worker managed to escape and
alert president ulyses S Grant of the
mistreatment going on inside that
something was done about it this is
where o 5-1 and a progenitor of the SCP
Foundation would get involved there was
a small but Elite group of Union
Soldiers commissioned by President Grant
to work behind the Confederate lines
specializing in tackling the strange and
Supernatural down south this group of
course was led by
05-13 Grant knew that these would be the
men to send on this vital Mission and
president Grant's faith and these men
was rewarded though it wasn't an easy
fight they were able to infiltrate and
defeat the forces of the factory they
fought their way through Anderson's
sadistic guards through his menagerie of
terrifying homemade monsters and
eventually they got to Anderson himself
they were so appalled by the horrors
they'd seen inside the factory they
couldn't stop themselves from torturing
Anderson to death and dismembering his
corpse they freed the trapped workers
and rooted out whatever remained of
Anderson forces within the building
however this is where they made their
first pivotal decision rather than
simply destroying the soared place and
leaving it as Rubble they instead
decided to utilize it and the many
anomalous objects that It produced this
became the foundation of the foundation
over time their organization grew and
the 05 Council was formed they began
spreading their influence and capturing
anomalies all over this was however
until they engaged in a bloody war with
the super Superior military forces of
the Fay despite their augmented weaponry
and tools from the factory when the Fay
performed an allout assault against them
they were decimated in his greatest
shame 0 5-1 fled the battlefield into
the bows of the factory as his friends
and allies were slaughtered by the Fay
behind him eventually after locking
himself in a room with an ornate door he
encountered the true demonic heart of
the factory using Anderson's dismembered
corpse as a mouthpiece 0 5-1 struck a
terrible deal with the factory they
wiped out the Fay entirely and reversed
all the damage they had done the SCP
Foundation grew beyond the factory and
eventually covered it in rubble out of
shame but the factory wasn't done it is
still very much alive and Furious at
being betrayed it will keep producing
deadly anomalous objects and creatures
and releasing them out into the world
until the foundation pays what it owes
in full and the occasional sacrifice
d-class researcher and guard won't cut
it forever or at least that's how 05 D1
tells it it's a chilling story but can
it really be called a complete one we
wanted to find out for ourselves which
is why we asked every other member of
the 05 Council to tell their side of the
Factory's tale these are 12 tales about
a factory 0 5-2 upon being asked went
white as a sheet he cleared his throat
and made the admission that in truth the
factory came back with him as it turned
turns out
[Music]
one piece of technology he brought back
was a hyper advanced piece of technology
known as a nanofactory which as the name
suggests is a machine that uses Nanobots
to construct pretty much anything like
the ultimate futuristic 3D printer it
resulted in the creation of a huge
number of futuristic items that helped
the SCP Foundation along in their
mission to secure contain and protect
including amnestics however what 05 d2e
was that a rogue AI was also nested in
the nanofactory and the AI soon went
berserk as a result the nanofactory
became the factory producing dangerous
anomalies with Reckless abandon to the
detriment of both the SCP Foundation and
the World At Large on the whole it was
somewhat of a mixed bag 0 5-3 seemed a
little spaced out about even being asked
he claimed that he was there to witness
the very birth of the factory but it
didn't happen in reality as we know it
it happened in cyberspace he and his
colleagues were very interested in the
matrixes Journey of downloading their
minds into computers back in the day
both for practical reasons and to play
extremely immersive games of Doom
however one day something fundamentally
changed a new Consciousness was born in
then Soviet Russia 053 and two of his
companions all operating in cyberspace
went to go check it out along with a few
helpful AI constructs eventually they
discovered it an ever expanding data
packet that would transform into a
powerful artificial Consciousness known
as the factory with mysterious motives
and seemingly malicious intent something
it more than proved when it erased the
mind of one of 053 companions killing
him since this incident the factory has
only gotten more powerful its modus
operandi is affecting machines in the
real world and causing them to produce
anomis items which then become the SCP
foundation's latest problems to deal
with o 5-4 seemed both Twitchy and
indignant when the topic was brought up
they lamented the fact that the
foundation hadn't put more research into
the factory and how to stop it because
technically it is their most dangerous
and mysterious enemy group of Interest 0
5-4 explained it as follows the FBI
unusual incidents unit is a joke are we
cool yet is just a bunch of pretentious
privileged Rich Kids Marshall Carter and
dark limited only care about money and
thus can be bought off the glob Global
occult Coalition often helps them take
care of more challenging anomalies the
Church of the broken God and the sarcs
are often too busy waging Petty
religious wars against each other to do
real meaningful damage to the SCP
Foundation Prometheus Labs had already
fallen and Doctor Wonder tainment
wouldn't Thrive forever the factory
however was a truly unknown quantity
it's just out there somewhere pumping
out anomalies that soon become everyone
else's very dangerous problem 05- for
personally resented that the foundation
and their fellow council members don't
see this and allocate more resources to
the cause because someday soon it might
really come back to bite them as these
things often do 0 5-5 was considerably
bitter as in they denied that the
factory ever even existed claiming that
the SCP Foundation made it up to cover
up a bunch of anomalies that they
themselves had created and then told us
to um
F off if you know what I
mean some people get so hostile when you
just want simple answers next came the
tale of 0 5-6 which came in the form of
a World War II Espionage anecdote of
course this was also during the height
of the seventh occult war and Hitler
assisted by the fuel society and obscura
corpse was trying to get his greasy
little hands on as many anomalies as
possible in hopes of turning the tide of
the war in his favor 0 5-6 was working
undercover Behind Enemy Lines disguised
as an SS officer as he slowly helped
dismantle Hitler's anomalous offensive
from within he'd heard whisperings of
the Nazis developing a weapon unlike any
other a factory that would produce
anomalies for them on demand and give
them the supernatural Edge 0 5-6 didn't
believe it at first until he was
attacked by a group of vicious living
Punch and Judy dolls created by the f
Factory he nearly managed to survive the
Ambush but seemed Disturbed in
recounting the fact that when he
destroyed the dolls they bled profusely
eventually the leads he was following
led him to a ruin at the base of Zug
swootz inside he discovered the ruin was
Hollow and filled with floating Stone
orbs producing energy that allowed the
Theo Society researchers to produce more
anomalies 05- 6 was able to destroy this
anomaly Factory but he took a souvenir
SCP 627 a little Stone ball that rolls
around on the ground when it comes into
contact with people 057 admitted
somewhat sheepishly that while there was
technically no real physical factory
factory product anomalies are real and
they're all his fault he purchased a
bunch of random items from Walmart and
printed a fake logo for the factory on
the back his plan was to give these
totally innocent objects to Junior
researchers both to mess with them for
fun and to test their critical thinking
skills however it turned out that simply
placing this logo onto an item results
it in becoming an anomalous item
admittedly it was rough for 057 to have
to follow the cool story about fighting
magic Nazis 05 d8 made the far more
exciting claim that the factory is
actually all the way up on the moon back
when the SCP Foundation were first
founding Moonbase Alpha they discovered
that some ancient and unknown
civilization had already built a covert
base under the surface it was a
storehouse of anomalous alien technology
the first 13 people to enter were
immediately vaporized by the laser
defense system but the fourth to enter
was given an even worse fate he was
pulled into the machine and fused with
it at which point the factory was truly
activated it began to produce anomalies
and transport them to random locations
all across the globe and it's been a
problem ever since when we spoke to 05-
9 on the matter with a Steely look in
his eyes die he simply muttered the word
Atlantis no further comments were made
on the matter 05-10 explained that the
factory was a single man a truly ancient
and Brilliant anomalous Craftsman that
they found in a Mountain Temple in Tibet
he was taken by the foundation and
contained but given far more high-tech
tools to work his magic so they could
keep reaping the anomalous fruits of his
labors however the Craftsman was
appropriately crafty and managed to
produce a duplicate of himself to
distract the Foundation while he made an
escape he's still out there to this day
making more anomalies a one-man Factory
o 5-11 claimed that the factory was
alien in origin but it wasn't on the
moon it was the true explanation for the
iconic 1947 Roswell New Mexico UFO
incident a flying saucer descended and
offered 05-11 who was the commander of
the response team at the time the most
wonderful things this saucer became the
factory but he vanity and 05-11 were
deceived it wasn't long before this
extraterrestrial Factory was producing
countless deadly anomalous nightmares
the world over with nothing we could do
about it 05-12 said that the factory is
a mess it's a remnant of the
foundation's attempt to erase the
supernatural from Human belief
Foundation researchers claim that due to
the inherent power in human belief the
belief in the Supernatural gave it power
and phasing Humanity as a whole out of
this belief was a Maj factor in making
sure things weren't much worse than they
are today however some hearty things
slipped through the cracks and because
reality has a strange sense of humor
these things are marked with the logo of
the factory to round things off we have
a bonus take from the mysterious
05-13 who is instrumental in helping us
put the rest of this video together he
claims that he created the factory and
that it acts as a kind of countermeasure
against interdimensional Invaders while
it may seem like the fact is creating
anomalies it's actually intercepting
them and making them safer some
anomalies that seem to come from the
factory may be dangerous but if 05-13 is
to be believed then they'd be a hell of
a lot more dangerous if the factory
wasn't here and there you have it folks
the story of the factory from every
possible angle even though it feels like
each angle is facing in an entirely
different direction in the words of
Oprah Winfrey so what is the truth is
there a nugget of reality beneath all of
the fallacy or do you think the 05
Council was trolling all of us for even
daring to ask we leave that question to
you dear viewers let us know which
Theory you believe down in the comments
below the man's bedroom hadn't been
silent for over 100 years now the carpet
had been worn down a thick layer of dust
had gathered on every surface and the
same trapped air had stagnated for so
long that it become unbearable for
anyone entering the room but no one was
allowed to enter the room nobody could
open that door ever again or it could
Mark the beginning of not just an
apocalypse but a breakdown in the nature
of reality itself figures shuffled
around the room sometimes dozens
sometimes as few as three all rotting
but never dying researchers peered
through the window in abject Terror day
after day as the laws of physics broke
down before their very eyes all of them
except one lone scientist with a plan to
get inside that room a plan that the
foundation would shoot him dead for a
plan that he was seconds away from
enacting as the improvised explosive
device in his Satchel clunked heavily
against his thigh in many ways we are
just as trapped as SCP 001 if not more
so we are trapped in our own
three-dimensional world take a stick
figure drawn on a piece of paper that
stick figure knows up and down left and
right and that is their world you draw a
box around them and they are trapped
unable to Simply step forward out of the
page and walk around it for us looking
down at the stick figure we might laugh
at their foolishness trapped inside a
child's drawing of a house it begs the
question is there a creature looking
down at us and laughing we may be able
to move up and down left and right
forward and backward outsmarting the
simple stick figure but in time we are
just as caged in living our entire lives
on this razor thin piece of paper called
the present the future is always just
Out Of Reach the past always repelling
us we have no choice but to exist in the
now slowly creeping through history
without any agency of our own curse to
be born Live and Die in that order you
can never be a child again never see
your mother's face for the first time
beaming down at you you cannot skip
ahead to your dying minutes knowing what
it is you will have to face up to in
your life maybe the idea of facing up to
things at all will fade with the freedom
of exploring what once was and what will
be as if it were no more difficult than
taking a step out of a 2d box the bell
rang cutting Professor Davies off he
hadn't meant to go into such an
existential tangent especially for his
first year students most of them looked
like they were in a days not really
listening to anything he had been saying
quantum mechanics sure was a complex
topic to cover in just one semester at
University he'd spent his entire career
trying to wrap his head around it and
still spend most of his days with the
same bored and Confused glaze over his
eyes as the teenagers who made their way
to the back of the hall but one figure
standing just beyond the doorway peering
down at him caught the professor's eye
little did he know how drastically his
career was about to change in just a few
minutes a preeminent physicist at just
28 years old
Professor Davies had already achieved
the status that many academics will not
see within their lifetimes whenever
anyone asked him about it he always made
the joke that he was cheating he didn't
believe in the concept of a linear
lifetime in the first place still too
young to be taken seriously by many of
his peers he had flown under the
academic radar for much of his career so
far perhaps it was as simple as that or
perhaps certain undercover agents had a
hand in suppressing news of his
blossoming career in Quantum research
his hands trembled as he approached the
reinforced glass he gripped the bag
tightly trying his best not to let his
fear show if any of them saw what he was
about to do if they even suspected
something he would have a dozen bullets
flying through the back of his skull
before he'd even have a chance to put
his hands up shifting his weight from
foot to foot he waited for the airlock
to be open for him a siren blared red
lights flashed and the first glass door
slid open stepping inside he waited for
the atmosphere in the chamber to adjust
both doors were closed in front of and
behind him if they wanted to kill him
now would be the time he closed his eyes
and waited with baited breath the bomb
weighing heavily on his shoulder but
they would not kill him he knew that now
what he was about to do was inevitable
it took several months for Professor
Davies to be granted the full security
clearance he needed they kept referring
to his project as a k class anomaly
whatever that meant in order to get him
up to speed with the nature of what he
was going to be working on the
foundation assigned him to various other
scps first SCP 5027 2821 1887 any
instance that had some link to Quantum
Mechanics or complex theoretical physics
they wouldn't even tell him which SCP he
was being trained up to work on until
one morning when a team of Agents was
waiting for him at the door to his
quarters he wasn't allowed to bring a
bag or any personal possessions standard
issue clothing a toothbrush and
everything else he needed would all be
provided for him it was only then that
they told him which SCP he was being
assigned to SCP 001 he was blindfolded
for the entirety of the journey car then
plane then another car it was a full 10
hours before his blindfold was removed
and his new project was revealed to him
professor Davies found himself in sight
01 the place where all of this started
all the scps all the research the
secrecy the assassinations the deaths of
countless innocent people and in equal
number of guilty parties it all started
right here site 01 the site itself
resembled a large sarcophagus similar to
the one found covering the Chernobyl
nuclear power plant where do you think
the Soviets got the blueprints from
everything in the room is arranged in a
circle around the center research desks
maintenance equipment raw materials
including a stockpile of wood wooden
planks and reinforced metal sheetss
monitoring equipment security cameras
and of course some of the most advanced
automatic weapon systems in the world
all pointed at a great glass box in the
middle of the hanger measuring 30 m in
each Direction the glass was 50 cm thick
even all those High Caliber weapons
would have had a hard time creating a
chip in that but it wasn't the glass box
itself that was so interesting it was
what was trapped inside of it a house
inside a perfectly round glass bowl with
no entrances or exits complete with a
front lawn sidewalk porch and even a
tree in the backyard a regular American
house trapped in a box like some kind of
science experiment there was some kind
of transparent airlock system at the
entrance on the other side was just a
normal walk up the garden path to the
edge of the second glass bubble
enclosing the house but on closer
inspection Professor Davies realized
that this wasn't your typical American
house at all the Street Lamp wasn't
electric it was made of iron with little
glass painted windows an oil lamp in
fact the house did look odd to him there
was no electric doorbell but instead an
actual physical Bell System the whole
house looked out of place not just
because it was in a box in the central
hanger of a 42,000 ton sarcophagus but
because it was from another era entirely
you see sight 01 was constructed around
this house the glass box and bubble the
sarcophagus all of it was built around
the already existing building beneath
the foundations a 100 m beneath the
surface is an immense metal plate that
forms a perfect seal with the defenses
up top the only way in and out of site
01 is through an immense reinforced door
but even all those defenses will prove
utterly futile if anyone ever opens the
thin wooden door to the bedroom on the
top floor of the house that is the home
home and the prison in which SCP 001 is
trapped it is the job of the foundation
to make sure that it remains trapped
there indefinitely what is SCP 001 as
Professor Davies made his way through
the airlock for the very first time and
entered the site under the supervision
of four of the highest ranking SCP staff
alive today he laid eyes on the entity
itself for the first time standing on a
scissor lift parked outside the front of
the house just inches away from the
glass bub he was lifted high enough to
look through the window into what looked
like a young boy's bedroom on the top
floor layers of dust coated the surfaces
black and white photos sat in frames
antique children's toys sat all around
the walls but Davies didn't notice any
of them he was too busy watching the men
walking in all directions unhurried but
with purpose well over a dozen men
walked in all directions across the
carpeted floor they were all identical
around 6 ft feet with heavy rotting skin
that seemed to hang off their limbs like
it would a carcass left in the sun human
cadavers Milling about in a young boy's
bedroom Davies was so taken aback by
their appearance and behavior that it
took him a long time to notice something
truly strange the reason he was brought
here in the first place they were
walking through the bed in the middle of
the room not just over it or around it
but straight through it as if it wasn't
there
but wait something else was wrong too
there weren't 12 of them in the room it
was closer to 20 had he miscounted a
moment ago then he saw it take place one
of the cadavers reached the edge of the
room and paused as if in thought at that
moment it split not in half but rather
two versions of itself emerg from where
one had been standing both walking in
different directions a thrill of
excitement ran through Professor Davy's
body the uncertainty principle it was
there in action in front of him he was
looking at Schrodinger's cat inside the
box and seeing both its corpse and its
living self where uncertainty exists
this entity was somehow embodying both
possibilities in real time he watched
the two selves walk around the room
following different paths for several
minutes until eventually they converged
again back into one being he turned to
the researcher accompanying him lit up
with excitement and asked what they were
doing here the researchers face was Grim
when he replied they're pacing waiting
the airlock door hissed open he felt the
stale 1800's air hitting his face
perfectly maintained at 20° in front of
him was the Garden Path leading up to
his goal that glass bubble ripping the
Satchel he set off up the path slow
enough not to attract any unwarranted
attention over the next few days
Professor Davies learned everything that
the foundation had on SCP 001 it had
been a human once a radical physicist
born in the late 19th century intent on
kickstarting the next Century with a
nuclear Renaissance the young man had
created a working model for stable
nuclear fusion the potential
ramifications were enormous free clean
electricity on a mass scale with no
harmful byproducts his research was
almost complete when a covert private
military group poisoned him with his own
radioactive nuclear agent the young man
made it back to his house where he died
in his sleep that night powerful
military personnel and prominent
scientists who had been working
alongside the young man knew immediately
what had happened bursting into his home
they were about to walk through his
bedroom door and save him when they saw
the shadow of two feet standing by the
door then another pair the young
scientist had died but he also hadn't
much like Schrodinger's Cat the man was
suspended in a dual state of death and
not death this shocking Discovery led
the group of people present to form a
rudimentary Foundation established to
secure and contain their once friend
within his room never to be discovered
by The Wider world through close
observations since this time it has been
established that SCP 001 exists
independently of linear time in a kind
of superposition relative to the world
around it it is capable of occupying any
space that will or has been empty at any
point in time say you have two chairs in
a room one chair has always been there
the other was added to the room just 5
minutes before
the SCP is unable to walk through the
chair that was always there since it has
always existed but the chair that was
added can be passed through with no
problem because there was a point in
time when that chair had not been there
but it also works in the future if a
third chair was present which had always
been there but was removed 5 minutes
after the experiment SCP 001 could pass
through that chair also the foundation
theorizes and hopes that the start of
this clock that SCP 001 operates on was
the point at which the young scientist
died and did not die that is why it is
incapable of escaping its bedroom and
that is why it is of vital importance
that the bedroom door remains closed
forever ongoing maintenance work and
preservation techniques are being
employed to keep the house in as stable
of State as possible should anything
happen to damage the Integrity of the
structure the quantum chaos contained in
that space could lead to a total
breakdown of the laws of physics
destroying not just the world but the
fundamentals of mathematics as we know
them the bomb bumped against Professor
Davy's thigh as he walked up to the
house an old man whose life had been
devoted to denying the world its future
a reality where what is and what could
be are just as real as one another a
world where the pain of living in the
now Fades when you can travel to any
moment in your life and relive its Joy
when you aren't trapped by the aging
process infinite renewable energy to
solve the world world's problems a
chance to see your deceased loved ones
again a way to look at the universe
Through The Eyes Of God the head of 001
containment he had spent his entire
career overriding all of the safeguards
tweaking containment rules just enough
each year all so he could walk across
this grass with a satchel on his
shoulder and an explosive more important
than the atomic bomb at his hip he
approached the glass of the inner sphere
if he had done the math right this
should do do just enough damage to
create a hole in the containment
structure the pressure change wouldn't
be too great inside but it should be
just enough to blow say a bedroom door
wide open the woman fell to the ground
clutching her ankle in pain it had
crunched badly as she'd fallen and now
as she looked down at it she could see
that it was been totally out of shape
the heavy metal collar choking her neck
made it difficult for her to catch her
breath as she tried her best not to
hyperventilate the rain was hammering
down so ferociously that she could
barely see more than 20 ft in any
direction but she didn't need to see far
to know how deadly of a predicament she
had found herself in she cried out at
the top of her voice for someone to come
and find her anyone but the only sound
that filled her ears was the wild
howling of the wind and the steady
hammering of water into the bog all
around her she would get hypothermia and
and die no wait she couldn't could she
she knew she couldn't die but she also
knew that she was still capable of
suffering just how bad would it feel to
be in the clutches of hypothermia with a
broken ankle and know that no matter how
bad the pain and suffering got she would
never feel the release of death she
closed her eyes trying her best not to
think of the worst possibilities just as
the sound of gunfire erupted in the
nearby buffer she cried out out again
holding both hands up in the air doing
the best she could around the heavy
metal collar but no one shouted out in
reply there was a pause in the gunfire
maybe they'd heard her maybe they were
trying to figure out a way to come down
and rescue her crack a bullet split open
a rotted tree trunk just a few feet to
her right the woman threw her hands over
her head and cowered in the dirt feeling
the metal of her collar digging into her
skin tighter than ever please don't let
it happen again she prayed silently into
the dirt encased in the collar around
her neck were 4.5 kg of plastic
explosives each with a fragmentation
layer pointed inwards towards her neck
and head with just a push of a button
they could she didn't want to think
about it all she knew was that she
couldn't let that happen to her again
looking through eyes bloodied with tears
and Rain she saw lying in the dirt just
a few feet away from her that infernal
machine that was the sorry cause of all
all of this the SCP Foundation has long
stood as a Bastion of Hope information
and security for the entirety of the
human race I'm sure you are well aware
of the number of world destroying
catastrophes that have been adverted by
the hardworking researchers agents and
other members of the foundation all
without the general public having the
slightest clue that something was a Miss
with stateoftheart holding cells all
over the globe and the sharpest Minds
Humanity has ever produced working
around the clock to ensure the
protection of humanity it is hard to
imagine an entity that should not be
contained by such a group and yet one
such entity does exist SCP 001 you may
have come across the 05 Council by this
point while the SCP Foundation operates
beyond the world's jurisdiction the 05
Council operates beyond the foundation's
jurisdiction the rules methods and
protocols that are the Cornerstone of
securing containing and protecting
countless entities around the world
sometimes cannot be applied certain
entities require us to temporarily
abandon our Humanity abandon our sense
of order and step briefly into chaos for
the greater good I'm telling you all of
this because SCP 001 is not held in a
containment cell there are no keypads
locked doors observation windows or
health and safety forms SCP 001 is not
confined to a specific territory or even
a specific country for some scps this is
a practical necessity serpents that are
hundreds of kilometers long swimming
through the depths of the ocean for
example but for SCP 001 it serves a more
psychological purpose the Scottish
Highlands are the most remote part of
the United Kingdom out there you can
walk for miles and miles without seeing
a single soul open Countryside mountains
locks and forests surround you in all
the directions the weather is Harsh and
unrelenting the walking even more so on
a regular basis Walkers fall and break
their legs but without phone service or
anyone else nearby to come and help they
can quickly disappear into the
Wilderness forever the Pete bogs of
Scotland used to see human sacrifices in
early settlements afraid of the ghosts
and spirits that haunted the bogs people
would throw their family members into
the deepest parts and watch them drown
hoping that whatever was lurking beneath
wouldn't come and find them so as the
group of soldiers crusted the top of the
mountain and looked down beneath them to
the Eerie Pete bogs obscured by mist and
constant rainfall you would forgive a
shiver running up their spines but of
course it didn't that was because this
group of soldiers were quite unlike any
others that Humanity has ever produced
all were nameless none of them existed
on any government databases on any
foundation databases or even on the
databases of the 05 Council itself their
individual backgrounds nationalities and
families were totally unknown to
everyone other than themselves some had
been tortured for years others had been
the torturers the thing that United them
however was their inhuman ruthlessness a
squad of eight soldiers utterly devoid
of any sense of empathy what could they
possibly have to be afraid of in the
Pete bogs when they themselves were the
evil ghosts walking through but then one
person was afraid a shiver ran up her
spine as she looked over the edge and
down into the murky black and green
below SCP
01-1 around her neck was the bomb collar
each of the eight soldiers surrounding
her had a button mounted on a watch on
the back of their wrists at any moment
any one of them could hit the button and
all 4 and 1/2 kg of plastic explosives
would go off sending her on an Express
trip to Oblivion aside from the collar
she wore a plain white dress made of
cotton it was muddy and torn apart at
the Hem from Days of walking through the
Scottish Wilderness when she had first
arrived she had begged those around her
to supply her with some warm clothes
something practical that would keep her
comfortable and Stave off any illness
her requests however had not been
acknowledged clutching in her trembling
outstretched hands was the machine as CP
001 d a from its external experience you
would think it was nothing more than a
wooden box a perfect cuboid made from
glossy dark wood there were no symbols
no seams no latches nothing to indicate
any method of operation when the woman
in the machine had first been delivered
into the hands of the 05 Council the
researchers had spent weeks and millions
of dollars trying to activate the
machine their best scientists had
scanned for every possible form of
radiation and tried every method they
could conceive to stimulate the box into
opening the ultimate failed attempt
involved traveling to North Korea where
they negotiated placing the Box 20 cm
beneath a small nuclear warhead in
return for granting the dictatorship key
information on how to construct such a
weapon as we have established the 05
Council operates Beyond any kind of
jurisdiction yet at the bottom of the
irradiated crater set a perfectly intact
wooden box that was cool to the touch
and showed no signs of radioactivity
only one person could interact with the
box and unearth the secrets that were
inside
scp-1 the woman who stood trembling on
the side of the mountain a gun jabbed
her in the back forcing her to continue
moving she had asked the soldiers around
her how much longer they had to walk
that day but none of them had replied
they never did in the six years that she
had been held hostage by this tiny
militia she had never once heard any of
them say a word not even to each other
perhaps it was this telepathic
understanding that seemed to run between
them that unnerved her the most despite
having never spoken to each other each
Soldier seemed to understand the others
intimately and she had no doubt that any
one of the eight would press the button
on their wrist at a moment's notice
sadly for her she knew this from
experience the incident happened 4 years
ago now as the group was traveling
through Patagonia it was a day almost
identical to the one she was having now
they had been transported by a
helicopter flown by one of the eight
into the middle of the Wilderness there
they had marched for days without saying
a single word exhaustion had overtaken
her legs and she stumbled to the ground
unfortunately for her this happened
slightly too close to the female soldier
in front of her her knees hadn't even
hit the ground before the blast went off
the woman didn't remember it of course
how could she in an instant her mind had
been utterly destroyed what she did
remember was the next 18 months as her
body slowly healed itself one brain cell
at a time it wasn't so much like waking
up from a nightmare it was more
constructing a nightmare slowly
alongside your Consciousness as neuron
by neuron your brain reformed itself
each individual cell screaming in Terror
at what had happened to it they had her
marching again before before she was fit
to move her motor controls had been all
over the place she had fallen over
regularly and the terror of having one
of the soldiers pushed the button again
engulfed her with every movement and yet
Perhaps the most incredible thing about
SCP
0011 was the fact that if you had asked
her if she should have been held in this
kind of containment she would
immediately have agreed without batting
an I the only person capable of opening
the box she recognized how dangerous her
existence was only she had seen into the
mysteries of the Box only she had seen
the horrors laid inside of it and so
only she could fully understand the
gravity of their situation they kept her
on the Move in order to keep the world
safe had she been held in a containment
cell she would have posed too great of a
risk out here in the wilderness the
entire planet was her containment cell
hidden in the middle of Humanity's
biggest hay stack no one not even the 05
council's Central Command knew her
location
the only people who were aware of it at
any given time were herself and the
eight soldiers surrounding her with guns
drawn so you can imagine her horror when
out of the Sheets of Rain appeared the
figure of a person carrying a rifle the
gunfire broke out before sccp 001 D1
even had a chance to hit the ground
bullets whizzed through her hair and
cracked open the Rocks all around her
the eight soldiers surrounding her die
for cover as the figure in the rain
slumped to the ground lifeless one of
the soldiers grabbed The Woman by her
explosive collar and threw her behind a
rock clasping her hands over her ears
she closed her eyes and waited for the
fight to be over no one was shooting
until a second figure emerged from the
rain waving their arms wildly gunfire
again she wasn't quite sure what had
happened but all of a sudden the woman
was falling down the cliff she' just
been trying to shift her position to get
deeper into cover but she clearly hadn't
noticed just how close to the edge she
was down and down down and down she fell
until with a crack in her ankle she
landed in the peep bog gunfire cracked
on the mountain above her but the only
thought that filled the woman's mind was
the terror that at any moment the
explosive collar around her neck would
be detonated as one of the soldiers
above her realized that she was missing
seconds passed as the fear mounted in
her chest with each passing moment the
anxiety grew more and more crippling she
had to know she had to prepare herself
if it was about to happen she had to use
the machine and look into the future
dragging herself forward through the
muck the woman snatched at the wooden
box it came alive at her touch different
pieces shifted and open beneath her
fingers like some kind of elaborate
puzzle no one had taught her how to use
this thing it just happened her fingers
would just dance across its surfaces
pushing and pulling opening and closing
twisting and turning and locking into
place and until all of a sudden there it
was the box was wide open in front of
her taking a deep breath and allowing
the rain to fall on her head for another
brief moment the woman leaned forward
and stepped into the box on the trail
above her the gunfire stopped without a
word of communication the soldiers had
deafly flanked the group of people who
had approached them in less than a
minute they neutralized each individual
that came their way in unison the group
of them walked up to the bodies turning
them over to examine their faces they
were nobody's just a group of hikers
lost in the rain what had looked like a
gun turned out to be nothing more than a
walking pole five of them in total none
of them older than 24 without words the
soldiers picked up the bodies and threw
them over their shoulders as they
scrambled their way down to the cliffs
to the woman in the machine beneath them
once they reached the bottom of the
slope they discarded the five bodies
carelessly into the bog within a couple
of hours those five hikers would have
sunk to the bottom and begun the long
process of being involved calmed Into
the Depths perhaps someone would find
them in a few thousand years time as
part of an archaeological dig perhaps
but it was not their concern the eight
soldiers surrounded the women gun drawn
and stared at her coldly I used the
machine she told them I used it without
your permission I I don't know what the
rules are I don't know if we even have
any rules here but I I thought you
should know the soldiers continued to
look at her in Silence the box was
closed now sitting back on her lap as it
always was I I try to see my future
anytime I've used the Box before I've
looked at the lives of others I've seen
economic crashes climate disasters
genocides Wars love and life and death
I've done so at the hands of the 05
Council as they've told me given them
the information and prevented the
destruction of the world never once have
I looked at my own future the soldiers
lifted her to her feet and tried to
March her onwards not listening to a
word she was saying her broken ankle
buckled and screamed beneath her she had
to hop to keep up with them what other
choice did she have they would push the
button if she didn't she didn't know why
she kept talking but she did For the
First Time The Machine lied to me I saw
that I was assassinated in 1987 in Cuba
it was years before I even built the Box
before any of this happened to me I saw
in my future that I no longer existed
that the machine no longer existed but
that future was years ago and none of it
happened the machine doesn't lie so why
is it lying to me now why can't I see my
own future if any of the soldiers were
paying attention they and show it they
just continued to March her into the
rain as the bomb weighed heavily around
her neck now go check out scp1 the
children or boros cycle and insane SCP
001 fight gate Guardian versus scarlet
King